TO ORDER. IN RESPONSE TO THE
CALL THAT NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
TODAY IN THE CAPITAL WITH SOME
OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY REMEMBER
ATTENDING REMOTELY TODAY A
SENATOR STERN- CENTER STERN IF
YOU ARE PRESENT- THE RESTAURANT
IS PRESS. SO STERN IF YOU HAVE
A STAFF MEMBER WITH YOU WOULD
YOU PLEASE IDENTIFY THAT STAFF
MEMBER. YEAH I MEAN MY DISTRICT
OFFICE WITH THAT MY DIRECTOR
JEREMY WILL. THANK YOU SENATOR
STERN- CENTERS REMINDER I THINK
YOU'VE DONE THIS ENOUGH TIMES
THAT YOU KNOW THE PROCESS IN
TERMS OF MUTING YOUR- PHONE IN
YOUR COMPUTER AND RAISING YOUR
HAND- TO ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS
WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS. TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. WE HAVE
SEVERAL BILLS TODAY WHERE THERE
ARE A LARGE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY. SO IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE ESTABLISH THE
PROTOCOLS RIGHT UP FRONT. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT TO SPEND
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED. ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO SIX SIX ME LET
ME START OVER AGAIN EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX. EIGHT ONE
FIVE TWO. THE ACCESS CODE IS.
DRUM ROLL. EIGHT TWO EIGHT
SEVEN EIGHT TWO FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. WILL MOVE THE PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY
MODERATOR DIAL ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. PRESSES
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THERE
MAY BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE THE MODERN TO
CALL YOUR NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
THAT'S YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT
TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTE IT
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO. ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE IN ORDER
FOR US TO HEAR US CLEARLY. AND
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING OR LISTENING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. SUPPORT THAT WE HEAR
FROM YOU. AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I'LL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. ANY INDIVIDUAL
REMOVED FROM THE HEARING. THE
REMOTE HEARING SERVICE. OR
HEATHER. MUTED WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE. THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS AND IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
NECESSARY. THE CUSTOMARY. MAYBE
SOME LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
WHO ARE JUST IN THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENTS ALL INTERESTED PARTIES
CAN BE HEARD. STUDENTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. THE COMMITTEE CHAIR
THAT'S ME WILL INSTITUTE TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY. EACH SIDE
WILL BE PERMITTED EQUAL AMOUNT
OF TIME. WHICH IS TO WITNESSES
TO WITNESSES WILL HAVE. THEY
WILL HAVE EACH TWO MINUTES
ANOTHER WORDS FOUR MINUTES FOR
THE PRIMARY WITNESSES. ALL
THOSE WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON MEASURES. I WANNA MAKE IT
CLEAR UP FRONT THAT OF MID EACH
SIDE SUPPORT OPPOSITION DIP TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES. EACH PRIMARY
WIN AS WE PREVENTIVE TESTIFIED
FOR TWO MINUTES FOR TOTAL OF
FOUR MINUTES. THEN WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO IS I'M GOING TO TURN
TO THE PHONE LINES. AND WE'RE
GONNA GET EACH SO AN
OPPORTUNITY. PROVIDE COMMENTS
BY PHONE. BUT IT'S LIMITED TO
FIFTEEN MINUTES PER SIDE. AND
SO THAT'S WHY IT'S NECESSARY
FOR AS MANY PEOPLE. AS POSSIBLE
TO GIVE THEIR TESTIMONY PROVIDE
THEIR OPINION THAT WOULD BE
LIMITED TO NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. BEFORE WE BEGIN THE
PRESENTATION THE BILLS LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM A MAN CHIEF
COUNSEL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FOR PURPOSES OF ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM UMBERG YEAH- BURKE HERE
BORJAS. BARGES PRESENT COPY AT
ALL. DID ALSO. DID I SO HE
GOING. GONZALEZ HERE HERTZBERG.
JONES LAYERED. BLARED SORRY
STERN. STERNUM STEARNS HERE
WHITE HOUSE SKI. BY CAL SKI
HERE WIENER WIENER PRESENTS YOU
HAVE A QUORUM ESTABLISHED.
THANK YOU A MAN CHIEF COUNSEL.
I WANT TO NOTE THAT THE FILE
NUMBER THREE SB SIX TWO THREE
BY CENTER NEWSOME HAS BEEN POLL
SEES ME NEWMAN SENATOR NEWMAN
HAS BEEN PULLED FROM DAY'S
AGENDA AND WILL NOT BE HEARD
WITH EIGHTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA FOR WHICH ON CONSENT THE
ADDAMS I CONSENT COUNTY ARE AS
FOLLOWS PHYLUM NUMBER FOUR S.
B. THREE FIVE FOUR BY SENATOR
SKINNER WITH AMENDMENTS. FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB FIVE THREE
SENATE SEVEN BY SEN RUBIO WITH
AMENDMENTS FILE NUMBER SIXTEEN
SB FIVE ONE EIGHT BY CENTER
LAYERED AND FILE NUMBER
NINETEEN S. B. FIVE SIX NINE BY
SENATOR UMBERG THEIR MOTION ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. CENTER
LAYERED MOVES THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MADAM CHIEF COUNSEL
TO CALL THE ROLL. ON THE CAN.
CALENDAR HI NUMBER I FORGES.
BARGES HI CAMBIADO. THE RUSSELL
DID US I GOING. GONZALEZ I
HEARD. JOE LEHRER LAYER HI
STERN. STERN I WIECKOWSKI HI
WHITE HOUSE I WIENER WE HI YOU.
EIGHT SO FAR ALL RIGHT WE'LL
PUT THAT THE LONG CALL US IN
BRADFORD YOU'VE BEEN PAY WAIT
CENTER BRADFORD YOU'RE READY-
SB NUMBER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBER I STAND HERE
BEFORE YOU TODAY TO PRESERVE S.
TWO. BETTER KNOWN AS THE KEY
ROTH JUNIOR PLEASE BE SURE TO
FOR ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THIS BILL IS NOT NEW TO ANY
HERE IN THE- BECAUSE- WE THIS
BILL ALLOW HERE. AS A B. SEVEN
THREE ONE. I'M HONORED STAND
HERE TODAY TO HAVE THE PROTIUM
AS A JOINT AUTHORS. ALONG WITH
MYSELF. OF THIS PRIORITY
LEGISLATION. NOT ONLY FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS. NOT
ONLY FOR CALIFORNIA BUT IT
SHOULD BE FOR ALL OF AMERICA.
KENNETH ROSS JUNIOR WAS A
VIBRANT TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD
YOUNG MAN WHO GREW UP IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD. HE WAS SIMPLY
RUNNING ACROSS A PARK. THREE
YEARS AGO. WHEN HE WAS SHOT IN
THE BACK TWICE BY A R. FIFTEEN
BY A GUARDIAN A POLICE OFFICER
AN OFFICER WHO HAD BEEN
PREVIOUSLY EMPLOYED. BY ORANGE
COUNTY POLICE AGENCY AND YET
LEFT THERE ONLY TO BE HIRED BY
THE CITY OF GARDENA AFTER HE
HAD BEEN INVOLVED IN THREE
PREVIOUS SHOOTING INCIDENTS IN
ORANGE COUNTY. THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE A STATEWIDE PROCESS TO
REVOKE THE CERTIFICATION OF AN
OFFICER AFTER THE CONVICTION OF
SERIOUS CRIMES OR TERMINATION
FROM EMPLOYMENT DUE TO
MISCONDUCT. WE ARE NOW ONE OF
ONLY FOUR STATES IN THE NATION
IT DOESN'T HAVE A PRAYER AND A
CRUEL THE CERTIFICATION PROCESS
FOR BAD OFFICERS. ARE GOVERNOR
OFTEN LIKE TO SAY THAT
CALIFORNIA IS THE NEXT COMING
ATTRACTION WE LEADING
TECHNOLOGY WE LEAD IN
ENVIRONMENT WE LEAD AND ALL
THOSE THINGS THAT IMPORTANT
EXCEPT FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM I HOPE TODAY YOU WILL
JOIN US AND JOIN ME IN MAKING
CALIFORNIA THE NEXT LEADING A
TRACTOR WHEN IT COMES TO
MEANINGFUL POLICE REFORM. DOES
IS A TO REVOKE TO SERVE. OR OF
BAD DAY. LAWYERS EVEN BARBERS
COMP CONVERT. YOU CAN EVEN
RECALL ELECTED OFFICIAL BUT IS
UNABLE TO DE CERTIFY. POLICE
OFFICERS WHO HAVE BROKEN THE
LAW AND VIOLATED PUBLIC TRUST.
BILL WOULD CREATE A FAIR AND
AFFECT THE PROCESS TO ENSURE
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
WHO BREAK THE PUBLIC TRUST BY
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
ACTIONS AND NOT ALLOW THE
SIMPLY MOVED FROM ONE AGENCY
ARE IN ONE DEPARTMENT TO THE
NOT A TO ANOTHER HOUSE WITH.
THE OFFICER WHO SHOT HIM ROSS
JUNIOR. ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
ALLOWS THE COMMISSION ON PEACE
OFFICERS AND STANDARDS IN
TRAINING BETTER KNOWN AS POST.
THE COMMISSION THAT IS
PRIMARILY MADE UP OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT. TO INVESTIGATE
GROUNDS OF OFFICERS MISCONDUCT.
AUTHORITIES IMPORTANT TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE CREATING AN
EFFECTIVE THE CERTIFICATION
SYSTEM. WOULD ALSO CREATE AN
ADVISORY BOARD WITH IMPOSED
THAT WOULD MAKE INITIAL
RECOMMENDATIONS ON WHETHER POLL
SHOULD BE CERTIFIED OFFICER OR
NOT. FINALLY THIS BILL ALLOWS
THE COMMISSION DEFINE BY
REGULATION THIS BILL SPECIFIC
GROUNDS OF SERIOUS MISCONDUCT
THAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED FOR
DECERTIFICATION. SEVERAL OF
THESE EGREGIOUS BROWN'S ARE
LAID OUT IN THIS MEASURE. SUCH
A SEXUAL SAW THIS HONESTY. A
BRIEF THE ABUSE OF POWER.
TAMPERING WITH THE EVIDENCE BUT
ULTIMATELY THE COMMISSION HAS
THE AUTHORITY TO FIND EXACTLY
WHAT MISCONDUCT IS THAT COULD
LEAD TO THE DEATH CERT OF AN
OFFICER. WE FILL THIS APPROACH
IS FAIR. IT IS NOT A RADICAL
APPROACH TO WHAT OTHER OR WHAT
I SHOULD SAY WHAT MANY OTHER
STATES ARE CURRENTLY DOING.
CERTAINLY THIS BILL MAKES
CHANGES. TO STRENGTHEN THE TOM
BAIN CIVIL RIGHTS ACT. IT
ENSURES THAT A FAMILY MEMBER OF
A PERSON KILLED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS ALSO ABLE TO
ASSERT IT CALLS OF ACTION UNDER
THE BAN ACT. IT CLARIFIES THAT
THREE OF THE MOST EGREGIOUS
IMMUNITIES CALMLY ASSERTED BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT ARE NOT
APPLICABLE. APPLICABLE I SHOULD
SAY THE CLAIMS BROUGHT UNDER
THE BANNER. THESE INCLUDE
PLANTING EVIDENCE OR FRAMING
SOMEONE. ENTERING A PRISONER.
ARE FAILING TO PROVIDE CARE A
RENDER AID TO A PERSON- A
PRISONER THAT IS IN YOUR
CUSTODY. WHERE MANY IN THE BILL
TO CLARIFY THAT WE ARE REMOVING
THESE IMMUNITIES FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
SPECIFICALLY. LASTLY I WOULD
LIKE TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
REGARDING SECTION TO SECTION BE
TWO OF THE BANNACK AS IT
RELATES TO THE STANDARD OF
INTENT THAT IS APPLE CO TO THE
BLACK BANNACK CLAIMS. WE HAVE
OFFERED AMENDMENTS THROUGHOUT
THE WEEKEND TO ADDRESS. THE
CHAIRED. AND AT EVERY TURN.
THEY DO NOT GO FAR ENOUGHAND
HAVE BEEN REJECTED. I HAVE
COPIES OF ALL THREE. MIMIDS
THAT WE HAVE BROUGHT FORTH OVER
THE LAST. TWENTY FOUR FORTY
EIGHT HOURS I'LL BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO PROVIDE INTO EACH AND
EVERY MEMBER SO THEY CAN REVIEW
FOR THEMSELVES. WE HAVE OFFERED
MEMBERS AGAIN THROUGHOUT THE
WEEKEND THE DON'T GO FAR ENOUGH
FIRST WE HAVE TRIED TO THE
LEAKED. SOME DEFINITIONS THEN
WE BELIEVE OTHER PROVISIONS
REGARDING INTERFERENCE. THEM WE
SUGGESTED THAT THE ENTIRE SUBS
SUB DIVISION BE REMOTE THINKING
SURELY THIS WOULD BE ACCEPTED.
BUT ONCE AGAIN IT WAS ONLY
REJECTED WE HAVE OFFERED
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT NEGLIGENCE IS NOT
SUFFICIENT. IT SEEMS THE ONLY
THING THAT WOULD SATISFY THE
COMMITTEE WOULD BE TO REMOVE
THE CHANGES TO THE BAN ACT IN
ITS ENTIRETY. MEMBERS. WHY DO
BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN THEIR LIVES AND
THEIR JUSTICE. BETWEEN THEIR
HOPES AND THEIR PEACE BETWEEN
THEIR PROTECTION AND FREEDOM.
WHEN WILL BLACK PEOPLE HAVE TO
START CHOOSING BETWEEN MEETING
THEIR EXPECTATIONS OR US FOR
FILLING. OUR PROMISES. CHANGE
MUST COME TO POLICING THE
CALIFORNIA AND CHANGES NEEDED
NOW MEANING MEANINGFUL REFORM
NOT JUST SUPERFICIAL CHANGES
NIBBLING AROUND THE EDGES THE
KEEP THE STATUS QUO IN PLACE
THAT ALLOWS POLICE TO BE
ACCOUNTABLE ONLY TO THEMSELVES.
HOW MANY MORE BILL GARDNER DO
WE NEED. HOW MANY MORE STEPHON
CLARK'S DO WE NEED HOW MANY
MORE EASIER FOR TO DO WE NEED.
HOW MANY MORE DANTE. WELCOME WE
NEED HOW MANY MORE UNDER
GUARDADO'S WE NEED. MORE REGGIE
AB- ORIGINAL RODNEY KING DO WE-
HOW MANY MORE MIRAI IS TO A- I
GO ON AND ON AND ON ABOUT THE
MAN. ONE COMMON THREAD ALL THE
NAMES THAT WE CONTINUE TO
MENTION IS THAT THERE ARE BLACK
AND BROWN. I ASSURE YOU. IF MY
WHITE COLLEAGUES WILL BE KILLED
AND BRUTALIZED AT THE SAME RATE
AS POLICE OFFICERS THEY WOULD
NOT ONLY BE STANDING IN THE
STREET SANDY BONTA BROUGH
POLICE BUT THEY DEFINITELY
WOULD SAY THIS ON THE POLICE. A
RECENT SURVEY. OF OVER EIGHT
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS FOUND THAT
76% OF THOSE POLLED SUPPORT
EITHER DECERTIFYING. OR
REMOVING LEGAL IMMUNITY FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. ONLY 19%
WE'RE NOT SUPPORT OF.
CALIFORNIA DESERVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT THEY CAN TRUST
THAT WILL TREAT THEM FAIRLY.
AND WE WHAT AND WILL HOLD
ACCOUNTABLE WHEN THEY ABUSE
THAT TRUST. THIS BILL IS A
PRIORITY AS I STATED FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS IT'S A
PRIORITY FOR ME AS A BLACK MAN
WHOSE EXPERIENCE MANY OF THESE
INDIGNITIES LAW ENFORCEMENT
IT'S SUPPORTED BY A WALL OF
COMMUNITY AND GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATIONS. AND SUPPORTED BY
THOUSANDS IF NOT MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS WHO SAID ANOTHER WAS
ENOUGH IN THE WORDS OF FANNIE
LOU HAMER WE'RE SICK AND TIRED
OF BEING SICK AND TIRED. WHO
TESTIFIED IT'S OF THIS MEASURES
WILL TEACH OUR BRAVE. MOTHER OF
MORE SYRUP. BEREN AND OF STOP.
BECAUSE DOUGLAS BOARD MEMBERS
UP IN ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
WE ALSO HAVE JULIE YOU
PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL
POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY PROJECT
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD-
LET'S FIRST TURN TO- MISTER.
MISTER CARL DOUGLAS IS
AVAILABLE. YES CENTER I AM
MISTER DOUGLAS THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN-
BURKE AND OTHERS MY NAME IS
CARL DOUGLAS AND FOR FORTY ONE
YEARS HI THE REPRESENTED
CALIFORNIANS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE- BEEN INJURED DUE TO THE
WRONGFUL CONDUCT OF POLICE
OFFICERS. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
I TELL YOU FORTY ONE YEARS I'VE
BEEN DOING THIS. I HELP THEM
PUT THEIR LIVES BACK TOGETHER
AFTER THEY'VE BEEN INJURED. I
COME BEFORE YOU TODAY
ADVOCATING FOR THE ADOPTION OF
SB TWO. THIS MATTER IS A REAL
FOR ME BECAUSE I REPRESENT
CANADA LOST A THIRD MISTER ROSS
INTENSE SUDDEN A YOUNG BOY WHO
LOST HIS FATHER FAR TOO YOUNG.
THE BILL PROPOSES THREE
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE TOM BANG
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT. THE NEED FOR
EACH OF THESE CHANGES WHICH I'M
SUPPORTING WORK CREATED BY THE
COURT SYSTEM AND WE'RE NEVER
CONTEMPLATED BY TOM BAIN WHEN
THE ACT WAS FIRST PASSED IN THE
MID EIGHTIES. THE MOST
IMPORTANT OF THESE CHANGES
WOULD ADJUST THE MENTAL INTENT
REQUIREMENT NEEDED TO APPROVE A
VIOLATION OF THE ACT BRINGING
IT IN ALIGNMENT WITH FEDERAL
LAW. SO IF I WERE TO SUE A
POLICE OFFICER FOR SHOOTING AN
UNARMED BLACK MAN FOR EXAMPLE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW I HAVE TO
PROVE NOT ONLY THAT THE OFFICER
INTEND TO FIRE THE GUN WHICH IS
CALLED A GENERAL INTENT. BUT
THERE'S A SECOND LAYER OF PROOF
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE ME TO PROVE
THAT THAT SAME OFFICER ALSO
INTENDED TO VIOLATE MY CLIENT
CIVIL RIGHT. THAT IS AN ADDED
AREA THAT WE WANT TO ELIMINATE
SINCE WAS NOT IN BY THE
ORIGINAL DRAFTERS THE ACT. THE
SECOND CHANGE CORRECT THE
FUNDAMENTALLY. RESULT IN MY
EXAMPLE THAT IF THE BULLET THE
OFFICERS BY YOUR HELLO I'VE
MICHAEL LIFE. HE COULD DAMAGE.
BUT IF THAT SAID BULLET
HAPPENED TO HIM. INSTEAD OF I
HIM. UNDER THE CAR DAY ACT I
WOULD BE PER FOR FIVE A- DEATH.
ON BEHALF OF HIS FAMILY. THAT I
WAS FOR TO GO TO COURT TO
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF CAN WATER.
THE THIRD CHANGE WOULD ALLOW
SOME OF THE WHICH PREVENTS CAL.
FROM SO PUBLIC AND FOR INJURIES
AND DEATHS. OCCUR TO OCCURRING
TO PRISON OR BY TWO THANK YOU I
HAVE SO MUCH TO ADD BUT THIS IS
MY AND I THINK YOU FOR THIS. TO
YOUR SO. FOR SB TWO THANK YOU
MISTER THANK YOU MR DOUG-
MISSED. ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
THANK YOU I AM GOING MISPRINT
PLEASE GOOD MORNING INTO. CAN
YOU HEAR ME I WE CAN GO AHEAD-
OKAY GOOD MORNING THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK ON SB T.
LAW. AND TO BE HALF OF MY FOR
THE MURRAYFIELD AND THE
COUNTLESS OTHER FAMILY. THAT
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY- STATE
THEY STREET SANCTIONED VIOLENCE.
MY SON MARIE AS WE CALL THEM TO
WAS BY FIRST BORN IT WOULD
CUTTING GIVE. CORD AND HE WAS
ALSO HAD A BLACK BELT- TRAINING
WORKING COSTS FOR SELF DEFENSE.
SO MY SON WOULD NEVER GO UP
AGAINST THE COP HE WAS ALWAYS
FRIENDS WITH THEM. MY FRIEND
WAS MURDERED ON OCTOBER TENTH
HE WAS HAVING A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS. WE DON'T KNOW WHY IT
SOMEHOW HE ENDED UP ON THE I.
FIVE FREEWAY WITH IT BY A CAR.
ON THE PRINCIPLE. EVEN ACTED IT.
BUT WE HAVE BEEN FORTUNATE IS
TO- OKAY. MAXAR AND THEN MODIFY
SEATS DRIVE UP. WELL SCORECARD
TRAFFIC BREAK FROM REASON HE
APPLY FOR SEVENTY FEET AWAY
THREE SHOT ONCE IN THE ARM WENT
TO THE HEAD. CAUSING HIM TO
LOSE. MY SON WAS DONE ARE IN.
AND THE OFFICERS STATED HE'S
NOTHING ABOUT HIM. THERE WERE
NO WITH. THE RADIO DROPPED THEY
DID NOT CALL FOR BACKUP YES
CABS DOWN SECTION. AT THE TOP
OF THEIR PARTICULAR. MEANT
THREE TIMES. DINNER WAS TWENTY
SEVEN WHEN KILLED TO UP BEFORE
HIS TWENTY BIRTHDAY. THE OLDER
SISTER IN HIM HAVE SHARED THEIR
BIRTHDAY. WE HAD TO BURY MY
AUDIO ADDED DURING BIRTH. EVERY
OUR SOBRE. ARE FILLED WITH BUT
TO GET. SB TWO IS CRITICAL
BUILDING CARE OF MY APART TO
BUY. ASSEMBLY BACKED BY POLICE
VIOLENCE. EVERY TIME AND PERSON
IS LOCKED UP TO ABOUT SITTING
IN A ARE TO SAY WHEN THEY'RE
GOING TO PLEASE THE STATE I
PREFER MY LIFE WORK SIDE BY.
YOU SHOULD ARE ALMOST ALWAYS
JOKE ABOUT IT IN THE LITTLE
DOES ATTORNEYS AND OF JOE.
THERE NEVER THE ABSENCE JUST
NADIA THE FAMILIES INVOLVED
LEFT UP THE PIECE OF UP TO WIDE
HAPPENED TO THEIR LOVED. OKAY
ALL THREE LAUNCH AND THEN TURN
INTO OFFICE SHOOTING WHY
BREAKING NEWS ON IT BUT WHAT A
LOT WAIT NEARBY FOR BETTER
ALIVE. I LOOK AT THE TV. I
FOUND OUT BY SIDE BY. THE NEW.
LORD AVAILABLE THE COVER OF THE
TRUTH ABOUT WHAT TO MY PHONE
OKAY DAY AT ALL A LOT ABOUT
THEIR FAMILY DO THAT BUT- WOULD
AT THE NOW GOING ATTORNEY. WHO
DEFENDED THE UP WITH REASONABLE
RESPOND FOR BUT SHE DID NOT TO
TELL APPLICANTS WITHOUT TO ME
CHANGES TO OUR COMMUNITY THAT
HAVE BEEN FROM THE VIOLENT. THE
PARTY GENERAL DO YOU GET THE-
WE'RE HOLDING THEM. AS WELL AS
THE NEWLY TO CHECK GENERAL
BONTA. IT'S LIKE WE'RE YOU
ACCOUNTABLE ABOUT PLEASE IT
BRAVER EVENT BE TWO. YEAH
SENATOR BRADLEY SET UP WERE
ABOUT REPORTS STATE WHAT ACROSS
WOULD BE PROVIDE UP WITH. WE
DON'T WANT TO ANSWER WE WANT TO
DO. PLEASE I URGE YOU TO TALK
GET ON THE STATE LEVEL FOR THAT
THERE IS EQUITY IN
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR ANY UP WITH
WHO COMMITTEE CRIMES. SAID THEY
ARE NOT ABOUT THE LAW SB TO BE
ABLE. FOR THEIR ACTIONS.
BECAUSE OF. WE NEED TO A
CERTIFIED FOR THE- OF A PUBLIC
CHILL PARK BEACH. HAPPENED TO
YOUR LOVED IT IS BETTER TO BE
JOB THIS BAKER YOU. COULD YOU
DON'T KNOW THANK THANK YOU MISS
AND- IN I IMAGINE THE PAIN OF
YOUR LOSS WE'RE WE'RE SORRY FOR
YOUR LOSS OF. THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THE FORTITUDE AND
COURAGE TO COME FORWARD AND
MAKE SOMETHING. PERHAPS
POSITIVE FOR OTHERS FROM YOUR
LOSS SO WE WILL NOW TURN TO THE
GALLERY FOR WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. ANY WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO I
SEE NO ONE MOVE THE MICROPHONE
LET'S MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE.
I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE- WE'RE NOT GOING TO TURN
TO THE PHONES JUST AS A
REMINDER FOR THOSE ON THE
PHONE. THAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS
WE'RE GONNA TAKE FIFTEEN
MINUTES OF TESTIMONY- IN ORDER
TO ALLOW AS MANY PEOPLE AS
POSSIBLE TO PROVIDE THEIR
TESTIMONY AND ASK YOU YOUR NAME
YOUR FILIATION YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL- MADAME MODERATOR IF
WE COULD TURN THE PHONE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF. S. B. TWO YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. NINE TWO HUNDRED AND
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEP YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF CALL
ONE DID NOT WANT IT INCLUDES
ALL OF ADVOCACY HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE RECORDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA. AND A COALITION OF
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE MUSIC
SECTOR HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
MY THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OKAY JANET CALLED
FROM ANY THIRTY CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER
ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND THE TRUMP REPORT
ABOUT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE FOUR HUNDRED AND FOR YOUR
MIND OH I'M SORRY ONE TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SCHMIDTI SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF
S. YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA AND
CONCORD. THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JIM WEINBERG
ON BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION IN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWO THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
HUNDRED AND FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WILL BE ACTUALLY SHOT ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT AND
ALTHOUGH IN COURT ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE MOMENT ONE TWO HUNDRED AND
TWO. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK TWO HUNDRED AND
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOU MAY BE ON MUTE.
MOVING ON. LINE FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ELLIE- WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STOP COLLECTION
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. MY TWO HUNDRED
AND NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON OF COOKING UP ON
BEHALF OF EVERY TOWN FOR GUN
SAFETY AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE THREE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES YOUR LINE IS
OPEN OKAY- HI LARRY KING LAST
OCTOBER MY MESSAGE I THINK IN
THE CITY OF SANTA ANA- INSTRUCT
THE CLERK AT THE- THANK YOU.
NINE FOUR HUNDRED AND TEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THERE IS. FINDING WHAT. AT A
LOCAL DIRT. THE PROPER
SPONSORED RIGHT WHAT SB TWO.
THANK YOU. ONE FOUR HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALSO BE USED
AS COALITION- SAW THE POOR.
THANK YOU. NINE THREE HUNDRED
AND NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I TREATED I
THINK A MEASURE PROHIBITING
APPARENTLY. AS TRUMP THE COURT.
THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
TWENTY THREE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LOCHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS- ARE
YOU MONNING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION AGAINST
STATE SANCTIONED VIOLENCE ON
THE SUPPORT SB TWO. THANK YOU.
NINE THREE HUNDRED AND NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES HI MY NAME IS
TONYA MCKENZIE I'M A GUN
VIOLENCE SURVIVOR IMBALANCE
HERE WITH EVERY COUNTER BY
VERSION THAT WORKING MOMS
DEMAND ACTION. I AM A STRONG
SUPPORTER SB TWO THANK YOU.
NINE TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FOUR ONE MOMENT PLEASE. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ROBERT GREAT BRITAIN. I'M
ELECTED DIRECTOR OF THE
SENTENCING SCOPE AREA RAPID
TRANSIT DISTRICT. ON APRIL
TWENTY SECOND TO PULL APART
PORTANTINO TO SUPPORT SB TWO
AND WE ENCOURAGE IN YOUR
SUPPORT SENATE BILL TWO THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ONE TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. ONE TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PLAN TO FORTY
THREE YOU MAY BE A NEW PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS 30% I'M FROM WHAT POLITICAL
AND I HAVE EXPERIENCE LEAST BY
ONE MYSELF AND THAT IS WHY I A
STRONG SUPPORT A. B. SB TWO.
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
TINA MCCANN- AND I AM FROM LA
BOY I AM A STRONG SUPPORT FOR
SB TWO. THANK YOU. NINE THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE ONE THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE FOUR HUNDRED
AND ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BARBARA
DOCUMENTS ON BEHALF OF THE
BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. NINE THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS COURTNEY IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO. THANK YOU. ONE THREE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON KELOLAND ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA INDIVISIBLE STATE
STRONG COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THE NINE THREE HUNDRED
AND FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THREE
HUNDRED AND FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
DARLENE PATRICK REPRESENTING
INDIVISIBLE STANISLAUS IN
STRONG SUPPORT SB TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
TO THINK ABOUT IT. I AM ALSO
MET THERE WHO HAD TO. VERY
HELPFUL PLEASE LET ESCALATION
AND I'M HOPING YOU WILL
CONSIDER THAT FELL STRONGLY.
THANK YOU BE ABLE TO- THANK YOU.
MY TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS EBONY ABRAM. CALLING ON
BEHALF OF LA BOYS. IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB TWO. THANK THANK
YOU. NINE THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHT PM YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE EIGHT
EIGHT NEGATIVE. MY NAME IS
VICTOR BY ABOUT EIGHT.
CORRECTED COMMUNITY ORGANIZER
FROM THE CITY OF HUNTINGTON
BEACH. AND I AM IN FULL SUPPORT
OF S. B. TWO THANK GOD I HAVE A
SPORTY IN REGARDS OF THANK YOU
SIR. THE BILL THANK THANK YOU
SIR. ONE THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI WHICH IS
GREAT BUT OUR INPUT AND- WE ARE
CLOSED. THE BILL AND GET BOTH
AND I AM ALSO CALLING. EIGHT
THE ANSWER PUBLIC. OPTICAL
BURGEONING. THANK YOU. NINE TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE
ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT THE
ATTY. YOU KNOW THE. TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY NINE HUNDRED AND NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WHEN MOMENT
PLEASE. THINK ABOUT WHAT. MY
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN
FOR AS POLICE CHIEF IN THE PAST
AND POLICE DEPARTMENT. EXACTLY
EXACTLY BOARD MEMBER CALIFORNIA
PLEASE USE OUR MEMBERS AND WE
SUPPORT DECERTIFICATIONBUT I
DON'T SUPPORT THE CURRENT
STRUCTURE OF SB TWO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR HUNDRED
AND FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS JOHN
GROGAN SHE POINTS. COMMENT.
TWENTY ONE. OF COURSE OKAY
AWESOME GLOBAL WARMING
INCINERATOR MATAMATA WE SEEM TO
HAVE SOME CONNECTION DIFFICULTY
NEXT CALL PLEASE. ONE MOMENT.
THANK TO SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
IS LIBBY SOLOMON FROM THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OF ORANGE
COUNTY AND WESTERN VICE CHAIR
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE
THREE HUNDRED AND FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY TO EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS A CLEAR. I'M A GUN
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS AND
VOLUNTEER WITH EVERYTOWN
SURVIVOR NETWORK A MONTH DEMAND
ACTION CALLING IN SUPPORT SB
TWO. THANK YOU. NINE TO SIXTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE MOMENT. NINE THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD HI MY NAME
MY NAME IS FORREST ADAM
RECEIVED APART AND- MEMBER THE
CAL KELP IS DISASSOCIATION AND
I SUPPORT BUT OCCASIONALLY-
HELLO THAT IS. THANK YOU THIS
IS FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. TWO. RIGHT IT'S CALL
PLEASE. NINE THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME I'M
ATTENDED ON BOTH OF THEM YAKA
YAKA WHO IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN FIVE OCTOBER THE PARK.
I'M ALSO A BLACKBOARD I'M I DID
IN THE MID NOT COALITION I'M
ACCOUNTABLE AT. TWO THANK YOU.
MY FOR HER AND FIFTY THREE LINE
IS A PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
HELLO. I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE- OPEN PRIVACY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF. SB TWO THANK YOU.
NINE FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BUT CERTAIN MEMBERS
OF. I FUNDING IS AT THE END OF
POLLUTION SHOP FOR THANK. THANK
YOU FIND FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS RYAN CARL GOT
I'M A RESIDENT OF SAN DIEGO AND
I URGE YOU TO DO THE RIGHT
THING AND REPORT SB TWO. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MY AND TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS ANTHONY YEN- I AM
A CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND I AM
WAS. ENDING CORPORATE ADMITTED
PROJECT PARTNER ABOUT THE
CLASSROOMS- GRASSROOTS PROJECT
I STRONGLY SUPPORTED THE ENDING
OF I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB TWO
AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SB
TWO AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. NINE ONE NINETY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
TWENTY FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING SANDERS WITH. HAPPEN
MARTINEZ WOULD BE AND THEN
QUALIFIED IMMUNITY PROJECT AND
WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO DO THE
RIGHT THING TODAY. AND VOTE YES
ON SB BILL TO DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT OF THE
THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR HUNDRED
AND THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MINOR HONOR. DELCOURT THE
GIFFORD FOUGHT HARD TO PREVENT
GUN VIOLENCE. THANK YOU. MY TWO
HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE THREE FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS THAT A MODERATE- I
HAVE BEEN A MODERATOR WEEK
WE'VE NOT GONE BEYOND FIFTEEN
MINUTES WILL TAKE TWO MORE.
COLORS BUT THOSE ARE ON THE
PHONE SHOULD KNOW THAT. WE
WILL- WILL ACCEPT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY OR ANY WRITTEN
MATERIAL IF YOU GO TO OUR
WEBSITE YOU'LL SEE HOW TO
SUBMIT THAT SO MANY MODERATE
LET'S TAKE TWO MORE CALLS.
THANK YOU ONE THREE FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE FOUR HUNDRED AND
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE MILITARY BACK ON
WE HAVE A COMMUNITY. JUSTIN
O'CONNOR IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR HUNDRED
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WELL. FOR ALL. AB SO
NINE. YEAH THANK YOU MA'AM ALL
RIGHT WE'RE WE'RE NOT GOING TO
TURN TO OPPOSITION- I BELIEVE
THERE'S TWO PRINCIPAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION MISTER DAVID
MISTAKE ME AND MR JONATHON
FELDMAN THIS MISTAKE ME ARE YOU
AVAILABLE. YES SIR ALL RIGHT
MISMAS TECHNIQUE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU SENATORS FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK BEFORE YOU TODAY I
DO WANT TO I I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF IRAQ AND I DO WANT TO
REITERATE- WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER FELDMAN IS GONNA ALSO
SAY AND THAT IS THAT. WE
SUPPORT A LICENSE THE
CERTIFICATION REGIME.
UNFORTUNATELY SB TWO FAILS
BASIC DUE PROCESS REQUIREMENTS
FOR THAT I KNOW THAT'S NOT WHY
WE'RE HERE TODAY SO I'M GOING
TO FOCUS MY COMMENTS ON THE
BANE ACT BUT I AM HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN ANY QUESTIONS
REGARDING THE LICENSING ASPECT.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
THE BAN ACT IS A STATUTE THAT
WAS INTENDED TO ADDRESS HATE
CRIMES BY PROVIDING ENHANCED
LIABILITY. MEETING ATTORNEY
FEES WITH MULTIPLIERS STATUTORY
DAMAGES INJUNCTIVE RELIEF AND
EVEN CRIMINAL. SANCTIONS IN
SOME CIRCUMSTANCES FOR
INTENTIONAL VIOLATIONS OF CIVIL
RIGHTS. THERE IS NO QUALIFIED
IMMUNITY THAT IS AVAILABLE TO
PEACE OFFICERS UNDER CALIFORNIA
LAW OR THE BAN ACT AS IT STANDS
TODAY. THE MAIN ACT IS NOT A
GENERAL TORT LIABILITY STATUTE
BUT RATHER IS TO ADDRESS
SPECIFIC PROBLEMS THERE ARE
OTHER REMEDIES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE FOR CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT DON'T NEED THAT.
UNDERSTANDABLY HIGHER
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE PAIN ACT
THERE'S BACK. ASSAULT
NEGLIGENCE INTENTIONAL
INFLICTION OF EMOTIONAL
DISTRESS AND EVEN WRONGFUL
DEATH CLAIMS THEY'RE AVAILABLE
UNDER GENERAL TORT LAW IN
CALIFORNIA THE NINTH CIRCUIT
RECENTLY IN A CASE CALLED THE
BEARS VERSUS HUNTINGTON BEACH.
ISSUED A PUBLISHED DECISION
RECOGNIZING THAT GENERAL
NEGLIGENCE CAN PROVIDE RELIEF
BEYOND THE PAIN ACT AND EVEN
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE IN
EXCESSIVE FORCE CASES. THIS
BILL WOULD ALSO AFFECT NOT JUST
LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT ALL PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES IN CALIFORNIA. IN
FACT MANY OF THE CASES UNDER
THE BAN ACT INVOLVED TEACHERS
AND SOCIAL WORKERS THERE'S
PUBLISHED CASES INVOLVING BAY
NOT CLAIMS AGAINST DANGEROUS
YOU MISTER MILLER AG IF YOU'D
WRAP IT UP. YES FOR VIOLATING
EQUAL ACCESS UNDER THE ADA FOR
REFUSING TO KEEP THAT CHILDREN
AND NOT FREE ENVIRONMENT
ANYTIME BANKING THANK YOU MR
MUSEVENI. WE'RE GONNA NOW TURN
TO MR FELTMAN MR FELDMAN ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. YES SIR HI
MISTER FILMON GO HEAD. J.
MEMBERS JONATHAN FELDMAN ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION I WANT TO
START BY SAYING THAT EPCA
EMPATHIZES WITH ANYONE WHO'S
LOST A LOVED ONE AND FULLY
SUPPORTS A DEEPER CERTIFICATION
SYSTEM THAT PERMANENTLY REMOVES
OFFICERS GUILTY OF SEARCH
MCCARTY MISCONDUCT. INCLUDING
EXCESSIVE FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT
THAT'S ON YOUR. RACIAL BIAS.
WE'LL GET A RADICALLY HOWEVER
WE ARE OPPOSED SB. WHICH NOT
ONLY CAN TRAIN I LIKE GAME BUT
SWEEPING CHANGES TO CIVIL.
EXPOSURE AND BAN ACT. WHICH OF
THE COMMITTEES DRASTIC ALTHOUGH
THEIR- AS WE TO MAKE SURE MAJOR
CHAIN TO THE BAY ACT. THE STATE
FROM SPECIFIC AND TO J. OKAY.
IT INTRODUCE ON PRODUCT CLAIMS
AND THE BANNER AND IT'LL ST
DAYTON. ARE THE FIRST TWO ARE
THE- PHONE WORKING. ALL TARGET
I CALL THERE AND THE GENERAL
FAN MSP TO IT ONLY NEEDS TO BE
PROVEN A PERSON. TO ACT NOW THE
BANK TO BUY THE RIGHTS OF
ANOTHER. OR DID SO. OR DELIVER.
THIS IS CAN GIVEN THE FACT THAT
WE OFTEN TASK PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
POLICE OFFICERS SOCIAL WORKERS
TEACHERS. JOBS AT OCCASIONALLY
PLACEMENT SITUATIONS OR CHOIR
THAN TO TAKE ACTIONS. THAT MAY
HAVE BRIDGE A PERSON'S RIGHT.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO SEND SHOW
WAS BY. WE NEED PROOF
INDIVIDUAL EITHER I TO LIVE.
RECKLESSLY OR WITH THE INTENT
TO VIOLATE THE RIGHTS. OF
STANDARD OF GENERAL INTENT AS
IN SB TWO FORTIES OPPOSITE
OTHER PUBLIC EMPLOYEES TO AN
UNTENABLE STANDARD.
ADDITIONALLY BY PLACING
WRONGFUL DEATH LIABILITY INTO
THE BAND ACT WE WILL SEE THOSE
CASES. WHICH ARE NOW THAT WITH
IN FEDERAL COURT MOVE INTO
STATE COURT. THIS IS
SIGNIFICANT. THERE IS NO
QUALIFIED IMMUNITY IN STATE
COURT. AS TWO THEREFORE THANK
LOW. AND DOES NOT ACCOUNT. FOR
OFFICERS ACTUAL INTENT OR
RECKLESS DECISION AND
EFFECTIVELY ELIMINATE QUALIFIED
IMMUNITY IN WRONGFUL DEATH
CASES. THESE ARE MONUMENTAL
CHANGES. IT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THE BAN ACT AS MY
COLLEAGUE STATED- IS NOT THE
ONLY- STATUTE. THAT SOMEONE CAN
FILE UNDER FOR LEGAL REMEDY IN
THESE CASES AND INVESTED-
SEVERAL. STANDARD VERY UNDER
EACH OF NEW STATUTES THAT ALLOW
FOR ACCOUNTABILITY. HOWEVER THE
STANDARD IN THE BAND ACT
REQUIRES PROOF OF INTENT
BECAUSE REMEDIES INCLUDE. THE
SEVERE FINES AND OTHER PUNITIVE
DAMAGES ATTORNEYS FEES XRF.
ANYTIME BETWEEN THE LONG COULD
BE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. THANK
YOU MANY PEOPLE THAN OTHERS AND
SPENT THE LAST WEEK DID RATTLE
IN CLOSING CBCA HAS. YES SORRY
SIR. HE WAS HIT BY THE LAST
WEEK TRYING TO NEGOTIATE A
COMPROMISE UNFORTUNATELY WE'VE
NOT SEEN LANGUAGE. ALTHOUGH IT
DIDN'T MAKE IT REMOVED I DON'T
THINK I MISS ENTITLEMENT. AT
THANK YOU. THANK AYE SIR. ALL
RIGHT. FOR NOW GOING TO TURN
TO- ANY IN THE GALLERY WHO THE
TEST. IN OP. TO S. B. TWO. A NO
ONE MOVE THE MICHAEL. WILL TURN
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. I SEE NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE- NOW WE
WILL TURN TO THE PHONES- AS-
YOU RECALL.WE PROVIDED FIFTEEN
MINUTES TO SUPPORT ACTUAL MORE
BUT WILL ALSO PROVIDE FIFTEEN
MINUTES TO OPPOSITE MAX OF
FIFTY MINUTES OPPOSITION. SO MR
OR MADAM MODERATOR- IS THERE
ANYONE THE PHONE. QUESTION IN
OPPOSITION TO SPEAK TO. YES
THERE ARE ALRIGHT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER IF YOU
LIKE YOU CAN OPPOSITION ALL
RIGHT SO FOR THOSE ON THE PHONE
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION YOUR
NAME YOUR- AND YOUR POSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. LOCALI NUMBER FOUR FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. WE
MISS EACH OTHER MEMBERS RYAN
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION. SANTA
ANA POLICE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
HELD FORTY POINTS OFFICERS BOTH
PATIENT AND LOS ANGELES SCHOOL
POLICE LOCATION ALL. IN
OPPOSITION. TO NEXT ABOUT A
LINE NUMBER FOUR TWO FOR YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. MISTER TERRY
MEMBERS THE FOURTEENTH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. NINE FOUR EIGHTY YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS NAMELY
PETRONE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TAXI TO
THANK YOU. THANK ONE FOUR FOUR
FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRIS THOUGHT IT OFF ON BEHALF
OF PUBLIC RISK INNOVATION
SOLUTIONS AND MANAGEMENT OFTEN
ENOUGH TO PUT THEM IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
ONE FOUR SEVEN SIX YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE THIS IS STEVE WALKING
THE CHIEF OF POLICE OF EUREKA
CALIFORNIA AND A MEMBER OF THE
CALYCES DISSOCIATION BOARD- I
DON'T EVEN KNOW I SUPPORT. THE
CERTIFICATION BUT I AM OPPOSED
SB TO IT. THANK YOU. ONE FOUR
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MATTHEW STYLING ON THE
HAPPINESS OF THE ASIAN FOR LOS
ANGELES DEPUTY SHERIFFS
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
Q. ONE FOUR FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS DAVE OVER POLICE CHIEF
OF MONTEREY MEMBER OF C. PCA.
SUPPORT DECERTIFICATION BUT I'M
OPPOSED TO SB TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONE FOUR SEVENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME SHE- MORGAN CAL THE
DEPARTMENT AND NUMBER. I
SUPPORTER. AND OPPOSED TO EACH
YEAR THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE
TWO ZERO THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS GOOD
AFTERNOON AUDIBLE SENATORS MY
NAME IS ELIZABETH WITH THE
SANTA ANA POLICE DEPARTMENT
REPRESENTING CHIEF POLICE.
WHILE WE SUPPORT THE
CERTIFICATION BUT WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE TO
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALL MY WAS
DIRECTOR ABEL CHIEF OF POLICE
FOR THE MANHATTAN BEACH POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION BOARD HI SO.
I SUPPORT THE CERTIFICATION BUT
I'M OPPOSED TO SENATE BILL TWO
AND IT'S FOR THANK YOU THANK
YOU. MY TWO HUNDRED YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. THE GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS CALLED LESSEN THE
POLICE CHIEF FOR THE CITY OF
GLENDALE. AND A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION. I ALSO SEE THE
CERTIFICATION BUT I'M OPPOSE TO
S. B. AN A.
FORMAT. HELLO MY
NAME IS ERIC UNIONISM AGREES TO
PROMOTE ELEMENTOS POLICE
DEPARTMENT THE MEDIA AFTER. OF
THE CAL POLICE TO OF. I SUPPORT
THE CERTIFICATION MINIMUM. TO
HAS. TWO THANK YOU. THE BLIND
TO WE YEAR IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY IS PAUL SMART THE
ON THE PLEA CHIEF. CITY OF
CARMEL BY THE SEA A MEMBER OF
THE A- OR DO YOU. BUT I AM A PO
TO AT THE- THANK YOU. ONE FOR A
ONE LINE OF THE. FOUR EIGHTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS HEARING
READ REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HIGHWAY
PATROLMEN WE SUPPORT THE
CERTIFICATION BUT NOT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. ONE FOUR FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS JOSH CELLS WORK
PLEASE CHIEF FOR THE CITY
BISHOP A NUMBER OF- CAL PLEASE
JESUS. SUPPORT THE SORT OF BUT
OPPOSE SB TWO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE TO YEAR LIGHTED UP
HELLO MY NAME JIM HANSON CHIEF
OTHER HIGH SPRINGS OF THE PC I
SUPPORT THE STEVE BUT I'M UP.
TO TWO THANK YOU. NINE TWO SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE TWO
SIXTY LINE ITSELF. IF YOUR MIND
IS NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR
YOU. MOVING ON TO MY TO NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NME IS RICK HELLMAN POLICE
CHIEF FOR THE CITY OF FOLSOM
BOARD MEMBER OF C. PCA AND
PRESIDENT OF THE CENTRAL SIERRA
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION I
SUPPORT THE CERTIFICATION BUT
I'M OPPOSED TO SENATE BILL TWO.
THANK YOU. LINE TWO THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME'S BRIDGET KITCHEN HOW THE
POLICE CHIEF OF THE DA'S POWER
WHICH DEPARTMENT AND A MEMBER
OF C. PCA I SUPPORT THE
CERTIFICATION BUT I'M OPPOSED
TO SB TWO. THANK YOU. ONE FOUR
OH SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS PAT
NIKOLAI POLICE CHIEF FOR THE
CITY OF SANTA CLARA AND MEMBER
OF S. C. P. C. A. WHILE I
SUPPORT THE CERTIFICATION I AM
OPPOSED AS B. TWO. THANK YOU.
ONE FOUR FOUR ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO STRUGGLED. PLEASE
FOR THE CITY OF CURRENT. NCPC
MEMBER. I SUPPORT
DECERTIFICATION BUT IN THE POST
S. TO HAVE SUBMITTED THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONE THREE ZERO FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE OH FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IF YOUR MIND
IS MUTED OR UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
HOLDING ONTO ONE TWO FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS MATT EGAN POLICE CHIEF
OF GLENDORA POLICE DEPARTMENT
AND MEMBER OF CAL CHIEFS
SUPPORT DECERTIFICATION BUT
RESPECTFULLY I AM OPPOSED TO SB
TWO. THANK YOU. NINE TWO TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S MIKE
HOFFMAN I'M ASSISTANT SPECIAL
AGENT IN CHARGE OF THE ATF LOS
ANGELES. I SUPPORT
DECERTIFICATION BUT I AM
OPPOSED TO S. B. TWO. THANK YOU.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN
MUNCIE POLICE CHIEF THE TOWN
HALL AND MEMBERS CP. I SUPPORT
DE SER BUT I'M OPPOSE TO AS TWO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU. NINE TWO TWO TWO YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
SCOTT. PLEASE KEEP THE CITY
VOEPEL A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS. I
SAID. IT BUT MOST VOTE TO THANK
YOU. THANK LIKE ONE EIGHTY YEAR
IS THE- HELLO MY NAME IS ABDUL.
THANK BUT HE SIDE AND PRESIDENT
OF THE CAL PLEASE IS A- I AM-
THE AFTER SUPPORT BE SORT OF.
BUT I'M A CO TO IT. THANK THANK
YOU. ONE TWO FORTY YOUR LINE IS
NOW A. ONE TWO FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME.
WE CAN GREAT THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ROB ANNA
KENNEDY ON THE CHEAP THE TRULY
TO PLEASE PART AND OF THE STATE
DIEGO CA SHE ASSOCIATION I HOLE
HARD SUPPORT PETER. BUT I
OPPOSED TO AT TWO AS THANK YOU.
ONE TO THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. YEAH MY NAME IS DAMON
WASSON CHIEF OF POLICE FOR THE
CITY OF SOLAR THAT IN MONTEREY
COUNTY MEMBER OF CPC EIGHT I
SUPPORT THE CERTIFICATION BUT
OPPOSE SB TWO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NINE TWO ZERO ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. RIMINI IS STILL
GONNA CHECK POLICE CHIEF FOR
THE CITY IS STILL BEACH IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND MEMBER OF
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE. A SPORTY
CERTIFICATION BUT IMPOSED TO
SEND A BILL TO AS PROPOSED NEXT.
THANK YOU. WHY DON'T NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS NW OPEN. ONE
ONE NINE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THEY REMOVE THEMSELVES FROM Q.
WILL ONE TO ONE TO THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RUBEN
TRAVIS SERVER CHIEF OF POLICE
THE CITY OF. AND I'M A OF THE
PCA. I SUPPORT SERVER CARE BUT
I STRONGLY OPPOSE AS TWO AS
WRITTEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BLANK TWO TWO ZERO ONE IS OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS KEITH VOID ON
THE POLICE CHIEF. IN KINGS. I
REMEMBER OF C. B. C. A. IN I
SUPPORT THE SORT OF. BUT A AT
TWO ASPIRIN. THANK YOU. NINE
TWO THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. JUST CANCEL IT OKAY CHIEF
CITY OF PETALUMA AND MEMBER OF
POLICE TO ASSOCIATION I SAID DE
SER. BUT OPPOSE SB TWO AS A
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE TWO
EIGHT YEAR LINE IS NOW. ONE TWO
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IF
YOUR LINE IS NEEDED WERE UNABLE
TO HEAR YOU. WE CAN'T. BY THE
COULD YOU. FOR WEBER WE'LL GET.
I SUPPORT EIGHT BUT I OPPOSE IT
BECAUSE READ. THANK YOU. BY TWO
FORTY SIX ZERO THAT WILL. DAVID.
KEEP AN EYE OUT OF NUMBER OF.
WORK AND A MEMBER OF THE PTA I
SUPPORT DO YOU TO CERTIFICATION
BUT I'M OPPOSED TO S. B. TWO
AND ITS CURRENT FORM THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MY TO FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. NINE TWO FOUR
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HE SINCE.
YOUR MIND IS NEEDED ONE ABLE TO
HEAR YOU. BALANTA LINE ONE
NINETY FIVE THE LINE IS NOW
OPEN. ONE ONE NINETY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IF YOU WANTED ME
TO WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
BERMAN BONTA MY NUMBER TWO
TWENTY FIVE LINE TO TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. TWO
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BERMAN BONTA MY NUMBER THREE
ZERO EIGHT THREE OH EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHEN MEMBERS EARLY START FOR
THE ACCOUNT- WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. LINE FOR FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CORY SAYS
HELLO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE THREE TEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO ASSISTANT CHIEF
PAUL CONNELLY ON BEHALF OF
POLICE AS CHIEF OF POLICE DAVID
KNOWS LIKE THE SAN DIEGO POLICE
DEPARTMENT WE SUPPORT
DECERTIFICATION BUT OPPOSE SB
TWO AS WRITTEN. THANK YOU. ONE
FOUR TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HELLO THIS IS ROBERT
KAREM REPRESENTING POLICE CHIEF
TROY BURKE FROM OF THE CITY OF
ROSEVILLE AND MEMBER OF C. PCA
WE SUPPORT THE CERTIFICATION
BUT OPPOSE SB TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ONE FOUR EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DILUTION
HERE ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES
POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE GET
THE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION OF SAN
DIEGO AND SAN FRANCISCO POLICE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OP
REGRETTABLY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE CURRENT VERSION OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. A NINE
THREE FIFTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THREE FIVE TWO YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. IF YOUR MIND IS
NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
WILL MOVE ON TO MY NUMBER FOUR
NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN OF BATTLE
CHIEF OF POLICE FOR THE
PACIFICA POLICE DEPARTMENT AND
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE. I SUPPORT THE
CERTIFICATION BUT I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO SB TWO.
THANK YOU- I'M NOT A MODERATOR
WE'VE NOW REACHED FIFTEEN
MINUTES SO TWO MORE CALLS.
THANK YOU SIR RIGHT TO EIGHTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SURE
MEMBERS SAYING LEVINE ABOUT THE
LONG BEACH POLICE OFFICERS
STATIONED THE SENSATION ARMS
COUNTY DEPUTY SHERIFFS SURE
SIMPLY BENEFIT ASSOCIATION SAN
MARINO COUNTY CALPERS STATEWIDE
LAW ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA KERNEL OR POLICE
SACRAMENTO DEPUTY SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION. ALL OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. LAST CALL. ONE FOUR
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS ROGER
HANSON POLICE CHIEF POLICE
CHIEF IN THE CITY OF SAN BRUNO
NUMBER OF C. PCA I ALSO SUPPORT
DECERTIFICATION BUT I'M OPPOSED
SB TWO IN ITS CURRENT FORMAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT-
THAT ENDS THE CALLERS ON THE
PHONE IN OPPOSITION. I WILL NOW
BRING IT BACK TO THE FLOOR I
SEE SENATOR RUSSELL AND I SEE
CENTER BOARD JUST SENATOR
RUSSELL. I SEE CENTER WIENER IN
CENTER HERTZBERG. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I'D LIKE TO MOVE
THE BILL WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE.
AND UP I ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE- AUTHOR OF THE BILL WHO
WORKS VERY VERY HARD. TO TRY TO
REFORM OUR POLICE SYSTEM.
BECAUSE WE DO NEED TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY. WE ALL HAVE
RESPECT AND APPRECIATION FOR
THE MAJORITY OF POLICE OFFICERS
THAT DO SERVE HONORABLY AND
THEY PUT THEIR LIVES AT RISK.
AT THE SAME TIME WE SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO CHOOSE. OVER THE
DISPARITIES THAT EXIST WITHIN
OUR SYSTEM. BLACK AND LATINO
COMMUNITIES FACE A POLICING AND
JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT SIMPLY DOES
NOT TREAT THEM FAIRLY TREAT US
FAIRLY. WE MUST TAKE ACTIONS TO
BEGIN THE PROCESS OF RESTORING
TRUST WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES THAT OPERATE WITHIN
THEM. ADDRESSING THE INJUSTICES
WITHIN OUR SYSTEM SHOULD NOT BE
A POLITICAL ISSUE IT SHOULD NOT
BE A BLACK ISSUE OR LATINO
ISSUE. WHAT ARE POLICING SYSTEM
HARMS INDIVIDUALS BECAUSE OF
THE COLOR OF OUR SKIN THAT
SHOULD MATTER TO ALL OF US. A
CULTURE OF POLICING IN THIS
COUNTRY MUST CHANGE. SB TWO IS
A NECESSARYSTEP TO MAKE SURE
THE INSTITUTIONS RESPONSIBLE
FOR EVERYDAY RIGHTS OF OUR
SAFETY ARE ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE. WITHOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND WITHOUT
TRANSPARENCY WE CANNOT REBUILD
THE PROCESS OF TRUST. WE SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
SUPPORTING OUR COMMUNITIES OR
LAW ENFORCEMENT THIS I NOT AN
US VERSUS DIVIDE WE WANT TO
CREATE THE SYSTEMS IN PLACE TO
MAKE OUR OMMUNITY SAFER. AND
FIND COMMON GROUND. AND WITH
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES I
URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU SENATOR
ALSO SIR BORDERS. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A
VERY CHARGED ISSUE OF FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR FRANKLY OUR
NATION. BUT I WANT TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT WE. WE LOOK AT
THIS- WITH THE SOBRE APPROACH
AND MAKE CERTAIN THAT- WE ARE
CREATING THE BEST POLICY TO
ADDRESS THE COMPELLING IS THAT
WE HAVE- WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES. I THINK WE'VE
HEARD THAT- FROM SOME OF THE
COLORS THAT EVEN THE POLICE
FORCE LAW ENFORCEMENT FORCE- IT
IS OPEN TO DECERTIFICATION SO I
KNOW IT SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S A
WILLINGNESS. TO ADJUST TO SOME
OF THE CHANGES THAT ARE NEEDED.
ALL OF THE CONCERNS THAT I HAVE
ABOUT THIS IS THAT THIS.
COMMISSION AND FORGIVE ME I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE BEEN ANY
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN ADOPTED OR PUT FORWARD. ON
MAKE CERTAIN THAT MY COMMENTS
ARE UP TO DATE. I'M NOT AWARE
OF ANY BUT THAT THIS COMMISSION
WOULD BE. SUPERIOR TO POST. AND
I THINK WHEN THE AUTHOR OPENED
UP WITH HIS COMMENTS HE TALKED
ABOUT THE ACCREDITING BODIES
WHETHER BEING THE BAR
ASSOCIATION OR THE MEDICAL
BOARDS THAT'S ACTUALLY ACCURATE
INDIVIDUAL LAWYERS AND DOCTORS
CAN HAVE THEIR LICENSES REMOVED
FOR MISCONDUCT AND THAT'S
ENTIRELY APPROPRIATE. THERE'S
BAD APPLES IN EVERY SINGLE
PROFESSION NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. I THINK ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE HERE IS
THAT THE COMMISSION THOUGH IT
IS. GOING TO BE SUPERIOR TO
POST. AND THAT. THE MAJORITY OF
THE MEMBERS ON THIS COMMISSION
COULD BE MADE UP OF INDIVIDUALS
BUT DO NOT HAVE A BACKGROUND IN
THE FIELD WEATHER- MY
UNDERSTANDING THERE'S TWO
INDIVIDUALS FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT POLICE TO FROM
ACADEMIA. AND THE REST MIGHT BE
MADE UP OF OTHER APPOINTEES
INCLUDING THOSE AGGRIEVED BY
POLICE MISCONDUCT FOR TOTAL I
THINK OF NINE. BUT IF WE WERE
TO ADD UP THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE MANDATED TO HAVE A
BACKGROUND IN POLICE REFORM OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE. IT WOULD BE A
MINORITY. ON THE BOARD. AND SO.
THE CRITERIA THAT I'M LOOKING
AT HERE. IS TERRIBLY BROAD AND
IF I MAY SHARE REFERS SOME OF
THE PROVISIONS. IN THIS BILL IN
POINT MY EYES ARE GOING EXCUSE
ME- IS IT. GROUNDS FOR REMOVAL-
DECERTIFICATION WOULD BE ACTS
OF DISHONESTY. WE HAVE. ZACKS
DEMONSTRATING BIAS- BASED ON
RELIGION OR GENDER IDENTITY.
AND FELIZ KINDA GOES ON BUT I
DON'T THINK I UNDERSTAND THE
RATIONALE FOR MAKING THIS
COMMISSION SUPERIOR. TO POST.
WOULD IT NOT MAKE MORE SENSE
FOR THE COMMISSION TO OFFER
RECOMMENDATIONS TO POST. AND IT
MAY BE RE CALIBRATE HELP POST.
IS DETERMINING WHETHER NOT
INDIVIDUAL OFFICERS BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE WITH IT IF THEY
LOSE THEIR CERTIFICATION OR OR
NOT. BUT I'M LOOKING AT WHAT I
THINK IS. ATTENTIONAL
ACCOUNTABILITY INSTITUTIONS FOR
EXAMPLE YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
INTERNAL AFFAIRS. YOU COULD
POSSIBLY HAVE THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE FOR
MISCONDUCT. IF YOU HAPPEN TO BE
LIVING IN A CITY OR
MUNICIPALITY OR A COUNTY THAT
HAS A POLICE AUDITOR. THAT'S
NUMBER THREE AND NOW THIS COULD
BE FOR SO POLICE OFFICER COULD
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE BY FOUR
SEPARATE ENTITIES- WHICH I
THINK MIGHT BE A BIT MUCH. BUT
ULTIMATELY. I WOULD THINK THAT
IF LAW ENFORCEMENT IS WILLING
TO DISCUSS THIS FURTHER THE
DECERTIFICATION ISSUE THAT
MAYBE IT WOULD BE WORSE
CONTINUING THESE CONVERSATIONS
SEE WHAT COMMON GROUND COULD
EXIST. I AM I IMAGINE YOU'VE
MADE THOSE OVERTURES- BUT
ULTIMATELY IT MY CONCERN IS
THAT A COMMISSION LIKE THIS
SHOULD NOT BE SUPERIOR. FIVE TO
POST AND HOURS AGO ALONG WITH
THAT I THINK COULD BE DANGEROUS
ESPECIALLY MADE UP OF
INDIVIDUALS A MAJORITY OF WHICH
MIGHT NOT BE MINE I HAVE A
BACKGROUND IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
AND I BELIEVE THE LAWYERS AND
THE DOCTORS THAT WOULD REVIEW-
CERTIFICATION ISSUES AT THEIR
LEVEL OUR HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
BACKGROUND IN. LAW OR MEDICINE.
BUT THOSE ARE JUST SO MY
COMMENTS SHARE AND I'LL LEAVE
IT UP TO THE AUTHOR IF YOU WANT
TO COMMENT. ON THOSE IN HIS
CLOSING OR WHENEVER HE SEES FIT.
SENATE CENTER BRADFORD WOULD
LIKE TO RESPOND NOW IN YOUR
CLOTHES HOW DO TO MICHAEL'S ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU- ALL RIGHT OF
CENTER WIENER. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- I SUPPORT SB TWO AND
I'M PROUD TO CO AUTHOR AND I
REALLY WANT TO THANK. THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS PERSISTENCE AND
I HAVE TO THIS- BILL IN ITS
PREVIOUS FORM- FALTERED DURING
THE TUMULTUOUS END OF SESSION.
LAST YEAR FOR REGROUPING AND
COMING BACK WITH ANOTHER STRONG-
WITH ANOTHER STRONG BILL ON
MIKE. COME WITH THIS I MAY HAVE
A- BUT NOW THE- ATTORNEY
GENERAL BONTA IS NOT IN THE
LEGISLATURE ANYMORE I MAY BE
THE ONLY MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND MIGHT BE WRONG
BUT I THINK I MIGHT BE THE ONLY
NUMBER WHO IS ACTUALLY
LITIGATED- THESE CASES ARE BOTH
UNDER THE MAIN ACT AND UNDER
SECTION NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE
MR BONTA NEVER COLLEAGUES IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO CITY
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE TOGETHER ON
THE SAME. TEAM HANDLING THESE
AND OTHER CASES. AND SO I HAVE.
HANDLED THESE CLAIMS BOTH
FEDERAL AND- STATE CLAIMS IN
FEDERAL DISTRICT COURT IN
SUPERIOR COURT. ON APPEAL. AND
SO FORTH AND I'VE SEEN THE GOOD
THE BAD. AND THE UGLY. AND THE
CHALLENGE YOU KNOW AND LOOK AT
THE BIG PICTURE- WHEN MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. HAVE A
PERCEPTION I AM PARTICULARLY
WHEN THAT PERCEPTION IS
COMPLETELY JUSTIFIED THE POLICE
OFFICERS CAN ACT WITH IMPUNITY
AND THIS IS NOT THE BROAD BRUSH
ALL OFFICERS BUT THAT POLICE
OFFICERS- WHO HARM PEOPLE AND
WHO VIOLATE THE LAW CAN DO SO
WITH IMPUNITY. THAT IS SO
DAMAGING. THIRD TO THE SYSTEM
IS SO DAMAGING TO THE ABILITY
TO HAVE EFFECTIVE POLICING OF
PEOPLE THANK AN OFFICER CAN DO
WHATEVER THEY WANT. WITH
IMPUNITY- THIS BILL HELPS TO
ADDRESS THAT WE'VE SEEN AT
LEAST A SHIFT ON THE CRIMINAL
SYSTEM WE SAW WITH THE
CONVICTION OF DRUG SHOP IN A
FEW WEEKS AGO HAVING SOME LEVEL
OF ACCOUNTABILITY. THERE HI
THIS BILL ADDRESSES IT IN THE
BOOK THE DECERTIFICATION. BOB
PERSPECTIVE. IN TERMS OF THE
OUTRAGEOUS NO SEVEN OFFICER
JUST BEING ABLE TO RESIGN IN
THE MIDDLE OF INVESTIGATION GO-
WORK FOR ANOTHER AGENCY AND
FINALLY SAYING NO THERE'S SOME
OFFICERS WHO NEED TO BE
CERTIFIED AND SHOULD NEVER
WORKERS OFFICERS AGAIN. AND
THEN THE PIECE THAT IS UNDER
THE JURISDICTION OF THIS
COMMITTEE OF CIVIL LIABILITY-
AT THE IDEA OF A CALIFORNIA
SHOULD HAVE A CIVIL RIGHTS LAW
THAT IS ACTUALLY A CIVIL RIGHTS
LAW. AND THAT IS NOT A TEST TO
BE FRANK HERE THE HOT MESS BUT
THE BEING ACT IS IN TERMS OF
HOW IT'S DRAFTED AND HOW COURTS
HAVE INTERPRETED. BY AND WHAT I
LEARNED DURING MY YEARS AND
YEARS- LITIGATING SECTION
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE CASES AND
BAN ACT CASES. IS IF YOU ARE
SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN BADLY
HARMED BY A POLICE OFFICER OR
THE FAMILY OF SOMEONE WHO'S
BEEN KILLED BY A POLICE OFFICER.
YOU HAVE IT BUT CHOICE OR YOU
CAN DO BOTH BUT THE TWO OPTIONS
ARE YOU OF A SECTION FEDERAL
SECTION NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE
CASE. WHERE YOU HAVE TO
OVERCOME THE MOUNT EVEREST OF
QUALIFIED IMMUNITY. AND PEOPLE
ARE ABLE TO OVERCOME THAT- BUT
IT IS EXTREMELY EXTREMELY HARD.
OR YOU CAN GO AND PURSUE A BAN
ACT- CAUSE OF ACTION WHERE WE
DON'T HAVE QUALIFIED IMMUNITY
UNDER STATE LAW BUT YOU HAVE
THIS. WEIRDLY DRAFTED- STATUTE
THAT HAS BEEN INTERPRETED AND
BUTCHERED BY THE COURTS OVER
THE YEARS. SO IT'S ALMOST HARD
TO KNOW HOW YOU'RE EVEN
SUPPOSED TO SATISFY THE
ELEMENTS OF IT. BECAUSE IT'S SO
EXTREME IN TERMS OF THE
DRAFTING PARTICULARLY THE
INTERPRETATION AND INTERPRETED
THE COURT OF APPEALS WHO KNOWS
NO OFFENSE TO THE COURT OF
APPEAL BUT IT'S THE CURRICULA
HOUSING BANGLES THIS SITE YOU
MORE AND MORE MORE OVER TIME.
TO THE POINT WHERE IT'S ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO PLEAD IMPROVE A
CAUSE OF ACTION FOR VIOLATION
OF THE BAN ACT PARTICULARLY IN
THE POLICE. SETTING SO WHAT THE
BILL DOES. IS IT SAYS FIRST OF
ALL WHATEVER THE INTENTION OF
THE LEGISLATURE WAS DECADES AGO
THERE THE LEAD WITNESS MADE A
REFERENCE TO IT BEING ABOUT
HATE CRIMES. THAT'S THAT
WHATEVER THE INTENTION WAS
DECADES AGO WHEN THE BAND ACT
WAS PASSED WE HAVE TO GO WITH
WHAT OUR CURRENT ATTENTION AS
AND I BELIEVE OUR INTENTION
SHOULD BE. FOR CALIFORNIA TO
HAVE A STRONG AND VIABLE CIVIL
RIGHTS STATUTE SO THAT. PEOPLE
WHOSE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
HAVE BEEN VIOLATED INCLUDING BY
POLICE OFFICERS WHEN THEY WERE
SHOT OR OTHERWISE HARM. HAVE A
VIABLE CAUSE OF ACTION AND SO
THE JURY CAN MAKE A DECISION
WHERE YOUR RIGHTS VIOLATED OVER
YOUR OR WAS THE POOL OR WAS THE
OFFICER JUSTIFIED. INSTEAD OF
HAVING A STRATEGY WHERE YOU
CAN'T EVEN GET THAT FAR BECAUSE
OF HOW IT'S BEEN INTERPRETED.
AND SO S. B. TWO ACTUALLY TO ME
SOON SMOOTHS IT OUT MAKES A
COMPREHENSIBLE MAKES IT A-
STATUE WHERE SOMEONE CAN
ACTUALLY HAVE A SHOT A PLEADING
AND PROVING. THIS CAUSE OF
ACTION- AND THEN I FINALLY WANT
ONE AS AN BY TALKING ABOUT. THE
IDEA OF SPECIFIC CONTENT
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN THIS.
FIGHT IN HONESTY TO. OF COURSE
TO MAKE A- EASE. THAT IS EITHER.
INTENT TO VIOLATE SOMEONE'S.
RIGHTS ARE SO BURKE TO THE- AND
I JUST THINK THAT THAT IS A
GOOD IDEA- THAT'S NOT WHAT WE
DO HAVE UNDER FEDERAL AND THE
FEDERAL CIVIL RIGHTS CHARGES
UNDER SECTION NINETEEN EIGHTY
THREE- AND WE SHOULDN'T GO THAT
ROUTE IN PROGRESSIVE-
CALIFORNIA. AUG TO PROVE TO
HAVE TO PROVE THAT A POLICE
OFFICER- SPECIFICALLY HAD A
SPECIFIC INTENT. TO VIOLATE
YOUR CIVIL IT'S- THAT THAT'S I
MEAN YOU CAN LOOK AT A LOT OF.
VERY WELL KNOWN CASES
INCLUDING. THE MURDER OF GEORGE
FLOYD. AND IT WOULD NOT BE
IMMEDIATELY APPARENT TO ME.
THAT SOMEONE COULD APPROVE IT
AND CIVIL COURT. YES IN
SPECIFIC CONTENT BECAUSE IT IS
SUCH A HIGH STANDARD. AND IT IS
SO EASY AS A DEFENDANT. TO
ARGUE THAT THE WORLD EVEN IF
YOU THINK I MESSED UP EVEN IF
YOU THINK I WAS YEAH MAYBE
RECKLESS I DID NOT HAVE THE
SPECIFIC CONTENT I DID NOT
INTEND TO VIOLATE YOUR CIVIL
RIGHTS- THAT THAT'S TO ME THAT
THAT IS NOT A GOOD PATH. FOR US
AND CITING THE WAY THAT THE
STATUES DRAFTED NOW IS A MUCH
MUCH BETTER APPROACH AND AGAIN
THIS IS ABOUT IMIA AND- WHETHER
A JURY IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THAT DECISION. DID YOU
VIOLATE A PERSON'S RIGHTS THEY
DO NOT VIOLATE THE PERSON'S
RIGHTS NOW WE KNOW THE INJURIES
GO BOTH WAYS ON THESE ISSUES IS
NOT A FOREGONE CONCLUSION BUT
PEOPLE SHOULD AT LEAST HAVE A
DECOR AND SHOULD HAVE A
FUNCTIONAL. OPERATIONAL USEFUL
CIVIL RIGHTS STATUTE WHICH
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT HAVE RIGHT
NOW WE SHOUL. AND SAWYER IS AN
AYE VOTE IN SB TWO. THANK YOU
SIR WIENER AND I KNOW THAT-
SENATORS STERN IS RAISED HIS
HAND ELECTRONICALLY SENATOR
STERN WITH YOUR HAND UP. IT IS
SENATOR STERN. I'M HAPPY TO
FURTHER OF OTHER MEMBERS YET
OTHER MEMBERS IN Q. ALL RIGHT
SENATE AND SALAS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I TO AND 'M
SUPPORTIVE OF S. B. TWO AND I
WANT TO THANK SENATOR BRADFORD
FOR HIS CONTINUED WORK- ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT. VERY IMPORTANT
BILL I AM ALSO VERY GLAD TO
HEAR OF MANY- LAW ENFORCEMENT
THAT IS IN IN FACT- VERY MUCH
SUPPORTIVE OF THE
DECERTIFICATION PORTION. AND
SPEAKING TO THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS IN MY
BACKYARD AND TALKING TO THEM
TODAY AND OVER THE LAST WEEK OR
SO I AM VERY GLAD TO HEAR THAT
BUT THIS IS NOW A YEAR AFTER.
WE HAD THIS INITIAL DISCUSSION
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IT IT
REALLY ASKS US TO DIG DEEPER TO
ENSURE THAT THE MOST EGREGIOUS
ACTS OF POLICE MAKE MISCONDUCT
ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE. AND I
KNOW THAT SENATOR BRADFORD WILL
CONTINUE WORKING WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS- IF THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD TODAY- BUT WE
HAVE TO GET THERE WE CANNOT
SOLELY RELY ON JUST TH
DECERTIFICATION PORTION TO GET
US TO. A PLACE WHERE OF EQUITY
FOR COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
DEEPLY HURT- BUT AGAIN THANKS
FOR EVERYONE FOR CALLING IN AND
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS THAT HAVE
BEEN ALONGSIDE THE SENATOR
DURING THIS PROCESS. ALREADY
THANK YOU SENATE GONZALEZ
CENTER HERTZBERG. NAME IS
GERMAN- YOU KNOW I THINK WHAT
SENATOR WIENER SAID WAS EXACTLY
CORRECT IN THE SENSE THAT.
OFFICERS DOING WHAT THEY WANT
TO DO. UNDERMINES CONFIDENCE IN
PEOPLE YOU KNOW WHEN YOU TRAVEL
THE WORLD AND YOU SEE PEOPLE OF
A BADGER UNIFORM AND YOU SEE
FOLKS THAT COME TO THIS COUNTRY
AND HOW SCARED THEY ARE OF THE
POLICE BECAUSE OFTEN THERE
ISN'T A RULE OF LAW AND THAT
LEVEL OF PROTECTION FOR FOLKS
AND I THINK THAT THERE'S A
MARRIAGE TO THAT AND I AND I
CERTAINLY SUPPORT AS EVERYONE
ELSE HAS THE DECERTIFICATION
PIECE WHAT CONCERNS ME AND
WHAT'S BEEN OCCUPYING MY TIME
THE GERMANS TIME TO THE MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE. IS REALLY
THE MAIN ACT CIVIL CODE SECTION
FIFTY TWO. IN THE CAR THE POINT
THAT SENATOR WIENER ALSO
MENTIONED ABOUT BEING THE STATE
LAW BEING A HOT MESS HE'S
CORRECT- AND BUT THE DIFFERENCE
IN WHAT EVERYBODY'S. IT WOULD
WHICH GRABS MY ATTENTION HERE.
I CERTAINLY NEVER EVER
EXPRESSED AND- ANYBODY ELSE IN
THIS COMMITTEE WHO EXPRESSED
SPECIFIC CONTENT. BECAUSE WHEN
I TALK TO THE AUTHOR OF THIS
MEASURE HE RAISE THE POINT
WHICH I HAVE 1000% AGREE WITH
HIM. THE OFFICER WHO KILLED
GEORGE FLOYD DID NOT GET UP IN
THE MORNING WITH THE INTENT TO
KILL GEORGE FLOYD NO QUESTION.
ENGAGED IN HORRIBLE RECKLESS
BEHAVIOR THAT THE JURY FOUND
HIM GUILTY OF. AND SO THE
QUESTION BECOMES UNDER VEINS
FOR THOSE WHO TRY THESE CASES
IN MY OFFICE DID TRY THESE NINE
TITLE SIX TOTAL OF FORTY TO
NINETEEN FORTY THREE CASES. AND
THAT WAY BACK IN THE WAY BACK
MACHINE. IS THAT. THE PROBLEM
YOU REALLY FACE IN THIS SPACE
AND THE REAL ESSENCE TO ME OF
WHAT I HAVE CHALLENGES WITH
THIS BILL ARE. IS THAT THE
FEDERAL COURT ALLOWS YOU TO GET
THE WRONGFUL DEATH. BUT NOBODY
IN THE IN THE LOWER THE BARS
STATE CITY TYLER COMMITTEE
LIKES GOING TO THE FEDERAL
COURT BECAUSE JUDGES PICK THE
JURORS AND YOU HAVE A MUCH
BETTER CHANCE IN STATE COURT.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IN A
VERY SIGNIFICANT WAY IS IT IS
IT'S NOT JUST THE STANDARD BY
WHICH- WE LOOK AT PROTECTING
CIVIL RIGHTS IT'S THE REMEDY.
AND THE REMEDY IS THAT IF
SOMEONE GETS HURT IT'S ONE
THING BUT IF THEY DIDN'T GET A
REMEDY IF THEY DIE AND THIS
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGES THE
PROCESS. OF HOW. THE BRAIN ACT
WORKS BECAUSE IT APPLIES TO
WRONGFUL DEATH AND IF YOU TALK
TO ANY PRACTICING LAWYER IN THE
SPACE OF WHICH I HAVE TALKED
AND SPOKE TO A NUMBER IT WITH
RESPECT TO PREPARATION FOR
TODAY IN ANTICIPATION IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHOR. ON
THIS THEY WILL TELL YOU. THAT
HAVING A WRONGFUL DEATH CLAIM
IN THE STATE COURT IS A
GIGANTICALLY APPROPRIATE
ADVANTAGE. SO THAT BEING SAID
THEN YOU LOOK TO THE STANDARD.
THE STANDARD HAS BEEN AS WAS
EXPRESSED ALL MARKED UP.
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN COURSE
CASES THAT SAID WELL WHEN YOU
SAY RECKLESS IT REALLY MEANS
INTENTIONAL. AND IN THE BILL IF
YOU LOOK AT PAGE SEVEN OF THE
MEASURE. AND I WAS TALKING TO
SOME OF THE ADVOCATES ON THIS.
THE SECOND PAGE THE PARAGRAPH
TO SECTION A LINE EIGHTEEN TO
THIRTY TWO. THE THREATS
INTIMIDATION OR COERCION RECORD
OF THE SECTION. THAT'S WHETHER
YOU'RE HANDCUFFED OR SOMEONE
DRAWS A GUN OR WHATEVER THE
CASE MAY BE. IT HAS IN MY
JUDGMENT CONFUSING LANGUAGE AT
THE ONE HAND IT SAYS FOR
PURPOSES OF THIS SECTION A
PERSON ACTION POTENTIALLY WHEN
THE PERSON ACTUALLY GENERAL
INTENT. A COUPLE OF LINES ABOVE
IT TALKS ABOUT DELIBERATE
INDIFFERENCE OR RECKLESS
DISREGARD. WHAT IS IT. I'M
TELLING YOU THAT YOU KNOW IN
THESE DISCUSSIONS I'VE HAD WITH
A LOT OF VERY BRIGHT FOLKS. ON
ALL SIDES- I THINK THAT THAT
THE UNDERLYING ISSUE HERE I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY OBJECTS
THAT WE AT LEAST ANYBODY I'VE
SPOKEN TO WHO ARE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE. OR THIS
LEGISLATURE TO A NEW STANDARD
THAT'S NECESSARY BECAUSE OF
WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON IN A
HORRIBLY INAPPROPRIATE WAY. AND
THE QUESTION IS WHAT'S THE
REMEDY AND ARE YOU GOING TO ARE
YOU GOING TO SAY WELL WORK IN
THIS GONNA TAKE THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING TO DRAMATICALLY CHANGE
THE REMEDY. BUT NOT LOOK AT THE
STANDARD ESPECIALLY WHEN THE
STAIRS SCREWED UP NOW THIS
MORNING I WAS ON THE CALL. VERY
PRODUCTIVE CALL WITH SOME OF
THE ADVOCATES IN THIS MEASURE
WHICH THEY'D OFFERED A SERIES
OF AMENDMENTS- WITH THERE'S
BEEN DISCUSSIONS OF AMENDMENTS
DEALING WITH THE IDEA OF
RECKLESS AND- WHICH I WHICH I
SUPPORT. RECKLESS INDIFFERENCE
OR WRECKED I MEAN DELIBERATE
INDIFFERENCE OR RECKLESS
DISREGARD. YOU KNOW MEANING IF
YOU PULL THE GUN OUT AND YOU
MADE A MISTAKE BECAUSE YOU
THOUGHT YOU WERE PULLING OUT A
TASER HE PULLED A GUN.
SIGNIFICANT SET OF FACTS THAT
ARE DIFFERENT. ON AN EDIT
REQUIRES GIVEN THE FACT THAT
THE LAWS SO MARKED UP AND GIVEN
WHAT'S BEEN MADE CLEAR TO ME
PARTICULARLY BY SOME OF THE
ADVOCATES IN THE SPACE THAT
PERSUADED ME. A ON ON THE SIDE
OF SUPPORTING THE BILL. IS THAT
IS THAT THE LAW REALLY IS
MARKED UP AND THAT MAYBE WE
SHOULD LOOK AT THE FEDERAL LAW
TITLE FORTY TWO NINETEEN EIGHTY
THREE. BUT THAT'S THE THAT AND
APPLY THOSE STANDARDS BECAUSE
THEY HAVE A BETTER BODY OF CASE
SUPPORTING ONE OF THE THINGS
ALL THE LAWYERS TALKED ABOUT IT
TALK TO THE LAWYER. TODAY WHO
HAND WHO'S HANDLING THE TO
HANDLE THE- A CORNELL OVER SAN
FRANCISCO CASE- AND THE
QUESTION BECOMES. RIGHT DO WE
CALIFORNIA LAW THE CASE IS
ALREADY SO MESSED UP WE
INITIALLY TALKED ABOUT
ELIMINATING THAT CASE
ABROGATING THE CASE BUT IT
CREATES PROBLEMS. AND SO IF YOU
GET INTO THE DETAILS YOU KNOW I
WAS LIKE TO SAY WHAT MAKES VAN
ROAD GREAT THE ILLINOIS CHICAGO
ARCHITECT THAT. GOD IS IN THE
DETAILS NOT LEVEL TO DETAILS IN
THE D. GOT OF THE G. TWO. WITH
THE HOW MANY PAGE HERE- THIRTY
SIX PAGE MAY WITH A LOT OF
PARAGRAPHS AND I ONLY BEEN
FOCUSED ON THIS ONE ISSUE
RELATING TO. THE STANDARD OF IF
WE'RE GONNA APPLY. ON THE BETA
ACT TWO WRONGFUL. DEATH WITH
THE CONSEQUENCES ARE
SIGNIFICANT THE DAMAGES TO
CITIES AND COUNTIES
SIGNIFICANT. THERE'S NO ISSUES
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY ALL THE
OTHER ISSUES THAT RELATE TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHICH THERE ARE
PUBLISHED BY THIS WHICH I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH. BUT HOW
DO WE GET TO THAT POINT SO THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT THE ONE OF
THE SUGGESTIONS THAT I HAD IS
MADE WE JUST PUT THIS BILL
OVER. AND THEN WE TAKE THE TIME
TO. TO CONTINUE THIS AND IF WE
HAVE TO SET A SPECIAL HEARING
GIVEN THE CHALLENGES MAYBE
THAT'S THE SOLUTION THAT WASN'T
REALLY. SUGGESTS IT WAS IT WAS
A PEOPLE ARE EXCITED ABOUT THAT
BUT I DO THINK THAT IN THIS
COMMITTEE THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE OF THE CALIFORNIA
SENATE WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
GET IT RIGHT. I'M NOT WORRIED
ABOUT INDEMNITY- MUNITY I'M NOT
WORRIED ABOUT THE ISSUES WITH
RESPECT TO THE- YOU KNOW THE
OTHER ISSUES OKAY IN THIS CASE
THE CERTIFICATION ISSUES. I'M
JUST REALLY WEIRD ABOUT THIS
LIABILITY ISSUE AND GETTING THE
STANDARD RIGHT AND THERE'S SOME
CONCERN AMONG ALL PARTIES THAT
IF WE ADOPT THE STATE STANDARD
WE CREATE A NEW STANDARD. WE
CREATE A WHOLE NEW STORIES
SIZES AND RULE OF LAW WHICH
CONCERNS ME. I'M NOT LEARN
ENOUGH TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
CASE IS ALREADY HAS BEEN UNDER
TITLE FORTY TO NINETEEN FORTY
THREE OF THE FEDERAL LAW SO YOU
KNOW MY VIEW ON THIS IS. IS
THAT THIS STILL NEEDS WORK. ON
ALTHOUGH THE ON IT. IS RIGHT.
AND I'M ACTUALLY CONVINCED IN
THE GOOD FAITH IS THE ADVOCATES
WITH WHOM I'VE SPOKEN WITH. WHO
ARE THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL
TOGETHER WITH THE AUTHOR. THAT
WITH A LITTLE BIT MORE HOMEWORK
OF THIS COMMITTEE WE CAN GET
THERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG
CENTERS STERN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMING THROUGH OKAY.
YES YOU ARE. OKAY IT JUST GIVEN
BALLING RIGHT- WHO. ARE YOU
SURE DO YOU MEMBERS FOR IT
EXCELLENT THE- COLLOQUY THIS
FOR. PUTTING SOME FURTHER
CLARITY ON THESE ISSUES- TO BE
CLEAR TO THE AUTHOR- THIS IS
THE YEAR WE HAVE TO GET. THESE
REFORMS DONE- I BELIEVE THIS IS
THE BILL M. BELIEVE YOU'RE THE
AUTHOR TO DO THAT- YOU FORCED
ALL OF US TO LOOK OURSELVES IN
THE MIRROR. AND RECOGNIZE THAT.
WALKING AROUND WITH- ONE SET OF
SKIN IS VERY DIFFERENT THAN
WALKING IN A VERY AND- IN A
BODY OF DIFFERENT COLOR SKIN.
AND THE NOT JUST THE- POLICY
EXPERIENCE DRIVING THIS BILL
BUT THE- THE LIFE EXPERIENCE
DRIVING THIS AND ALL THE
INCIDENTS. THAT MAY NOT EVEN BE
QUOTE QUALIFIED IN THIS
LEGISLATION- THAT WILL AFFECT.
ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW ON THE
STREETS REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THEY'RE EVEN CAUGHT UP IN ONE
OF THESE TERRIBLE INCIDENTS OR
NOT. THERE'S A BROADER CULTURE
OF FEAR THAT WE BUILD- ADDED
THAT- COLLECT FROM STATE
GOVERNMENT AND FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT STEPPING UP TO
ACTUALLY HOLD. OUR OWN OFFICERS
ACCOUNTABLE- IN THESE NEEDS
SERIOUS CASES OF MISCONDUCT SO
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
INSISTING ON. COMING BACK AGAIN
ANDBRINGING SOMETHING REALLY
STRONG TO THIS COMMITTEE- A- MY
I GUESS MY QUESTIONS ARE. ABOUT
THIS SPECIFIC- THE DEBATE WE'RE
HAVING I GUESS RIGHT NOW I'M
READING UP IN THE ANALYSIS OF
THIS DEBATE ABOUT SPECIFIC
VERSES GENERAL INTENDS. AND I'M
HOPING TO GET SOME CLARITY AND
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER IT'S FROM-
THE EXPERT WITNESS- THE
ATTORNEY OR THE AUTHOR OR MAYBE
IN THE CLOTHES OR WHATEVER IS
APPROPRIATE BUT- ADAM WHAT WHAT
SPECIFICALLY. DIDN'T WORK ABOUT
THE VARIOUS STANDARDS THAT HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSED BACK AND FORTH
IT SEEMS LIKE THERE'S A LOT OF
VARIATIONS BETWEEN FULL GENERAL
INTENDS AND WHAT WHAT FOLKS ARE
CALLING SPECIFIC INTENT WHICH
IS YOU KNOW COULD BE
CHARACTERIZED AS AN OFFICER
DELIBERATELY INTENDING TO
VIOLATE SOMEBODY CIVIL RIGHTS
OR COULD BE RECKLESS
INDIFFERENCE TO THOSE RIGHTS OR
COULD JUST BE SIMPLY. IGNORING
YOU KNOW KNOWING CIRCUMSTANCES
ARE- MAKING IT SAY- ARREST-
THAT WAS THE WRONG SUSPECT- BUT
USING SOMETHING LIKE RACES THE
QUALIFIER WHICH WE KNOW MANY
PEOPLE TO GO THROUGH- THOSE
KINDS OF STOPS ARRESTS SEARCHES.
THE QUESTION TO ME IS IT JUST
JUST TO GET INTO SPECIFICS A
LITTLE BIT HERE AND TRY TO
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BETTER.
WHAT IT HOW EXACTLY WOULD. WHAT
WHAT KIND OF CONDUCT WOULD
ACTUALLY MEET THE STANDARD IN
THIS BILL BECAUSE I'M I'M STILL
KIND OF CONFUSED BY THE DEBATE
AND BY. THEN ALICE'S. ENDS IS
THERE ANY AND WHETHER THERE'S A
CONCERN ABOUT THE EVIDENTIARY
STANDARD FOR EXAMPLE THAT WOULD
BE REQUIRED- TO BE PRESENTED-
IN THESE CASES OF SAY
DELIBERATE INDIFFERENCE OR
RECKLESS DISREGARD. IF IT'S
REALLY BAD EVIDENCE- AND
CONCERNED ABOUT NOT HAVING
SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE OR IF IT'S
MORE- ABOUT THE DETERRENCE
AFFECTED THAT YOU MAY BE HOPING
FOR THIS TO HAVE SAY. YOU KNOW
IF- ALL OUR COUNTIES AND CITIES
AND EVEN THE STATE ARE GONNA BE
LIABLE FOR- THAT CONTACTED YOU
KNOW EAT. A WIDER MUCH MUCH
WIDER RANGE OF CONDUCT MAYBE
TELADOC DIFFERENT POLICIES AND
THEN. IN EFFECT BATTLE TO TURN
THE CONTRACTORS IS REALLY ABOUT
WINNING BIG CLAIMS AND REALLY
PURSUING THE CIVIL PENALTIES IN
THE MONETARY SIDE OF THIS THING
WHICH- I DON'T WANT TO- UNDER
CUT IN ANY WAY THE IMPORTANCE
OF. OF BOTH THAT IS A
DETERRENCE MECHANISM BUT REALLY
ALSO IS. YOU KNOW IS IT IS A
STANDARD FOR- FOR GETTING SOME
KIND OF JUSTICE ALTHOUGH IT
NEVER GETS- YOU KNOW NO MATTER
HOW MUCH MONEY. MS BERING WHO
TESTIFIED WON'T WON'T GET HER
SON BACK- ENDS. YOU KNOW
KENNETH KENNETH ROSS THE THIRD
WILL GET THAT BACK IN- SO MANY
OTHER EXAMPLES AND WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT BY THE WAY TO THE LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS YOU KNOW
THE- TO SUGGEST THAT THE TO
BARIS CASE IS GOING TO BE
SUFFICIENT IN THAT WE CAN USE
SIMPLY A NEGLIGENCE STANDARD.
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES THAT I
THINK MISSES THE POINT SOMEONE-
BECAUSE THAT CASE ALSO AT THE
CENTRE WINNERS POINT STRUCK
DOWN THE MAIN ACT VIOLATION IT
DISMISSED THAT AND IT'S A MARS
FAMILY- JONES WIDOW IN THEIR
FAMILY HAD NO NO RECOURSE UNDER
ME. NOW IN THAT CASE THERE'S A
MENTAL HEALTH INCIDENT. AND THE
OFFICER DIDN'T PAY ATTENTION TO
THE AT SO THE SITUATION WASN'T
CALLED TO THE SCENE BECAUSE OF
ANY CONFLAGRATION OR ANY ISSUE
AND JUST ACTED INDEPENDENTLY.
AND IN SEVEN GUNSHOTS- AT A
FIFTEEN FOOT DISTANCE AND EVEN
THOUGH THEY FOUND THAT ACTION
TO BE A JURY WOULD RECENTLY
FIND THAT THAT KIND OF
NEGLIGENT BIG STILL COULDN'T
FIND A BANE ACT. VIOLATION THAT
TO ME IS A PROP I DO WE HAVE TO
SOLVE THAT IN HIS LEGISLATION
HERE TODAY I JUST I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE GET THERE-
AND SO PROVIDING SOME CLARITY
ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT KIND OF
EVIDENCE YOU HAVE TO BRING
UNDER THE CURRENT STANDARDS
VERSES SOME OF THE OTHER
VARIATIONS WITHIN THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE. I WOULD
REALLY HELP BUT I THINK I THINK
OUT OF THIS HOPEFULLY OUT OF
HIS HEARING IT OUT OF THE
SESSION WE CAN FORM A MUCH
BIGGER CONSENSUS AND YOU KNOW
GETTING RID OF QUALIFIED
IMMUNITY HERE TODAY AND GETTING
WRONGFUL DEATH ON THE BOOKS AND
SOME STANDARD IT'S ACTUALLY
GONNA WORK TO GET US TO BE
ENACT VIOLATIONS. I THINK WOULD
BE A MASSIVE STEP FORWARD FOR
THE CIVIL RIGHTS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS- SO ANYHOW I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE. APPROPRIATE TIME
IS MISTER CHAIR TO ANSWER THIS
QUESTIONS BUT- I WOULD. SOME
IT'S- THANK YOU SENATOR
INCIDENT DODD YOU CAN ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE WHEN YOU'RE I WILL
ALLOW OUR LEADER WITNESS- TO
RESPOND TO THE SPECIFIC ACTS
THAT ARE SENATOR FROM. MALIBU
INQUIRED ABOUT AND I WILL TRY
TO ENCAPSULATE HIS OTHER
CONCERNS IN MY CLOTHES ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SIR BRADFORD
MISS YOU ARE YOU AVAILABLE ON
THE PHONE. BONTA MODERATORS
MISUSE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
BETTER I WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES AND
SENATOR LEADERS THAT WERE IN A
HOT MESS. BUT THE GOOD NEWS I
FRONT OF THE PACIFIC IMPACT. IS
REALLY ONLY STARTED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN. PEOPLE
WERE NOW KATE BAD SUPER
IMPORTANT PACIFIC IMPACT FOR
THIRTY YEARS OF THAT BEING
HACKED WE DID NOT HAD ANY
PROBLEM FIGURING OUT WHAT I
PROVIDE WHAT MEN DO WAY OUT OF
MY TO WHAT CONSTITUTIONAL.
VIOLATION THE PROBLEM THE LAND
THAT WERE HAVING NOW IS THAT WE
ALL HAVE A- THAT. IMPRENTA IS
NOT REQUIRED IT SHOULD NOT BE
WEEK. AND WE SHOULD GET OF IT I
THINK THERE IS A CONSENSUS THAT
FROM THAT WHAT'S WRONG IN A
THREE. IT IN. WITH THE SPIRIT
OF. NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE. WHAT
WINDOW IS THAT WE HAVE REPLACED
THE TYPICAL PASS WITH RECKLESS
NAY WHICH HAD ALL DEFINITIONS
ONE WAGE IN CORNELL IT THAT THE
PICK AND PACK. WE ARE GETTING
READY AND THEN INVITE YET RIGHT
BACK I'M NOT A DIFFICULTY WITH
NEW THAT BLACK YEAH. BECAUSE
WHAT HAPPENED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY. I WE DIDN'T DISCUSS
THAT- AT SOME OF THAT COMIC BY
SENATE. SO. LET ME GIVE YOU A
EXAMPLE FOR A BI RECENT OF THE
UNLESS. THE WEEKLY. NEED THAT
BIG. BOB UNREASONABLE. DONE
WITH THE OBJECT EIGHT AND NOT
CONTACT WE CAN'T MEAN I
INTENDED BUY A NEW ON NECK. AND
DOING SO WHY OBJECT AND WE- IN
THE COUNTRY OFFICER WOULD NOT.
HE'S ON SOMEBODY THAT FOR NINE
MINUTES THAT IT TO PROVE EIGHT
<c.cyan>OUR AMENDMENT CULT. IN NOW IF</c>
WE SAID YOU TO SHOW RIGHT THAT
IN A BAG. THANK WHICH MEANS THE
OPPOSITE BAG I BET VICTIMS TO
SHOW THE OFFICE IN HAND TO BUY
SOMEBODY. RIGHT BY THE THEIR ON
BOARD THAT CREDIT ALL YES AND
IS SOMETHING THAT
CONSTITUTIONAL CONSTITUTION NO
WEEK. READING WE'RE DO WE DO AT
THE CHIU. EIGHT TAKING A BIT
BACK TO HELP YOU WHY. BEFORE
FOR NOW IN. TWO THOUSAND. CLAIM
UNDER THE BILL'S STANDARD
VERSUS- SOME STANDARD IT DIDN'T
JUST ALLOW GENERALLY TEND SO
WHAT LIKE. SPEC A HYPOTHETICAL
OR SOME YOU KNOW CITY SOME SOME
A LITTLE MORE SPECIFICITY ON
WHAT WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE IN
THE EVIDENTIARY JONES AT THIS
IS YOUR CLASS SENATOR DO YOU
NEED ME THE STAND APPROPRIATE
ABOUT.
BEYOND REASONABLE DOUBT
CLEAR CONVINCING. LANGUAGE I
THINK THE QUOTED LANGUAGE IS
THE- WOULD HAVE TO PROVE THAT
THE ACTED WITH THE CONSTANT
OBJECTIVE TO ENGAGE IN CONDUCT.
THAT INTERFERES OR TAKEN TODAY
WITH THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
SO. WHAT'S THAT WHAT'S THAT
CONDUCT LIKE HOW BROAD IS THAT
THE LESSER STANDARD O REVIEW
MORE SO THE SHOWING. GET
ACTUALLY GET DISCOUNTED SCORE
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SIR SIR LET
ME DIRECT IT TO THE CENTER
PRESS CENTER BRADFORD YOU WANT
TO TAKE BACK OR DO WOULD YOU
PREFER TO HAVE MISS YOU TAKE
THAT. OR NOT YOU HAVE THAT
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S CLEARLY
SPELLED OUT IN THE BILL WITH
THOSE OF IT INTRIGUED- THOSE
CONFLICTS ARE WHICH LEADS TO-
A- DEFINING WHAT'S MISCONDUCT
OR INTENTIONAL. OKAY OUR ACTION
I SHOULD SAY HI THANK YOU TANK
SENATE. REFERENCE YOU DID YOU
WANT TO ADD ON TO THAT. AT THE-
OF THE MONTH ISSUE. GENERAL
INTACT ONLY GETS THE FIRST STEP
OF A CON VIOLATE ONE IS THAT
YOU HAVE TO ACT DILIGENTLY
MEANING WE CANNOT. I INTENDED
TISSUE THAT TIME. THAT GENERAL
IN. IN GAME IN A- CON BUT THAT
COULD NOT MOVE UP
CONSTITUTIONAL VIOLATION YOU
CAN ONLY DO SO. BY IN ADDITION
TO BEING FAT FIND OUT WHAT
OBJECTIVELY UNREASONABLE OF
COURSE UNDER THE OTHER
CONSTITUTIONAL CLAIMS THIS
STANDARD IS SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
SO UNDER THE- FOURTEENTH
AMENDMENT YOU HAVE OBJECTIVELY
UNREASONABLE. STANDARD INSTEAD
OF. OTHERS YEAH- EIGHT THEM. SO
THE WEIGHT THAT THE PORT CABS
AT ANALYZE ALL OF THAT DEBATE
GENERAL IN TIME MEANING THAT
YOU INTENTIONALLY AND
VOLITIONAL ENGAGED IN A
PARTICULAR CONTACT. AND IN
ADDITION TO THAT YOU VIOLATED
THE CONSTITUTION ALL OF THE
STANDARDS THAT ARE SEPARATE
DEPENDING ON THE. STATUS OF THE
DESKTOP. NINETY THANK YOU MISS
YOU PRESIDENT. THANK VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANTED TO-
MAKE MY COMMENTS PROBABLY WOULD
HAVE BEEN REAL APPROPRIATE
RIGHT AFTER- SENATOR- FROM LA.
I WANTED TO BASICALLY SAY THAT
I DON'T HAVE ANY PROBLEM WITH
THE WHOLE ISSUE OF IMMUNITY OR
THE ISSUE OF DECERTIFICATION-
AND ALL THE LICENSING I THINK
NEEDS WORK A LOT OF WORK THIS
COMMITTEE DOESN'T HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER THE LICENSING
BUT- BUT IN REGARDS TO. THE-
THE LIABILITY ISSUES I HAVE
SOME CONCERN AND I WANTED TO
BASICALLY SAY THAT I THINK WE
NEED TO TAKE THE TIME- I THINK
SENATOR BRADFORD HAS DONE A
TREMENDOUS JOB- IN BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD BUT I THINK
IT NEEDS SOME WORK AND IT'S
RARE. BUT JUST SAY IT IT'S VERY
RARE. TO INTRODUCE A BILL AND
NOT HAVE ANY AMENDMENTS AT ALL.
THE CLARIFY AND TO- MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE PICKING THE RIGHT
STANDARDS AND THAT IT MAKES
SENSE AND THAT THERE'S NO
CONFUSION BASED ON ON THE
LANGUAGE THAT WE'VE USED AND- I
HAVE SOME REAL ISSUES WITH SOME
OF THE LANGUAGE WILL GO INTO
THEM HERE I THINK. YOU KNOW WE
CAN TALK ABOUT THIS ALL DAY BUT
I JUST THINK WE SHOULD TAKE THE
TIME AND I THINK IT'S
LEADERSHIP. AND LEADERSHIP IS
INVOLVED IN THIS BILL WE CAN
WAIVE THE RULES. THAT ARE IN
PLACE AND THERE'S NOTHING THAT
JUST DRIVING US TO DO
SOMETHING. TO PASS SOMETHING
RIGHT NOW THAT ISN'T IN THE
SHAPE IT NEEDS TO BE SO I
WOULD. I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT WE CONSIDER TAKING
THE TIME WE NEED TO GET THIS
RIGHT. I GUESS ON THE COPIER I
DO NOT SEE ANY OTHER
MICROPHONES REYES- CENTER
BRADFORD A COUPLE POINTS HERE.
FIRST OF ALLTHIS IS MEANINGFUL
REFORM- THIS IS PROBABLY THE
MOST MEANINGFUL REFORM WITH
RESPECT TO CIVIL JUSTICE AND
POLICING. CERTAINLY IN IN MY
CAREER- WE AGREE ON THE GOALS
ACCOUNTABILITY. ABSOLUTELY DO
WE NEED GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY
ABSOLUTELY THE DECERTIFICATION
PROCESS PROVIDES THAT
TRADITIONAL ACCOUNTABILITY AND
WE SHOULD MOST DEFINITELY
WITHIN THE SESSION. ENACT
LEGISLATION THAT PROVIDES A
MECHANISM PROCESS. FOR
DECERTIFICATION. WRONGFUL DEATH
IT IS SOMEWHAT EMBARRASSING.
THAT SOMEONE DOESN'T HAVE
RECOURSE IN A WRONGFUL DEATH
ACTION WHEN THERE'S BEEN A
POLICE OFFICER WHO'S COMMITTED
BASICALLY A WRONGFUL DEATH IN
THIS BILL DOESN'T THIS BILL
ALLOWS SAID THE SAME THING WITH
MUNICH FOLKS HAVE TALKED ABOUT
QUALIFIED IMMUNITY THIS BILL
REMOVES THE STATE IMMUNITIES
THAT IS HUGE. THAT IS HUGE- S.
WAS RAISED BY SEVERAL FOLKS.
THAT WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION HERE
BESIDES EFFECTING POLICY BUT
pOBLIGATION MAKE SURE WHEN THIS
LAW IS APPLIED THAT IT'S CLEAR
I ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS OF SENATOR WIENER FROM
SAN FRANCISCO. THE MAIN ACT IS
A HOT MESS I LOOKED AT THE JURY
INSTRUCTION YOU PROBABLY FILE
THE JURY INSTRUCTION THE BANE
ACT IS A HOT MESS IS THAT EXIST
TODAY. AND OUR JOB IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT DOESN'T EMERGE
FROM THIS COMMITTEE. CONFUSING
AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE GONE BACK
AND FORTH ON SOME OF THE ISSUES.
THE MEN'S RAY OF THE SPECIFIC
CONTENT VERSUS GENERAL INTENT
VERSUS THE LEVELS OF
CULPABILITY DOES NEED TO BE
DEFINED WE NEEDED TO FIND. NOT
I NOR I THINK ANYBODY ELSE
WANTS TO SEE A SPECIFIC INTENT
STANDARD THAT EXIST TODAY. WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE A STANDARD
WHERE SOMEONE HASTO PROVE THE
SPECIFIC INTENT TO KILL.
SENATOR BRADFORD PROVIDED
SEVERAL EXAMPLES TO ME WHERE
FOR EXAMPLE IN OFFICER PUNCHES
A WOMAN THE FACE AND PERHAPS
SHE DIES. THAT'S AT LEAST
RECKLESS CONDUCT I THINK IT'S
INTENTIONAL CONDUCT BUT IT'S AT
LEAST RECKLESS CONDUCT AND
SPECIFIC INTENT. SHOULD NOT
HAPPY PROVED IN THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE- CELEBRATE FOR
JUST A POINT. ABOUT THIS BILL I
SERVE WITH TOM BEING TOM BEING
WOULD BE HORRIFIED AS TO WHAT'S
HAPPENED TO HIS LAW. RIDLEY
WRITTEN AS A HATE CRIME LAW BUT
WHAT HE WOULD BE HIS BE PROUD
OF YOU. THE PROUD OF THE
DEDICATION AND THE PASSION YOU
BROUGHT TO THIS ISSUE. SO YOU
CAN CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LET ME START
MICHAEL'S BY THINKING YOU.
EIGHTEEN MY SENATOR FROM LOS
ANGELES FOR THE TIME THAT YOU
HAVE TRULY WORK AT TRYING TO
GET THIS RIGHT AND TO ALL MY
THE COLLEAGUES OF THIS MAN-
COMMITTEE WHO HAVE MET WITH ME.
ONE ON ONE SIDE BARS TO DISCUSS
YOUR CONCERNS YOUR INTEREST IN
YOUR SUPPORT. OF THIS MEASURE.
THIS IS A TOUGH ISSUE. BUT IT'S
A RIGHT TO SISTER. AND IT'S A
ISSUE THAT GIVES WHAT ONE FOR
SPRINT WANTS TO BE ON THEIR
SIDE. INTENTIONALITY AND WE
WANT TO BE INTENTIONAL ABOUT
WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN IT COMES TO
POLICE REFORM IN THIS IS WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IT'S VERY
INTENTIONAL IN SPELLING OUT
WHAT IT IS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE. WE MIGHT BAKER ABOUT
THE SEMANTICS. I'M NOT A
LAWYER. NOR DO I PLAY ONE ON TV.
BUT I'VE TRUSTED AND TALKED TO
MANY. IN THIS PROFESSION WHO
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A FAIR.
OUR MEASURE AND FAR BETTER THAN
ANYTHING THAT EXISTS TODAY. LET
ME ADDRESS MY CONCERNS FROM MY
FRIEND FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY
A COLLEAGUE THAT I ESPECT
TREMENDOUSLY BUT THIS IS NOT A
RUSH TO MEASURE THIS MEASURE
WAS INTRODUCED LAST YEAR WE HAD
A YEAR TO WORK ON THIS MEASURE.
SO BY NO MEANS HAS THIS BEEN
RUSHED AND IN MY TEN YEARS HERE
IN THIS LEGISLATURE AND MY
TWENTY TWO YEARS AS AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL THERE'S NOT BEEN ONE
ISSUE THAT I HAD DEDICATED MORE
TIME TO GETTING RIGHT THEN THIS
ISSUE RIGHT HERE TODAY SO I
SAY. HOW MUCH LONGER. THE
QUESTION HOW MANY MORE LIVES
NEED TO BE LOST. THE
RECKLESSNESS TO INTENTIONAL
ACTIONS BY LAW ENFORCEMENT HOW
MANY MORE PEOPLE REGARDLESS OF
COLOR NEED TO LOSE THEIR LIVES
BECAUSE OF THE CALLOUS ACTS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT. TO MY FRIEND
FROM FRESNO WHO ASKED THE
QUESTION ABOUT THE ADVISORY
BOARD DEVICE REPORT IS JUST
THAT AN ADVISORY BOARD IT HAS
NO HIERARCHY OVER POST
COMMISSION THERE ARE SUGGESTED
THEY PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT POLLS CAN TRULY OVERALL
IT'S AN ADVISORY BOARD. BUT IT
RAISES QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
COMPOSITION OF THE
QUALIFICATIONS OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS. IT'S MEMBERS IN
THIS LEGISLATURE WHO DECIDE ON
ISSUES THAT THEY HAVE NO IDEAL
ABOUT HOW IT WORKS IN REAL
LIFE. BUT WE ENTRUST THE
BORDERS OF CALIFORNIA THE TRUST
US TO DEAL WITH A MYRIAD OF
ISSUES. AND WE TRY TO GET HIM
RIGHT. WE TRUST TWELVE MEMBERS
IN A BOX. TO DETERMINE ONE'S
LIFE OR DEATH SITUATION EVERY
DAY IN A JURY TRIAL NOBODY
ASKED ABOUT THEIR
QUALIFICATIONS SO TO SAY THAT.
ONLY LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN POLICE
THE POLICE THAT IS WHAT LED US
HERE TODAY AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE
GOT AHUNDRED AND TWENTY YEARS
OF WHAT WE'VE DONE. AS OF ONE
GUY WANTS IT WE KEEP DOING WHAT
WE DO WHEN WE GOT BIG KEEP
GETTING WHAT WE GET. AND THAT'S
NOTHING. THIS IS GOOD POLICY.
AND IT'S TIME FOR CALIFORNIA
IT'S TIME FOR US AS LEGISLATORS
TO LOOK OURSELVES IN THE MIRROR
AND I APPRECIATE. MY COLLEAGUES
FROM MALIBU. WHO SAID THIS TIME
LOOK OURSELVES IN AMERICA AND
UNDERSTAND THEIR TO. SYSTEMS OF
JUSTICE IN THIS COUNTRY. IT'S
TWO SYSTEMS BUT YOU'LL NEVER
KNOW UNTIL YOU WALK A DAY IN MY
FERRAGAMO'S. REALLY UNDERSTAND
IT'S FAR DIFFERENT THAN
ANYTHING ANY OF YOU GUYS HAVE
EVER ENCOUNTERED OR WILL
ENCOUNTER. AND ALL WE'RE ASKING
FOR IS A OPPORTUNITY TO NOT
ONLY SAVE LIVES BUT FOR THOSE
WHO ARE LOST THE GET JUSTICE TO
GET ACCOUNTABILITY THE GET SOME
SENSE OF FAIRNESS. THIS IS NOT
A PERFECT BILL. BUT WE WOULD
ALL AGREE THERE'S NO SUCH
PERFECT BILL. BUT IT'S BETTER
THAN WHAT WE HAVE AND IT SURELY
BEAT NOTHING. IT IS BEEN WELL
THE BRAIDED. BUT WE SHOULDN'T
STAND HERE TODAY LED. THE
PERFECT BE THE ENEMY OF THE
GOOD. WE SHOULD WE SHOULD TAKE
BOLD AND DECISIVE ACTIONS WE
SHOULD TAKE FAIR ACTIONS AND
LET ME THINK THOSE INDIVIDUALS
ON LAW ENFORCEMENT I APPLAUD
YOU FOR SUPPORTING THE
CERTIFICATION BECAUSE THE SAME
AGENCIES THAT SUPPORTED TODAY
BEEN SUPPORTED LAST YEAR SO
WHAT A DIFFERENCE A YEAR MAKES.
WHAT A DIFFERENCE A YEAR MAKES
THOSE SAME AGENCIES WORK
ADAMANTLY OPPOSED WHEN IT
SIMPLY WAS A DE SER BILL BUT
NOW WE HAD BRAIN ACT IN ALL I
SUPPORT THE SEARCH I JUST DON'T
LIKE THE BANNER. WE SHOULD BE
PROTECTING PEOPLE'S CIVIL
RIGHTS AS WELL. WE SHOULD
AFFORD THEM TO FIND JUSTICE NOT.
BEING MADE WHOLE BECAUSE
NOTHING'S GOING TO MAKE THE
FLOYD FAMILY HOLD THESE L. FORD
FAMILY HOLD THE TO MERE RICE
FAMILY WHOLE DODGERS GUARDADO
FAMILY THE RYAN ROSS FAMILY
HOME WE CAN GO ON AND ON AND
ALL IS NOTHING THIS IS NOT
ABOUT. FINANCIAL JUDGMENT
BECAUSE AFTER FLOYD FAMILY AT
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION IS NOT
GONNA BRING GEORGE FLOYD BACK.
BUT WE NEED A SENSE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY WE NEED SOME
RESPONSIBILITY AT ALL THIS BILL
DOES WITH THE BRAIN ACT IF PUT
SOME SKIN IN THE GAME BECAUSE
WE ALL KNOW. IT WERE HELD CIVIL
CIVIL CYBELE LIABLE WE'RE GOING
TO CHANGE OUR BEHAVIOR IT'S
ANOTHER GUARD RAIL TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN HOLD. IN CHANGED
BEHAVIOR. WE DON'T HAVE A
POLICING PROBLEM IN AMERICA.
BECAUSE IT WORKS AND WHY
COMMUNITIES IT WORKS QUITE WELL
THE WAY IT SHOULD. WE GOT A
TRUST PROBLEM. WE GOT A FEAR
FACTOR. BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
DO NOT HATE THE POLICE THEY
FEARED A POLICE AND WHERE
THERE'S FEAR THERE WOULD NEVER
BE TRUST THIS BILL ALLOWS US TO
ESTABLISH A LEVEL OF TRUST. AND
I REMAKE OMITTED AS I STATED
THE WORKING WITH EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU HERE. BUT I
ALSO REMAIN COMMITTED TO
PASSING A BILL. THAT ARE
ADVOCATES CAN FULLY SUPPORT.
AND WON'T BE A REFLECTION OF
THE STATUS QUO WE'VE SEEN THAT
TOO MANY TIMES THE WASHINGTON
REPEAT. ARE YOU TO LOOK AT OUR
COMMITMENTS AS I STATED WE
OFFERED UP THREE VERSION. AND
HERE ARE SUPPORTERS AND WORK
WITH US FOR MEANING FULL.
REFORM AND SOLUTIONS FOR
POLICING HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
MEMBERS WE HAVE OPPORTUNITY
TODAY THE BE ON THE RIGHT SIDE
OF HISTORY. I SAY THIS AGAIN WE
HAVE OPPORTUNITY TO BE ON THE
RIGHT SIDE OF HISTORY. AND AS
MARTIN LUTHER KING SAID IF NOT
NOW. THURMOND IF NOT ME THEN
WHO I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU CENTER BRED FOR
ANOTHER SEVEN RAZA MOD BILL BUT
SHE'S NOT HERE IS THERE IS
SOMEONE ELSE WHO WHICH IS TO
MAKE THE MOTION SENATE GONZALEZ
I THINK IT'S ALSO MOVES THE
BILL- MADAM CHIEF COUNSEL. THIS
CALL ROLE. THE AMENDMENT THAT
YOU'VE ACCEPTED THERE'S SOME
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT YOU
TO ACCEPT THAT EARLIER TO GO
AMENDMENTS AND AGAIN WE
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS BILL
AS A MOVE FOR. THANK YOU- THIS
IS SB TWO BY SENATOR BRADFORD
WITH A MOTION BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
THEN RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS- BURKE.
BORJAS SPORTIST SNOW CABALLERO.
THE DOCILE. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG. JONES. LAYERED ARE
LAYERED I STERN. WHY CAL SKI.
WIENER HI WIENER AYE YOU HAVE
THREE TO ONE SO FAR ALL RIGHT
WE'LL PUT THE BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD. ALL
RIGHT WE NOW MOVE ON TO. NEXT
ITEM. ON THE SECOND. CENTER
NEWMAN CENTER NEWMAN HAS BEEN
WAITING QUITE PATIENTLY S. B.
TWO EIGHT NINE CENTER NEWMAN-
ON A REGULAR AND I AGREED THAT
I WOULD GO I HAVE ASSUME AT
FOUR O'CLOCK IN TO COME BILL IF
YOU DON'T MIND. IF THAT'S OKAY
WITH THE OTHER AUTHORS- CENTER
ACTUAL IT IS REQUESTED THAT WE
TAKE UP. HIS ITEM WHICH IS ITEM
NUMBER. MAN CHIEF COUNSEL WHICH
ITEM NUMBERS- SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY TWO MISTER CHAIR. IT IS
ITEM NUMBER FIVE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE ALL RIGHT FIND OUT IN THE.
FIVE I REMEMBER FIVE SB THREE
NINE TWO CENTER TO LET UP
CLOSURES THANK YOU MISTER FOR
DON'T DESCEND AND- MY-
COLLEAGUE CENTER NEWMAN I
APPRECIATE THE AT THE TIME THAT
YOU'VE ALLOWED ME THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MMBERS
I AM HERE TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL THREE NINETY TWO
REGARDING. HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION ELECTRONIC DOCUMENT
DELIVERY I HAVE RECENTLY TAKEN
AMENDMENTS HEADING INTO THIS
COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
VOICED IN THE PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE. THIS BILL SENATE
BILL THREE NINETY TWO WILL
IMPROVE ACCESSIBILITY TO
WOULDN'T TO IMPORTANT DOCUMENTS
AND REDUCE DELIVERY COSTS BY
REQUIRING HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION TO COMMUNICATE WITH
HOMEOWNERS VIA EMAIL. UNLESS
THE RESIDENT CHOOSES TO RECEIVE
COMMUNICATIONS VIA ANOTHER
METHOD SUCH AS TRADITIONAL MALE.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO MORE THAN
FIFTY TWO THOUSAND COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS MADE UP
OF CLOSE TO FOUR POINT EIGHT
MILLION HOUSING UNITS ACROSS
THE STATE THESE COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS ARE GOVERNED BY
THEIR RESPECTIVE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION WHICH ARE REQUIRED
TO FOLLOW THE REGULATIONS AND
GUIDELINES ESTABLISHED IN THEIR
INDIVIDUAL BYLAWS AND UNDER THE
STAGE. DAVIS STERLING COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENT ACT. UNDER
THE DAVIS STARTING BACK
ASSOCIATIONS MUST PROVIDE
MEMBERS WITH THE NECESSARY
DOCUMENTS INCLUDING ANNUAL
BUDGETS POLICY STATEMENTS OR
NOTICES VIA FIRST CLASS MAIL
UNLESS ELECTRONIC DELIVERY S
OTHERWISE REQUESTED BY THE
INDIVIDUALS. PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION HAS SOUGHT TO
PROTECT HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
MEMBER FROM EXORBITANT FEES BY
LIMITING THE AMOUNT OF SOCIO
AGENTS CAN CHARGE FOR COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH PROCESSING
PREPARING AND DEVELOPING THESE
DOCUMENTS. ADDITIONALLY TO
FURTHER INCREASE FURTHER
INFORMATION ACCESSIBILITY THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED SENATE BILL
THREE TO THREE AND TWENTY
NINETEEN WHICH REQUIRED
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION TO
DELIVER MEMBERSHIP BOARD
ELECTION RULED BY INDIVIDUAL
DELIVERY OR BY POSTING ON A
WEBSITE. IN THE MIDST OF THE
GLOBAL TEND TO DAMPEN THAT
MAKE- WORK MAIL DELIVERIES ARE
COMMON OR MISS MAIL DELIVERIES
ARE COMMON COST SAVINGS ARE
CRUCIAL INFORMATION
ACCESSIBILITY IS VITAL UPDATING
THESE PROCESSES TO BE
ELECTRONIC IS MORE IMPORTANT
MORE THAN EVER TODAY. SENATE
BILL THREE NINETY TWO MANDATES
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION TO
ELECTRONICALLY DELIVERED
NOTICES AND DOCUMENTS TO THIS
MEMBERS BEGINNING JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THREE IF A
RESIDENT OPT IN TO RECEIVE
EMAILS COMMUNICATIONS IF THE
RESIDENT CHOOSES NOT TO OPT IN
THE ASSOCIATION WILL CONTINUE
TO DELIVER THEIR DOCUMENTS BY
MAIL. HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS
CAN ALSO CHOOSE TO OPT OUT OF
THE ELECTRONIC DELIVERY IF TWO
THIRDS OF THEIR MEMBERS VOTE IN
FAVOUR OF A DIFFERENT FORM OF
DOCUMENT DELIVERY NOTICE OF
DELIVERY. I HAVE TAKEN
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE
THE PREVIOUS WEBSITE
REQUIREMENTS TO CLARIFY THAT
OUR RESIDENTS PERSONAL
INFORMATION PROVIDED TO
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION IS
PROTECTED AND TO CLARIFY THAT A
RESIDENT WILL BE FULLY INFORMED
OF THE OPT IN OR OPT OUT
SITUATION VIA EMAIL
COMMUNICATIONS PROCESS. THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTE
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. IN WITH ME ON THE
PHONE TODAY I HAVE- JENNIFER
SEBEK REPRESENTING THE BILL'S
SPONSOR WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU AS MISS
JENNIFER SPECK ON THE PHONE.
YEP RESPECT YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JENNIFER SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS PROBLEMS WITH SB THREE
NINETY TWO FIRST WOULD LIKE TO
THANK CHAIRED THE COMMITTEE AND
STAFF WILL BE OFFERING HIS
DOCTOR THEIR WORK ON THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT BEGIN. THE
PRODUCT BY THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS. I'M MEMBERS FROM THE
WEBSITE REQUIRE INITIAL THAT
HOME OF THE ALTERNATE CONTROL
THEIR PREFERRED METHODS OF
COMMUNICATION. FOLLOW SHINE THE
CONSUMER PRIVACY IS ALSO
PROTECTED. EXACTLY WHAT
OCCURRED PROPERTY OWNERS
ANNUALLY PROVIDE AN H. AWAY
UPDATED CONTACT INFORMATION BUT
DOES NOT REQUIRE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS TO TRANSMIT
INFORMATION TO HOMEOWNERS WE
EMAIL EVEN BETTER THE
HOMEOWNERSHIP PREFERRED
DELIVERY METHOD. SIMPLY
EXPLAINED SB THREE NINETY TO
COMPILE HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS.
TO COMMUNICATE WITH HOMEOWNERS
VIA EMAIL. I DON'T REMEMBER
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT PROPERTY
OWNER GIPSON FINAL TWO BILLS
COMMUTER METHODS NOW TO BE A
FIFTY. FINELY COMMITTEE MOMENT
ALSO SHOW HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS MAY NOT SOUND
PROPERTY OWNERS PERSONAL
INFORMATION TO A THIRD PARTY.
GIVEN THE TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCEMENT OVER THE LAST
THIRTY YEARS AND IN RESPONSE TO
THE GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
HIGHLIGHTED THE DECISION
THROUGH THE LAST OF THE
COLLABORATION WITH THEM
GREENERY MIGHT BE AN OPTION
DRIVEN BY THE HOMEOWNER DID NOT
THE ASSOCIATION PRESIDENT. SB
THREE NINETY TWO WILL IMPROVE
ITS ABILITY TO IMPORTANT
DOCUMENTS MODE YOU CAN DELIVERY
COSTS BY REQUIRING HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION TO COMMUNICATE WITH
HOMEOWNERS IN THE EMAIL. THAT
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER. ANY
QUESTION RESPECTFULLY AFTER I
BOUGHT. THANK YOU ON ANY OF
WITNESSES ON S. B. THREE NINE
TWO- I SEE NINE HEARING THE
GALLERY NONE IN ROOM ONE. LET'S
TURN TO THE PHONE LINES NOW-
BARAMATI RAIDER IF YOU COULD
ASK THOSE TO QUEUE UP WERE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE NINE TWO
PLEASE GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR
FILIATION IN YOUR POSITION. I'D
BE GLAD TO ANSWERLADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE NINETY.
THREE NINETY TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT THE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU LIKE IT
BECAUSE SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS
AT ONE ZERO FOUR SB. THREE NINE
ZERO. AND I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
ONE IN SUPPORT ALRIGHT LET'S
NOW TURN TO OPPOSITION- I
pBELIEVE WE HAVE. OF MARJORIE
MOORE MORAIS AND ELAINE LET
LOVE PLANT ONLINE IN OPPOSITION.
STE MARIE ARE YOU ONLINE. IF
MISS MURRAY'S NOT ONLINE LET'S
SEE A MISSED LET LOVE PLANT
DOES ONLINE. SENATOR BURKE AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS ELAINE LEAD LAP PLAN CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU. SB THREE
NINETY TWO ASSOCIATION ARE
ATTEMPTING TO EXEMPT THEMSELVES
FROM THE CONSUMER PRIVACY
PROTECTION. Q. ASPECTS OF THIS
VIOLATE EXISTING REGULATIONS
MOST IMPORTANTLY THAT'S A
CONSENT AND THAT TOOK
DISCLOSURE STATE AND FEDERAL
PRIVACY LAWS HOLD THAT EMAIL
ACCOUNT OUR PERSONAL NON PUBLIC
INFORMATION AT THE INDIVIDUAL
AND HE'S SAYING THAT EMAIL
ACCOUNT HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED.
THE EMAIL ACCOUNT IS THE
PROPERTY OF THE INDIVIDUAL WHO
CREATED THE ACCOUNT AND THE
ONLY PERSON WHO CAN DECIDE HOW
IT IS TO BE USED IN RECEIPT.
CAN REPLY EMAIL COMMUNICATION.
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO SEND
COMMUNICATION TO AN EMAIL
ADDRESS WE MUST FIRST OBTAIN
AFFIRMATIVE CONSENT OF THE
OWNER SB THREE NINETY TWO
IGNORE THIS AFFIRMATIVE CONSENT
TO REQUIREMENTS IT TRANSFERS
THE USE AND CONTROL OF THE
INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNERS EMAIL TO
THE H. AWAY BOARD WORSE IT
STATE THAT THE MEMBERSHIP OF
THE ASSOCIATION CHEMTRAILS AND
WHETHER TO USE EMAIL ACCOUNTS
FOR THE DELIVERY OF DOCUMENTS.
THE MEMBERSHIP ITSELF HAS NO
AUTHORITY. TO DECIDE WHETHER.
OR HAVE AND IN MEMBERS EMAIL
ADDRESS CAN BE USED. SENATE
BILL NINE THIRTY TWO DOES NOT
REQUIRED THAT THE HM EIGHT
BOARDS EXCUSE DISCLOSED TO THE
MEMBERSHIP WHAT INFORMATION
WILL BE COLLECTED FOR WHAT
PURPOSE IT WILL BE USED AND TO
WHAT THIRD PARTIES THAT MIGHT
BE DISSEMINATED EXISTING STATE
AND FEDERAL LAWS REQUIRE THAT
AN ANNUAL CHRISTMAS HE NOTICED
BE DISSEMINATED BY ANY ENTITY
THAT COLLECTS PERSONAL NON
PUBLIC INFORMATION OR PERSONAL
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION. H.
AWAY BOARDS AND THEIR AGENTS
SHOULD NOT BE EXEMPT FROM NEEDS
CONSUMER PROTECTION. MANDATE
LLANELLY CARGO DON'T KNOW.
EIGHT ME IF WOULD WRAP IT UP.
YEAH WELL ALREADY SB OKAY SB.
THREE NINETY TWO IS TRYING TO
EXAMINE EACH AWAY BORDER TRIED
TO DAMAGE THEMSELVES EMILY
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A PROTEST
NOW ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MA'AM.
AND HOW ABOUT MISS MARIA YOU
ONLINE. I ON THE LINE CAN YOU
HEAR ME NOW WE CAN GO AHEAD
MISS MARIE. FIRST OF ALL WE
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
TAKING THE AMENDMENT WHICH
EXERCISES THE WEBSITE
REQUIREMENTS- WHICH IS
UNREACHABLE BY MANY
ASSOCIATIONS WHERE INTERNET
SERVICE AND EVEN SELF CELL
PHONE SERVICE IS NOT AVAILABLE
THROUGHOUT LARGE AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA- I WANTED TO
INTRODUCE MISLED LOVE PLANTS
WHO IS AN AUTHORITY ON THE
ISSUE OF STATE AND FEDERAL
PRIVACY LAWS. SHE IS A TAX
ATTORNEY SHE IS AN ADJUNCT
PROFESSOR AT ONE OF OUR LOCAL
COLLEGES. AND IS IN THE FORTY
WITH TWENTY YEARS WORTH OF
EXPERIENCE AND COMPLIANCE
MATTERS IN THE FINANCIAL
INDUSTRY. SO WE WERE- THAT.
VERY FORTUNATE TO HAVE HER PUT
THE PUT SB THREE NINE TWO IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE STATE AND
FEDERAL PRIVACY LAWS AND I DO
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT. BECAUSE
OF THE ASIAN ALREADY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY AND THE POWER TO BE
ABLE TO DELIVER DOCUMENTS BY
EMAIL THE CRITICAL POINT IS
THAT THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
OBTAIN THE CONSENT OF THE OWNER
OF THE ADDRESS BEFORE
DELIVERING DOCUMENTS. SO WE
WANT TO STRESS THAT POINT AND
THEN MISLED LOW PLANTERS
ALREADY SAID THERE ARE ALSO
DISCLOSED DISCLOSURE ISSUES
WITH THIS BILL. THERE IS NO
INDICATION OF EXACTLY WHAT
INFORMATION IS GOING TO BE
COLLECTED AND HOW IT IS GOING
TO BE USED. BUT THE CONSENT
ISSUE REALLY GOES TO THE HEART
OF THE MATTER THAT THE EMAIL
ADDRESS IS OWNED BY SOMEONE AND
NOBODY ELSE CAN TELL THEM WHAT
TO DO WITH IT. OR DELIVER
DOCUMENTS TO THAT ADDRESS
WITHOUT THEIR EXPLICIT. WRITTEN
CONSENT. FOR THE MEMBERS CAN'T
VOTE I MEAN THAT THAT'S JUST
YOU'RE RELEVANT PROVISION OF
THE BILL THAT SOMEHOW THE
GENERAL MOTORS- IF YOU'VE BEEN
A GOOD RUN UP. YES I JUST WANT
TO MAKE THAT ONE LAST SENTENCE
THAT IT'S IRRELEVANT SAID
SOMEHOW THE GENERAL MEMBERSHIP
OF AND ASSOCIATION CAN VOTE ON
HOW THEIR NAME NEIGHBORS CAN
USE THEIR PRIVATE EMAIL
ADDRESSES. THAT REALLY NEEDS TO
COME OUT OF THE MEASURE ALL
RIGHT THANK ALSO MURRAY WE WISH
THE COMMITTEE VOTING NO ON A
FAIRLY. THANK YOU- LET'S NOW
TURN TO THE GALLERY ANYONE THE
GARY IN OPPOSITION. NOW IN THE
GALLERY ROOM ONE TWELVE NO ONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. ANYONE ELSE
ON THE PHONE LINES IN
OPPOSITION MATAMATA WRITER IF
YOU WOULD TO THEM UP. THOSE WHO
OPPOSED TO SB THREE NINE TWO
GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR
FILIATION YOUR POSITION. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE NINE TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE NINE TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO ACTIVE
TIME. AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE A
WE HAVE ONE PERSON AN OPERATOR.
HOLD ON THE LINE OF FIVE FOUR
SEVEN FIVE FOUR SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. MY NAME IS TOM
THIRD I LIVE IN A SENIOR- THE
IDEA GONNA COUNTY AND I'M HERE.
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MY FATHER
WHO HAD AN EMAIL ADDRESS SET UP
BY HIS GRANDDAUGHTER SIR ARE
YOU ALSO BELIEVE IN SUPPORT OF
IT THE BILL. I AM OPPOSING THE
HEAD. HE WOULD HAVE BEEN THE
VICTIM OF THE- MODERATOR FOR
THE NEXT NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I
HAVE NO ONE ELSE WOULD YOU AT
THE TIME SIR ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONE
LINE SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. I'M
READY TO DOMINATE THE REMINDER
FROM GOING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THAT TIME. ALL
RIGHT AND I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION GREAT I SEE-
CERTAINLY BECAUSE HE'S GOT A
MICROPHONE UP OR BRING IT BACK
HERE THE CHAMBERS AND WHAT
HEALTHY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I STAYED OFF THIS BILL WHEN IT
WAS IN HOUSING CáC I'VE DONE A
COUPLE OF BILLS AND WITH THE
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
PARTICULAR WITH ELECTIONS. AND
THIS USE OF THE- EMAIL LESS AND
ALSO MEMBERSHIP LIST BECAUSE
LOTS OF MEMBERS WANT TO
COMMUNICATE WITH EACH OTHER. SO
I GUESS MY THE CLARIFICATION IS
THAT. IF WITH THE- H. AWAY. IF
THEY- THESE EMAILS. ADDRESSES
FOR. THE FAULT- INDIVIDUAL
NOTICE WELL THESE MOVE OVER TO
THAT COMMUNICATION- A SECTION
WITH ALL STAR COMMUNICATING
WITH WITH MEMBERS VERSUS JUST
GIVING THEM NOTICE. NO AND
NOTICE ONLY A REASON I ASKED
THAT QUESTION. EITHER AUTHORED
THE ADVOCATES CAN CITIES
BECAUSE THEN WILL THE MEMBERS
BE ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THOSE. EMAILS WHEN THEY WANTED
TO COMMUNICATIONS DURING
ELECTIONS IN THE LIGHT. ZURCHER
YOU CAN TAKE THE QUESTION OUR
NEW CLOTHES- I'LL DO IT NOW IF
YOU DON'T MIND- SENATOR THANKS
FOR YOUR QUESTION THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE PUT TOGETHER
FROM LAST COMMITTEE IN THE
COURSE FOR THE CHAIRS INVOLVED
WITH OUR COMMITTEE. WE ADDRESS
THE ISSUES OF PRIVACY AND
PERTINENT INFORMATION
PERTAINING TO ONLY THE
ASSOCIATION BUT ALASKA-
JENNIFER SABIC THE ALSO JUMP IN
ON THAT. QUESTION AS WELL.
JORDAN DOT ORG COPY. REDUCE Q.
V. AND THOUGH THIS WERE NOT
CHANGING THE PROCESS BY WHICH
HONORS COMMUNICATOR PRIMARY
SUMMIT COMMUNICATIONS WITHIN
THE ANNUAL NOTICE. ASSEMBLY
ADDING ANOTHER LINE TO THAT TO
ALLOW IN ADDITION TO U. S. MAIL
BEING IN. FOR A FAST EMAIL
MEMBERS EMAIL TO BE USED FOR
THAT COMMUNICATION DOES NOT USE
N. B. ELECTIONS ARE BETTER
PLAYERS. OKAY SO IT'S JUST FOR
NOTRE SONG WRITERS NO OTHER.
OBVIOUS OTHER COMMUNICATIONS
THAT GO ON BETWEEN HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION. IS THAT CORRECT
THE CIVIC. WHAT ARE THANK. IF
YOU TURN LEAD THING THAT OF NEW.
THE ONLY AND OTHER INFORMATION
CURTAIN. TO FOR THE THIRD
STRAIGHT ACTIVITY WHICH ARE IN
A NOTICE RELEASED. THE RESERVE
STUDIES TO THE HOMEOWNERS WHERE
WE'RE THEY'RE SUPPOSED FENCE
LINE. AND RATHER NOT. OUR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. A SINGLE OTHER
QUITE. SURGERY COULD CLOSE YEAH
THANK YOU WAS CHAIR WE YOUR IN
BY. WITH THE COMMITTEE AND THE
MEN WOULD TAKE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
IS THERE MOTION. SO WE ARE
MOVES THE BILL. ALL RIGHT WHEN
CHIEF CUNSEL CALL THE ROLL
THIS IS. THREE HUNDRED AND TWO
BY AND ARE LET THE AND- THE
MOTION BY SENATOR WIENER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR- BURKE HI
NUMBER FIVE FORTUS. CABALLERO
HI I HAVE A AT ALL I DID
AWESOME HI PRESS SO I GONZALEZ
HI. GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG.
JONES LAYERED HI THERE I STERN.
K. BY CAL SKI. WIECKOWSKI NOT
VOTING. WIENER WIENER AYE SO
FAR YOU HAVE. SIX TWO ZERO ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU WILL PUT THAT
ON CALL THANK YOU IT'S AN ARCH
ALETTA NOW SENATOR NUMEROUS
THANK YOU. THAT ARE NEWMAN.
GETS THE AWARD. MERITORIOUS
SERVICE AWARD. FOR BEING THE
MOST PATIENTS TODAY. SAN ROMAN
WE HAVE BEFORE US SB TWO EIGHT
NINE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AT THAT'S WITH AN
OAK LEAF CLUSTER I MIGHT ADD.
INDEED MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'M HERE BEFORE YOU
TODAY TO ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
S. B. TWO EIGHT NINE WHICH
WOULD CREATE A CONVENIENCE
STATEWIDE PRODUCER FUNNY
COLLECTION AND RECYCLING
PROGRAM FOR CONSUMER BATTERIES.
AS YOU'RE PROBABLY AWARE
BECAUSE OF THE HAZARDOUS METALS
AND CORROSIVE METAMATERIALS THE
BATTERIES CONTAIN CALIFORNIA
CLASSIFIES BATTERIES AS
HAZARDOUS WASTE WHEN EXPRESSLY
BANS THEM FROM SOLID WASTE
LANDFILLS WHEN PEOPLE ARE DONE
WITH THEIR LOOSE BATTERIES IN
PORTABLE ELECTRONICS. THEY ARE
EXPECTED TO SAVE THEM SORT THEM
AND THEN FIND INAPPROPRIATE
DISPOSAL OPTION. UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY
LACKS A STREAMLINED AND CONVENE
A COLLECTION AND RECYCLING
SYSTEM FOR BATTERIES AT THE
MOMENT THIS TEND TO BE MORE THE
EXCEPTION THAN THE RULE. I
WOULD ASK YOU AS CONTACTING
CONCERNING THE BILL BEFORE YOU
TODAY TO TAKE A MOMENT TO THINK
ABOUT ALL OF YOUR BATTERIES
THINK ABOUT ALL THE DOUBLE A.
AND TRIPLE. A. AND OTHER TYPES
OF BATTERIES YOU GO THROUGH A
YEAR. GOING ALL THE MANY
DEVICES THE ARE SO DEEP
EMBEDDED IN OUR- MODERN LIVES
THESE DAYS THE REMOTE CONTROLS
THE COMPUTER KEYBOARDS THE MICE
THE CLOCKS THE FLASHLIGHTS.
YOU'RE LIKELY TO PRESSURE KIDS
TOYS IT CENTER NOW. THINK ABOUT
ALL THE RECHARGEABLE DEVICES
EVERYBODY CARRIES THESE DAYS AS
WELL EACH ONE WITH ITS OWN
LITHIUM ION. OR SIMILAR BATTERY
NOW MULTIPLY YOUR BATTERIES BY
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION JUST
UNDER FORTY MILLION PEOPLE IN
THEN CONSIDER HOW CHALLENGING
IT IS TO PROPERLY RECYCLE. ALL
OF THOSE BATTERIES ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU CONSIDER THE FACT THAT
THERE'S CURRENTLY NO UNIFIED
SYSTEM IN PLACE. IN CALIFORNIA
FOR DOING SO NOW CONSIDER THIS
ALARMING FACT AS WELL. EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THOSE BATTERIES
CONTAINS HAZARDOUS TOXIC AND
CORROSIVE MATERIALS LIKE
MERCURY CADMIUM. LITHIUM AND
LET WHEN IMPROPERLY DISCARDED
BATTERIES POSE A SERIOUS
ENVIRONMENTAL HAZARD. BECAUSE
OF A COMBINATION INCREASE
CONSUMPTION A LACK OF CONVENE
DISPOSAL OPTIONS. HIGHER LEVELS
OF TOXIC BATTERIES AND PRODUCTS
ARE CONTINUE ENTERING
CALIFORNIA'S WASTE STREAM. WHEN
BATTERIES ARE TOSSED INTO THE
TRASH INSTEAD OF PROBABLY
RECYCLE THE END UP IN LANDFILLS
WHERE THEY DECAY AND LEAKAGE
DISPOSABLE BATTERIES CORRODE.
CHEMICAL SOAK INTO SOILING
CONTAMINATE GROUNDWATER AND
SURFACE WATER. DELEGATE ALREADY
STRAINED ECOSYSTEMS ARE
COMPROMISED WHEN EXPOSED TO
BATTERY CHEMICALS WHEN WE DRINK
FROM TAP WATER FAUCETS. WE
COULD BE INGESTING DANGEROUS
METALS. LITHIUM BATTERIES IN
PARTICULAR CAN BE VERY UNSTABLE
AND WHEN IMPROPERLY DISPOSED
OPPOSE SERIOUS FIRE HEALTH AND
SAFETY HAZARDS. IN FACT OVER
THE PAST DECADE THE MASSIVE
INFLUX OF IMPROPERLY DISPOSED
OF LITHIUM ION BATTERIES. INTO
CALIFORNIA VOICESTREAM HAS
RESULTED IN ALARMING NUMBER OF
FIRES IN OUR MATERIAL RECOVERY
FACILITIES WASTE COLLECTION
TRUCKS. AND OUR LANDFILLS WHEN
LITHIUM ION BATTERIES BURNED IT
RELEASES FLUORIDE GAS WHICH
POSES SERIOUS TOXIC THREATS. TO
HELP TO THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF WORKERS. FIREFIGHTERS AND
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITY TO
VAPORIZE COMPONENTS OF BURN
BATTERIES ALSO GET TRAPPED IN
THE ATMOSPHERE AND POLLUTE
LAKES AND STREAMS IN THE FORM
OF ACID RAIN AS WELL AS
CONTRIBUTING. TO GLOBAL
WARMING. ACCORDING TO A TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA PRODUCTS
TUITION COUNCIL SURVEY TWENTY
OF THE TWENTY SIX MATERIAL
RECOVERY FACILITIES THEY
SURVEYED. EXPERIENCED AT LEAST
ONE FIRE DURING THE PREVIOUS.
TWO YEARS 65% OF WHICH WE'RE
ALMOST TO THE WERE TRUE. IN
DISCARD BATTERY. WITHOUT
DRAMATIC REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
LITHIUM ION BATTERIES AND WE
CALIFORNIA'S WAY STREAM.
CALIFORNIA WILL SUFFER
ADDITIONAL FIRES THAT WOULD
JEOPARDIZE WASTE OPERATIONS IN
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
WORKERS AND OUR COMMUNITIES
YOU'LL BE HEARING FIRST HAND
FROM ONE OF THE LEAD WITNESSES.
THIS AFTERNOON ABOUT THE
DEVASTATING IMPACTS. OF THESE
FIRES. HUNDREDS PROVISIONS SB
TWO EIGHT NINE WILL CREATE A
COORDINATED SYSTEM. OF FREE AND
CONVENIENT COLLECTION BINS FOR
MOST LOSING PRODUCT EMBEDDED
BATTERIES. AT RETAIL LOCATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE TO ALLOW
CONSUMERS TO PLACE BATTERIES
INTO THE BINS FOR PROPER
DISPOSAL. RATHER THAN
DISCARDING THEM ALONG WITH THE
REST OF THEIR HOUSEHOLD TRASH.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO CREATE A
CONSUMER OUTREACH AND EDUCATION
CAMPAIGN TO EDUCATE
CALIFORNIANS AND ENCOURAGES THE
PROPER DISPOSAL OF ALL
BATTERIES. THIS APPROACH TO
POLICY GENERALLY FOR TWO IS
EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY WHICH SB TWO
EIGHT NINE. WILL PROVIDE A
CONSUMER BATTERIES HAS FIRM
ROOTS IN CALIFORNIA LAW HAS
BEEN PREVIOUS EMPLOYED
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY
IMPROVED. RECYCLING FOR AN
ARRAY OF HARD TO RECYCLE
MATERIALS FROM MATTRESSES TO
AUTOMOBILE TIRES TOO. NOT
COINCIDENTALLY CAR BATTERIES IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THIS LEGISLATOR
PASSED THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
BY NEARLY UNANIMOUS VOTE SB TWO
ONE TWO. AUTHORED BY OUR
COLLEAGUE FORMER SENATOR HANNAH
BETH JACKSON. WHICH REQUIRES
MANUFACTURERS IN THE
PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRY TO TAKE
BACK UNUSED AND WASTED NEEDLES
AND DISCARDED DRUGS. SB TWO
EIGHT NINE REPLICATE THIS MODEL
AND CONTINUES THIS VERY
POSITIVE TREND. THE OPPOSITION
IS LIKELY TO ASSERT THAT THE
BILL WOULD INCREASE THE COST OF
VITAL PRODUCTS TO CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS. TO THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY POINT OUT THAT THE
COSTS OF THESE LITHIUM ION
INDUCED FIRES AS WELL AS THE
GENERAL ENVIRONMENTAL DANGERS.
ARE ALREADY BEING BORNE BY OUR
WASTE RECYCLING OPERATORS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FIRE PROFESSIONALS
THE ENVIRONMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
AND CONSUMERS. AS A PARTIAL
CONSEQUENCE CALIFORNIA CITY
CENTERS FOR THE GARBAGE RATES
WILL INCREASE INCREASE. IN THE
NEXT THREE YEARS AND IN THESE
LITHIUM ION BATTERIES. IF THESE
LITHIUM BY EMBARRASSED CONTINUE
BECAUSE TAX DEFERRED GROWTH
STATE THE COST OF INSURING
LOCAL WASTE. MANAGEMENT
FACILITIES IS CERTAIN TO
INCREASE AS WELL. THE PRODUCERS
OF CONSUMER BACK ADORATION
CURRENTLY SHOULDER ANY OF THE
COSTA. WITH THE TALKS FIRES IN
OUR INVENTOR INVITE HARMS. BY
THEIR PRODUCTS BY ENROLLING
PRODUCERS AS PART OF A MORE
EFFECTIVE AND IN SYSTEM FOR
RECYCLING CONSUMER BATTERIES.
WE CAN PREVENT THESE DISASTERS
FROM OCCURRING THEREBY SAVING
THE COST PART GARBAGE RATES.
WHILE PROTECTING THE HEALTH OF
THE PUBLIC REDUCING THE RISK TO
WASTE PERSONALLY WORKERS AND
BETTER SAFEGUARDING
CALIFORNIA'S LAND. WATER AND
AIR. BINDING MANUFACTURES AND
RETAILERS TO A SYSTEM SUCH AS
THIS IS EMINENTLY SENSIBLE AND
FAIR. AND CONSISTENT WITH OTHER
SIMILAR EFFORTS IN CALIFORNIA
AND ACROSS THE NATION. YOU
LIKELY HER OPPOSITION MAKE
REFERENCE TO A SIMILAR BILL
THAT PASSED WATCHING TO SEE HOW
THIS BILL COULD MODEL THAT ONE.
SB TWO EIGHT NINE SHARES A
FRAMEWORK SIMILAR TO THE DC
BILL HOWEVER PLEASE NOTE THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS ROUGHLY FIFTY
SEVEN TIMES THE POPULATION
WATCHING BC. IN A MUCH
DIFFERENT RURAL VERSUS CITY
DIVIDE. THEREFORE WELL WE VIEW
THE DC MODEL IS A GOOD AND
RELEVANT TO REFERENCE POINTS.
NEPR BATTERIES AT RECYCLING
PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA WILL BE
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS BASED ON
OUR SIZE OUR DEMOGRAPHICS INTO
RECYCLING STRUCTURES. USING DC
HAS REFERENCE HOWEVER WE ARE
CURRENTLY CONSIDERING MAKING
ADJUSTMENTS. AROUND PERFORMANCE
GOALS IN THE SIZES OF BATTERIES
IN PRODUCTS COLLECTED. THE
BILL'S SPONSORS IN MY OFFICE
HAVE BEEN MEETING WITH
OPPOSITION AND WILL CONTINUE TO
BE OPEN TO DOING SO WERE
CENSORED THEIR TO THEIR
CONCERNS AND COMMITTED TO
GENERATING SUPPORT AMONG ALL
PARTIES. WHILE LEAVING THE
INTENT OF THE BILL INTACT. WITH
ME HERE IN THE CHAMBER TODAY TO
TESTIFY AS JASON SCHMELZER. ON
BEHALF ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL. AND ON THE PHONE IS
JOE LAW MARIANA EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF RETHINK WASTE I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THIS AFTERNOON. I YOU
SENATOR. WELL WORTH THE WAIT-
ALL RIGHT. SO MR SCHMELZER.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AT JASON'S MOTHER HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL ONE
OF THE THREE CO SPONSORS OF SB
TWO EIGHTY NINE SENATOR NEWMAN
FOCUSED ON THE NEED FOR SB TWO
EIGHTY NINE SO I'M GONNA FOCUS
QUICKLY ON THE MECHANICS OF THE
BILL SO WHAT IS THE BILL DO I'M
SB TWO EIGHTY NINE ESTABLISHES
A PERFORMANCE BASED RECYCLING
SYSTEM FOR LOOSE BATTERIES IN
CONSUMER PRODUCTS THAT CONTAIN
NON REMOVABLE BATTERIES.
PRODUCERS WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
DESIGN FUND AND OPERATE A
PROGRAM THAT WILL COLLECT AND
RECYCLE THEIR PRODUCTS THEY CAN
COMPLY INDIVIDUALLY BUT THE
LIKELY RESULT IS THAT THEY WILL
COMBINE TO FORM A STEWARDSHIP
ORGANIZATION TO MANAGE THE
PROGRAM ON THEIR BEHALF THE
STEWARDSHIP ORGANIZATION
SUBMITS A PLAN TO THE
DEPARTMENT WHO THEN CHECKS THE
PLAN TO MAKE SURE THAT IT MEETS
ALL THE STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS.
SB TWO EIGHTY NINE WOULD ALSO
ESTABLISH A FEW DIFFERENT-
PERFORMANCE GOALS TO KEEP THE
PROGRAM O TRACK BUT OTHERWISE
IT FREES UP THE INDUSTRY TO
IMPLEMENT THEPROGRAM THAT WORK
FOR THEM IT'S PERFORMANCE BASED
AS OPPOSED TO COMMAND AND
CONTROL THE DEPARTMENT CAN
ADJUST THOSE PROGRAM
PERFORMANCE GOALS OF YOUR
REGULATIONS FOR ALL
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE THE ABILITY.
TO PROVIDE FEEDBACK AND I WOULD
NOTE IF YOU LOOK AT EXISTING
RECYCLING PROGRAMS HAVING SOME
SORT OF FLEXIBILITY AND NOT
HAVING CONVENIENCE STANDARDS
LOCKED. INTO STATUTE- IS QUITE
USEFUL. THERE'S NO FEE ON.
COVER THE PRO. THE INDUSTRY.
THE COST- AND WORKS OUT THOSE
DETAILS AMONGST THEMSELVES.
THEIR PENALTIES FOR NON
COMPLIANCE BUT THEY'RE
CONSISTENT WITH THE LAST
PROGRAM THIS TYPE. THAT WAS
PASSED BY THE LEGISLATURE
EXTENDED ESTABLISHES AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE SO WHETHER
STAKEHOLDERS. CAN HAVE INPUT
INTO THE PROCESS. SB TWO EIGHTY
NINE A STRUCTURED SIMILARLY TO
RECENT LEGISLATION AS NOTED BY
SENATOR NEWMAN. THE CREATED A
PROGRAM FOR LEFTOVER DRUGS AND
NEEDLES AT THE STATE HOUSE
MAKERS OF. VITAL MEDICINES TO
MITIGATE THE END OF LIFE
IMPACTS OF THEIR PRODUCTS. AND
ALL OF THE LEGISLATURE CAN
CERTAINLY ASK THE SAME OF
BATTERY MANUFACTURERS. TO BE
CLEAR WE HAVE BEEN AND WILL
CONTINUE PRO ACTIVELY WORKING
WITH VARIOUS OPPONENTS WE FEEL
VERY POSITIVE ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF COMING TO TERMS
OF POLICE SOME OF THEM. AB FOR
THOSE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR VOTE TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISSPELLED HER
MISTER. LEMERRE JANA ARE YOU ON
THE PHONE. YES I AM MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SO MUCH GO
AHEAD- YOU IN THE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS JOE LIBERTY ANA I AM
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
RETHINK WEIGHT PUBLICLY OWNED
REGIONAL SOLVE PUBLIC WASTE
MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY WE ARE
FORMED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO.
WE'RE VERY CONSERVATIVE COUNTY
AND WE SIR FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THOUSAND RESIDENTS AND
ABOUT ELEVEN THOUSAND
BUSINESSES ACROSS ELEVEN
JURISDICTIONS FOR ME AWHILE TO
TALES BOROUGH. ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED OF OUR WORKERS OUR PEAK
SUMMER FACILITY EVEN HANDLE
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
TONS. OF WASTE MATERIALS EVERY
YEAR. THE WORKERS TAKE AND
FACILITY- AT THREE RISK. FROM
LITHIUM ION BATTERIES ALL THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE GAVE
THE YEARS THAT WE OPERATE. IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN WE EXPERIENCED
IT FIRSTHAND CATASTROPHIC.
FIRES THAT WE BELIEVE WAS DUE
TO A LITHIUM ION BATTERY AT A
RECYCLING CENTER. OUR FACILITY
WAS CLOSED DOWN PERFORMANCE IN
BECAUSE EIGHT AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS WITH OF DAMAGE
IS. OVER SIXTY WORKERS WERE
FURLOUGHED DURING THIS TIME AND
IT TOOK ABOUT A YEAR TO READ
ONLY REPAIR EVERYTHING. IT THE
FIRE HAD ONE INSURANCE PROVIDER
TODAY WE NEED SEVEN FOR THE
SAME LEVEL OF COVERAGE. IN FOUR
YEARS OUR INSURANCE PREMIUMS
HAVE RISEN TWELVE TIMES IN OUR
DEDUCTIBLES HAVE MULTIPLIED BY
A FACTOR OF OVER THREE HUNDRED
TIMES. WITH HIM I AM BATTERIES
ARE AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT. TO
THE STATE SOLID WASTE INDUSTRY
INTO THE SAFETY OF OUR TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF WORKERS. INSURANCE
PROVIDERS ARE SIMPLY FINDING IT
TOO RISKY TO COVER. FACILITIES
LIKE OURS AFTER THE EXTENT OF
DAMAGES IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
OTHER FIRES IN OUR INDUSTRY.
WE'VE IMPLEMENTED MANY
PREVENTATIVE MEANT MEASURES TO
REMOVE LEVINE MINE BATTERIES
FROM OUR WASTE STREAM. BUT
WE'RE STILL STRUGGLING TO GET
THEM ALL OUT. THE BATTERY
WRITTEN A VERY TECH OVER A
FUNDED WASTE COLLECTION AND
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE.
SYSTEM ACROSS THE STATE. CRISIS
MUST HAVE A SOLUTION NOW. HAS
WILL BE MINE BATTERIES HAVE
BECOME MORE AND MORE COMMON IN
EVERYDAY PRODUCTS. SB TWO EIGHT
NINE PROVIDING RESPONSIBLE WAY
TO HANDLE MATERIALS AT THE END
OF THEIR USEFUL LIFE. AND IS
CRITICAL TO PROTECTING OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKERS I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MR LEMAY ON. ANYONE ELSE IN THE
GALLERY IN SUPPORT SAYING NONE
ANYONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
SEEING NONE LET'S TURN TO THE
PHONE LINES NOW. MATAMATA
WRITER IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE TO THE UP IN SUPPORT.
OF S. B. TWO EIGHT NINE. YES
SIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB. SB TWO EIGHT NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WELL OPEN NINE FIVE FOUR
TWO ONE FIVE FOUR TWO UNITED
HELP ON. GOOD EVENING ARMCHAIR
NUMBER PROPOSED IT OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING KOREAN
SPECTRUM BUT THE WASTE
MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY TOPWEIGHT.
PUBLIC WITH ADDITION OF NORTH
AMERICA ON WEDNESDAY THE
PASSPORT AND PUBLICLY
INNOVATION SOLUTIONS IN
MANAGEMENT OFTEN OCCURS ON ON
THE COURT SB. EIGHTY NINE THANK.
YOUNG THANK YOU THANKS PLEASE.
WHAT FIVE THIRTY ZERO IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAPTAIN FREEMAN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING ALL FIFTY EIGHT
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE THREE
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CAPTION CHAMBERS NECROPOLIS OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE
WHERE PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THE
BILL IN IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ONE FIVE FIVE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JOHN KENNEDY
WITH THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVE CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
FIVE FIVE NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. AMERILA THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE FIVE
SIX SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IT
COMING WITH THE L. A. COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE FIVE FIVE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHARE
MEMBERS THEIR COFFEE UNHAPPILY
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO EIGHTY NINE. THANK YOU.
ONE FIVE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS JIM WEINBERG ON
BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION THAT CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE THREE TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
ERIC SETS MERCED COUNTY
REGIONAL WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT OF THE S.
B. TWO EIGHTY NINE. THANK YOU.
NINE THREE SEVENTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL DAPAAH
THE PAY MCKINLEY ON BEHALF OF
REPUBLIC SERVICES AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE FIVE
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS FEELING
GRIEF OF THE DANCE MEDICAL
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION NO
POSITION ON THE BILL TODAY BUT
REALLY APPRECIATE SENATE-ROOM
AND WORKING WITH US ON
TECHNICAL ISSUES AND- THANK YOU
HAVE A SEPARATE. THANK YOU.
BEFORE YOU OPEN NINE FORTY
SEVEN AS A REMINDER IF YOU LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR A THREE
TWO EIGHT NINE. ONE FORTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
QUALITY FROM HEALTHCARE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC INTEREST
RESEARCH GROUP AND FOR THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AT THE
TIME AND NO ONE ELSE'S
SUPPORTER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S NOW TURN TO OPPOSITION
UNDERSTOOD MISTER SCOTT
GOVERNOR IS HERE IN THE CHAMBER
IS THE GOVERNOR. THE GALLERY IS
YOURS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR STOP OVERNIGHT
HERE ON BEHALF OF PR BA THE
RETURNS WILL BATTERY
ASSOCIATION. I WEHAVE SPOKEN
WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
PROPONENTS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE TO SPEAK WITH THEM.
WE'VE NOT MADE ANY PROGRESS YET
BUT WE UNDERSTAND AMENDMENTS
WILL BE COMING OUT SHORTLY. YES
WE DID SUGGEST THEY LOOK AT THE
DC MODEL AND LAW CALIFORNIA'S
EXPONENTIALLY LARGER THAN
WASHINGTON DC. WE STILL THINK
IT HAS SOME IMPORTANT ELEMENTS
THAT ARE WORTH CONSIDERING. IN
THIS BILL FOR EXAMPLE THERE IS
A LACK OF DIRECTION CAL RECYCLE
WHICH IS SOMEWHAT CONCERNING
GIVEN THAT THEY HAVE A LOT AN
ABSOLUTE. FIGURE FORTY WITH NO
PERHAPS AS DOES EVERY OTHER
STATE AGENCY THAT MAY BE
IMPACTED BY BATTERY DISPOSAL.
THE SENATOR NEWMAN DISCUSSED
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT WATER
IMPACTS SIX CETERA THIS MEANS
THE T. S. C. C. P. EIGHTY W.
WALKED CALIFORNIA REX SARAH
XCERRA. WOULD ALL BE ABLE TO
IMPOSE FEES RETAILERS ARE
ENTITLED TO IMPOSE FEES FOR UP
FOR SPACE EMPLOYEE TRAINING
INSURANCE. SIX CETERA- THE
MEASURE REFERS TO PROVIDE. AND
PRODUCERS IS KIND OF A- TIMER
FOR TO THE BACK MAKER. THE
PRODUCT MAKER HIM BATTERY IN IT
THE IMPORTER DISTRIBUTOR AND
RETAILER ALL THOSE ENTITIES
WOULD HAVE TO REGISTER WITH
POWER CYCLE. BY APRIL FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO FOUR
MONTHS AFTER THE BILL TAKES
EFFECT NOW WE WON'T KNOW WHICH
OF THOSE ENTITIES WILL BELONG
TO THE STORE TO SHOP AT THAT
POINT. SOME OF THE REPORTING
WILL BE ENTIRELY REDUNDANT AS
NEAR AS WE CAN TELL FAILURE TO
REPORT WOULD SUBJECT THEM TO
ATTEND A FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
PER DAY. PENALTY BY CAL
RECYCLE- YOU THIS MEASURE COULD
GET THERE EVENTUALLY IT NEEDS A
LOT OF CLARIFICATION- AND
SIMPLIFYING- WE HOPE TO GET
THERE EVENTUALLY WITH THE
PROPONENTS BUT FOR NOW WE
REMAIN OPPOSED. AND ASK FOR YOU
KNOW ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR GOVERNOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN OPPOSITION. TO S. B.
TWO EIGHT NINE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF IN OPPOSITION OF
SB TWO EIGHT NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WELL THE
MY NUMBER FIVE ZERO THREE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. WE HAVE TO
SHARE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ADAM WRITERS CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE- IN OPPOSITION AT
TIMES AND- LOOKING COURSE I WAS
THE AUTHOR ON. THE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FROM THE MODERATOR
ONE SECOND IS IT LET ME LET ME
ASK IS ANYONE ELSE IN THE
GALLERY WHO'S HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWO EIGHT
NINE. SEEING NONE AND I SEE NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO EIGHT NINE
LET'S RETURN TO THE PHONE LINES.
YES ONE THREE OH ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU- GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JIM TAYLOR FOR THE PERSONAL
INSURANCE FEDERATION WE ARE
WITH THAT IN OPPOSITION BUT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
OFFICER TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS. WERE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THOSE EFFORTS
AND ARE HOPEFUL THAT OUR ISSUES
WILL BE RESOLVED SOON. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. SIX ONE FIVE
FOUR ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS YOU ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED TO SB TWO
EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU THEY GIVE
NEXT. NINE FIVE SIXTY ONE
UNITED OPEN. THUNDERSTORMS KEY
WITH ME Q. CALCULUS SAYS YES ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION REGRETTABLY OPPOSED
TO SPEECH. READING THANK YOU
NEXT. BEFORE WE OPENED FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN OF THE REMINDERS
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL SB TWO EIGHT NINE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONE FIVE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN BIRDS ASPECT MEANWHILE
ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU. I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION EITHER THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR BRING IT BACK
TO THE CHAMBERS HE SAID A WHITE
CAL SKIS MIKE IS UP SOMEWHERE
CAL SKI. ZURCHER I WOULD SIT ON
THE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE SO I ENJOYED. THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ANALYSIS- I'D
LIKE TO DRAW. YOUR ATTENTION
INTENTION THE AUTHOR TO PAGE.
STARTING AT PAGE ELEVEN WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT THE PROHIBITION
AGAINST ECONOMIC. PROTECTIONISM
AND EMBEDDED IN THE- DOORMAT OF
COMMERCE CLAUSE. IT APPEARS.
HERE'S THE WELL- THE KEY SAID
ON PAGE THIRTEEN C. A. CARBONE
VERSUS THE TOWN OF CLARKSTON.
IT IS DISTINGUISHABLE BECAUSE
THIS IS ONE CITY IN THE STATE
IN YOUR PURSE THE WHOLE STATE.
THE LANGUAGE THAT'S USED IN THE
ANNUAL REPORT AND THE-
PREFERENCE THAT THE TO
PRIORITIZE IN USE OR USE OF IN
STATE PROCESSING FACILITIES
OVER. OUT OF STATE PROCESSING
FACILITIES ON ITS FACE OF
VIOLATION OF DEPARTMENT
COMMERCE CLAUSE SO. IF THE- ALL
THE EXPERTS- THE. CHALLENGE
THAT THIS OTHERWISE FIND BILL
HAS THANK YOU MISTER WHAT
KOWSKI SAID A NEW ONE YOU COULD
ADDRESS THAT NOW IN YOUR
CLOTHES- I'LL DO IT NOW SO. I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONCERN- AS AS
MOVES FOR A LOOK INTO IT I
THINK YOU RAISE A SELLING POINT.
YEAH RT. BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT
ELSE TO SAY OF WELL SAID SENATE
HUESO- THAT THE BILL WILL BE A
AS WE MOVEFOR FROM THERE TO
ADDRESS IS FOR THE- THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT I SEEN OTHER
MICROPHONES AND YES I DO SENATE
CAREER MICROPHONES OFF. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR THIS- THIS BILL I THINK-
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WE HAVE
IS WE- CONTINUE TO EXPAND THE
USE OF ELECTRONIC- OF. DEVICES
AS WELL AS- BATTERIES AS AT AND
USE BATTERIES FOR STORAGE-
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THE REAL. ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
THAT MINING FOR THESE PRODUCTS
HAS ON THE WORLD IN THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE- SEE AT PLACES ALL
OVER THE WORLD IN MIND THIS
REALLY IMPORTANT MINERAL THE
IMPORTANT MINERALS THAT GO INTO
THESE DEVICES AND THEN WE'RE
JUST THROWING THEM INTO THE
LANDFILL TO THE MORE THAT WE
CAN SET UP A REASONABLE LOGICAL
RECYCLING OPPORTUNITY TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE OUT THAT MATERIAL
REUSE IT IS IT'S GOING TO BE IN
THE BEST INTERESTS OF ALL OF US
SO I SUPPORT BELLI. AM NOT I
MAKE GNOSTIC AS TO HOW WE DO
THIS WHETHER IT'S A FEE ON THE
SALE OF A PART OF THE PROJECT
THE THING GOES INTO RECYCLING
OR THE WAY THAT IT'S PROPOSED
IN THIS BILL BUT I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT. THANK YOU
SAID A COUPLE YEARS. HERTZBERG
I WANT TO SAY MAKE TO CENTER
COULD BE COME ABOUT THE PRO BY
I GOTTA TELL YOU I SPENT.
TWELVE YEARS OF THE GOVERNMENT
WORKING IN THE RENEWABLE ENERGY
SPACE IN THE PRINCIPLE AREA
THAT I WAS FOCUSED ON WAS
ELIMINATING BATTERIES THE
LANDFILL PROBLEMS AND ALL THE
CHALLENGES WE TEND TO THINK
THAT. WE HAVE RECHARGEABLE
BATTERIES THE EXTRAORDINARY
CONSEQUENCES TO THE STUFF I WAS
TRYING TO USE SOLAR IN LIEU OF
BATTERIES. BUT BUT- WHATEVER
BUT IT BECAME SO CLEAR TO ME AS
I TRAVELED AROUND TO SO MANY
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE WORLD
WITH A BIG PROBLEM THIS IS AND
I DON'T KNOW ENOUGH ABOUT HIS
REGULATORY STRUCTURE IN TERMS
OF THE BILL BUT I JUST WANT TO
JOIN IN BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS
SUCH AN IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I
APPLAUD. THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING
IT ON IT'S A VERY VERY BIG
ISSUE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER HURTS. ALL RIGHT ANY
OTHER MICROPHONES NO
MICROPHONES. SENATOR YES
CENTERS FOR YOU AT SOMEONE ELSE
OR YOU WANT TO JUST A LITTLE HE
MOVED THE BILL ALL RIGHT SIR
NEWMAN THERE A PLAGUE MISTER
THANK YOU COMMITMENT SO TO.
SEND A COUPLE YEARS POINT HERE
JUST A STEP- INTO SEVEN RUN A
BIRD EACH. THAT'S FOURTEEN
YEARS PEOPLE IN THE UNITED
STATES THROUGH A TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION TONS OF CELL PHONES
TV'S COMPUTERS AND PRINTERS AND
ALL OF THE ASSOCIATED LITHIUM
IN BATTERIES WITHIN THEM. JERRY
THIS IS A SERIOUS PROBLEM I
WILL SAY- I TAKE SERIOUSLY MR
GOVERNOR'S COMMENTS- WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS NEITHER
TOO COMPLEX- NOR TOO EXPENSIVE-
BUT AND ENTERED SYSTEM LIKE
pWORKED IN OTHER STATES. AND
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE RANGE
OF SUPPORT- TO INCLUDE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS COUNTY
CITY GOVERNMENT AND WASTE
MANAGEMENT AGENCIES WHERE THREE
QUARTERS OF THE WAY THERE THE
NEXT STEP IS TO GET OUR
PRODUCERS AND RETAILERS- TO A
PLACE WHERE THEY'RE COMFORTABLE
AND COMMITTED TO WORKING TOWARD
THAT. ENHANCE RESPECTFULLY FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY THANK YOU
THE. CENTER HERTZBERG MOVE THE
BILL. BANNON CHIEF COUNT A
STRONG PLEASE THE ROLL. THIS IS
AS TO A NINE SENATOR NEWMAN
WITH- BY SENATOR. THE MOST IS
DEEP. BUT FIRST BE REAR TO
COMMITTEE A PER. AMBER I- BURKE
AYE BOARD YES. CABALLERO CAVITE
I DID I SAW LINES THAT ARE I.
HI GONZALEZ HI. FOR ITS FOR I'D
JOE. PLAYER BY CLEARED STERN.
YEAH WAIT CAL SKI. I CAN'T AYE
WIENER. YES TO ZERO SO ALREADY
WE'LL PUT THAT AND CALL THANK
YOU SIR NEWMAN THANK YOU DOLLY
I CENTER HERE MOMENT AGO CENTER
HERE THE CHAMBER. IF CENTER
DAHLE IS NOW HERE. I SAW.
EGGMAN HERE. IS WHAT WILL WILL
GIVE CENTER DOLLAR JUST A FEW.
ALL RIGHT- WHILE WE GO AHEAD
LET'S HEAR A CENTER EGGMAN'S
BILL. SO THAT IS S. B. SIX OH
FIVE NUMBER EIGHT ON YOUR
ACCOUNT ON YOUR SCHEDULE. RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS IT IS MY
PLEASURE TO BE HERE. YOU'RE
LISTENING TO YOUR HAVE VIGOROUS
CONVERSATIONS- PERSONAL LIKE TO
START UP BY ACCEPTING THE
COMPANY AMENDMENTS LAID OUT IN
THE ANALYSIS AND THINK- THE
CHAIR AND THE STAFF FOR WORKING
ON THIS. A VERY FINE ANALYSIS
IF WE MAY ADD- SB SIX OH FIVE
IS A NARROW BILL AIMED AT
IMPROVING THE ACCESS AND SAFETY
OF REPAIRING MEDICAL DEVICES-
BUT I THINK IT'S A FITTING FOR
ME TO MENTION THE BROADER RIGHT
TO REPAIR MOVEMENT IN LIGHT OF-
THE OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. AT%
THE GOALS OF THE RIGHT TO
REPAIR AND PEOPLE MAY KNOW IT'S
A MOVEMENT KIND OF MOVING
AROUND THE COUNTRY HAS BEEN FOR
A WHILE- THE GOALS OF THAT ARE
TO REDUCE WASTE. INCREASE
COMPETITION FOR REPAIR TO
SUPPORT LOCAL BUSINESS TO
IMPROVE PRODUCT DURABILITY AND
TO RESTORE WHAT IT ACTUALLY
MEANS TO TRULY OWN OUR OWN
STUFF I THINK WE CAN PROBABLY
ALL AGREE ON THOSE BROAD
PRINCIPLES. I AM A AND OUR
CONVERSATION TODAY THE SADISTIC
HAPPENING ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
AND THE IS THEN HOW DO WE TAKE
THESE BROAD PRINCIPLES THAT WE
ALL BASICALLY AGREE ON. AND PUT
THEM INTO PUBLIC POLICY WHICH
IS WHAT'S BEFORE US TODAY.
YOU'LL SEE A LARGE NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND SOME YOU'LL THINK
WHY ARE THEY OPPOSED TO THIS
SPECIFIC BILL. WELL THE IF THIS
TURNS TO BE A BUSINESS MODEL
WHERE A MANUFACTURER. PRODUCES
A DEVICE FILLED IT TO YOU AND
THEN ALSO. MADEYOU MAY OR MAY
NOT KNOW BUT THEN ARE THE ONLY
ONES WHO WANT TO BE ABLE TO FIX
THAT SAIDDEVICE SO. THE
QUESTION THEN BECOMES DO YOU
OWN THAT DEVICE OR DOES THE
MANUFACTURE CONTINUE TO OWN THE
DEVICE. AND KEEP YOU TETHERED
TO IT THROUGH MAINTENANCE AND
REPAIR AND PARTS- SO WHILE THIS
BILL IS VERY NARROW AND
SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY TO
MEDICAL DEVICES IN HOSPITALS
AND CLINICS- THE OPPOSITION
TENDS TO GROUP TOGETHER
BECAUSE- OF A- BECAUSE AGAIN
IT'S A BUSINESS MODEL THAT GOES
ACROSS DIFFERENT KINDS OF.
ELECTRICAL ELECTRONIC
APPLIANCES- THIS BILL TAKES A
SIMPLE APPROACH LOOKING AT JUST
ONE CATEGORY PRODUCTS POWERED
MEDICAL DEVICES AND TRIES TO
OPEN UP. THE REPAIR MARKET BY
ALLOWING ACCESS TO THE NEEDED
PARTS TOOLS DOCUMENTATION AND
SOFTWARE. FOR MAINTENANCE AND
REPAIRS NOW LET ME STAY BEFORE
I GO ANY FURTHER BECAUSE PEOPLE
SAY OH YOU CAN'T DO THAT. THIS
IS ALREADY DONE. THIS IS
ALREADY LEGAL THIS IS ALREADY
HAPPENING HOSPITALS CAN HAVE
THEIR OWN- BIO TECHNICIANS THEY
CAN CONTRACT WITH EITHER. A
LOCAL BIO TECHNICIANS WITH
OTHER LOCAL REPAIR SHOPS. BUT
THE ISSUE IS A LOT OF THE
MANUFACTURERS WILL THEN PUT ON.
HOLD NOT MAKE PARTS AVAILABLE
WILL NOT MAKE SCHEMATIC
AVAILABLE WILL NOT MAKE TOOLS
AVAILABLE WILL NOT MAKE
TRAINING AVAILABLE SO ANYONE
ELSE WILL BE ABLE. AND
OFTENTIMES WILL- PUT IN CODES
SO THAT YOU CANNOT ACCESS. TO
BE ABLE TO WORK ON THESE
DEVICES- ACCESS TO THESE
RESOURCES WOULD BE LIMITED ALSO
A TO OPENING THAT UP. TO MAKE
THEM NEEDED PARTS DOCUMENTATION
AND SOFTWARE FOR MAINTENANCE
REPAIR ACTIONS THESE RESOURCES
WILL BE LIMITED TO HOSPITALS
AND THOSE INDEPENDENT
INDEPENDENT SERVICE PROVIDERS
REFER TO AS I. S. P.'S WORKING
WITH HOSPITALS ON THE
MAINTENANCE AND REPAIR OF THEIR
EQUIPMENT. EARLY REPORTING ON
COALBED HIGHLIGHTED NOT JUST A
LACK OF INVESTMENT IN OUR
SUPPLY AND EQUIPMENT STOCKPILES
BUT THE CHALLENGING. AB DE THAT
PRESENTS IN TRYING TO REPAIR
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT THE KEY TAKE
AWAY IS NOT THAT THIS WAS A
PROBLEM BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC
BUT WE ALL JUST LEARN MORE
ABOUT THE EXISTING PROBLEM.
THAT WAS ALREADY THERE MADE
VISIBLE BY THE PANDEMIC.
HOSPITALS IN CALIFORNIA MAY
EMPLOY IN HOUSE BY A TECHNICIAN
BIOENGINEERS TECHS THAT WORK ON
IN AN INDEPENDENT. ON ALL CAR
BASIS- THESE ARE ROFESSIONALS
WHO ARE TRAINED TO THE TO THE
DEGREE AS AS THE MANUFACTURER'S
TECHNICIANS BUT THEY'RE
INDEPENDENTLY EMPLOYED OR HAVE
THEIR OWN BUSINESS- THESE ARE
PROFESSIONALS AVE IDENTIFIED
THE MANUFACTURER CREATED
BARRIERS TO REPAIR. IS CRUCIAL
HINDRANCE TO THEIR WORK. AND
PAID INTO PATIENT CARE JUST
LAST YEAR IN A SURVEY OF
BIOMED. YOU WHISPERED FOUND
THAT 92% OF RESPONDENTS REPORT
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN DENIED
ACCESS TO SERVICE INFORMATION
FOR CRITICAL EQUIPMENT. 30%
REPORTED EQUIPMENT AND THE
FACILITIES THAT COULD NOT BE
USED DUE TO RESTRICTIONS ON
SPARE PARTS AND SERVICE
INFORMATION. AND NEARLY 7%
ABOUT 70% OF RESPONDENTS AT THE
HOSPITAL HAD TO DELAY PATIENT
PROCEDURE BECAUSE THEY WERE
WAITING ON A MAC MANUFACTURER
SERVICE REPRESENTATIVE TO FIX
THE DEVICE. THE SURVEY NUMBERS
CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS WHO
SUPPORT THIS EFFORT AND REPORT
THAT MANUFACTURERS ARE OFTEN
UNABLE TO SERVICE EQUIPMENT AT
THE TIME FRAME NEEDED. AND THE
HOSPITAL'S TEAM MUST THEN
DECIDE BETWEEN TAKING A MACHINE
OFFLINE- THAT IS DUE FOR
REGULAR MAINTENANCE. OR NOT
HAVING IT MADE ITS MAIDEN
SCHEDULE WHICH THEN COULD
RESULT IN THEM AT NOT BEING
PAID BY MEDICARE AND BECAUSE
THEY ARE A GOVERNED UNDER CMS
SO THEY HAVE TO KEEP THE
MACHINES UP TO DATE. WITH
MAINTENANCE. I AM DEPARTMENTS
WOULD ARGUE THAT THE EQUIPMENT
IS TOO COMPLICATED. THAT ONLY
THEIR TRAIN PEOPLE CAN REPAIR
THEM- BUT THE WRIST CARE REALLY
FALLS ON THE PATIENTS AND
HOSPITALS RELY ON THESE
MACHINES TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
MACHINE READY TO BE USED WHEN
THE PHYSICIAN WHEN THE
HOSPITAL. NEEDS TO USE IT- ALL
THE CONSUMER ADVOCATES AND
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS AGREED
THAT THIS BILL COULD HELP. IN
THE HEALTH CARE ANALYSIS THEY
CITED- AND ALSO IN YOUR
EXCELLENT ANALYSIS DID A GREAT
JOB BREAKING DOWN THE FINDINGS
OF THE FTA. REPORTS IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TO HIGHLIGHT A LITTLE
BIT- THAT AFTER EXTENSIVE
REVIEW THEY DID NOT BELIEVE
THAT A SAFETY PROBLEM EXISTS
WITH THE SERVICING MAINTENANCE
AND REPAIR OF MEDICAL DEVICES
BY EITHER THIRD PARTY
ORGANIZATIONS. OR MANUFACTURING
THIS BILL SIMPLY REQUIRING THAT
THE SAME PARTS TOOLS
INFORMATION SOFTWARE AND
TRAINING AVAILABLE TO
MANUFACTURERS AUTHORIZED REPAIR
NETWORK. ALSO BE AVAILABLE TO
THOSE EXPERT THIRD PARTIES AN
IN HOUSE ENGINEERS WHO ALREADY
WORK ON THIS CRITICAL.
EQUIPMENT WHEN DEVICES GO
OFFLINE AND CARES DELAYED ITS
PATIENTS THAT SUFFER. THIS BILL
CAN INCREASE COMPETITION REDUCE
COSTS AND HELP PEOPLE. IT
EGGNOG IS THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE
OUT THERE WHO CAN FIX THINGS
WHOSE JOB IT IS TO FIX THINGS.
AND SAYS THEY SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT TO ACCESS TO THOSE TOOLS
PARTS DOCUMENT. AND TRAINING SO
THEY CAN DO SO SAFELY. AND
TIMING- I HAD WITH ME HERE
TODAY IS KEVIN O. RILEY WITH U.
S. PER LIG. AND AT. NOT HAMOUD
A SEASON CLING ENGINEER MANAGER
UP TO YEARS. ALL RIGHT MISTER
RILEY. YOUR AVAILABLE. I AM-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AMERICAN
MEMBERS COMMITTEE HOW MANY
KEVIN ALL I A TO ADVOCATE WITH
US PURGING BURGER COSTA THE
BILL. MANUFACTURERS ARE. RICH
HOT AND INDEPENDENT BIOMEDICAL
REPAIR TECH- BIOMED FROM BUT
CENTRAL. RIGHT THE ACTION HE
SAID- MARCH TWENTY INDEPENDENT
SURVEY ORDER RISKY ONE HUNDRED
FROM THE HOSPITAL TO WORK ON
THE STORY RUNNING IT YEAH YES
YOU HAVE ANOTHER TO ON THE NEAR
YOUR- MICROPHONE. A COMPUTER
ANOTHER AYE AYE HAVE THAT OKAY
BY I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE IS
GOING TO. SORRY ABOUT THAT- SO
YEAH I DON'T SAYING THAT WOULD
LIMIT SERVICE. THAT RECEIVED
HUNDRED. FROM HOSPITAL GOOD
WORKS WITH AND DOES VENTILATOR.
KILEY USE MEANING FOR MONTHS
THAT THEY COULD NOT BE USED TO
TREAT COPD PATIENTS. I DON'T
HAVE ANYWHERE CLOSE TO THAT
MUCH TIME TO WAIT ESPECIALLY
DURING A PANDEMIC. AND THIS
DOESN'T JUST HAPPEN WITHIN A
LEADERS OR JUST WITHIN THEIR-
INDEPENDENT SERVICE PROVIDERS
IT'S NO WONDER THE STORES
RECEIVES SUCH STRONG SUPPORT
FROM HOSPITALS PARTICULARLY IN
RURAL COUNTIES THAT OFTEN
EXPERIENCE LONGER WAITS FOR
MANUFACTURE TECHNICIANS.
MANUFACTURED IS THAT WHILE THEY
HAVE MONOPOLIZED ASPECTS OF
REPAIR IT IS A BENEVOLENT
MONOPOLY ONE DONE TO PROTECT
US. BUT WE CAN'T IGNORE THE
DAMAGE OF REPAIR RESTRICTIONS
THE PATIENT. THE FACT THAT
RAISES THE COST OF HEALTHCARE.
ONLY TAKES CONCERNS SERIOUSLY
SO WE LOOK AT THE DATA AND IN A
TWENTY EIGHTEEN REPORT THE FDA
STATED THAT MANY THIRD PARTY
ENTITIES PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY.
AND EFFECTIVE SERVICING ON
MEDICAL DEVICES AND THAT THE
CONTINUED AVAILABILITY OF THIRD
PARTY ENTITIES TO SERVICE
REPAIR MEDICAL DEVICES IS
CRITICAL TO THE FUNCTIONING OF
THE U. S. HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
THAT'S WHY WE NEED ANOTHER
CONSUMER AND PUBLIC HEALTH
GROUPS SUPPORT SB SIX APPLIES.
THIS BILL DOES NOT MAKE ANY
CHANGES TO THE EXISTING
LIABILITY STRUCTURE IN THE RARE
CASE THAT A DEVICE FAILURE
LEADS TO INJURY. WEBER IS FOUND
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE PART FOR
THE PROBLEM BE IT A
MANUFACTURING DEFECT OF ALL TO
REPAIR OR USER ERROR. WILL BE
HELD LIABLE. IT IS COMMON
PRACTICE FOR HOSPITALS AND
INDEPENDENT SERVICE PROVIDERS
TO KEEP LIABILITY INSURANCE FOR
SUCH CASES. AND ALL OF THIS
WILL CONTINUE TO BE THE CASE
WHEN THE BABY COMES LAW.
ULTIMATELY SB SIX OH FIVE WILL
HELP PATIENTS IN HOSPITALS IN
EVERY CORNER OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S WHY WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU TO VOTE ALL RIGHT- HAPPY TO
THE GROUND ANSWERING QUESTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MISTER ARNOLD ARE YOU ON. YEAH
IT CIRCLE- EVERYONE. MY NAME IS
NOT A HOME WITH- THE CLINCHING
MANAGER AT THAT CALIFORNIA
HEALTH SYSTEM I HAVE OVER
TWENTY YEARS OF EXPERIENCE IN
THE FIELD THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION TO THINK ABOUT WHY
MEDICAL RECORDS THAT IS
BECAUSE- FOR CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURE AND MANUFACTURE
THEM POSE BARRIERS AFFECTING
MEDICAL DEVICE OF THE MIND THE
STATE HAS BEEN HIT BY A PROBLEM
DURING THE PANDEMIC BUT THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING YOU. BUCKLE TIMES
THROUGHOUT MY CAREER I'VE HAD
TO COME INTO THE HOSPITAL IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT OF THE
BOND THAT EARLY MORNING
SURPRISE WILL FAR FROM
DIFFERENT SOURCES AND DEVICES
FOR A BETTER DEVICE THAT MUCH
NEEDED FOR PATIENTS PROCEDURE
IN THOSE MOMENTS WE DIDN'T
HAVE. DAYS OR WEEKS OR EVEN OUR
THREE FOUR MANUFACTURED BECAUSE
OUT OF SERVICE FOR THE BY THE
VISION THAT THE FIVE FIVE AWAIT
SUCH CASES THE ABILITY OFF THE
IN HOUSE BY ABOUT THE QUICKLY
AND YOUR BETTER CRITICAL
MEDICAL DEVICES CAN BE A MATTER
OF LIFE OR DEATH. THIS IS NOT
THE JOKE BY GIVING HOSPITAL BY
MATT AND THE SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS ACCESS FOR THE
THOROUGHBRED MATERIALS AND
INFORMATION THAT WILL REDUCE
DELAYS. AND IMPROVE PATIENT
CARE AND SAFETY. AT THE SAME
TIME THAT THE LOOK. ON THE WAY
OR IF YOU'RE HEALTH CARE COSTS-
ONE WHAT MENTIONED ALREADY
BRINGING. AND SIMPLY ENJOY
COMPETITION THE MONTH THE MONTH.
WE GOT IT YOU OVERHEAD AND BUT
THOSE SAVINGS FOR THE BASE. I
THAT ONLY THE MY- ARE TWELVE TO
SERVE MEDICAL EQUIPMENT. THANK
FOR. THE BY MY AND CLINICAL.
THE MIGHT BE AND ON AND
PENINSULA ARE GOING TO. WE ARE-
WITH AND- EARN DEGREES
CERTIFICATIONS AND UNDERGARMENT
BETTER CONTAINER EDUCATE. COST
IN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SECTOR
WORKING WITH. BUT BY THE TIME
THE AGAIN MEDICAID SERVICES THE
YOUNG COMMISSION ADVOCATE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC- DENTISTRY
WEATHER ALERTS THE ARE AND HOW
BY OUR- OR BEN THOSE OWNER. OR
BY THE MAN. WELL BILL HELLO
THIS WILL PUT- NUMBER CONCERN
IS ALWAYS FISH SAFETY BUT
BETTER MEDICAL WILL ALLOW US
THE PATIENT QUICKLY AND SAFELY
WHILE ALL REFUSED HEALTHCARE.
THIS IS. SB SIX FIVE FOUR
FOURTEEN AND AFFECT ME YOUR
VOTE I ABOUT THE STATE BROWN
QUESTIONS AS WELL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITH MOON. BY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT THE GALLERY C. NONE
ROOM ONE TWELVE C. NINE. ONE
PHONE. DOZENS OF BETTER
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD TO THEM.
THOSE THE SPORT OF SPC OKAY
PLEASE GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION AND YOUR PER.
LADIES GENTLEMEN TO SPEAK OF
SUPPORT BILL AT SIX ZERO FIVE
PRESS ONE AND OUT THE TIME. AND
LOCAL NUMBER FOR NINE OR MY IS
OPEN. DANIEL SERVING IN A OF
SEIZURE OF CENTER AGING ALL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NECKLINE SIX
L. A. GETTING INTERMEMBRANE
PERSONAL KID OFF ON BEHALF OF
NATIONAL ACTION COUNCIL IN
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT YOU'RE
SUCCESSFUL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YOU. FINE FOR EIGHTY SEVEN YEAR
LIGHTED OPEN. YES GO AHEAD.
APOLOGIES ARE QUALITY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC INTEREST
RESEARCH GROUP I'D LIKE TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU TO SOME
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL I RECKON COLLEGE OF
CLINICAL ENGINEERING CO SPONSOR
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
AFSCME CALIFORNIA. LOCATION
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT.
MEDICAL DEVICE ORGANISATION
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED
AMERICANS CALIFORNIA BLACKHAWK
NETWORK. CALIFORNIA HEALTH
ADVOCATES. IN THE STATE WON'T
HELP WITH THE- CARE ACT. THE
LOGICAL CARE THAT THE EXACTLY I
THINK THAT COULD SPONSORED. THE
FROM THE NUMBER OF POLLUTION IT
SURE. WITH EXCEL STRATEGIC
HEALTH CARE WITH THE LLP. ERIC
EXPERIENCE THAT PART. TREME
HELLO HARPER HOOKED SYSTEM OUR
RECORD THE BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANKS PLEASE. LINE TWO
NINE NINE YEAR LINE IS OPEN.
CAN MEMBERS US AT THE CORBIN HI
THERE ARE BEHALF THE L. FOR
FOUNDATION AN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE FOR A YOUR LINE IS- OPEN.
GOOD EVENING OUT CALIFORNIA THE
TELL HOSPITAL SO SHE AND THANK
YOU. LINE FIVE NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI I'M PAUL KELLY
DIRECTOR OF BIOMEDICAL
ENGINEERING AT WASHINGTON
HOSPITAL AND IS CERTIFIED BY
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT TECHNICIAN
FROM FREMONT I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB SIX OH FIVE FOR OUR
PATIENTS. THANK YOU. LINE SIX
ZERO NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SIX OH NINE. I CAN'T SAY THIS
IS CASTRO FUNDING MANAGER IN
CALIFORNIA IN FAVOR. THANK YOU.
BEFORE WE OPEN NINE THREE SEVEN
TWO AT THE REMINDER IF YOU LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
ZERO FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
THE BUREAU AT THIS TIME ONE
THREE SEVEN TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE THREE SEVEN TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOUR MIND IS
MUTED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
AND WITH NO RESPONSE OPEN MY
NUMBER SIX ONE ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS- REGAL REQUEST
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT- SERVICE
MANAGER AT THE HOSPITAL AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN SUPPORTER. THANK YOU GREAT
WESTERN THE OPPOSITION NOW.
WELL WE HAVE FIELDING GREAVES
AND JEFF SIMONA SIMONA ON THE
PHONE MISTER GRAVES ARE YOU
AVAILABLE. YEAH CAN YOU HEAR ME
THIS YEAR YES GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
FEELING RECENTLY ADVANCED
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
OPPOSED SB SIXTY SIX OH FIVE
BECAUSE OF THE GIFT AND PATIENT
SAFETY LIABILITY CYBERSECURITY
AND INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
PROBLEMS WITH THE BILL. BUT BE
CRYSTAL CLEAR MEDICAL DEVICE
COMPANIES ARE THE ONLY ENTITY
IN THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
REGULATED FOR MEDICAL BY
PREPARE. INDEPENDENT REPAIR
PROVIDERS ARE NOT REGULATED BY
ANY GOVERNMENT ENTITY
SUPPORTERS CLAIM THEY'RE
REGULATED BY CMS BUT THE MATH
OF NOT REGULATE REPAIR MEDICAL
BY. THIS ELIMINATES ANY FOR
INDEPENDENT PROVIDERS SEEK
AUTHORIZATION FROM DEVICE
COMPANIES AND AUTHORIZATION IS
A CRITICAL TOOL FOR UPHOLDING
STANDARDS CREATING
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR REPAIRS.
BECAUSE IN A REPAIR PROVIDERS
HAVE NO REGULATION NO OVERSIGHT.
AND NO RECORD KEEPING
REQUIREMENTS IT'S A CONDITIONS
WHERE. REPAIRS WILL. INJURIES
AND MEDICAL HELP CLAIMS WILL
RISE WITHOUT YES TO WHO SHE
LIABLE. JUST A LOT WEEK WE'VE
BEEN IN. RECALL OF INFUSION IN.
REPAIR BY ANDRE TECHNICIANS WHO
HAD ACCESS TO BE AT THE PARTS
BUT CHOSE TO A THEM TO CAMP.
AND SECOND GUESSED FDA INSTEAD
IS CHIU ON A PER PARTS CREATING
DANGERS TO PAY. WELL WITH ERINA
WILD AS YOURSELF SHOULD BE LAW
THE STITCH. WOULD YOU WANT
LOVED ONE TREATED USING A QUICK
REPAIR BY PEOPLE THAT ARE UNDER.
AND LACK OF. SHOULD BE LIABLE
PRIVATE. BREACH FOR RANSOM
ATTACKS. AND HOW DO WE PUT
ELECT PROPERTY IS THE BAY OF
THE LIFESAVING. WE OBJECT IN
THE IDEA THAT THE CURRENT
SYSTEM DOES NOT WORK THERE'S
ROBUST COMPETITION THE
INDEPENDENT REPAIR SPACE UP TO
TWENTY THOUSAND TO REPAIR
COMPANIES IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND THE REPAIR PROVIDERS OF BIO
MED'S PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
THE SYSTEM. BUT AUTHORIZATION
PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE IN
UPHOLDING STANDARDS REGULATION
PATIENT SAFETY. THE BILL IS
DANGEROUS THE RESULT RELATES
HOLDEN ARBITRARY CORNER CUTTING
BY INDEPENDENT CARE PROVIDERS
WANT ALL OF OUR TECHNOLOGY
WITHOUT ANY OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO REGULATION WE
URGE YOUR. NO VOTE TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR GREEN. MISTER
SIMONE THIS IS A MONNING. YEAH
MITCHELL CAN YOU HEAR ME SIR
YES GO AHEAD. RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MY NAME'S JEFF SIMONE THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF QUALITY PRIMARY
MEDICAL SYSTEMS. WE MAKE
MEDICAL LINEAR ACCELERATORS
WHICH CREATE RADIATION TO TREAT
CANCER. VETERANS MEDICAL LINEAR
ACCELERATORS ARE SOPHISTICATED
MACHINES MORE QUICKNESS LOCATED
WITHIN SHE'LL BUNKERS HAVE
SPECIAL POWER AND WATER
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE SAFETY
FOR PATIENTS. AND CLINICAL CARE
STAFF WE RESPOND TO SERVICE
CALLS ANYWHERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITHIN THIRTY
MINUTES BECAUSE OUR HIGHEST
PRIORITIES TO ENSURE PATIENT
CARE CONTINUES. WE OFFICES OF
DANGEROUS BY. LIKE OVER
FIREWALL AND CYBER SECURITY
PROTECTIONS IN A WAY ALLOWS
PATIENTS PERSONAL HEALTH
INFORMATION TO BE BREACHED.
OVERRIDING SAFETY INTERLOCKS
IMPROPER SERVICING OF THE
MECHANICALS OF THE DEVICES LIKE
A COLLECTING WATER LINES AND
RADIATION SHIELDING
ADJUSTMENTS. OCCASIONALLY TO
THE POINT A FULL MACHINE
FAILURE. THE ULTIMATE LIABILITY
FOR MACHINE ENDS UP WITH US
EVEN THOUGH WE HAD NO KNOWLEDGE
WHAT WAS BEING DONE BY THE
IRAQIS ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
MAINTAIN RECORDS. THERE'S NO
LIABILITY PROTECTION INCLUDED
THIS BILL FOR US WITH OUR
MACHINES ARE ADULTERATED BY
OTHERS. FINALLY STILL DOES NOT
PROTECT VERY INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY WE PROVIDE SERVICE
MANUALS AND TRAINING AND PARTS
FOR CERTAIN BASIC SERVICES
FIFTIES WE WANT OUR CUSTOMERS
TO KEEP CANCER PATIENT
TREATMENT ON TIME. AND WITHOUT
DISRUPTION HOWEVER. I SEVEN
DECADES OF EXPERIENCE ALLOWS US
TO MORE QUICKLY RESOLVE
PROBLEMS WITHOUT MACHINES IN
EITHER OUR CUSTOMERS OR IRAQIS.
THIS BILL WOULD FORCE US TO
TURN OVER SENSITIVE
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY WHICH IS
DESIGNED TO PREVENT
ADULTERATION OR DAMAGE
EQUIPMENT THAT COULD ALSO
EXPOSE CLINICAL PERSONNEL TO
DANGEROUS RADIATION. SO I ASK
YOU WOULD YOU WANT YOUR FAMILY
TREATED ON ONE OF THESE
MACHINES BUT UNREGULATED
TECHNICIANS. AND WHO WOULD BEAR
THE LIABILITY OF THE UNINTENDED.
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS DANGEROUS
BILL. BUDGET SPC OH FIVE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU
MISTER SMALL ALRIGHT NOW
TURNING TO BILLS IN THE GALLERY
ANYONE ELSE IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION SAYING NINE ROOM ONE
TWELVE SEEING NONE ON THE PHONE
MATTER MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
QUEUE UP THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED
SB. SIX ZERO FIVE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX ZERO
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WELCOME MY NUMBER
FOUR FOUR TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
MEMBERS KEVIN DIMITRI ON BEHALF
OF TECHNO IN OPPOSITION. THAT
SB SIX OH FIVE THANK YOU. LINE
THREE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS MARK WAKEFIELD
ON THE FIELD ENGINEER
CALIFORNIA WITH HOLOGIC HELLO
CLOSE THIS BILL. ONE THREE
THREE FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THANK YOU MEMBERS. A LOGICAL
OPPOSITION. THREE TO FIVE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY NAME IS
TYPICALLY SOLD PLYMOUTH SILVA
JUNIOR IN CALIFORNIA WITH LOGIC
AND I DO OPPOSE THIS BILL. NINE
THREE FIVE THREE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HELLO THIS IS KIM
MULLER ISTRICT SERVICE MANAGER
WITH THIRTY FIVE YEARS
EXPERIENCE WITH PHILLIPS
HEALTHCARE LIVING IN BASKETBALL
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. SIX TO EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBER LAURA
THREATENING COMBI HALF OF THE
MEDICAL IMAGING AND TECHNOLOGY
ALLIANCE STRONGLY OPPOSE. NINE
SIX TWO TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. ONE SIX TWO TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YOUR LINE IS NEEDED
WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. MOVE
ON TO MY NUMBER THREE ZERO
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THREE OH THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THREE OH THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ERICA
HANSON BROWN I'M TO SEE A CEO
AND FOUNDER OF ONE CANCER PLACE
A COMMUNITY OF STRICTLY CANCER
PATIENTS AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ONE FOUR SIX NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS TODD
FRESNO I'M IN MEDICAL
TECHNOLOGY SERVICE TECHNICIAN
WITH MEDTRONIC BASED IN
CARLSBAD CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SIX ZERO
FIVE THANK YOU. LINE SIX
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GLOBAL WITH VARIAN MEDICAL
SYSTEMS STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NINE FIVE NINE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TO ME
JACKSON VIACOM CALIFORNIANS
STRONG OPPOSITION. ONE SIX
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS TOM GETTERS AND THE
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY SERVICE
TECHNICIAN WITH MEDTRONIC IN
THE LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SIX OH FIVE
THANK YOU. ONE SIX ONE TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES SIR ALL MY NAME IS HERBERT
JOHNSON I WORK FOR A LOGICAL
FIELD SERVICE ENGINEER BUT I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS. NINE
FIVE NINE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MANY HERE WOULD
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION STRONG OPPOSITION.
ONE FOUR NINE FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MONICA DO
SELL AND I'M A REGIONAL SERVICE
MANAGER WITH MEDTRONIC BASED
OUT OF CARLSBAD AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. NINE THREE
THREE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS JIM LEWIS I AM
A FIELD ENGINEER CALIFORNIA
WITH LOGIC AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. ONE THREE NINE TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS JONATHAN
ARAMBULA ON BEHALF OF CTIA THE
TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY AND WE OPPOSE
SB SIX OH FIVE THANK YOU. ONE
TWO FIVE SIX YOUR LIGHT IS OPEN.
THIS IS MICHAEL WITH MEDTRONIC
FIELD SERVICE ENGINEER I
STRONGLY OPPOSE OF SB SIX OH
FIVE THANK YOU. ONE FIVE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
JAPANESE ARMY MEDICAL TECHNICAL
SERVICE REPRESENTATIVE WITH
MEDTRONIC BASED OUT OF CALLS
BACK CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. HE WROTE FIVE THANK YOU.
ONE FOUR THREE FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS KIM BANK OF
THE MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY SERVICE
TECHNICIAN WITH MEDTRONIC IN
CARLSBAD AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB SIX OH FIVE THANK YOU. ONE
FIVE EIGHT NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES THIS IS LLOYD GAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE'RE IN OPPOSITION.
NINE SIX NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS SARAH CROWE
AND MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY SERVICE
TECHNICIAN WITH THE TRONIC
BEACON CALL BAD BUT SHALL WE
OPPOSE SB SIX OH FIVE THANK YOU.
ONE SIX TWO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I DON'T HAVE ON THE
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY SERVICE
TECHNICIAN WITH MEDTRONIC BASED
IN CARLSBAD CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB SIX OH FIVE THANK YOU.
ONE TWO SEVEN EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN
DOES SOME FIELD SERVICE
ENGINEER IN CALIFORNIA WITH
METRO NYC AND I STRONGLY
BECAUSE OF THE- ONE SIX
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SO
MANY USER JOE GOMEZ TO
EXPORTING ALL OF THE NEXT NEW
SOUTH KOREA OR METONIC I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. LIME
THREE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS JAMIE TELECOM
A MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY SERVICE
EXECUTIVE WITH MEDTRONIC BEST A
CARLSBAD STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
SIX OH FIVE THANK YOU. ONE FIVE
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY
DAVID CAN WITH INTUITIVE
SURGICAL WITH KEY OPERATIONS IN
SENATE DISTRICT TEN IN
OPPOSITION. ONE FIVE NINE TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M GONNA
WRITE A MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
SERVICE MANAGER WITH MEDTRONIC
LIVING IN SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE OPPOSE SB
SIX O'CLOCK THANK YOU. ONE FIVE
NINE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
THAT'S RIGHT GROUP DIRECTOR OF
THE REPAIR DONE RIGHT COALITION
WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU. ONE FIVE FOUR FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
JOHN KNAPP I'M AN FSC. SAN
DIEGO AREA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE BILLS SB SIX OH FIVE.
NINE FIVE NINETY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. DAVID CARPENTER WITH
VARIAN MEDICAL SYSTEMS IN LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. FIVE
THREE TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS STEVE CALLS ON THE
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY SERVICE
TECHNICIAN WITH MEDTRONIC BASED
IN CARLSBAD CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB SIX
O'CLOCK. THANK YOU. FIVE FIVE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR
MORNINGS JOHN PARKER STEALING
MY MEDICAL TECHNOLOGIES
RECOGNITION WOULD MAKE CHRONIC
PAIN AND CRAWLED BACK
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB SIX O'CLOCK THANK
YOU. TWO SEVEN TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE TWO SEVEN TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU
NAME YES SIR. YES MY NAME'S OF
LOCAL I AM A MEDICAL
TECHNOLOGIST SERVICE TECHNICIAN
WITH MEDTRONIC THEY HM HOW'S
THAT I'M SORRY OPPOSE SB SIX OH
FIVE THANK YOU. FIVE NINE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
RANDY MATHIS I'M A MEDICAL
IMAGING SERVICE MANAGER WITH
THE HEALTH CARE WITH THIRTY TWO
YEARS IN THE INDUSTRY WARNING
INTERESTED PATIENTS THINK WE
SAFETY I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. FIVE NINE NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AFTERNOON MEMBERS
EXTREMELY HOT WITH THE CIVIL
JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
TO THE BILL THANK YOU. SIX ZERO
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS HERE AT THE DIARY I AM
BUILDING JUNIOR AND CALIFORNIA
RECALL LOGIC AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. SIX OH ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS MATTHEW
BERGENFIELD ENGINEERING
CALIFORNIA WITH HOLOGIC I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
EXTEND YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
ANNA KOURNIKOVA EMPLOYEE WAS
INDIAN AND JOSE OPPOSED THE
BILL. SIX OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS KRISTIN CAL
HAVE- WITH THE MAN THAT HELPED
IN THE AIRSPACE AND GOT OUR
START WITH. A CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYER- IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL THANK YOUNG. SIX THREE TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHARE
MEMBERS DAVID TOP ON BEHALF OF
ABBOTT LABORATORIES AND OUR
SEVEN THOUSAND MEDICAL DEVICE
EMPLOYEES IN CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. SIX OH SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SH. WELL YOU GOT
THE JOB DONE THE VICE PRESIDENT
SERVICE FOR SIEMENS
HEALTHINEERS I LIVE IN OUR
WATER HILLS CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. SIX
THREE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER BARNES I'M
A MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY OPERATIONS
MANAGER WITH MEDTRONIC I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
DECREE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU MIGHT HAVE WOULD BE V. AS
IN VICTOR AND I OPPOSE SB SIX
O'CLOCK. SIX THREE FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS ENERGY
I MAY- CERTIFIED BY A MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT TECHNICIAN AT UCSF
MEDICAL CENTER AND I STAND
ALONGSIDE THE THOUSANDS OF
HEALTHCARE TECHNOLOGY
MANAGEMENT PROFESSIONALS IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU. SIX THREE EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I'M NOT BACK
REPRESENTING EDWARDS
LIFESCIENCES IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. NEVER MIND IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
BILL SB SIX ZERO FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE HAVE ONE PERSON WITH AN
OPERATOR. EIGHT SIX TWO TWO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. SIX TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR LINE IS
NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
ONE POINT TWO FIVE FOR YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. TWO FIVE FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR LINE IS
MUTED OR UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
WILL MOVE ON TO LINE SIX
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS REGINA LAURELL A
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY SERVICE
TECHNICIAN WITH MEDTRONIC BASED
IN CARLSBAD I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB SIX OH FIVE THANK YOU. SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS FRANK THAT IS WITH TECH
SUPPORT- BASED ANIMATRONIC
CARLSBAD AND AYE OPPOSED SB.
SIX OH FIVE. AND AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM MODERATOR I SEE NO
MICROPHONES HERE ON THE FLOOR-
ALREADY THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER EGGMAN SIR EDMUND JUST
JUST A COUPLE OBSERVATIONS IS
THAT I KNOW THE CONCERN WITH
RESPECT TO I. P. I SHARE THAT
CONCERN I ALSO KNOW THE CONCERN
WITH RESPECT TO A PARTICULAR.
ISSUE AREAS OR INDUSTRIES OR
DEVICES THAT MAY REQUIRE MORE-
SOPHISTICATION MORE TRAINING
THAN THAN OTHERS AND- YOU AND I
SPOKE ABOUT THIS BRIEFLY BUT I
ASSUME YOU'LL BE AMENABLE TO
FURTHER IMPROVEMENTS TO THE LAW
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE IP IS
PROTECTED. AND THAT IN CERTAIN
AREAS THAT REQUIRE. MORE
TRAINING FOR EXAMPLE- OR MORE
TECHNOLOGY THAT YOU'LL BE
AMENABLE TO ENTERTAINING SUCH
CARVE OUTS. CERTAINLY MISTER
CHAIR WE'VE BEEN WORKING IN THE
SPACE FOR YEARS AND WILL
CERTAINLY DO WHATEVER WE NEED
TO DO TO ADDRESS OUR ISSUES AS
WE STATED WE DON'T WE DON'T
THINK THERE'S- I. P. ISSUES BUT
WE CERTAINLY RESPECT THAT THAT
THERE COULD BE A DIFFERENCE OF
OPINION AND WITHOUT REALLY TO
LOOK AT THAT. AND AS WELL AS
LIKE WE WE'VE WILL CONTINUE TO
NARROW AND WE ARE CERTAINLY.
OPEN TO NARROWING FURTHER IF
NEED BE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR EGGMAN ALL RIGHT TO GET A
CLOSE. I'M SORRY- SIR JONES IS
YOUR MICROPHONE UP SOME JONES I
WAS NOT SIR I'M JUST I'M SORRY
I MISSED THE OPPORTUNITY TO.
FOR A- COMMITTEE COMMENTS I
JUST HAD A QUICK QUESTION IN. I
KNOW THAT I DON'T THINK CMAT
HAS. OPINED ON THIS YET
OFFICIALLY BUT I KEEP HEARING
THAT THEY MAY HAVE OPPOSITION
AND I THINK ONE OF THE- THINGS
THAT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR IS A
AMENDMENT. DEALING WITH MEDICAL
MALPRACTICE FOR THE DOCTORS SO
I WAS JUST WONDERING IF YOU HAD
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. YOU KNOW
WHAT WHERE YOU ARE AT AND THAT
PROCESS- AND THEN A LOT OF THE
CALLERS- THAT WE'RE CALLING IN
TODAY- ARE FROM MY AREA SO I
NEED TO LOOK INTO THAT TOO SO
IF YOU CAN JUST ADDRESS TO SEE
ANYTHING THAT BE GREAT.
CERTAINLY YEAH WE HAVE JUST
HEARD RECENTLY FROM CMA THAT
THEY MAY HAVE SOME ISSUES OTHER
ISSUES ARE ARE AROUND. AND
UNITY YOU KNOW MALPRACTICE AS
WE WOULD UNDERSTAND THEIR
ALREADY EXISTING CO AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THIRD
PARTY. RIGHT SO WHOEVER IS
RESPONSIBLE THIS IS RESPONSIBLE
SO- WE HAVE REACHED OUT FOR
CONVERSATIONS AND WILL
CERTAINLY BE WORKING WITH THEM
GOING FORWARD. AND YES THE- THE
BIOMED COMPANY THAT SERVICES
THE EQUIPMENT A LOT OF THEM ARE
IN YOUR AREA SO I'M SURE. THAT
YOU'LL BE HEARD FROM A LOT OF
THEM TODAY ASSEMBLY BY THE
MANUFACTURER AND SERVICE PARKS.
I NOTICED THE BILL HAS. SUPPORT
I'M GONNA LAY OFF TODAY BUT-
WILL CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE AUTHOR. THANK YOU
SENATE JOHNSON SAID WHAT IS
YOUR MICROPHONE UP. YES SIR. GO
AHEAD THANK YOU. WE CERTAINLY
HAD A LOT OF COLORS. THERE'S A
LOT OF- INTEREST IN THIS BILL-
I'M KIND OF TORN HIS YOU CAN AS
A MAGICAL A LOT OF OUR
COLLEAGUES ARE AND I USE THE
EXAMPLE OF SOMETHING THAT WAS
KIND OF FRUSTRATING TO ME ONCE-
TO WATCH IF YOU. LET'S SAY YOU
HAVE A WATCH AND- YOU WANT TO
SEND IT TO A REPAIR SHOP AND
NEXT THING YOU KNOW IT IT
WOULD- IT WOULD DO AWAY WITH
THE WARRANTY BECAUSE- MAYBE
IT'S ON AUTHORIZED REPAIR SHOP.
WERE WORKING THROUGH AN
AUTHORIZED DEALER. AND I THINK
IT'S- IT'S A ONE SIDED IT COULD
BE HELPFUL TO HAVE AS MANY
INDIVIDUALS. TRAINED IN HOW TO
REPAIR- THESE THESE DEVICES AS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE IT FACILITATES
CIRCULATION THE PRODUCT
CIRCULATES. THE THE TECHNOLOGY
BASE AND THOSE LEARNING AND HOW
TO BE A PART OF IT. ON THE FLIP
SIDE IS. EVEN THOUGH THESE ARE
PUBLICLY OF LARGELY PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE MATERIALS THERE IS
SOME CONCERN ABOUT INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY LOSS. AND I DIDN'T
KNOW IF YOU HAD ANYTHING
COMMENTS ON. COULD YOU NOT JUST
SIMPLY CREATE AN AUTHORIZED
REPAIR ENTITY THAT WOULD BE
DOWN FOR EXAMPLE TO ME OF SOME
FORM OF NON DISCLOSURE TO YOU
STILL GET WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
AS A THROUGH A THIRD PARTY
REPAIR. BUT THERE'S
INTELLECTUALLY PROTECTIONS IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
DISCUSSED AT SOME LENGTH- I
BELIEVE WHEN THEY DID THE LAST
STUDY THAT'S WHAT THEY
SUGGESTED TO THE MANUFACTURERS
THAT THEY PUT IN SOME KIND OF
PASSWORD CODE AND TO BE ABLE TO
GET THROUGH SO THEY COULD
MAINTAIN WHAT THEY NEEDED TO
FOR INTELLECTUAL PROPERTIES.
BUT STILL MAINTAINS ACCESS TO
FIXING IT BUT I WOULD ASK MY
EXPERTS IF THEY'D LIKE TO COME
IN AS WELL. YEAH THIS IS KEVIN
O'REILLY WOULD GET. AFTER THAT
THE ONE THING THAT I MENTION
ABOUT INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY IS-
WE SUBMITTED A LETTER ON THE
APPLE TWELVE- I. T. LEGAL
EXPERTS- ALL STATED IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL STATING THAT- I'VE
BEEN BACKED UP. BY CONGRESS AND
THE COURTS- TIME AND AGAIN THAT.
NOT SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
PROTECTED BY COPYRIGHT SO THIS
BILL IS NOT ABOUT TRYING TO GET
ANY SORT OF- YOU KNOW TRADE
SECRET COMPACTOR IS AN
EXEMPTION FOR THE BILL TO MAKE
SURE THAT. YOU KNOW NOTHING- IN
THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE
MANUFACTURERS TO PROVIDE
BETWEEN SECRET. YOU HAVE TO DO
TO SERVICE OR SOMETHING OF THAT
NATURE SO WE ABSOLUTELY DON'T
WANT TO EXPOSE. ANY OF
MANUFACTURE SECRETS AND- WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
PUTS RISK. I'M MAY COULD I ASK
FOR THE CLARIFICATIONS PRESENT.
GO AHEAD- SEARCHERS USING- THAT
GETTING EDUCATED THROUGH THAT
MANUFACTURE- IN THAT WHOLE LINE
OF- OF INFORMATION. OUR INTO
HERE THAT CORRECTED THERE'S NO
TRADE SECRET COMPONENT IN THE
REVELATION OF- THE
FUNCTIONALITY OF THOSE PRODUCTS.
SO. SO AS FAR AS REPAIR GOES
RIGHT- THIS BILL DOESN'T
REQUIRE- MANUFACTURE TO TURN
OVER ANY SORT OF DESIGN
INFORMATION OR THINGS LIKE
THAT- THERE IS YOU KNOW
TRAINING IS INCLUDED IN THE
BILL- IN ORDER TO- YOU KNOW
AGAIN TO POINT TO THAT LETTER
FROM THE TECHNICAL EXPERTS.
THEY ARGUE THAT. THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION IS NOT PROTECTED BY
COPYRIGHT- THAT SAID YOU KNOW I
THINK THAT- THE PROTECTION THAT
WE HAVE IN PLACE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE. IS NO LOSS OF TRADE
SECRETS AND ALSO ARE YOU KNOW
THAT THE ONE OF THE THINGS.
THAT THE BIOMED WORKING IN
HOSPITALS IN POOR EYES. ARE NOT
LOOKING TO TRY AND PUT. ANY
SORT OF COMPUTING DEVICE ON THE
MARKET RIGHT WHAT THEY WANT TO
DO IS MAKE SURE THAT THE
PATIENTS ARE HOPEFUL THAT NEED
CARE. NEEDS I. THIS CALL ORDER
TO USE. LIFESAVING TREATMENT.
THAT DAY CAN SIX CLIP AND MAKE
SURE. THE PATIENT CO THE BEST
CARE. OKAY I COOPER GO ON BUT
AT THE I THINK- I THINK OF AS
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT I
THINK ARE MOST MOST IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER MICROPHONES ANY OTHER
MEMBERS FIVE SENATE MANY
CHEMICALS. ED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- DO WE NEED A MOTION. THAT
WOULD BE A GOOD IDEA SYLER
MOVES. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
AS I AS I SAID THE BEGINNING
THE OPPOSITION WILL COME ON
FEARS AND FULL FORCE AND TRY TO
SCARE YOU- YOU MIGHT RECALL IF
YOU WERE IN THE LEGISLATURE
COUPLE YEARS AGO I DID ONE ON.
ALL RIGHTS REPAIR AND THEY WERE
GOING AROUND SAYING YOUR PHONE
COULD EXPLODE INTO AND BLOW UP
THE BUILDING BECAUSE IT WAS SO
DANGEROUS TO REPAIR WE KNOW WE
KNOW THAT'S NOT TRUE AND WHO IS
MORE CONCERNED ABOUT PATIENT
SAFETY THEN THE VERY HOSPITALS
THAT ARE PROVIDING THE CARE-
THE TECHNICIANS ELECTRONICS
THEY ARE ALL HIRED FROM THE
SAME POOL RIGHT IF THEY WORK
FOR THE ISO OR THEY HAVE A-
THEIR OWN INDEPENDENT COMPANY
OR THEY WORK FOR THE HOSPITAL.
THIS IS ALSO ABOUT SAVING
HEALTH CARE COST AN MRI MACHINE
WHO GOES UP TO A MILLION
DOLLARS IF YOU HAVE TO HAVE
THAT CONTRACT WITH THAT-
MANUFACTURE THAT CAN BE A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
LIKE A 10% RIGHT. AN IN HOUSE
BIOMED PERSON CAN DO THAT A LOT
MORE EFFECTIVELY ESPECIALLY IN
RURAL PARTS OF THE STATE
ESPECIALLY IN MORE REMOTE PARTS
OF THE STATE TO BE ABLE TO GET
THE WORDS OUT OF THE EQUIPMENT
AGAIN WHICH I'M NOT REDUCING
WASTE IMPROVING SAFETY
IMPROVING HEALTHCARE OUTCOMES.
AND MAKING SURE THAT IF YOU BUY
SOMETHING YOU ACTUALLY OWN IT
AND AREN'T TETHERED TO THAT
MANUFACTURE FOREVER FOR REPAIRS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ABOUT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
COUNSEL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS SB SIX OH FIVE BY
SENATOR EGGMAN WITH THE MOTION
BY SENATOR THERE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND THEN RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
BURKE. NUMBER GUY BURGESS.
PORGES NOT VOTING. CABALLERO I
HAVE A I DID ALSO HI GUYS SO I
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG. JONES LAYARD ARE
LAYERED ICE STERN. WHITE HOUSE
SKI WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER.
THE OF SIX TO ZERO SO FAR.
THANK YOU. PUT THAT BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU CENTER EGGMAN
CENTER DOLLY. THANK YOU CENTER
DOLLY THE FLOOR'S YOURS. GOOD
AFTERNOON- MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS- FIRST TIME I'VE EVER
PRESENTED IN FRONT OF THIS
COMMITTEE SO- THE FARMER IN
FRONT OF A BUNCH OF LAWYERS
MIGHT BE KIND INTERESTING
TODAY. TODAY IN PRESENTING SB
FIVE FIFTEEN WHICH WILL PROVIDE
EQUAL PROTECTIONS TO THE
EMPLOYEES OF THE LEGISLATURE
THAT EVERY THAT THE SAME WAS
REQUIRED IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR-
CURRENTLY THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED THOUSANDS OF LAWS
DICTATING EMPLOYEE WORK
CONDITIONS AND HUNDRED
REGULATIONS EACH YEAR. ON ON
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN CONVENE
EXEMPTED. FROM THE SAME
BURDENSOME LOS. LET ME GIVE A
FEW EXAMPLES PROPOSITION SIXTY
FIVE WHICH IS CHEMICALS HIGH
FREQUENCY IN LAWSUITS AGAINST
BUSINESSES THINGS LIKE
FORMALDEHYDE IN YOUR IN OUR
OFFICE FURNITURE THAT CAN CAUSE
CANCER AND BIRTH DEFECTS PRIME
RETARDANTS THATCAN CAUSE
CANCER BIRTH DEFECTS AND LEAD
FROM BRASS OBJECTS THAT CAN
ALSO CAUSE CANCER BIRTH DEFECTS.
WE'RE THE LEGISLATURE IS
EXEMPTED FROM WAGING OUR
OVERTIME PAY ALTERNATIVE WORK
SCHEDULES. MILLIN REST PERIODS-
WHICH ARE OFTEN IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR YOU CALLED PAGA LAWSUITS.
BY VOTING AGAINST THIS BILL
YOU'RE VOTING AGAINST THE
LOWEST PAID EMPLOYEES TO
PROTECT YOUR WHITE COLLAR
EMPLOYEES ACTUALLY IN THE
ANALYSIS AYE I LEARNED A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT. THE EXEMPTIONS
AT THIS BILL THE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS. SHIFTED FROM
MY LAST COMMITTEE SO. IF YOU
PAY DOUBLE THE MINIMUM WAGE.
YOU'RE EXEMPTED YOUR IS CALLED
THE WHITE COLLAR EMPLOYEES SO
THAT WOULD MEAN YOU WOULD EARN
323-100-0200 DOLLARS IN SALARY.
SO TWO TIMES THAT SALARY- WOULD
EXEMPT YOU FROM OVER TIME. AND
TIME AND A HALF RULES SO ANY.
LEGISLATIVE PERSON THAT WORKS
HERE THAT IS PAID UNDER SIXTY
TWO THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED-
WOULD BE. UNDER THE PRIVATE
SIDE WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR TIME
AND A HALF- WHEN THEY'RE WORKED
OVER EIGHT HOURS A DAY. I'M AN
EMPLOYER AND AS MANY YOU KNOW
AS AS SO YOU. SO I KNOW HOW
VALUABLE THESE PROTECTIONS ARE
AND I KNOW THE COST BECAUSE
THEY CAN IT HOW COSTLY THEY CAN
BE TO COMPLY WITH THESE LAWS.
FOR EXAMPLE A FEW YEARS AGO
THERE WAS A BILL WHICH EXEMPTED-
AG PRODUCERS FROM PAYING. THAT
IT WE HAD AN EXEMPTION WE COULD
WORK SIXTY HOURS A WEEK BEFORE
WE PAID OVERTIME. TYPICALLY WE
USE THAT DURING. THE FARM IN
THE PLANTING AND HARVEST TIME
WELL THE LEGISLATURE CHANGED
THE LAW- SO THAT THE IT'S
BASICALLY. AT A EIGHT HOUR DAY
OR FORTY HOURS A WEEK AND NOT
MANY THERE WAS MANY TIMES IN A
LOT. MANY MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE ASSEMBLY
THEN. IT SAID IT WAS IT WAS
ALMOST EQUIVALENT TO- SLAVE
OWNERSHIP. THE COMMITTEE IN
ALICE'S HIGHLIGHTED SOME
POLITICAL ACTIVITIES AS A
REASON TO NOT SUPPORT THIS BILL
LABOR CODE SECTION- ELEVEN OH
ONE THROUGH ELEVEN OH THREE. SO
I LOOKED IT UP. IN BUT IT
BASICALLY SAYS IS THAT- YOU CAN
ALLOW YOUR EMPLOYEES TO DO
POLITICAL WORK WELL. WE DO NOT
DO POLITICAL WORK IN THE
CAPITAL. WE DO WE DO POLICY
WORK HERE AND IF YOU RECALL
THERE'S MANY MANY MANY TIMES
THERE'S BEEN POLITICAL WORK
DONE IN THE CAPITAL. AND THE
FBI HAS BEEN IN HERE AND GOING
AFTER THOSE LEGISLATORS AND
PEOPLE WHO WERE- NOT ABIDING BY
LAW. IT HAS BEEN KNOWN FOR
DECADES THAT THE LEGISLATOR
DOESN'T APPLY WAGING OUR RULES
TO ITSELF. CAMPBELL VERSES THE
REGENTS OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA TWO THOUSAND FIVE
QUOTED THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
INDUSTRIALIZATION IS AS
FOLLOWS. THESE PROVISIONS ARE
SILENT AS TO THEIR APPLE BILL
BACK ABILITY PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
GENERAL. GENERALLY HOWEVER
PROVISIONS OF THE LABOR LAW
APPLY. TO EMPLOYEES IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR UNLESS THERE'S
SPECIFICALLY MADE OPTICAL TO
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES. EFFECTIVE
JANUARY ONE NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT I W. C. WHICH IS THE
INTERNATIONAL- INDUSTRIAL
WELFARE COMMISSION ELIMINATED
DAILY OVERTIME. FROM FIVE OF
THE OF THE EXISTING FIFTEEN
WAGE ORDERS. IN RESPONSE THE
LEGISLATOR PASSED AND THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED ASSEMBLY BILL
NUMBER SIXTY IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINE. THE EIGHT HOUR. D.
RESTORATION AND WORKPLACE
FLEXIBILITY ACT OF NINETEEN
NINETY NINE AMONG OTHER THINGS
THIS LEGISLATURE RESTORE THE
EIGHT HOUR WORKDAY IN THE
SECTION FIVE TEN AND MANDATED
MANDATED MEAL AND PRAYER AND
WRITTEN PERIODS IN SECTION FIVE
TWELVE. MEMBERS EVERY DAY THIS
LEGISLATURE TALKS ABOUT HOW BAD
IT IS OUT THERE IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR- WHILE NOT LIVING UP TO
THE SAME STANDARDS OURSELVES.
MAKING THESE CHANGES IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. AS WE WILL
IN THE DOUBLE STANDARD OF
EMPLOYEE PROTECTIONS THAT OUR
OWN EMPLOYEES DO NOT ENJOY.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE BROUGH
SUCH ARE AN ATTORNEY WITH THE
LIVER LAW FIRM AS AS MY LEAD
WITNESS MISTER CHAIRMAN. THANK
YOU SENATOR HOLLINGS OF MR
SERGEANT ARE YOU AVAILABLE. YES
I'M HERE CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN GO AHEAD. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I AM AN ATTORNEY
IN PRIVATE PRACTICE
REPRESENTING EMPLOYERS AND
BUSINESSES AND ALL ASPECTS OF
EMPLOYMENT LAW AND HAVE BEEN
DOING SO FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS.
I DON'T HAVE TODAY TO ADDRESS
THE COSTS AND IMPACTS WHICH THE
LEGISLATURE WHICH THEY WERE
REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH ALL OF
THE- EMPLOYMENT LAWS WHICH
APPLY TO CALIFORNIA PRIVATE
SECTOR BUSINESSES. NOW AND I
HOPE YOU KNOW THERE ARE A LOT
OF EMPLOYMENT LAWS IN%
CALIFORNIA SO IN MY TWO MINUTES
I'M ONLY GOING TO BE ABLE TO
FOCUS ON IF YOU. FOR EXAMPLE
LABOR CODE TWO TWO SIX WAGE
STATEMENTS. INCLUDE NINE
SEPARATE ITEMS EVEN IF AN
EMPLOYEE IS FULLY PAID ON TIME
EVERY SINGLE NICKEL THEY ARE-
ONE SMALL CARE ON A WAGE
STATEMENT CAN LEAD TO SEVERE
MONETARY PENALTIES. THE CO TWO
TO SEVEN POINT THREE THE FINAL
PAYCHECK MUST BE ACCURATE IF
THE FINALS PROJECT ONE PENNY
SHORT. WAITING TIME PENALTIES
OF UP TO THIRTY TIMES THE DAILY
WAGE RATES CAN BE IN CARL. MAIL
AND REST BREAKS BECAUSE NEIL IS
SCHEDULED ONE MINUTE TOO LATE
IN THE WORKING ANY PREMIUM OF
ONE HOUR OKAY NEEDS TO BE
PROVIDED. IT'S NOT JUST A LOT
HOW TO BAIL HIM FORCE PRIVATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ACT LOG. LET'S
TAKE AN EXAMPLE CLAIMS THAT THE
EMPLOYEES GOT THEIR MEAL BREAKS
TOO LATE AND THEY DID NOT GET
THEIR ONE OUR PREMIUM PAY. ALL
OF THEIR LEAD STATEMENTS WILL
ALSO INCORRECT ALL THOSE WHO.
IMPLEMENT THERE WAS AN ERROR ON
THEIR FINAL PAYCHECK YOU NEED
TO THIRTY DAYS TO PAY FOR
WAITING TIME PENALTIES. ALLOWS
FOR THE STACKING AND STACKING
AND STACKING OF MULTIPLE
PENALTIES BASED ON ONE SINGLE
PAYER. NEEDS LAWS AND OTHERS.
DO NOT APPLY TO THE LEGISLATURE.
IN UNDER OF THE- A COMMUNITY I
MOST BILLS. WOULD RATHER INCOME
LAW THE FOR. RATHER THAN
COMPOSED THESE LAW ON THE WAY.
TO THAT END I GET RID INTO
RECORD OF OUR PLANS. TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND GIVES
IMPACT THE- EARLIER THIS YEAR
IN WHICH WE DESCRIBE THE COR
POINT WHAT CHRIST CONTROL.
BECAUSE MAURICE OF THE STAGGER
EMPLOYEE WATCH FACED BY THE-
HERE IN THE GOLD. AND WHICH WE
OFFERS. FOR RANDOM SARGEANT
BRING YOU YOUR TIME AND
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU SIR. ALL
RIGHT. NOT ANYONE THE GALA IN
SUPPORT. ANYONE ONE TWELVE
SEEING NONE MISTER THE PHONE.
THOSE OF A B. 45% DOLLY PLEASE
QUEUE UP. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE FIVE ZERO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
FIVE ZERO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I HAVE
NO ONE IN SUPPORT THERE. ALL
RIGHT. LET'S NOT TURNED
OPPOSITION I DON'T KNOW THERE'S
ANYONE ANY PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. THIRTY ONE ON THE
PHONE LINE MATTER MODERATOR
IDENTIFIES HIMSELF OR HERSELF
AS A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE FIVE ZERO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ACTIVE
TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT LET ME
MAKE SURE THERE'S NO IN THE-GALLERY ANYONE THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION ANYONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE NO. ALL RIGHT- I SEE
CENTER LAYERS MICROPHONES ON
CENTER LAYERED. ONE SENATOR
ALSO AS WELL. SOMEBODY THERE WE
GO THANK YOU- I JUST WANTED TO
KNOWLEDGE THAT- THE SENATOR
DOLLY MENTIONED THAT. THIS IS
HIS FIRST BILL IN EIGHT YEARS
AND JUDICIARY AND WHEN THIS
BILL APPEARED IN THE LABOR
COMMITTEE IT WAS THE FIRST TIME
IN EIGHT YEARS HE HAD APPEARED
IN FRONT OF THE LABOR
COMMITTEE. AND WE WERE VERY
CAREFUL AT THAT MEETING TO
EXTEND HIS IMAGE INVITATION TO
THE ANNUAL MAY DAY PICNIC THAT
IS NOW GOING TO BE AT THE
BEEPER RANCH OF SENATOR DOLLY
AND THEN I'VE FURTHER HAVE
INFORMATION THAT IF YOU HAVE A
PICKET LINE IN YOUR DISTRICT
YOU SHOULD CHECK FOR HIS
AVAILABILITY HE HE MIGHT JOIN I
THINK HE'S READY TO CO AUTHOR
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS. AND
WE WOULD JUST REALLY LIKE TO
WELCOME OUR BROTHER TO THE FOLD.
SO IN THAT BILL GOT A TO KNOW
SUSPECTED HIT. THAT THAT DIDN'T
ONLY. ON LIKE AN OFFER SENATE
FOR ARE- THE SENATE THERE ARE.
I HAVE I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
THE AUTHOR A DOES THIS IN TERMS
OF EXTENDING RIGHTS OF FROM THE
PRIVATE SECTOR- INCLUDE THE
RIGHT TO COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN.
IN THIS IN THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION ACTUALLY OWN IT IS
MAYBE GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT
MORE INFORMATION I KNOW IT'S
BEEN A LONG DAY FOR ALL BUT- I
DON'T THINK PEOPLE REALLY TOOK
ME SERIOUS WHEN I FIRST RAN
THIS BILL YOU KNOW- IN THE IN
THE- I DIDN'T GET MUCH FEEDBACK
FROM THE COMMITTEES- FROM THE
CONSULTANTS AND I WAS HOPING
THAT I WOULD. HAVE A LITTLE
MORE- WHEN I FOUND OUT A COUPLE
YEARS BACK- THAT OUR EMPLOYEES
DIDN'T GET THE SAME THINGS I
GIVE TO MY OWN EMPLOYEES. I WAS
APPALLED QUITE FRANKLY BECAUSE
WE DO WORK LONG HOURS HERE AND
I THINK THAT AND WE ALSO HEAR.
A LOT OF SPEECHES ON THE FLOOR
ABOUT HOW WE'RE PRO THE WORKING
PERSON WHICH BIG SEVERAL LAWS
AND I AND SO. I ALSO. KNOW HOW
BURDENS IT IS TO DO THE LAWS
THAT ARE PASSED IN THE
LEGISLATURE. SO TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION. I REALLY HAVEN'T HAD
A LOT OF FOLKS WORKING WITH ME
ON THIS BILL I'VE BEEN KIND OF
ON MY OWN. BECAUSE I THINK THEY
THOUGHT IT WAS LIKE A STATEMENT
OR SOMETHING BUT I AM VERY
SERIOUS ABOUT THIS BILL I THINK
IT IS. THE RIGHTEOUS THING TO
DO FOR THOSE LOW DEFINITELY I
LEARNED IN THIS JUST FROM THE
LAST COMMITTEE ABOUT. THE
DOUBLE THE TO THE BILL WHICH
YOU ACTUALLY ASK ME THAT
QUESTION AND I DID NOT KNOW THE
ANSWER I FOUND THAT ANSWER OUT-
SINCE THEN SO IT'S DOUBLE THE
WEIGHT I DID NOT. I'M NOT GOING
AFTER COLLECTIVE BARGAINING I'M
I KNOW THAT. MOST PUBLIC
AGENCIES HAVE THAT. SO IN THIS
BILL I JUST QUITE FRANKLY
REALLY. IT REALLY MAINLY
FOCUSED ON THE- THE- THE PROP
SIXTY FIVE I MEAN. I BROUGHT IT
UP A COUPLE YEARS AGO THE
BOTTLES THAT ARE ON OUR DESK
AND HAVE. THE HAND SANITIZER
ADAM WAS AN EXAMPLE I USE THAT
IN MY BUSINESS I WOULD HAVE TO
LABEL THAT SO THAT THE-
EMPLOYER. EMPLOYEES WOULD KNOW.
WHAT'S IN THAT BOTTLE NOW WE
ALL KNOW WHAT'S HAND SANITIZER.
BUT TO THE LETTER OF THE LAW
WHICH MY WITNESS TALKED ABOUT.
YOU COULD BE SUED IS AN
EMPLOYER IF YOU DON'T HAVE THAT
LABEL ON THERE AND IT ACTUALLY
CAUSED. HARM TO EMPLOYEES. SO
THOSE AND THE AND THE OVERTIME
IS I THOUGHT I WOULD BE. ASKED
AS AT THE COMMITTEES TO NARROW
DOWN OVER TIME BECAUSE TAT'S
REALLY SOMETHING THAT WE-
DESPERATELY NEED TO DO SO I
HAVE BEEN ASKING BEEN KIND ON
MY OWN HERE- AND I THINK IT
WOULD BE GREAT BECAUSE A LOT OF
THE LEGISLATORS. WHO ARE IN THE
BUILDING. DON'T RUN BUSINESSES
AND DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS
TO GO THROUGH IT AND THE
RELATIONSHIP WE HAVE THEIR
PLACE WITHOUT THE GOAL OF THIS
BILL. I DID NOT BUT IN PART A
BARGAINING UNITS I KNOW THAT'S
BEEN TRIED IN THE PAST. AND IN
THE IN THE ASSEMBLY. IT WAS
TRIED I KNOW WHEN I THINK YOU
THE BILL GOT TO APPROACH AND
DIDN'T GET OUT SO. THAT STATE
YOUR BILL NO I DID NOT INCLUDE
THAT IN THIS BILL I WAS JUST
QUITE FRANKLY TRYING TO.
ADDRESS THE INEQUITIES THAT WE
HAVE. WITH MAINLY THOSE LOWER
PLATE EMPLOYEES WHO DO WORK
LONG HOURS AT A CERTAIN TIME
AND THEN. TO ALSO BE AFFORDED
THE SAME RIGHTS UNDER- THE
ASBESTOS IN THIS BUILDING IS
SOMETHING THAT I KNOW. I ASKED
A- THE- ONE OF THE EMPLOYEES OF
THE OF THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
DOLLIES IF THEY'D HAD. ANY
CONTACT FROM. THE HR DEPARTMENT
AND THEY DID SO HE THEY SENT ME
SOMETHING THAT. WAS COVERED
FROM DEBRA GAVE IT ABOUT.
NAILING THINGS IN THE WALL
BECAUSE- IN CERTAIN PARTS OF
THE HOUSE THERE ARE. HARMFUL
THINGS AND SAID WAS A- I DID
SEE AN EMAIL THAT CAME OUT SO
I'VE I'VE BEEN TRYING TO GATHER
INFORMATION ON BECAUSE WE DO
APPLY TO A LOT OF THE LAWS WE
DO WE APPLIED A LOT OF THE LAWS
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT I WAS ON
THE COMMITTEE FOR THAT. WE DO
THOSE SO- THAT'S KIND OF ANSWER
QUESTION MAYBE. PLEASE THANK
YOU SENATE ALI ALL RIGHT OTHER
QUESTIONS. OTHER QUESTIONS-
CYNICAL EUROPE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- SENATOR DOLLY I'M
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY I. THE CHALLENGE I HAVE
IS I HAVE BEEN IN AN EMPLOYER
AND SUB AND FRANKLY I REALLY
THINK WHAT WOULD BE A REAL GOOD
THING TO DO IS GO THROUGH THE
LABOR CODE AND TO TRY TO PULL
OUT THE DIMINISH KIND OF- OF.
ERRORS THAT CAN OCCUR IN ANY
ENVIRONMENT THAT ARE NOT DONE-
ON PURPOSE- NUMBER ONE NUMBER
TWO IS TO SET UP A PROCESS
WHERE IF YOU FOLLOW STATE
ADVISEMENT FROM THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER ABOUT HOW YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO CALCULATE
INFORMATION AND IT ENDS UP THAT
YOU THE COURT DETERMINES THAT
YOU'VE BEEN CALCULATING WRONG
BECAUSE YOU DID YOU RELIED ON
THE STATE ADVISEMENT. THEN I
THINK THERE OUGHT TO BE A GOOD
HARBOR- OF SAFE HARBOR FROM
THOSE KINDS OF- ERRORS AND- SO
MY CONCERN IS TO PUT. THE TO
MAKE. TO JUST COMPOUND THE
PROBLEM BY BY BY HAVING THE
LEGISLATURE- DO ABIDE BY THE
SAME RULES I GET YOUR POINT-
SOME OF THE SUPPORT SUPPORTED
TODAY BUT- BUT IT IS- IRONIC
THAT THERE ARE SOME THINGS THAT
WE- THAT WE DID WELL WE
LEGISLATE- THAT REALLY ARE DE
MINIMUS AND IT BECOMES
DIFFICULT AND SO. WITH THIS
BILL WE CAN NO LONGER HAVE
EMPLOYEES EATING AT THEIR DESK
AND WILL HAVE TO SEND THEM OUT
OF THE BUILDING IN ORDER FOR
HER SOMEWHERE IN A- IN THE CAN
AND HAVE. PLAY WHERE PEOPLE CAN
EAT. IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE NOT EATING AT THEIR
DESK BECAUSE IT IS A VIOLATION
OF THE LAW TO HAVE YOUR
EMPLOYEES EATING AT THEIR DESK
EVEN IF THEY WANT TO DO THAT
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH. SO BE CAREFUL
WHAT YOU ASK FOR SO I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO TODAY IN THE POINT YOU'RE
MAKING. WELL I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT- THAT'S EXACTLY MY POINT
TO ALL OF US EMPLOYERS IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR WHO QUITE
FRANKLY ARE NOT AT ODDS WITH
OUR EMPLOYEES WE'RE ACTUALLY
WE'RE PARTNERS. AND I MENTIONED
THAT MANY TIMES ON THIS FLOOR
THAT YOU KNOW YES THERE'S A FEW
BAD ACTORS OUT THERE BUT THE
MAJORITY OF THE RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN PRIVATE. LAWYERS AND
THEIR EMPLOYEES ARE NOT BAD
THERE THERE'S A TWO WAY STREET
AND WE NEED THEM THEY NEED US
AND WE'RE A FAMILY. BUT I WILL
TELL YOU JUST WAS. WHAT YOUR
YOUR O YOUR POINT IS THAT YOU
GET A TRIAL ATTORNEY OR A LABOR
ATTORNEY. YOU CAN TURN INTO
LAKEPORT SOME DISGRUNTLED
EMPLOYEE AND ALL SAID YOU'RE
OUT OF BUSINESS BECAUSE THE
LAWS ARE WRITTEN TO THAT STRICT
AMOUNT IT DOESN'T MATTER IT'S
JUST LIKE THE PARKING LOT IF
YOU. PAID IN POINT THEY GOT
PAID THEIR TOTAL WEIGHT BUT YOU
HAD THE DATE WRONG ON THE CHECK
YOU'RE LIABLE FOR. UP A TON OF
MONEY I MEAN UP TO SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT. AND WHO GETS THE
MONEY. NOTHING PLOY. THE
TOURNEY'S AT. THE END OF THE
DAY THAT'S TO REALLY WORKS OUT
SO- I'M I'M I WILL. BE HAPPY TO
LOOK AT THIS BILL IF I GET
OTHERS COMMITTEE AND MAYBE TIED
IT UP A LITTLE BIT- BUT-
REALLY. WE SHOULD IF IT CAN YOU
IMAGINE IF THE LEGISLATORS GOT
SUED BY THE EMPLOYEE AND A
POCKET CAME IN OR THE GOT THE
RULES COMMITTEE GOT SUED. MAYBE
WOULD BRING SOME LIGHT TO THE-
TO SOME OF THE THINGS WHERE WE
SHOULD HAVE A LITTLE MORE
COMMON SENSE AND MAYBE A LITTLE
MORE GRAYSON PEOPLE ARE TRYING
TO. PROVIDE JOBS ON A TWO WAY
STREET SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS AND I WOULD. LOOK AT
NARROWING DOWN MY BILL TO MAKE
IT MORE WORKABLE. THANK YOU
SENATE GONZALEZ THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND- THANK YOU
SENATOR DOLLY FOR BRINGING THIS
pBECAUSE I WAS. YOU KNOW I'M
STILL A LITTLE UNCLEAR AS TO
WHAT SORT OF TYPES OF
SITUATIONS AND IT'S- STATED IN
THE ANALYSIS PAGE FOR. THE
PARAGRAPH THAT SPARKS- FOR ME
IS THE PROBLEM IS THAT THIS
BILL DRAWS NO DISTINCTION
BETWEEN SITUATIONS AS AS I
MENTIONED IT WHICH IT MIGHT
MAKE POLICY SENSE TO TREAT
LEGISLATIVE EMPLOYEES
DIFFERENTLY. IT SWEEPS UP ALL
EMPLOYMENT LAWS APPLICABLE TO
THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND DUMP
THEM ON THE LEGISLATURE WITHOUT
TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION- SUCH
MOVE SO. I'LL I'M HAPPY TO VOTE
YES BECAUSE I LIKE THE WAY THIS
DIALOGUE IS TURNING OUT- BUT
I'D LIKE TO SEE WHERE YOU CAN
TIGHTEN IT UP AND CREATE
SITUATIONS- OUTSIDE OF- WHERE
WE ALREADY ALIGN WITH THE
PRIVATE SECTOR. AND WHERE THE
GAPS ARE- AS YOU KNOW AND IT
SEEMS LIKE YOU'RE GONNA BE
DOING THAT SO. HAPPY TO SUPPORT
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALREADY- C. NO OTHER MIKE- IS
THERE A MOTION. SIR JOHN'S MOST
THE BILL ALL RIGHT. SENATE ALI
CARE CLOSE I DO I JUST WANNA
SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
CONVERSATION I WILL LOOK INTO
THOSE- I WOULD BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO HAVE SOME HELP I
HAVEN'T HAD MUCH ALONG THE WAY
BUT I DO KNOW SOME OF THE
THINGS I WANT TO WORK O AND IT
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO FOR.
OUR EMPLOYEES TO GIVE THEM THE
SAME RIGHTS AS AS EVERYBODY
OTHER EMPLOYEE IN THE STATE OF
SO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ALREADY THANK YOU. MOTION
BY SENATOR JOHNS. BUDGET
COUNCIL STRUCK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS SB FIVE FIFTY BY
SENATOR DOLLY WITH A MOTION BY
SENATOR JOHNSON MOTION IS. DUE
PASSED BUT FIRST TO BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- BURKE. AND- I.
CARRIERA EVERY AT ALL I DID US
SO. IT US SO I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. JONES
JONES I LAYERED. LAYARD I.
STERN. QUAKE OWSKI WHY CASKEY
HI WIENER. AS A FOR YOU HAVE.
EIGHT ZERO. THANK YOU WILL PUT
THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU-
NEXT WE HAVE- SB SEVEN ZERO TWO
SECONDS ALSO YOU'RE GOING TO
PUT YOU KNOW WHAT I SEIZE
CENTER LEYVA YEAR SO WHILE WE
DO THIS SINCE SENATOR HAS GOT
TO BE HERE ANYWAY- WHY DON'T WE
TAKE UP S. B. SEVEN TWO SEVEN
BY SENATOR LEYVA. I'M GOING TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR THINKING MEMBERS THANK
YOU SENATOR GONZALEZ I MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
MISTER CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
WORK WITH ME ON THIS BILL. AND
TO THAT END I WILL BE TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WHICH ALL OF
YOU SHOULD HAVE. SB SEVEN TWO
SEVEN AIMS TO PREVENT WAIT
STAFF WITHIN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY. I WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT WE ARE SEEKING TO GO AFTER
THE BAD ACTORS IN THE INDUSTRY.
AND TO HELP THOSE THAT PLAY BY
THE RULES AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR WORKERS ARE PAID BACK ON
TIME. AND HELP THEM.
CALIFORNIA'S CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY BUILT OUR WORLD CROSS
CLASS INFRASTRUCTURE IS A KEY
DRIVER OF THE STATE'S ECONOMY
AND PROVIDED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF HOUSING UNITS
ANNUALLY. TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF GROWING CALIFORNIA
POPULATION. DUE TO THE SKILLS
REQUIRED IN THE FAIR WAGES AND
BENEFITS WORKERS RECEIVED THE
INDUSTRY PROVIDED A PATHWAY TO
THE MIDDLE CLASS. FOR TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS WHO COULD THEN AFFORD
TO PURCHASE THE HOMES THAT THEY
BUILT. UNFORTUNATELY FOR MORE
THAN THE LAST FORTY YEARS THOSE
STANDARDS HAVE BEEN GRADUALLY
ERODING. ORDING TO THE UNITED
STATES OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT CRITERIA OVER 50%
OF CALIFORNIA'S CONSTRUCTION
WORK FORCE FAMILIES CURRENTLY
FALL IN THE LOW INCOME
CATEGORY. LESS THAN 80% OF
MEDIAN FAMILY INCOME. AND OVER
ONE THIRD OF ALL CONSTRUCTION
FAMILIES ARE CLASSIFIED AS VERY
LOW INCOME LESS THAN 50% OF THE
MEDIAN FAMILY INCOME. LIKE MANY
OTHER SECTORS CONSTRUCTION
WAGES HAVE GONE DOWN BUT WAGE
THEFT AND CASH PAYMENTS HAVE
INCREASED. AND A KEY FACTOR FOR
THIS IS THE LACK OF ENFORCEMENT
OF BASIC LABOR LAWS ON
JOBSITES. UNSCRUPULOUS
CONTRACTORS TO DO NOT PLAY BY
THE RULES HAVE BEEN ILLEGAL AND
UNFAIR ADVANTAGE OVER ON ITS
CONTRACTORS AS THE UNDERMINE
WAGES AND WORKING CONDITIONS
THROUGHOUT THE INDUSTRY. LABOR
SHORTAGES CONSTRUCTION OUR
LARGER CLIENTS CONCENTRATED IN
THE LOW WAGE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY SECTORS OF THE
INDUSTRY. I WILL NOT GO INTO
ALL OF THE DETAIL AS TO WHY
THAT IS DANNY CURTAIN WHO'S
HERE WITH ME TODAY WILL DO
THAT. BUT I WILL SHARE THAT
WHILE S. B. EXCUSE ME AB
SEVENTEEN OH ONE BY THURMOND.
WHICH TOOK EFFECT IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN HAS MADE SOME
DIFFERENCE IT HAS NOT DONE
ENOUGH OR GONE FAR ENOUGH. SOME
CONTRACTORS STILL CONSIDER WAGE
THEFT JUST A COST OF DOING
BUSINESS. COLLEAGUES AT THIS
TIME THAT WE TREAT WAGE THEFT
IN THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
SIMILAR. TO HOW WE DO IN OTHER
INDUSTRIES. SB TWO SO WILL
PROVIDE NECESSARY ENFORCEMENT
TOOLS TO EFFECTIVELY DETER
CONTINUED WAGE THAT BY MAKING
SURE THAT DIRECT CONTRACTORS.
NO LONGER IGNORE THE VIOLATIONS
OF THE SUBCONTRACTORS THEY
HIRED TO BUILD THEIR PROJECTS
HERE WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY%
IN SUPPORT IS THE ANY CURTAIN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE
OF CARPENTERS. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SIR LEYVA AYE
SEEMS TO CURTAIN UP IN THE
GALLERY DISCOURAGING THE
GALLERIES YEARS. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SIMILAR.
FIRST OF ALL I THINK THIS FOR
IS SIXTY TWO BY OF THE DAY.
ADDRESS A JOINT LAW. ISSUE THE
GARMENT INDUSTRY. SB SEVEN TWO
SEVEN EXPANSE THAT SAME DIRECT
CONTRACTOR JOINT LIABILITY TO
INCLUDE PENALTIES LIQUIDATED
DAMAGES AND INTEREST. FOR
SUBCONTRACTOR. VIOLATIONS IN
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY. S.
THE LATEST OVER 4% OF THE
COUNTRY WORK FORCES YOU TO LOW
VERY LOW OR- LOW AND- OVER
THIRD ALMOST THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND WORKERS ARE BELOW THE
CALIFORNIA POVERTY STANDARD.
OVER 85% OF THOSE WORKERS ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THEM LATINO. OVER
THE LAST FOUR DECADES
CONSTRUCTION WAGES HAVE BEEN
FLAT AND ACTUALLY DROP IN THE
LOWER HALF OF THE INDUSTRY THAT
SAME AT THE SAME TIME THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY HAS
INCREASED OVER FOUR HUNDRED
PERCENT. ALMOST 20% OF THE
CONSTRUCTION WORKFORCE ARE
EITHER OFF THE BOOKS WERE
MISCLASSIFIED. WHEN THE
UNDERGROUND UNDERGROUND GOES UP
WORKERS WE JUST DOWN.
CALIFORNIA STATE LAY LAW. IS
ONE. THE OTHER HAVING A JOB
SITE. RANGE ONCE IN THREE
HUNDRED BY THE LABOR CAN. OR
ONCE IN THREE THAT YEARS BY THE
MULTI AGENCY JOINT ENFORCEMENT
STRIKE FORCE. AN ESTIMATED
TWENTY MILLION. TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN WAGES GOES
UNREPORTED. IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY CRIME DOES PAY.
OPPONENTS OF THIS BILL SUGGEST
WE NEED MORE LABOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT'S ONE PLACE WE
AGREE THAT AVOIDS THE REAL
ISSUE OF RESPONSIBILITY. THE
GENERAL CONTRACTOR IS TOTALLY
RESPONSIBLE AND LIABLE FOR THE
COMPLETION OF THE JOB THE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION THEY'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR LONG TERM
LATENT DEFECT LIABILITY THERE
ARE ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR
ENFORCING SAFETY ON THE ENTIRE
JOB. NO BLAMING THE
SUBCONTRACTORS THERE THE SINGLE
ENTITY THAT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
CONTROLLING THE PROJECT IN THE
ONE ENTITY THAT HAS THE TOOLS
TO DO SO. WE TAKEN MAJOR. TO
MAKE SURE CONTRACTOR ARE ONLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE THINGS THEY
CAN MONITOR. OPPONENTS SAID
THEY COULDN'T MONITOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PAYMENTS
AND WORKERS COMP PREMIUMS. THEY
WILL RIGHT. SO WE DROPPED THOSE
ISSUES FROM THE BILL NOT
BECAUSE THERE ISN'T RAMPANT
ABUSE BUT BECAUSE THEY CAN'T BE
MONITORED BY THE GENERAL
CONTRACTOR. WE'VE ADDED
IMPORTANT LANGUAGE MODELED ON
PUBLIC WORKS CONSTRUCTION LOG
THAT RELIEVES THE GENERAL
CONTRACTOR OF LIABILITIES FOR
PENALTIES. THE SUBCONTRACTOR
PAYROLLS AND DILIGENTLY TAKE
CORRECTIVE ACTION TO HALT OR
RECTIFY THE FAILURE. NOW
OPPONENTS ARE SAYING IT BE A
NICE TO ME THE- ACTUALLY IT'S
DONE ALL THE TIME IN THE UPPER
HALF OF THE CAN. IN THE
NIGHTMARE FOR ON THE SUB OF
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS WHOSE
FAMILIES LIVE IN POVERTY. IN
SPITE OF A FULL TIME JOB IN
WHAT USED TO BE A PATHWAY TO
THE MIDDLE CLASS. THIS IS NOT A
WAGE BILL THAT DOES NOT CALL
FOR HIGHER WAGES IT'S A WAGE
THEFT BILL IT'S A PLAY BY THE
RULES BILL THE RULES AND LAWS
THAT ALREADY EXIST. UNLESS
THERE IS A FINANCIAL PENALTY
FOR NOT PLAYING BY THE RULES
THE LAW IS SIMPLY A SUGGESTION.
CONTRACTORS KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT THEY'LL BE
NO MORE LOOKING THE OTHER WAY
WHILE SUBCONTRACTORS PLAY FAST
AND LOOSE. HONEST CONTRACTORS
IN THE BOTTOM HALF OF THE
INDUSTRY ESPECIALLY START UP
CONTRACTORS COMPETE IN THE WILD
WEST ENVIRONMENT. WHERE THEY
HAVE TO SQUEEZE THEIR WORKERS
HARDER OR THEY START CUTTING
CORNERS WITH THE RULES. IF
THERE IS A CHURCH SHORTAGE OF
WORKERS IN RESIDENTIAL INDUSTRY
IT'S BECAUSE WORKERS
PARTICULARLY YOUNG WORKERS SEE
NO FUTURE IN HARD DIRTY WORK
THAT PAYS POVERTY WAGES. I ASK
YOU TO KEEP THIS IN MIND AS YOU
CONTINUE TO PUSH FOR MORE
DESPERATELY NEEDED HOUSING.
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF WORKERS WHO ARE ALSO IN
DESPERATE NEED. THIS BILL IS
START I WANNA THANK SENATE
LABOR TAKING THIS CHALLENGE SB
SEVEN TWO SEVEN IS TELLING THE
PRIVATE SECTOR IT'S O'CLOCK
TIME TO CLEAN UP YOUR INDUSTRY.
I JUST AN ASIDE MR I WOULD LIKE
THANK THIS. WHEN YOU'RE OUTSIDE
THIS MAKING FOR ESPECIALLY
UNDER PANDEMIC. IT'S A TO
FORGET OR UNDER. HOW MAY
CRITICAL THEY REALLY ARE I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER KERN YOU'VE TO
A THREE MEN AND THIRTY SECONDS-
I DON'T KNOW IF MISTER. DESMOND
LEE IS ON THE LINE- WELL WILL
GIVE HIM THIRTY. YES I AM HERE-
THANK YOU. GO AHEAD. GLAD LUCK
IS THERE A SPECIFIC QUESTION.
NO NO SPECIFICALLY ON IF THERE
ARE NO I DIDN'T BEN I UNDER MR
ALL AVAILABLE BY TECHNO SO. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITH IN THIS.
IN THE GAS C. NONE OF WE IN
SOME ROOM ONE TWELVE SEEING
NONE ALL RIGHT AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE IS A FOLKS ARE ALSO.
WE'RE GOING TO DO SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AND WILL TAKE ONE
ONE COMMENT FROM THOSE THAT ARE
TWEENER SPARRING. SO LET'S GO
TO THE PHONE LINES THOSE IN
SUPPORT. OF SB SEVEN TWO SEVEN
BY CENTER LEYVA PLEASE QUEUE UP.
HENLEY'S JOHN HR IN SUPPORT OF
AB OR A SEVEN TWO SEVEN SORRY
SB SEVEN TWO SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AGAIN SUPPORT PRESS
THE SEVEN TWO SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE
DO HAVE ABOUT NINE IN OUR QUEUE.
WE'LL START WITH NUMBER FOUR
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH I THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
KEEP DONE WITH THE DISTRICT
COUNCIL OF IRAN WITH CAL IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL BY ME
CURTAIN YOU HAVE FOR YOUR YES
VOTE. THANK YOU. NEXT TO BE NO
FIVE THREE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MATT KREMIN ON BEHALF
THE MEDICAL ABOUT BRINGING. WE
ARE TODAY AND STRONG THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT WE NUMBER FIVE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
SENATORS ARGUED BELCHER WITH
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CARPENTERS CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS WAGE THAT BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WELL NOW
THE NUMBER THREE NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MODERATOR MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALSO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT TO BE NUMBER
FIVE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS ARE TONY CONCEALED
BILL REPRESENTATIVE LOCAL SEVEN
OH ONE COVERING PRESS WITH
TULARE AND KINGS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXUS NUMBER SIX FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS TONY WHEN YOU ALSO
CORPORATE LOCAL SEVEN THIRTEEN
OUT OF UNLIMITED THE SUPPORT
BEST SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN AM.
THANK YOU. NOT GONNA NUMBER
FIVE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS JESSE CRAWLERS-
CALLING FROM POPULAR LOCAL ONE
FIFTY TWO REPRESENT CONSERVE
COSTA COUNTY WHERE I'M STRONG
SUPPORTER SB TWO SEVEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXUS NUMBER
TWO. PLEASE AHEAD. CERTAINLY
YOU'RE JIM MORRIS WITH LOCAL.
ONE TO TWO REPRESENT INSTEAD OF
THAT WILL. FOR SAID LOCAL LAW
OF TALENT THE AMAZON CARE. THE
CALL STRONG. SB. SEVEN SEVEN.
NEXT WE NUMBER FOUR NINE PLEASE
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
MARKET TORY REPRESENTING
CORPORATE LOOK FORTY NINE ONE
ONE NINE MANY. EVERENCE YOLO
YOU COLUSA SUTTER OTHER OUT OF
PLASTER NEVADA ALPINE COUNTY
AND WE'RE IN STRONG. OF IT
SEVEN TWO SEVEN. THANK YOU.
HELLO GO TO LINE TWO THREE ONE
PLEASE GO. AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS MIKE WELL
REPRESENT THE INTERNAL UNION OF
PAINTERS AND TRADES AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AT THE
TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL
RIGHT- NOW WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION- I UNDERSTAND THAT-
SYMBIO FERRARI IS IN OPPOSITION
MISTER MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
MISTER FERRARI ON THE LINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN CAN
YOU HEAR ME. GO AHEAD MR FOR-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- THE BILL FOR OUR AND
AFTER CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO IT SENATE BILL
SEVEN TWO SEVEN I'M THAT EVEN
IN THE FORM I TO BE DOESN'T AS
A HOUSE KILLER. IF YOU LOOK AT
THE TO POINTS I WANT REVIEW
TODAY THE FIRST ONE IS- YOU
KNOW I NEED COMMITTEE TODAY I
WANT YOU KNOW THERE'S THAT
THERE ARE IN. OF DID FOR HOME
BUILDERS FOR MORE WITH THEM
KIND. YES NOT UP TO THEIR
OBLIGATIONS TO THEIR IN. THANK
YOU FOR UNDER IN THE SEVENTY A
ONE HOMEBUILDERS ARE THE HOOK
FOR UNPAID WAGES FOR BENEFITS
OTHER. ESSENTIALLY HOW BUILDERS
TO PAY TWICE FOR THE WORK PLUS
THE TURN FEES EXPERT WITNESS.
IN A SUBCONTRACTOR A BAND THERE
WAS. WHICH I BECAUSE THEY DO IN
THE- WE ALSO DON'T HAVE TO LOOK
INTO WORD BECAUSE FOR IT THE
CLOSING ESCROW X. RATE LOCK.
FINDING AND FOR SHELTER PUT ARE
IN DURING THAT PERIOD OF TIME
HE ALSO ARE NOW ON THE HOOK THE-
AND WAR. THE NEW. AND THAT IS
IN THE ANALYSIS IN THE IN THE
ON YOU CONDUCT HEY WITH ONLY
WORKS TO THE PREVAILING WAGE
WORRIED THIRD PARTY TO TURN AND
POP IT BECAUSE RATES IN THIS
CASE IT DO YOU R. RATE. IN THE
PRIVATE CONSTRUCTION RICHARD BY
WORK XP BY THE OF THEIR CRAFT
BUY THEIR PRODUCT THE LITTLE
CREATED SEPARATE THE CHANGE ONE
TO THE NEXT YOU CAN CHANGE THE
COST IN THE SINGLE OKAY IN THE
SAME TRADE AND THEY CAN CHANGE
FROM. ONE COMPLIANCE PASS THE
PRIVATE CONTRACTOR JEFF IN
REGARDS TO THE PAY WILL REVIEW.
WE SHARED ONE AND THE SHOULD BE
RESOLVED. BUT THERE ARE PRETTY
IN THE BILL THAT WE BELIEVE. BE
A GREAT WITH. THAT REQUIRE WITH
HOLD PAYMENT TO STOP AND
CORRECTIVE. WE HAVE NO ISSUE
THOSE BECAUSE- AS AS THE WHOLE
BUILDERS THE CON WE WILL HOLD
PAYMENT WE REMEMBER. THE ISSUE
WANT THE WORK PACE AND WE ALL
AGREED THE OFFICE IS THAT THE
END WE ALL WANT THE DESIRED
OUTCOME TO GET THAT ONE PAY.
THE LEAST ALL BE TO AGREE. THAT
THERE IS A- AND FOCUS A MAN TO
MAKE BILL WILL FOR THE PRIVATE
USE CON. SO WE ARE HOPEFUL CAN
WORK THIS COME WITH THE
AUTHORED SPONSOR TEXTING OUT
BECAUSE WHAT THAT IS WE
SOMETHING ON THE TAPE- LOOKS TO
WORK WITH SOME ON MOVING FOR.
BUT WE ARE SUPPOSED AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR ON
THE AMENDMENTS WITH CITIES- ARE
ASSOCIATION IS NOW NEUTRAL ON
THE BILL. WE DO LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR IN PROPONENTS. AND WAYS
TO ENSURE THAT THE ACTUAL
VIOLATORS. IF DURING THE
PROCESS THANK BY THANK YOU MR
GOVERNOR SCOTT. JAMIE CON HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATED
GENERAL CONTRACTORS AND I WOULD
LIKE TO BOB ECHO SCOTT
GOVERNORS- CLEMENTS AGENCY IS
LISTED AS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BUT AFTER THE AMENDMENTS AFTER
REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS
PROVIDED BY THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT TO WE APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK THAT HE AND YOU HAVE
DONE GERMAN. ON THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE WE HAVE DECIDED TO GO TO
NEUTRAL AND HOPE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE PROPONENTS ON
SOME DETAILS THAT WE LIKE TO
SEE RECTIFIED. BERNIE THANK YOU
AGAIN THINK OF IS KIND ALSO IS
MISTER EDDIE. BERNACCHI ON THE
PHONE. YES MISTER MISTER
CHAIRMAN ANYBODY KNOCKING- A
BEALF OF THE NATIONAL
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS. AND THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
OPERATORS OF THE PLUMBING
HEATING AND PIPING INDUSTRY
THESE ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENT
OVER TWO THOUSAND UNION
SIGNATORY ELECTRICAL AND
MECHANICAL CONTRACTORS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ORIGINALLY
WE WERE OPPOSE THIS MEASURE BUT
WE WERE MOVING OPPOSITION AND
WHILE THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE BEING TAKEN. TO CREATE
A FAIR PROCESS FOR DIRECT
CONTRACTORS REMOVE LIABILITIES
THAT ON THESE- AND DUE TO THE
MINISTRIES TO TAKE IN LATER
WORKERS COMPENSATION AND
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE- WE ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE SPONSORS THE
AUTHOR AND HER STAFF AND THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS IN BOTH.
LABOR AND THIS COMMITTEE FOR
ALL THEIR EFFORTS AND HARD WORK
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES- WE HAD
WITH THE BILL AND GET US TO
THIS NEUTRAL POSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR GNOCCHI. NO ONE
ELSE IN THE GALLERY WAS TO
TESTIFY OR IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
ASK THOSE WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION
AND I SUPPOSE ANYBODY WHO'S A
IN BETWEEN- TO LINE UP AND
PROVIDE THEIR NAME THEIR-
SOLICITATION. AFFILIATION IN
THEIR POSITION. IN LATE GERMAN
IF YOU IN OPPOSITE. OR NEUTRAL
ON SB SEVEN TWO SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO
PROPOSITION OR NEUTRAL FOR SB.
SEVEN TWO SEVEN. AT THE TIME WE
HAVE NONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MR ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
IF THERE'S NO ONE ELSE ON THE
PHONE LINE I'LL COME BACK TO
THE CHAMBER I SEE NO
MICROPHONES REYES. CENTER LEYVA
IS THERE ARE THERE IS A
MICROPHONE WOULD RAISE ALL I'M
SORRY CYNICAL YEAR THAT THAT
BETWEEN THREE PLEXIGLASS.
SCREENS IS TOUGH TO SEE YOU
OVER THERE SO YES IN A COUPLE
YEAR I DO APPRECIATE THAT MR
SURE BECAUSE I DO- CHAIR
SESSIONS AND IT'S HARD TO SEE
THE MIKE SOMETIMES I THINK VERY
MUCH I JUST WANTED TO THANK THE
AUTHOR I THINK HE'S DONE A-
STELLAR JOB IN IN- TRYING TO
MAKE THIS WORK. THERE WAS ONE
IS- SUGGESTION AND I AND I I'M
AND I'M GONNA ASSUME YOU'RE
GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK WITH-
WHAT WE REALLY WANT IS THE
ACTUAL VIOLENCE BY LEADERS
PUNISHED I THINK THAT'S WHAT
YOU WANT TO. AND THE MENTION
WAS- FOR AN ALTERNATIVE
COMPLIANCE PATH AND I AM I
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK YOU'VE
DONE AND I THINK THERE PROBABLY
ARE. EASY WAYS TO BE ABLE TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THE SUB HAS
DONE WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
DO AND- SO THAT THE CONTRACTOR
CAN RECTIFY THE ISSUE QUICKLY-
SO HOPEFULLY YOU'RE INTERESTED
IN TRYING TO REACH THAT AND I
SEE THAT THE THUMB UP AND I
REALLY APPRECIATED I'M GOING TO
BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
SEVERAL SINGLE OTHER
MICROPHONES REYES- I'M COMING
BACK TO YOU. SOONER OR LATER
THEIR MOTION. SENATOR SENATE
AWESOME THE BILL AND CERTAINLY
AYE AYE KNOW THE- YOU'RE STILL
IT'S WORKING WITH CIA AND SOME
OF THE OTHER. INTERESTED
CONTRACTORS THAT. HAVE NOT HAD
THEIR ISSUES ADDRESSED AT LEAST
TO THEIR ATISFACTION I KNOW
YOU CONTINUE TO WORK TO. SEE
THAT THAT THOSE ISSUES ARE
ADDRESSED SO. HAVING SAID THAT
SIR LEYVA THE CHEMICALS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
CENTER COVER YOUR FOR YOUR
COMMENTS THANK YOU COMMITTEE
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS
BILL. I THINK YOU DO YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF.
INTO LABOR COMMITTEE STAFF WE
HAVE REALLY WORKED HARD TO TRY
AND GET THIS TO A PLACE WHERE.
EVERYBODY IS A LITTLE HAPPY AND
A LITTLE UNHAPPY. AND WE WILL
ABSOLUTELY CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE REMAINING OPPOSITION
AND GET TO A PLACE WHERE.
HOPEFULLY THEY CAN BE A LITTLE
HAPPY AND A LITTLE UNHAPPY- BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY WE JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT WAGE THEFT IS
NOT A COST OF DOING BUSINESS.
SO WITH THAT MISTER CHAIR
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. BENCI COUNCIL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THISIS SB
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
LEYVA WITH EMOTION BY CENTER
DID US ALL. AND THE BUSHES TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND THEN RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
UMBERG I UMBERG I POUR.
PROBABLY AT. I HAD A I DID ALSO.
GET US OUT I. GONZALEZ I.
HERTZBERG JONES. JONES NOT
VOTING. BLARED HI CLEARED I
STERN. WHITE HOUSE SKI FIVE Y.
CASKEY I WIENER. THE OF SIX TO
ZERO SO FAR THE REMOTE TO PUT
THE BILL ON CALL CERTAINLY THE
NECTAR CARE THINKING MEMBERS
THANK YOU NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE THE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SB
SEVEN FOUR FOUR BY CENTER
GLAZER FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO MAY
BE WATCHING OR LISTENING-
CENTER LEMOND'S BILL SB SEVEN
ZERO TWO WILL BE PRESENTED BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ- BUT THAT'S
GOING TO BE AFTER. A CENTER
GLAZER PRESENCE SB SEVEN FOUR
FOUR SURVEYS THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL SEVEN FORTY FOUR THIS BILL
PROPOSES MODEST CHANGES TO THE
WAY THE STATE GATHERS AND
SHARES INFORMATION TO FIGHT THE
SPREAD OF INFECTIOUS DISEASE.
AS YOU KNOW MORE THAN A YEAR
INTO THE PANDEMIC WE STILL HAVE
VERY LITTLE SCIENCE THAT
EXPLAINS HOW THE VIRUS THAT
CAUSES COBIT NINE HAS SPREAD.
NOW GOOD SCIENCE DEPENDS ON
GOOD DATA AND WE HAVE
UNFORTUNATELY VERY LITTLE DATA.
EVEN THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH HAS A SYSTEM FOR
SHARING DATA WITH BONA FIDE.
UNIVERSITY RESEARCHERS. NOT A
SINGLE STUDY MEMBERS NOT A
SINGLE STUDY WAS PUBLISHED IN
TWENTY TWENTY. BASED ON THE
INFORMATION GLEANED FROM THE
NEARLY. THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION CASES. OF COVERT
NINETEEN HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE SITUATION IS BUT ARE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS AT EVEN
GREATER RISK. THIS BILL COULD
CHANGE THAT. BY GATHERING
BETTER DATA AND MAKING IT
EASIER FOR RESEARCHERS TO USE
FIRST WE WOULD GATHER MORE DATA
ON HOUSING WORKPLACE ENTRAPMENT
WHICH WE BELIEVE TO BE A MAJOR
SOURCES SPREAD. THEN WE WOULD
IMPROVE OUR EXISTING SYSTEM FOR
SHARING DATA WITH RESEARCHERS
BY CREATING A FAST LANE TO
ALLOW THEM TO SEE DATA IN REAL
TIME WHEN THEIR ANALYSIS IS
MOST NEEDED. TO INFORM BETTER
POLICY. WE WOULD DO THIS. WHILE
LEAVING IN PLACE ALL OF THE
EXISTING PROTECTIONS FOR
PERSONAL PRIVACY. WHICH IN
CALIFORNIA ARE PROBABLY THE
STRONGEST IN THE COUNTRY.
MEMBERS WE HAVE LOST MORE THAN
SIXTY THOUSAND FELLOW
CALIFORNIANS TO THIS DEADLY
VIRUS. WE CAN'T GO BACK AND
APPLY THE LESSONS WE LEARNED TO
SAVE THOSE LIVES. WE CAN APPLY
THOSE LESSONS TO THE FUTURE AND
WE SHOULD. I KNOW WE'RE GOING
TO HEAR A MOMENT FROM SOME
OPPOSITION FROM PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER COMMUNITY WONDERFUL
PEOPLE DOING GREAT WORK FOR US
I'LL BE HAPPY TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS THEY'VE RAISED A
LITTLE BIT LATER HEARING IF THE
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE. WITH ME TO
EXPLAIN THE ROLE THE DATA PLAYS
IN FIGHTING DISEASE AND HOW
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY PERFORMS
ON THAT SCORE IS DR JEFFREY
CLARK LISNER FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA KECK SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE. THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZERS CONTACT CLOSER YOU
ONLINE. I AM THANK YOU THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. HI MY NAME IS
DR JEFFREY KLAUSNER PRACTICING
INFECTIOUS DISEASE PHYSICIAN
MEDICAL EPIDEMIOLOGIST AND
PROFESSOR OF PREVENTIVE
MEDICINE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. I AM A
FORMER COUNTY DEPUTY HEALTH
OFFICER FOR OVER TWELVE YEARS
AND FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA STD CONTROLLERS
ASSOCIATION AS BEING IN STRONG
SUPPORTER SENATE BILL SEVEN
FOUR FOUR WHICH WOULD ADD. NEW
DATA ELEMENTS TO COMMUNICABLE
RESPIRATORY DISEASE REPORTING
AND REQUIRE THE STATE TO
SECURELY SHARE DE IDENTIFIED
DATA TO ENABLE CALIFORNIA BASED
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS TO
PERFORM EPIDEMIOLOGIC ANALYSIS.
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSE TO CALL THE NINETEEN
HAS BEEN AN ABJECT FAILURE.
NEARLY SIXTY THOUSAND US TWO
THIRDS DURING DISADVANTAGED
POPULATIONS A COLOR ISSUE LAST
EXTRACELLULAR THE CONTINUED
SCHOOL CLOSURES IN SOME AREAS
AND SEVERE ECONOMIC LOSS AMONG
THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. THAT CAN
CONTRIBUTE TO THAT FAILURE HAS
BEEN THE POOR USE OF
EPIDEMIOLOGIC DATA AN INABILITY
OF THE STATE TO USE AVAILABLE
DATA TO CREATE A TARGETED
RESPONSE TO FOCUS INTERVENTIONS
TO LIMIT THE COLLATERAL DAMAGE
CAUSED BY BROAD BASED.
STATEWIDE POLICIES BECAUSE OF
DECADES OF FUNDING CUTS TO THE
STATE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
THIS STATE HAS LIMITED CAPACITY
TO ANALYZE COLLECTED DATA
FURTHERMORE THE DATA COLLECTED
ARE INCOMPLETE AND INSUFFICIENT
TO SUPPORT SCIENCE BASS
RESPONSE. EXAMPLE THAT FAILURE
WHERE THE INDISCRIMINATE
CLOSURE OF OUTDOOR SPACES
BEACHES PLAYGROUNDS AND THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF UNFOUNDED
INTERVENTIONS LIKE DEEP%
CLEANING ACTIVITIES ON THE FLIP
SIDE THE LACK OF GOOD DATA
RESULTED IN THE NEGLECT. OF
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND THE
FAILURE TO IMPLEMENT TESTING IN
THE WORK FORCE WHICH COULD HAVE
IDENTIFIED EARLY CASES
IMPLEMENTED THE FOR THE SPREAD
OF INFECTION. SENATE BILL SEVEN
FOUR FOUR WOULD BE A STEP
TOWARD RIGHTING THE STATE'S DEL
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM BY ADDING
HOLDEN RESPIRATORY DISEASE
EXPOSURE ELEMENT. I CAN ASSURE
YOU THAT COLLECTING THE ADDED
TO THE ELEMENTS ARE NOT. A
BURDEN TO PRACTICING CLINICIAN
IN FACT IT DOCTOR ARE TAUGHT TO
GO THOSE. ARE KEEPING WRK HOW
TYPE TO TRAVEL. IN MEDICAL
SCHOOL. AS PART OF A GOOD MEDIC
HISTORY ONE OF THE- PATIENTS
WHO RESPITE DISEASE.
FURTHERMORE SO DATA OFTEN FOR
BY PAY UPON REGISTRATION OR
INPUT INTO A CHRONIC MEDICAL
RECORDS BY REGISTRATION STAFF
THE SAME WAY THAT THEY RECORD
INSURANCE INFORMATION. FOR
TOBACCO USE IN RESPONSE TO COPE
WITH NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS HAVE BEEN SWINGING
BLINDLY. IT IS NO WONDER THAT
THE DAMAGE HAS BEEN SO SVERE
WITH BETTER DATA PROVIDER
ACCESS IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY WE
CAN PROTECT THE PRIVACY OF
INDIVIDUALS WHILE PROTECTING
PROTECTING THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF ALL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU TO CLOSER. ALL RIGHT ALL
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY. TO SEE
NONE ROOM ONE TWELVE SEEING
NONE STERN TO THE PHONE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF
SUPPORT OF SB. SEVEN FOUR FOUR
PLEASE QUEUE UP. THE MODERATOR.
ANYONE OF S. B. SEVEN FOUR
FOUR. YOUR SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
FOUR FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. IN ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT OF SB. SEVEN FOUR FOUR.
AND WE HAVE TO IN THE QUEUE.
WE'LL START WITH NUMBER THREE
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT. I'M SORRY
GO HEAD VISION. YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION YOUR POSITION. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE OF BETTY
ARMSTRONG WITH THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IN OPPOSITION I WAS
A KID AND OF THE SUPPORT LINE.
RT OKAY WE'RE GONNA TURN
OPPOSITION IS SECOND SUPPORT
ANYONE ELSE OF THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT. WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIX FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING BROWN BOTH
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IN SUPPORT. GIVE ANYONE
ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT. AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN FOUR FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER IN
THE QUEUE ALL RIGHT ANY MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA
TURN OUT OPPOSITION IS MISSED
CAN THE BURKE OF A LITTLE. YES
I AM HERE. LAUREN WAS THE
BURGER HEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS KATHY
BURKE I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE HEALTH OFFICERS
AT THE STATION CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTATIVE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTY ENTRY CITY SUFFICIENT
HELP OFFICERS IN OUR STATE I
HOPE YOU'LL LET ME KNOW IF
THERE'S ANY PROBLEM WITH MY
AUDIO. IN CALIFORNIA BOTH THE
HEALTH OFFICERS MONITOR THE
HEALTH OF THEIR COMMUNITIES
WHICH IS ONE OF THEIR FIRST
DUTIES AND A PRIMARY TOOL FOR
DOING THIS IS DISEASE REPORTING
USING TITLE SEVENTEEN WHICH
REQUIRES HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
TO LET US KNOW WHEN THE SCENE
ONE OF THE CASES. EIGHTY EIGHT
IS THE- BUT WE KNOW THAT ALL
FOR. REPORT AND CASE THEY MIGHT
FORGET WHERE THEY MIGHT THINK
IT'S TOO MUCH TROUBLE. SO TO
KEEP THE SYSTEM RUNNING
SMOOTHLY WE TRY TO MAKE SURE IT
IS SIMPLE AND CONFIDENTIAL AND-
WE WANT TO REMOVE BARRIERS TO
DISEASE REPORTING. THIS BILL
WILL ADD MORE QUESTIONS TO BE
ASKED BY THE MEDICAL PROVIDER.
TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE TWENTY ONE
AND THE IN EIGHTY EIGHT AND-
NOT ALL THE QUESTIONS ARE
APPROPRIATE FOR EACH CITY BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY IT ADDS AND
BARRIER IT MAY END UP HARMING
DATA COLLECTION RATHER THAN
HELPING IT BECAUSE THE MORE
QUESTIONS WE REQUIRE PROVIDERS
TO ASK. THE LESS LIKELY THEY
WILL BE SURE PORTANTINO MRS.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE DOCTORS
OFFICES AND MATH TESTING SITES
LIKE WE USE FOR KOBE WE FOUND
THAT SOME MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY WERE NERVOUS TO SHOW
UP AT ALL. AND THE MORE
PERSONAL QUESTIONS WE ASK THE
LESS LIKELY PEOPLE NEED TO WANT
TO SHOW UP AND- SAY. THAT THERE
ARE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL WE
DON'T THINK OF QUESTIONS BELONG
IN THE DISEASE YOUR PARKING LOT.
WHICH IS WHY WERE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR BURKE
ALL RIGHT. OTHER IN OPPOSITION
I SEE NO ONE IN THE GALLERY. I
SEE NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
LET'S TURN TO THE PHONE LINES
THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN
FOUR FOUR. MISTER MODERATOR P.
TO THEM UP. AND IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN FOUR
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. WE HAVE
THREE IN THE QUEUE WE'LL START
WITH NUMBER TWO NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHEN MEMBER
KATARINA FAN SAID ON BEHALF OF
THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION PRIVACY RIGHTS
CLEARINGHOUSE AND A FEEL YOU
CALIFORNIA ACTION ON WHAT THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN WOULD YOU
REMAIN AT THE LAST MINUTE
POSITION AND CONTINUE TO URGE
FOR STRONGER PROTECTIONS AROUND
SHARING DATA WITH RESEARCHERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXUS
NUMBER FIVE FORTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS DATE YOUR
INVOLVEMENT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION- IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT TO BE NUMBER THREE NINETY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND APOLOGIES FOR THE CONFUSION
EARLIER BUT THE ARMSTRONG ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION JOINING
OUR HELICOPTER COLLEAGUES IN
OPPOSITION TO AT THE SEVEN
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE ANYONE ELSE ON THE
PHONE LINE. AT THE TIME WE HAVE
NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT. LET'S BRING
BACK THE CHAMBER I SEE NO MIKE
YES I DO SEE A MICROPHONE WAS
CYNICAL GYRO. MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU APOLOGIZE FOR BEING.
A BIRD **** THIS- THIS HEARING
BUT I WANT TO BE ON I WANT I
pWANT TO BE ASKED TO BE A CO
AUTHOR- I AM FLABBERGASTED.
THAT I THINK ALL THE
PARTICIPANTS BUT I'M
FLABBERGASTED THAT AT ANY
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIAL WOULD
SAY. WE DON'T WANT TO ASK THESE
QUESTIONS- WHEN THEY COULD SAVE
LIVES LET ME JUST TELL YOU THAT
IT WAS ABSOLUTELY PREDICTABLE.
THAT FARMWORKERS WERE GONNA END
UP ON THE FRONT LINES. FEELING
THE BRUNT OF THIS VIRUS AND IT
WAS PREDICTABLE BECAUSE OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THEIR HOUSING
THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF THEIR
TRAVEL AND THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF
THEIR- WORK ENVIRONMENT WE ARE
PASSING LEGISLATION IT'S GOING
TO HOLD EMPLOYERS. RESPONSIBLE
AND LIABLE FOR KNOWING WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THEIR WORKPLACE IN
REGARDS TO THESE THESE KINDS OF
PANDEMICS AND IF WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD THEM RESPONSIBLE WE ALSO
NEED TO HAVE DATA AND
INFORMATION. SO THAT WE CAN SEE
THINGS COMING AND PREPARE FOR
IT AND MAYBE CHANGE THE WAY
THAT WE DO. OUR WORK FROM A
PUBLIC HEALTH PERSPECTIVE
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC REACHES A
CRISIS STAGE AND SO- I THINK
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
INFORMATION. IT'S FOUR SIMPLE
QUESTIONS IF IT IF IT'S HARD TO
BE ABLE TO GET THIS DATA WE'VE
GOT TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO MAKE
IT REALLY EASY IN THE DAY. IN
THE DAYS. A DATA PRODUCTION I
FIND IT HARD TO BELIEVE THAT WE
CAN GET THIS INFORMATION TO
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS SO THEY
CAN MAKE. THEY CAN CREATE A
PREVENTATIVE SYSTEM SO WITH
THAT I- I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
THE BILL AND WHAT I'D LIKE TO
BE ASKED AT ITS CO AUTHOR THANK%
YOU- SENATE COVER EURO MOVES
THE BILL THANK YOU CYNICAL
EURO- OTHER. OTHER QUESTIONS
YES- CENTER BORDERS. I TO JOIN
MY- MY COLLEAGUE FROM SALINAS
IN SUPPORT OF- THIS BILL. I
THINK ONE OF THE SHOCKING MORE
SHOCKING EXPERIENCES I HAD
DURING THE PANDEMIC. WAS US
FIGURING OUT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THEREFORE TO THE STATE LEVEL.
IS THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH
VIABLE INFORMATION THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO BETTER UNDERSTAND-
TRANSMISSION RATES BASED UPON
INDUSTRY SECTORS. THAT WAS
TERRIBLY IMPORTANT AS WE WERE
DEALING WITH CLOSING AND
OPENING AND WATER PUBLIC HEALTH
POLICIES WERE GOING TO BE AT
THE STATE LEVEL. NOW I
UNDERSTAND THIS OF COURSE WAS A
COMPLICATED SITUATION BUT I
THINK. ACCUMULATING THIS
INFORMATION. THEN NOT HAVING A
DISCLOSURE OF IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION THAT WOULD IMPINGE
ON SOMEONE'S PRIVACY IN MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS HAS ALL
THOSE PROTECTIONS IN IT. THIS
IS THE RIGHT. STEP FORWARD I'M
I'M SURPRISED THAT WE DON'T
HAVE SOMETHING LIKE THIS TO THE
GREATEST EXTENT THAT IT'S
NECESSARY- BUT I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY AND I THINK
THIS IS- MORE ACTUAL PATH AS WE
CUMULATE DATA FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
PURPOSES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR BORDERS OTHER MICROPHONES
IF YOU'RE- NO OTHER MICROPHONES
BEING RAISED US IN A COUPLE
HEROES MOVE THE BILL-
SENEGALESE- DID YOU ACCEPT THE
MEMINTA SUGGESTED- AT. I
DIDN'T- HI THERE A ACTUAL
AMENDMENTS RECOMMENDED I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN SOME GOOD TOMATOES
TO THE RIVER MEMBERS PROPOSED
ANALYSIS ON PAGES EIGHT NINE
COMMON NUMBER THREE. SORRY
STILL NOT SEEN WHAT WHERE
YOU'RE REFERENCING MISTER
CHAIRMAN. IT SAYS THE NET THE
TOP OF THAT PAGE EIGHT THAT
I'VE AGREED THAT TO AN
AMENDMENT THAT LIMITS THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE EXPEDITED
PROCESS TO PERIODS WHEN THERE
IS A CLEAR PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY THAT'S CORRECT THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE REFERENCING TO THAT
THAT IS CORRECT THAT I THINK
THAT. WAS INTENDED TO BE
AMENDED INTO THE BILL BUT IF IT
IS NOT THERE- THAT IS THE
INTENTION ONLY A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY- THIS BILL APPLICABLE
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK THAT
CLARIFIES THE CAMPARI CARE
CLOSE I WOULD. HAVE BEEN A
COUPLE FOR THE SICK COUPLE
THINGS- FIRST- AS A MEMBERS NO-
YOU KNOW WOULD BE VI<c.cyan> I</c>
DESIRE TO HAVE THIS BILL BE
MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE THAN IT IS
UP FOR YOU TODAY- BUT- GIVEN
THE- THE PREVIOUS HEARING AND
THE DISCUSSIONS TOOK PLACE THE
BILL IS- IN A MORE LIMITED-
FORM. SECONDLY THE SUGGESTION
FROM MY GOOD FRIEND IN THE
PUBLIC HEALTH COMMUNITY SAID
THIS WOULD ADD QUESTIONS. TO
THE- MORBIDITY REPORT I HAD THE
MORBIDITY REPORT HERE. I WANT
TO CLARIFY THAT THIS IS AN AD
FOR QUESTIONS. IN THE MORBIDITY
POOR REPORT AS AN EXAMPLE. IT
ASKED THE QUESTION IS YOUR
HOUSING STABLE OR UNSTABLE
THAT'S THE QUESTION IN THERE.
IT'S NOT A GOOD QUESTION FOR
GATHERING DATA ON WHETHER
SOMEONE IS IN CROWDED
CONDITIONS. SO WHAT WE WOULD
ASK OUR- THAT THE QUESTION.
WHAT TYPE OF HOUSING IS THE
PERSON LIVING AND WHAT'S THE
SIZE OF THE HOUSEHOLD THAT'S AN
EXAMPLE OF HOW WE CAN IMPROVE
THIS MORBIDITY REPORT TO GET
DATA THAT'S ACTUALLY USEFUL
CROWDED CONDITIONS NOT WHETHER
IT'S STABLE OR UNSTABLE SO I
CAN GO AND EXPLAIN ON
OCCUPATION AND TRAVEL THAT
WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO TAKE
EXISTING QUESTIONS IN THE
REPORT AND MAKING THEM BETTER
SO THEY'RE ACTUALLY USEFUL-
SECONDLY THERE'S THE SUGGESTION.
THIS CREATES A NEW EXPOSURES ON
PRIVACY WE DON'T TOUCH THE
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA IN ANY WAY SHAPE OR
FORM UNDER THIS BILL NOTHING.
IS CHANGED. NOTHING IS CHANGED.
FINALLY I WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR FROM A SALINAS FOR
OFFERED A CO AUTHOR IN OTHERS
WE APPRECIATE THAT SUPPORT AND
WOULD BEHAPPY TO ADD THAT TO
YOU THE BILL IF IT MOVES
FORWARD WITH THAT MISTER
CHAIRMAN I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZERS A MOTION BY SENATOR
CAFIERO MANAGING COUNSEL
STARTED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THIS IS SB SEVEN FORTY FOUR BY
SENATOR GLAZER WITH THE MOTION
BY SENATOR KERR YET ALL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND THEN RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- BURKE HI I'M
BURKE AYE PORCHES. GORGEOUS I
CARRY IT ON I HAVE A I DID ALSO
THE REST SO I GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG AYE JONES HI JONES I
LAYERED. LAYERED I STERN. HEY
WAKE HOUSEKI HI WACO'S. I
WIENER- YOU HAVE NINE TWO ZERO
SO FAR. RIGHT SURREALISM PUT
THAT ON CALL THANK YOU THINK
JANET THANK YOUR COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR WORK ON THE BILL SORRY
THANK YOU. BOB WE NOW HAVE A-
SEVENTY MON IT IS WITH US-
CERTAINLY MON THAT'S ITEM
NUMBER NINE PHONE NUMBER NINE
S. B. SEVEN ZERO TWO. FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO ARE LISTENING- WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP THE CEREMONY
BILL SEVEN ZERO TWO I KNOW THATTHAT WE PASSED OVER IT AND THEN
THEN- WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO-
FILE ORDER. ALL RIGHT SALAMONE
CLOSURES. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MEMBERS EXISTING LAWS EIGHT OUR
POLICY IF HE THAT COMPENSATION
ESTATE THANK. REFLECT THE
GENERAL PUBLIC. SB SEVEN OH TWO
ESTABLISHES A WORKING GROUP S.
AND MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE
MOST EFFECTIVE WAYS- THE STATE
COMMISSIONS BURKE RIGHT TODAY.
THE STATE. THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRES BY AUGUST FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND ANNUALLY AFTER
IT REPORTED TO THE LEGISLATURE
WITH AGGREGATE DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION INDIVIDUALS UP BY
THE GOVERNOR. YOU INSURANCE
NEEDS LEADERSHIP REFLECTS ITS
POPULATION A COLLECTION OF BUT
IN TERMS OF POINTS YOU
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA IS A CRITICAL
STEP TO ACHIEVING GENDER RACIAL
AND ETHNIC EQUITY ON BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS. THE ANNUAL REPORT
WILL SERVE AS A TOOL TO
IDENTIFIED GAPS IN
REPRESENTATION. IN COURAGE OUR
WHICH TO COMMUNITIES AND
ADDRESS. AN APPOINTMENT THIS
BILL IS PREVIOUS EFFORTS BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE DIVERSITY
AND REPRESENTATION AT ALL
LEVELS OF. TODAY WE HAVE THE
BILL THEN IT'S ONLY OF THESE
PROTESTS ORGANIZED POLITICAL
EQUITY AND INDEX ACUSADA EARNED
BEHALF OF COMPLETE. SORRY APART
MISDIAGNOSIS ARE YOU AVAILABLE.
YES RIGHT AFTER CLEARING A
NUMBER OKAY. THANK YOU FOR
CARRYING OUR MY- THANK AND I AM
THE DIRECTOR OF TO FIND
ORGANIZED POLITICAL. ALSO KNOWN
AS HOPE HOPE IS A NONPROFIT
NONPARTISAN ORGANIZATION
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THE
POLITICAL AND ECONOMIC PARITY
OF LATINO LEADERSHIP ADVOCACY
AND EDUCATION TO BENEFIT ALL
COMMUNITIES AND THE STATUS OF
WOMEN ABOUT HOW TO USE THE
SPONSORS OF SB SEVEN OH TWO AND
ARE GRATEFUL TO BE WORKING WITH
SUNDERLAND MON ON THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC. SB SEVEN OH
TWO SIX TO CREATE TRANSPARENCY
AND GUBERNATORIAL APPOINTMENTS
BY REQUIRING THAT IN THE ANNUAL
REPORT BE RELEASED SCHERING THE
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA OF ALL
COMMITMENTS MADE QUICKLY THIS
YEAR THIS REPORT WOULD INCLUDE
IMPORTANT DEMOGRAPHIC DATA AS
MENTIONED AND IT IS IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THE DATA IS
ACQUIRED THROUGH SELF
DISCLOSURE IN COMPLIANCE. WITH
PRIVACY LAWS HERE. IN ADDITION
TO THAT GROWTH. OF I'M GONNA TO
CREATE A TIME WORKING GROUP BY
DID CLASS WITH. BARRIERS AND
SOLUTIONS TO. THE APPOINTMENT
PROCESS. ULTIMATELY IN OUR CORE
AND SUBSEQUENT POLICY SOLUTIONS
WILL HELP UNDERSTAND THE
COMPOSITION OF GUBERNATORIAL
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS ACROSS
THE STATE. IF ENACTED THE DATA
WILL BE A TOOL TO HIGHLIGHT
WHERE DISPARITIES IN
REPRESENTATION LIKE THAT AND
WE'RE COMMUNITIES INVOICES ARE
MISSING COMMITTEE TABLES.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT DIVERSITY
IN GOVERNMENT LEADS TO POLICIES
THAT BETTER REFLECT THE
INTERESTS OF THOSE BEING
REPRESENTED AND AS THE MOST
POPULOUS AND DIVERSE STATE IN
THE COUNTRY A CRIME PER
CALIFORNIA TO CREATE FORMAL
MECHANISMS. TO ENSURE THAT THE
GOVERNMENT'S TRULY REFLECT THE
COMMUNITY MANAGER. COULD
BELIEVE THAT DEMOCRACY AND
GOVERNANCE IS STRONGER WHEN
EVERYONE HAS A SEAT AT THE
TABLE FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR I.
BOATS TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MISS BAGNALL OF MISS.
BUT COM POCKETABLE. YES CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN THANK. OKAY
WONDERFUL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR HAVING ME HELLO CHAIR ON
BURKE AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS LINDA COULD YOU GOT ONE
I AM THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
LEAGUE LEADERSHIP EDUCATION FOR
ASIAN PACIFICS. MY ORGANIZATION
IS BASED IN LOS ANGELES. ENSURE
BURKE I AM ALSO ONE OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS BOB HUNTINGTON
BEACH. I'M CALLING IN TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN OH TWO
WHICH WILL REQUIRE AN ANNUAL
REPORT TO SCHOOL TO BE THE
DEMOCRATIC DATA OF ALL
GUBERNATORIAL APPOINTEES. FOR
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. LEAVE LEADERSHIP
EDUCATE FOR ASIAN. IS A
NATIONAL NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
WITH THE MISSION TO ACHIEVE
FULL PARTICIPATION AND EQUALITY
COURT ASIANS AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER. OR AAPI LEADERSHIP
EMPOWERMENT AND POLICY. SIMILAR
TO SB. EIGHT TO SIX EIGHTY NINE
SEVEN NINE WHICH REQUIRES
GREATER DIVERSITY ON CORPORATE
BOARDS I SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT DATA IN
TRANSPARENCY ARE CRITICAL TO
ENSURING DIVERSE VOICES ARE
REPRESENTED IN CALIFORNIA'S
LEADERSHIP. THERE IS TRUTH IN
THE SAYING THAT WHAT GETS
MEASURED GETS DONE.
SPECIFICALLY ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDERS ALONG WITH OTHER
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES BEING
FAIRLY REPRESENTED ON STATEWIDE
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS IS THAT
THE HEART OF THE WORK THAT THE
JUDGE. WE SUPPORT API
COMMUNITIES TO REALIZE THEIR
FULL POTENTIAL INTRODUCED
LEADERS WHO ARE READY TO SERVE
ON THE AND TO TWO YEARS
UNDERSTANDING THE CURRENT AND
FUTURE DEMOGRAPHICCOMPOSITION
OF GUBERNATORIAL APPOINTEES. IS
AN IMPORTANT FIRST STEP. SB
SEVEN OH TWO REQUIRES THIS
IMPORTANT DATA TO BE RELEASED
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS TO HIGHLIGHT
THIS IMPORTANT INFORMATION AND
TO DEVELOP SOLUTIONS TO ENSURE
THAT ALL COMMUNITIES. ARE
REPRESENTED IN OUR LEADERSHIP.
FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER TO THE PROBLEM. ALL
RIGHTY. OTHERS IN SUPPORT I SEE
NO ONE IN THE GALLERY I SEE NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE- MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD LINE UP
THOSE IN SUPPORT ON S. B. SEVEN
OH TWO I'D APPRECIATE IT. AND
IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN OH TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN. ONE ZERO FOR SO.
NO TO. THANK YOU. NEXT WE
NUMBER SIX SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING ADRIANA
RAMOS FROM LA HABRA IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN OH TWO THANK YOU.
NEXT THE NUMBER SIX SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
CHAIRMEN AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BELINDA AMERICAN AND I'M FROM
THE CITY OF SAN FERNANDO AND
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
SB SEVEN OH TWO. I HOPE THAT
YOU ARE SUPPORTED AS WELL THANK
YOU. NEXT WE NUMBER SIX SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT MEANS
THE SERVER OF A LABOR FINANCE
FROM LONG BEACH AND I AM A
STRONG SUPPORT OF AT THE. SEVEN
ZERO TWO. I WILL GO TO NUMBER
SIX SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING HELLO AND TEXTURES
SAN BERNADINO IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN OH TWO. THANK YOU. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NONE LEFT IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
ALREADY OF NOW THOSE IN
OPPOSITION I SEE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES OPPOSITION I SEE NO
ONE OF THE GALLERY KNOWN IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE MODERATORS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE WHO'S
IN OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN ZERO
TWO OPPOSITION TO SEVEN ZERO
TWO PLEASE LINE UP GIVE US YOUR
NAME YOUR AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION. YES I LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU LIKE TO SPEAK
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL
SB SEVEN OH TWO. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE TWO IN CUTER
CURRENTLY WITH OPERATORS ONE
MOMENT PLEASE THANK YOU. MY
PLEASURE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE WILL OPEN UP LINE SIX
EIGHT TWO ONE SIX EIGHT TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE SIX
EIGHT TWO. ONE SIX EIGHT TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ALL RIGHT
NEXT. AND WITH NO RESPONSE WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE CAN QUEUE THE
OTHER PERSON TOOK THEM OUT OF
TO FOR THE LAST YEAR ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR ALL
BACK TO THE FLOOR QUESTIONS I
SEE NO- YES I DO CENTER
GONZALEZ MICRONS REYES. YOUR
MICROPHONE IS NOT ON THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I JUST WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHORS SENATORS
LEE MALONE AS WELL ASHISPHONE
IS ORGANIZED FOR POLITICAL
EQUALITY FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND I'LL MOVE THE BILL
INAPPROPRIATE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR GONZALEZ- THOUGH THE
MICROPHONES BEING REYES SAID
AGAIN SALAS MOVES THE BILL-
CERTAINLY MONICA CLOSE. I
RESPECT. OUR NEIGHBOR ALL RIGHT
EXCELLENT- MANAGING COUNSEL
STRUGGLE YOU CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. YES THIS IS THE S. B.
SEVEN OH TWO BY SENATOR LEE
MOURNED AND THE MOTION IS BY
CENTER GONZALEZ AND THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS NUMBER. NUMBER
GUY BURGESS. PORGES NOT VOTING.
FIVE ZERO HI I DID ALSO DRESS
SO I GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG I'D JONES.
LAYERED FIVE LAYERED ICE STERN.
FORTY WIECKOWSKI HI MAY I ASK A
AYE WIENER. YOU HAVE. THE OF
SEVEN TO ZERO RIGHT NOW THANK
YOU. CEREMONIAL PUT THE BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO TURN THE BILL'S BY
MEMBERS OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE I DO NOT SEIZE NEXT
DOOR WOULD BE CENTER WIENER
THAN SENATOR STERN I DO NOT SEE
SAYS STERN- IN THE- IT REMOTELY
SO WE'RE GONNA TURN THE CENTRE
GONZALEZ OF SYNAGOGUES ALSO IS
READY PRESENT SHE IS TWO BILLS-
FOR THOSE OF YOU LISTENING
WATCHING S. B. FOUR FIVE TWO.
IN SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX. SECONDS
ALSO S. B. FOUR FIVE TWO YOU
REPRESENT YES I AM ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- GOOD
AFTERNOON WELL GOOD EVENING
NOW- MEMBERS- TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SP FOUR FIVE TWO.
THIS WILL ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT AND
REFUGEE AFFAIRS AGENCY TO
SERVICES FOR OUR STATE'S
DIVERSE IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE
COMMUNITIES. BY ESTABLISHING A
PERMANENT STRUCTURE WITHIN THE
STATE TO SERVE IMMIGRANTS AND
REFUGEES SB FOUR FIVE TWO WILL
CREATE A STATE FRAMEWORK TO
BETTER ASSIST OTHER STATE
AGENCIES IN EVALUATING THEIR
PROGRAMS FOR EXCESS ABILITY.
AND EFFECTIVENESS IN PROVIDING
SERVICES TO THIS VERY- NEEDED
POP POPULATION- AS WE KNOW
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN MILLION
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES
COMPRISING NEARLY ONE QUARTER
OF THE STATE'S POPULATION. SB
FOUR FIVE TO PROVIDE THE
PROACTIVE SOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM BY ESTABLISHING AN
OFFICE THAT WOULD BE DEDICATED
TO OFFERING DIRECT SERVICES IN
ADDRESSING RAPID STATE AND
FEDERAL POLICY CHANGES
IMPACTING IMMIGRANTS AND
REFUGEES ESPECIALLY AS WE'VE
SEEN. THIS LAST YEAR TO THE
PANDEMIC TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
TODAY I HAVE HEIDI CITY. POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE NATIONAL
PARTNERSHIP FOR NEW AMERICANS
AND READ A MEDINA STATE POLICY
AND ADVOCACY MANAGER FOR CHIRLA
THANK. YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NINE VOTE. THANK YOU
SEVEN INVOLVED ARE- HEIDI SAID.
ARE YOU THERE. HOW ABOUT-
READER MEDINA ARE YOU AVAILABLE.
YES I AM HERE TO HEAR THIS
MEDINA GO AHEAD. PETER CAMPBELL
AGAIN MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
RITA MEDINA AND POLICY ADVOCATE
MANAGER AT THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHT CHIRLA
WOULD YOU LIKE THE PROPERTY
MARKET SB FOUR FIFTY TWO.
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AFTER PROP
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN WITH AN ACTIVE
CALIFORNIA HAS COME A LONG WAY
WE WENT FROM LEADING AN ANTI
IMMIGRANT SENTIMENT TO BEING A
PRO IMMIGRANT STATE CONNECTION
FOR LEGISLATION BUDGET
INCREASED TUITION FOR
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AND
PROVIDING DRIVER'S LICENSES TO
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS. EACH
POLICY HELPED IMMIGRANTS
INTEGRATE IMMIGRANTS INTO OUR
STATE BETWEEN TEN POINT FIVE
AND ELEVEN MILLION UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS LIVE IN THE UNITED
STATES WITH APPROXIMATELY ONE
QUARTER LIVING IN CALIFORNIA
AND 50% OF CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
OF ONE PARENT WHO IS AN
IMMIGRANT. SB FORTY TWO WOULD
ESTABLISH OFFICE OF IMMIGRATION
REFUGEE AFFAIRS WITH THE NEWLY
CREATED IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE
AGENCY AND. SEVEN POINT
POPULATION OF CALIFORNIANS. A
WOULD REDUCE OPTICAL CHEMICAL
INTO. INTO THE SO. CULTURAL AND
POLITICAL EIGHT IT WOULD
COURTNEY WITH INCOME. OF STATE
EACH. EVALUE PROGRAMS
ACCEPTABILITY AND EFFECTIVENESS
IN PROVIDING SERVICES TO
ALREADY SEVERAL COUNTIES AND
CITIES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
HAVE TAKEN A STEP FORWARD AND
CREATED THEIR OWN OFFICES TO
COORDINATE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
OF THE NINETEEN PRESENTED MANY
CHALLENGES FOR IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES AND THEIR COUNTRIES
AND ABOUT THE CONSERVATIVE
VEHICLE TO MOVE IN THE
DIRECTION OF RECOVERY TO
PROVIDE FAMILIES THE SINGLE
PLACE TO GO FOR UPDATED
RESOURCES QUESTIONS ABOUT
QUALIFICATION FOR PROGRAMS AND
BENEFITS. AND LANGUAGE
ACQUISITION. INTRODUCTION TO
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
RELEASED A STUDY WITH THE
PEOPLE OF THE NEWCOMERS BECOME
CALIFORNIANS WHICH WITH
VISIONARY AT THE RECOGNIZED
THAT THE STATE CAN NOT QUITE
ACCEPT OR SUFFER THE
CONSEQUENCES. A FEDERAL
POLICIES THAT FAIL ARE FAMILIES
OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
BUSINESSES. JUNE TWO THOUSAND
TWO ENTRY TODAY THE STATE'S
FISCAL LONG TERM HEALTH IS
CONNECTED TO THE SUCCESS. OF
THE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY. EIGHT
MUST BE ABLE TO FISH. AND
RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS OF THE
POP. WITH THE TERM FOR
IMMIGRANTS IN REFUGEE. THE TIME
TO IN THE AGENCY IS NOW AND WE
ARE COMMITTED WORKING ALL. AT
THE BILL FORWARD. THANK YOU
VERY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
MEDINA OF MISS. HARDY CITY ARE
YOU AVAILABLE. YES I AM. NINE
I'M SORRY- MISTER CITY. SHARE
ON BERGEN MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
MY TESTIMONY TODAY MY NAME IS
HEIDI SOCIETY AND I AM THE
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
NATIONAL PARTNERSHIP FOR NEW
AMERICANS AT N. P. N. AB
BELIEVE AMERICA SUCCESS IS
ROOTED IN OUR ONGOING
COMMITMENT TO WELCOMING AND
INTEGRATING IMMIGRANTS INTO THE
FABRIC OF OUR NATION. AND TO
UPHOLDING EQUALITY AND
OPPORTUNITY AS FUNDAMENTAL
AMERICAN VALUES ONE OF THE WAYS
IN WHICH THESE COMMITMENTS CAN
BE ADVANCED THROUGH STATE
OFFICES OF IMMIGRANT AND
REFUGEE AFFAIRS. THESE OFFICES
HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED IN
MASSACHUSETTS MICHIGAN NEVADA
NEW JERSEY NEW YORK OHIO AND
VIRGINIA AND AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
STATES INCLUDING CALIFORNIA-
ARE CURRENTLY CONSIDERING BILLS
TO ESTABLISH A STATEWIDE OFFICE
THEY ALL CORNERS OF THE COUNTRY
THE DROPS OF SHARE THE COMMON
FUNCTION OF COORDINATING
SERVICES RESOURCES AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES. AND ACTING AS THE
CONNECTIVE TISSUE BETWEEN
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES THAT SERVE
IMMIGRANTS BECAUSE THE
NINETEENTH AND THEN MAKE HAS
BROUGHT INTO CLEAR FOCUS THE
WAYS IN WHICH OFFICES OF
IMMIGRANT AFFAIRS CAN HELP
GOVERNMENTS BETTER SERVE ALL OF
THE RESIDENTS. I THINK AND THAT
MAKE CONTINUES OFFICERS ABOUT
IMMIGRANTS ARE WORKING THEIR
EXISTING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
LOCAL ENTITIES AND IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES TO REACH ALL
RESIDENTS WITH CRITICAL
INFORMATIONDESPITE LANGUAGE
BARRIERS AND ARE PARTNERING
WITH STATE AGENCIES TO ADDRESS
COMMON ISSUES FACED BY
IMMIGRANTS OF THE THIS EMERGE.
DOCTORS CARRIED OUT THROUGH THE
DUMPSTERS HAVE DOUBTLESSLY KEPT
AMERICANS SAFER AND SET US UP
FOR A STRONGER RECOVERY AND AS
THE NETWORK OF STATEWIDE
IMMIGRANT FOCUSED OFFICES GROWS
SO WILL OUR COLLECTIVE ABILITY
TO RESPOND TO FUTURE CRISES AND
DOWNTURNS IN A. MATTER THAT
VALUES THAT UPLIFTS EVERYONE.
FOR MORE NASH PUSHED AND- THIS
NOW WILL BE MUCH WITH THE
PURCHASE OF CALIFORNIA. WHICH
HAS THE HIGHEST NUMBER AND
PERCENT OF FOREIGN BORN BRED.
OF ANY STATE. AND WE FROM
BELIEVE THAT CAL. WOULD BENEFIT
FROM MORE PROACTIVE INCLUSION
AND INTEGRATION OF NEW
AMERICANS IN THE STATE.
THEREFORE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB FOR PART TWO OF THE FEDERAL
STEP FORWARD IN CALIFORNIA'S
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION EFFORTS.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
NATIONAL PARTICIPATION AND
LEADERSHIP OF YOUR OFFICE OF
IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE AFFAIRS.
Q. SHERMAN TO THE OPPORTUNITY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE. YOU
MISTER SADDAM ALL RIGHT OTHERS
IN SUPPORT I SEE NOW IN THE
GALLERY TO SEE NEW WHAT KNOWN
AND ROOM ONE TWELVE- MODERATOR
IF YOU GET A LOT OF FOLKS IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. FOUR FIVE TWO.
I REQUEST YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR FIVE TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE. ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
THREE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MAYBE CENTERS ON BEHALF OF THE
IDEAL CALIFORNIA FONG THE BOARD.
TWENTY SIX NINE FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MISTER TURNED MEMBERS
WILL BE A TOTALLY SHOP ON THE
TOP OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NINE SIX SIX
BACK IN BALANCE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU BEFORE WE OPEN NINE
SIX SEVEN SIX LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER IF YOU
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR FIVE TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE SIX SEVEN
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY SIX
THAT SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IF
YOUR LINE IS MUTED WERE TO HEAR
YOU. ALLEN HARD TO STAND NATO
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IS ACTUALLY I'M SORRY WE HAVE
ONE PERSON WITH AN OPERATOR ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. AND THEY HAVE
REMOVED THEMSELVES FROM Q. YOU
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT LET'S NOT TURNED
OPPOSITION- I DON'T SEE ANY
PRINCIPLE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I SEE NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. MADAME MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. FOUR FIVE
TWO. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB FOUR FIVE TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR FIVE
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE NO
ONE IN OPPOSITION SIR ALL
RIGHT. A QUESTIONS FROM THE-
COMMITTEE I SEE NO MICROPHONES
REYES- IS OUR MOTION SENATE
THROSSELL. YEAH I JUST WANNA
THANK THE AUTHOR- WE ARE.
ALWAYS VERY- COGNISANT HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WERE
VERY PROUD OF THE- WAY THAT WE
HAVE CHANGED TO BECOME A
WELCOMING STATE FOR IMMIGRANTS
AND REFUGEES AND I'M VERY VERY
PROUD OF THAT UP BUT IT DOESN'T
HURT. TO KEEP MOVING IN THE
RIGHT TO KEEP MOVING IN THAT IN
THE MORE OR WAY UP THE HIGHEST
LEVELS- I KNOW I HEAR THE AS I
OUT IN CA- MANY EMR SAYING
ABOUT HOW. MUCH HOW WELL THEY
FEEL HOW GOOD THEY FEEL BOB IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO- I
AM VERY PROUD AND- OBVIOUSLY
GOING TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
ALSO MOVES THE BILL ANY OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS SEEING NONE.
OF THE CIVIC IT'S ALWAYS VERY
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANNA THANK MISTER SAID
THAT I AND M'S MEDINA FOR THEIR
TESTIMONY TODAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. COUNSEL
ASTROLOGY CALL THE ROLL YES
THIS IS S. B. FOUR FIVE TWO BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ. WITH THE
MOTION BY SENATOR THAT ALSO.
THE IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG HI. I'M
BURKE AYE BURGESS. AYE IT'LL
AYE AMIRA AYE INDEED AYE SO.
DID I SO I GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG I'D JONES
LAYARD FIVE LAYERED ICE. STERN.
SORRY WE'RE CASKEY- IT WIENER
OKAY SO FAR YOU HAVE SIX TWO
ZERO. ALL RIGHT WELL WE'LL PUT
THAT BILLING CALL A SECOND
SALAS YOU HAVE SB SEVEN SEVEN
SIX. GREAT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND GOOD EVENING AGAIN
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES RECOMMENDED
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS OUTLINED
ON PAGE NINE OF THE ANALYSIS- I
AM HERE TONIGHT TO PRESENT S.
B. SEVEN SEVEN SIX WHICH WILL
MAKE VARIOUS STATUTORY CHANGES
TO ENHANCE THE STATE WATER
BOARDS ABILITY TO. MORE
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY
IMPLEMENT THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER ACT
IN TWENTY NINETEEN IF YOU'LL
REMEMBER THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
AND GOVERNOR NEWSOM SIGNED INTO
LAW SB TWO HUNDRED WHICH
ANNUALLY DIRECTS ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS TO FUND
SAFE DRINKING WATER EFFORTS AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE STATE. OVER THE NEXT
TEN YEARS THE STATE WATER BOARD
HAS WORKED HARD OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS TO IMPLEMENT THE
LEGISLATURE'S VISION FOR THE
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER PROGRAM BUT HAS
IDENTIFIED A NUMBER OF
CLARIFYING STATUTORY CHANGES
THAT NEED. A QUICK FIX THESE
DEFICIENCIES INCLUDE CLARIFYING
DEFINITIONS AUTHORIZING THE
BOARD TO MAKE ADVANCE PAYMENTS
PROVIDING THE AUTHORITY TO ACT
X. EXPEDITIOUSLY TO PROVIDE TO
PURCHASE SOME SORRY EMERGENCY
BOTTLED WATER AND PROVIDING THE
ABILITY TO QUICKLY SEND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS
pEFFICIENCIES. THESE EFFICIENCY
CHANGES ARE BALANCED BY THE
BILL'S PROVISIONS THAT RECAST
AND CONSOLIDATE THE BOARD'S
ADMINISTRATIVE ENFORCEMENT AND
FINING AUTHORITY. TO ENSURE
THAT THE STATE'S FUNDS DO NOT
FALL VICTIM TO FRAUD OR ABUSE.
IT'S A THOUGHTFUL MEASURE AND
MEASURED APPROACH AND PROVIDING
THE EFFICIENCIES OF THE WATER
BOARD NEEDS TO BE NIMBLE AND
EFFECTIVE IN GETTING S. B. TWO
TWO HUNDRED FUNDS AND PROJECTS
OUT THE DOOR AND INTO
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT THE
MOST. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
TODAY WE HAVE EVEN ON THE WEST
THE DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
ENFORCEMENT AT THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. BOARD
AND THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
I ALSO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. ON SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX.
FOR USERS GONZALEZ MISS WESLEY
AVAILABLE. I AM THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU CENTER
GONZALEZ. BUT AFTER DEVELOP PUT
IT OUT IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED TO THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED SB TWO THOUSAND
THE STATE BEFORE WELL DRINKING
WATER ACT. SINCE THAT TIME
THREE ONE FOUR HAS IDENTIFIED
SEVERAL FACTORIES CHANGES THAT
ARE NEEDED TO HELP COMMUNITIES
MORE QUICKLY. SB SEVEN SEVEN
SIX ALLOWS A LOT OF WORK TO
ADOPT EMERGENCY REGULATIONS TO
ENSURE DRINKING WATER QUALITY
DATA. IS READILY AVAILABLE AND
IS IN KEEPING WITH OUR EXISTING
AUTHORITY THAN OUR OTHER
PROGRAM. SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX
ALSO EXTEND TO LIVE OR TO
THIRTY TO REQUIRE TECHNICAL
REPORT. SHOULD INCLUDE STATE
SMALL WATER SYSTEM. SB SEVEN
SEVEN SIX ALLOW THE WATER BOARD
TO ADDRESS EMERGENCY SITUATIONS
THAT OCCUR AT FAILING WATER
SYSTEMS BY AUTHORIZING THE
BOARD TO PROVIDE UP TO TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS. WITHOUT A
WRITTEN AGREEMENT IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS DRINKING WATER
EMERGENCIES. AND THIS BILL
WOULD AUTHORIZE THE BOARD TO
MAKE ADVANCE PAYMENTS OF SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
FUNDS. GENERALLY SUPPORT MAKE
SUCH PAYMENTS ON A
REIMBURSEMENT BASIS HOWEVER
THIS PROCESS CAN BE A FINANCIAL
BURDEN ON DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT DO NOT HAVE
THE CASH FLOW. TO MAKE SUCH
PAYMENTS UP FRONT. ISN'T THAT
SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX WILL HELP
HELLO COMMITTEE ACCESS. WATER
MORE QUICKLY. SB SEVEN SEVEN
SIX ALSO INCLUDES AN EXEMPTION
FROM CERTAIN STATE CONTRACTING
REQUIREMENTS. ONE NINETEEN TO
OPEN TWENTY BUDGET ACT PROVIDED
THE SAME EXEMPTION TO THE BOARD
BUT AT THE TWO HUNDRED FAILED
TO. THIS PROVISION WILL ALIGN
THE LEGISLATURE CONTENT AND
ALLOW THE BOARD TO MORE QUICKLY
ADDRESS DRINKING WATER
EMERGENCIES. AND FINALLY SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX WILL PROVIDE A
THIRTY TO PREVENT AND ADDRESS
POTENTIAL FRAUD AGAINST
DRINKING WATER PROGRAM FUNDS.
pAUTHORITY CURRENTLY EXERCISED
BY THE WATER BOARD FOR OTHER
HELP PREVENT MISUSE OF PUBLIC
MONEY AND PROTECT COMMUNITIES
AND HELP ACHIEVE OUR SHARED
CLEAN DRINKING WATER GOAL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISS WEST OTHERS IN SUPPORT I
SEE NO ONE IN THE GALLERY I SEE
NO IN ROOM ONE TWELVE-
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX IF THERE ARE.
PERSONS ON THE PHONE LINE- WE
WELCOME YOU TO GIVE YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN SEVEN
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE. ZERO AT
THE TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE IF
SUPPORTERS ALL RIGHT ANY
QUESTIONS I SEE NO MICROPHONES
RAISED- CENTER ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO MOVE THE BILL YOU WOULD ALL
RIGHT SENATE ALSO MOVES THE
BILL SENATE GONZALEZ. WOULD
LIKE CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO THANK MISS
WEST FOR HER TESTIMONY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY VOTING
ON. THEM TO CANCEL THE CALL THE
ROLL THIS IS SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX
BY SENATOR GONZALEZ WITH THE
MOTION BY SENATOR DID I SO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND THEN RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG. NUMBER
AYE BURGESS. CABALLERO W. DON'T
FIGHT GRASSO DRESSEL HI
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ HI
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE JONES.
LAYERED BY LAYERED AYE STERN.
STERN AYE EIGHT WHITE HOUSE SKI
WIENER. THE OF SEVEN TO ZERO
THANK YOU WILL PUT THE BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU SENATORS ALSO A
C. SENATORS STERN CENTER STERN
UP WERE YOU PREPARED TO PRESENT
YOUR BILL. SB FIVE THREE THREE.
HEY MISTER CARE. I'M SORRY SIR
STERN. I'M ALL RIGHT GO AHEAD
SENATE STERN THE FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BEFORE BEGIN PRESENTATION TODAY
I WANT TO TAKE THAT OPPORTUNITY
TO REVIEW THE COMMITTEES AND-
THE AMENDMENTS WE'VE TAKEN
THAT. REMOVE HALF OF THE
OPPOSITION AT LEAST LISTED IN
THE ANALYSIS BOTH- TURN IT AND
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION OF
UTILITY EMPLOYEES ALERTED
COMMITTEE EARLIER TODAY THAT
THEY'VE REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION BASED ON THE CHANGES
WE MADE. IN SENATE ENERGY LAST
WEEK BUT HAVE ONLY BEEN IN
PRINT SINCE YESTERDAY- I I'D
ALSO LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS LIST ON
PAGE NINE INTENDED THE
ANALYSIS. ON THE AMENDMENTS
REMOVE REQUIREMENTS FOR THE PC
YOU KNOW YES TO CREATE A
DATABASE OF CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE INSTEAD
REQUIRING PA YOU SEEN- YES TO
HOLD PUBLIC MEETINGS ON WHAT
NEW DATABASES ARE NEEDED. EMAM
IS ALSO IT ADD ADDITIONAL
SAFEGUARDS ENSURING CUSTOMER
INFORMATION- AS AMENDED SB FIVE
THIRTY THREE SEEKS TO HOLD
UTILITIES ACCOUNTABLE AS WELL
AS THE REGULATORS TO OVERSEE
THEM- TO THE STANDARDS THEY SET
FORTH IN THEIR WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PLAN. JUNE I'M SURE
THAT THE- LOCATION OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS-
THAT THESE OUTAGE PROSJE PRONE
ZONES- THE PLANS TO FIX THESE
ZONES I WILL BE CORRECTED
PROBABLY BECAUSE WE'VE HAD FOR
TOO MANY YEARS OF- MAJOR DAMAGE
IN OUR REGION AND THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT
FROM. FROM POWER PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFFS OCCURRING. ON
TO PROJECT A COMMUNITY. NOT
REFINED ENOUGH AND NOT ENOUGH
DONE TO IT TO MITIGATE FRANKLY
THE IMPACT OF THOSE ARE FOR
THOSE WHO CAN LEAST AFFORD TO
HAVE THEIR POWER SHUT OFF THOSE
ARE THINGS LIKE- MOBILE
BATTERIES A BATTERY BACKUP
POWER AND MICRO GRIDS- AND
OTHER WAYS TO GET THROUGH AN
OUTAGE LIKE THAT- WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT CIRCUITS BY THE
WAY THAT IT SHUT OFF POWER TO
JUST A COUPLE HOUSES. BEEN IT'S
ENTIRE CITIES AND LARGE
PORTIONS OF COUNTIES- WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS AT A TIME- EVEN
THANKSGIVING OR THE HOLIDAYS.
AND YOU KNOW NO ONE'S BEEN
SPARED THIS WAS TO BE A LACK
RESORT. BY RIGHT NOW WE'VE
WE'VE BEEN. SEEING THEM USE.
MORE INDISCRIMINATELY AND LESS
REFINED MANNER THAT WE LIKE TO
SEE FROM OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
PERSPECTIVE AS WELL AS OUR
COMMUNITIES. WE'RE LOOKING TO
ENHANCE THEIR ABILITY TO GET
THROUGH THESE CRISES RESILIENT
LEE AND ENSURE THAT THE PC. IN
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES BRING THE PUBLIC INTO
THE PROCESS THAT THIS ISN'T
DONE IN A CLOSED DOOR MATTER
WHO REALLY CAN START TO LOOK AT
THE PLANS- AND BE VERY UP FRONT
WITH PEOPLE ABOUT WHAT THEY CAN
EXPECT. HOW MUCH IMPROVEMENTS
WE WILL NEED TO BE MADE AND
I'VE HEARD VERY ENCOURAGING
THINGS FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON IN PARTICULAR ABOUT
THEIR CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN-
AND SO WE'RE VERY EXCITED
ABOUT- THEY'RE ENDING UPGRADES.
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES
OUR COMMUNICATIONS PLAN AND WE
HOPE WE CAN GET ALL THIS SALT
BUT THIS BILL IS YOU'RE REALLY
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT- THEY
FOLLOW THROUGH ON THAT PLAN.
AND HOPEFULLY GO BEYOND IT- WE
ARE WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
IF PEOPLE DON'T LIVE IN THE
DARK HERE IN CALIFORNIA DESPITE
THE RAVAGES OF CLIMATE CHANGE
WILDFIRES AND WITH THAT.
MONITOR HERE TO HAVE TODAY THE
MAYOR OF. ONE OF OUR CITIES
THOUSAND OAKS WHO'S BEEN
IMPACTED MAYORCLAUDIA BILL DE
LA PENA. AS WELL WELL AS-
CHEROKEE LAUREL A DAY OUT WAS A
COMMUNITY ACTIVIST. AND A LONG
TIME RESIDENT OF CHATSWORTH
LIKE MANNER WHO'S GOING THROUGH
COUNTLESS HARDSHIPS YOURSELF
AND YET STILL REMAINS
RESILIENT. RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATORS-
MAYOR CLAUDIA. BILL DE LA PENA
OR CHEROKEE LARVAL- ARE EITHER
OF YOU ON THE PHONE. YES THIS
IS CLAUDIA BILL OPINION MAYOR
FOUR THOUSAND- ALL RIGHT.
MERTEUIL OPINION WOULD YOU- DO
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR. THANK YOU
SO MUCH I AM PLEASED TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE THIRTY
THREE AS I SAID I'M THE MAYOR
OF THE CITY OF THOUSAND OAKS IN
VENTURA COUNTY WHICH IS A VERY
HIGH WILDFIRE. THREAT ZONE THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS TO UPGRADE AND
REPAIR THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE TO
REDUCE RECURRING PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF. MODERNIZING
ELECTRICAL EQUIPMENT AND
HARDENING DISTRIBUTION LINE
WILL ALLOW AFFECTED CITIES LIKE
THOUSAND OAKS TO REMAIN
OPERATIONAL DURING THE
ENERGIZING EVENT. THE CITY OF
THOUSAND OAKS HOUSING TOWARDS
SEVERAL P. S. P. S. OUTAGES
NEEDLESS TO SAY THEY ARE A
MAJOR DISRUPTION TO OPERATIONS
AND THE COMMUNITY.ON JANUARY
NINETEENTH WE EXPERIENCE OUR
WORST THREE DAY EVENT RESIDENTS
BUSINESSES AND CITY OPERATIONS
WERE SEVERELY IMPACTED AND
DURING THIS PERIOD AT LEAST.
SEVEN SECOND FLOOR DOWN. OUR
TRY SO WENT OUT. ALTHOUGH TO
THING HAVE BATTERY UP TO RUN IN
FLASH MODE THE BACKUP POWER
ITSELF PLANNING OUT. THE CITY
HOW TO BRING IN STAFF AND HIRE
CONTRACTORS TO SWITCH OUT A
BATTERY OVER A THIRTY HOUR
PERIOD. AND TRAFFIC COLLISIONS.
WONDERS ABLE SECOND RESULTED IN
MAJOR EQUIPMENT FAILURE AT OUR
HILL CANYON WASTE WATER
TREATMENT PLANT WE HAD NO POWER
FOR MORE THAN FORTY EIGHT HOURS
THIS THREE DAY POWER OUTAGE
FRUSTRATED RESIDENTS TO NO END
AND SAT DOWN LOCAL BUSINESSES
TO. SENIOR ADULTS AND RESIDENTS
WHO RELY ON MEDICAL EQUIPMENT
WORK FEARFUL AND ANXIOUS. AND
IN THIS EMERGENCY THE CITY
COULD NOT GET A STRAIGHT ANSWER
OF SPECIFIC CIRCUIT FAILURES
WORK WHEN POWER WOULD RESUME.
THANKFULLY SB FIVE THIRTY THREE
WOULD ALSO DEPLOY MICROGRID
SYSTEMS IN PS PS PRONE AREA THE
CITY OF THOUSAND OAKS IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ASSURING
CRITICAL FACILITIES ARE
OPERATIONAL DURING SHUT OFF
SUCH AT THE POLICE STATION.
THAT WATER SYSTEM HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES TRAFFIC SIGNAL SB
FIVE THIRTY THREE WOULD REQUIRE
ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS TO WORK
WITH THE CPUC TO DEPLOY
MICROGRID SYSTEMS ESPECIALLY IN
VERY HIGH WILDFIRE THREAT AREAS
SUCH AS WINTER ACCOUNTING.
THANK YOU HELLO HELLO IT'S
ACTUALLY IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING A MICROGRID TO
SUPPORT OUR WASTEWATER
TREATMENT PLANNING THE
MICROGRID IS BEING DEVELOPED IN
COOPERATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MENTORING. PROGRAM
THANK YOU. YES OUR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- NEXT THING WE HAVE
WE HAVE- CHEROKEE LARGE DAY. HI
THIS IS CHEROKEE. HI THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. GO AHEAD YEAH MANY.
I'M SHARE CABLE R. O. DAY FROM
CHAPTER CLICK MANNER WHICH IS
AN UNINCORPORATED TOWN IN L. A.
COUNTY WE ARE A PERFECT AREA
FOR HAVING OUR OWN MICROGRID
SYSTEM WE HAVE BEEN EXTREMELY
AFFECTED BY THE WILDFIRES WE'RE
AT THE BOTTOM OF THE WILL BE
CANYON AREA OUR POWER HAS BEEN
TURNED OUT TREMENDOUSLY ALL OF
THE P. S. P. S. OUTAGES. IT'S
EXTREMELY AFFECTED THE QUALITY
OF LIFE FOR OUR ELDERS WE ARE
IN AN EXTREMELY HIGH FIRE ZONE
WE HAVE A HìNH OF COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AND SUPPORT FOR SB
FIVE THIRTY THREE WITH SENATOR
STERN OFFICE WE'VE BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY TRYING TO COME UP WITH
INNOVATIVE DEVELOPMENT PLAN
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT ACROSS THE
BOARD TO SUPPORT. ACTION SUCH
AS THAT. ANYTHING THAT CAN DO
IT BUT- TO SHOW OUR MOST. FOR
BILLS LIKE THAT WORK TO
PRIORITIZE THIS MEASURE AND
GREATLY APPRECIATE. GIVEN THE
FLOOR TODAY TO SPEAK WITH
SENATOR STERN IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU MISS A DAY ALL
RIGHT OTHERS THAT ARE IN
SUPPORT I SEE NO IN THE GALLERY
I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. ON THE PHONE- MODERATE
IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE THREE
THREE I'D BE GRATEFUL. YES
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE THREE THREE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE SIX TWO SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI JOHN
KENNEDY WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT AND APPRECIATE THE
IMMENSE BEING TAKEN COMMITTEE
TODAY THANK YOU. ONE SEVEN OH
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS GREGTURNER ON BEHALF
OF SCHNEIDER ELECTRIC NORTH
AMERICA IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
NINE SIX SIX SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIRMAN LEE BYNUM WITH UNITED
THE MAGIC WORKERS ASKED ME
LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY HERE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE ONE MORE PERSON IN CUBA
CURRENTLY WITH AN OPERATOR ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. BUT IN REMINDER
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE THREE THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO ACTIVE TIME. ONE
SEVEN OH FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE COURT THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT AND WE
HAVE NO NO ONE ELSE COULD YOU
THERE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MODERATOR- QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE I SEE NO MICROPHONES
REYES OR DO I SEE A MICROPHONE
WHAT RACE THEY SEE SOME
RECOUNTS HIS MICROPHONE REYES
SARAH CASKEY. CENTER AMBER
ALERT MISTER AT CHAIR- I WANT
TO CONTINUE THE WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR ON THIS AT THE THERE'S A
PARTNERSHIP THAT NEEDS TO BE
FED AND A DECREASE BETWEEN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BETWEEN
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS IN BETWEEN
THE I. O. USE IN THIS THIS THIS
FOCUS ON. INFORMATION FROM THE
I. R. USE BUT THE FIRE WHAT
WILDFIRE MANAGEMENT PLAN AND
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS NEED TO PLAY
THEIR ROLE I THINK IT'S LIKE
98% OF THE FIRES ARE CAUSED BY.
A LIGHTNING IN SOMETHING THAT'S
NOT A PRODUCT OF THE
ELECTRICAL- PULLS COMING COMING
DOWN AND I KNOW WE HAVE WE TEND
TO WHEN THE LIGHTS GO OUT
EVERYBODY WANTS TO HOLD
SOMEBODY ACCOUNTABLE BUT THIS
IS THERE'S. TOO MUCH OF A- TO
MANY TREES IN THE FOR NOW IT'S
CREE A VERY VERY DANGEROUS
SITUATION SAID THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE ALL THE
CITIES THAT TESTIFIED AND ALL
THE- THE PRIVATE LANDOWNERS TO
COME UP AND DO THEIR FAIR SHARE
SO. I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH HIM AND I'LL BE GOING UP
ON THE BILL. THANK YOU SO I CAN
SEE I HAVE BEEN A MODERATOR
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THAT
EVERYONE ON THE PHONE LINE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
HAS BEEN GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY.
ANY ANYONE ELSE ON THE FLIGHT
LINE. YES SIR LADIES IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE THREE
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE WILL OPEN
MY SIX NINE SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH HELLO MISS CAPPER
BOARD FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON AND WE APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK THAT THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMITTEE HAS DONE ON THE BILL
WE'RE CURRENTLY ANALYZING ALL
THE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
TAKEN AND HOPE TO GET TO A
REALLY GOOD PLACE WITH A BUCKET
THANK SANDERS TURNED THE STAFF.
ALREADY THANK YOU NEXT. NEXT
OPEN MIND SIX SEVEN TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DANIEL GUTIERREZ
ON BEHALF OF TURN THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK AND I STATED BY
THE AUTHOR EARLIER WE HAVE
REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL BASED ON THE LEAST AMOUNT
OF TIME WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HELPING ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
AS A REMINDER IF YOU LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE
THREE THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE OPPOSITION SIR
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL RIGHT OF BACK TO THE
FLOOR. QUESTIONS THE QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT- THREE LAYERED MOVES
THE BILL. CISTERN YOU CARE TO
CLOSE. AT SEVEN THIRTY CARE
CLOSE. SORRY I WAS TO. JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR ALL OF
YOUR ITEMS. SIR STERN- IT WE
COULDN'T HEAR YOU. CAN YOU HEAR
ME NOW WE CAN. JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THIS PROMOTION BY CENTER
LAYERED. MAN CHIEF COUNSEL TO
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS SB FIVE
THIRTY THREE BY SENATOR STERN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST. I'M SORRY
WHO IS THE OCEAN BY. THE
EARLIER. SIMILAR SIMILAR THANK
YOU. THIS IS SB FIVE THIRTY
THREE BY SENATOR STERN THE
MOTION IS BY SENATOR LAYERED
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
THEN RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG HI
NUMBER HI FORGES. CABALLERO I
DON'T I DID ALSO DID I SO I
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ HI
HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG AYE
JONES. JONES NO LAYARD ARE
LAYERED HI STERN. STERN STERN
AYE WIECKOWSKI HI WHITE HOUSE
SKI I WIENER WIENER HI YOU HAVE.
HE OF NINE TO ONE SO FAR WITH
THE MEMBER MISSING. BY THE BILL
GOING CALL WE NEED TAKE A VERY
SHORT BREAK LESS THAN TWO
MINUTES.
ALL RIGHT SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WERE BACK
TO BACK IN ORDER ON. BRIEF
HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENT. WITH
RESPECT TO- THE CENTRE GONZALEZ
IS BILL. SEVEN SEVEN SIX WE DID
NOT TAKE A POSITION ON THAT
BILL AND SO AS A CONSEQUENCE
AFTER WE DO SENATOR WIENER'S
BILL WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO
S. B. SEVEN SEVEN SIX BY
SILICON SALAS- AND- MAKE SURE
THAT THE OPPOSITION IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT SO.
THERE WILL BE SEVERAL WINNERS
BILL SB TWO SIXTY THEN WE'LL GO
BACK TO CENTER THEMSELVES BILL.
ALL RIGHT. SIR WIENER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN ARE
COLLEAGUES TODAY I'M PRESENTING
SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY OF THE
CLIMATE CORPORATE
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT SB TWO SIXTY
NOW REQUIRES ALL U. S. BASED
COMPANIES BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE- WITH- AT LEAST A
BILLION DOLLARS IN ANNUAL
REVENUE- WHO DO BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA THE REQUIRES THEM TO
REPORT THEIR FULL CARBON
FOOTPRINT- TO THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD. AFTER THIS
DISCLOSURE CARPOOL BE REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE A REPORT ON THE
CENTERPIECE OF THIS INFORMATION
IS TRANSPARENT TO THE PUBLIC.
THE REPORT WILL INCLUDE A ROAD
MAP FOR NECESSARY CORPORATE
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS TO ALIGN
WITH THE GOAL OF KEEPING GLOBAL
WARMING LEVELS BELOW ONE POINT
FIVE DEGREES CELSIUS- ABOVE PRE
INDUSTRIAL LEVELS WHICH IS WHAT
WE NEED. TO RUN A CATASTROPHE.
OTHER POOR WILL ALSO INCLUDE
REASONABLE ESTIMATES FOR TWENTY
THIRTY AND TWENTY FORTY FIVE
EMISSIONS LEVELS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE AND CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS ARE PROPERLY
IMPLEMENTED. SB TWO SIXTY OF
THE NECESSARY AND BOLD STEP
FORWARD TO ENSURE THAT WE NOT
ONLY HIT OUR CURRENT CLIMATE
GOALS. BUT HAVE THE NECESSARY
DATA AND INFORMATION TO SET NEW
STANDARDS AND GOALS. ARE YOU
CAN'T REGULATE WHAT YOU DON'T
KNOW AND AS THE STATE CONTINUES
TO CURB EMISSIONS ACROSS MANY
SECTORS WE HAVE A CLEARER WE
NEED TO HAVE A CLEAR IDEA OF
WHAT WORKERS REMAINING. AND
WHAT ACTION NEEDS TO BE TAKEN-
THE SAME CANNOT BE SAID OF THE
PRIVATE SECTOR CURRENTLY
EMISSIONS REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ARE LIMITED TO
LARGE- POINT SOURCE SUBMITTERS
LEAVING OUT VAST SWATHS OF
CORPORATE EMISSIONS. BY SOME
COMPANIES VOLUNTARILY REPORT
THEIR EMISSIONS. IT'S DIFFICULT
TO BE CERTAIN OF THE REPORT'S
VALIDITY- THERE ARE
CORPORATIONS TO OFFER PARTIAL
REPORTS- AND FRANKLY A TIMES
MARKETING MATERIALS. WHICH CAN
BE GREENWASHING WHEN IT'S NOT
ACTUALLY GREEN BUT- WE REALLY
DON'T KNOW BECAUSE THERE ARE NO
LEGAL REQUIREMENTS TO FORMALLY
REPORT AUDITED- CARBON
EMISSIONS- SO SB TWO SIXTY WILL
BRING CONSISTENCY AND
TRANSPARENCY. OF OUR LARGEST
CORPORATIONS- HAVE TO PUBLICLY
DISCLOSE OUR CARBON FOOTPRINT
AND HAS TO BE AUDITED AND WE
WILL KNOW THAT. IT IS TRUE-
REPORTING FALSE OF IMAGE HAS
BECOME RECOGNIZED ON AS A
NECESSITY FOR PROPERLY REDUCING
EMISSIONS AND A SUCH
ORGANIZATIONS- SUCH AS THE
WORLD RESOURCES INSTITUTE HAVE
DEVELOPED- THE GREENHOUSE GAS
PROTOCOLS TO HELP MANAGERS
PROPERLY REPORT. TO BE CLEAR
WE'RE NOT WORKING FROM SCRATCH
HERE THERE ARE EXISTING
STRUCTURES- AND FORMULAS. THAT
ALREADY EXISTS AND COMPANIES
THAT ARE ALREADY DOING A
VOLUNTARILY AND- THEY WON'T
HAVE TO DO MUCH MORE WORK
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALREADY. DOING
IT AND COMPANIES WILL SIMPLY BE
ABLE TO PLUG INTO THIS
EXISTING. PROCESS ACCORDS FOCUS
HERE ONCE COMPANIES ARE IN
COMPLIANCE- AND REPORTING OF
WILL BE TO ACTIVELY MAINTAIN UP
TASTE OF PUBLICLY FACING
WEBSITE DETAILING BEES. OUR
CARBON FOOTPRINT REPORTS.
ARKANSAS INVESTORS THE PUBLIC
EVERYONE WILL THEN NO- WHICH
NOT JUST WHICH BUSINESSES FOR
WHICH SECTORS ARE A PROBLEM OR
NOT A PROBLEM IN TERMS OF. A
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. SB
TWO SIXTY IS THE NEXT CRITICAL
STEP FOR CALIFORNIA. ON ITS- ON
ITS JOURNEY TOWARDS TRUE
CLIMATE ACTION UNDER SURE THAT
OUR CORPORATE SECTOR AND OUR
STATE OUR LINES IN OUR GOALS
AND WORKING DILIGENTLY. WE NO
LONGER HAVE A LUXURY TO ALLOW
CORPORATIONS TO WORK BEHIND A
CURTAIN EMITTING MORE MORE
CARBON WHILE PROMISING CHANGE.
SB TWO SIXTY PULLS BACK THE
CURTAIN AND SHINES A FLOODLIGHT
ONE ANY AND ALL POTENTIAL BAD
ACTORS AND ALSO ON THE GOOD
ACTORS WHO ARE TAKING CLIMATE
CHANGE SERIOUSLY. I
RESPECTFULLY FOR AND I. AND
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY OR-
ALICIA LOPEZ KERA WHO IS- A
SUNRISE BAY AREA VOLUNTEER IN
SAN FRANCISCO HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT- MELISSA AND MELISSA
ROMERO- WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS-
ADDITIONALLY ON THE LINE-
AVAILABLE FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. IS CALDERON CHEN THE
DIRECTOR OF CARBON ACCOUNTABLE
THANK YOU. MISTER MERRILL IF
YOU'RE AVAILABLE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. SHARE BY THREE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE IN NORTH
AMERICA CALIFORNIA WE GET
CONFIRMATION THAT IT HAD
SOMETHING THAT I THINK YOU TAKE
THE- PERFECT THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR HARD WORK
ON THE CELL. BECAUSE OF THE
CRITICAL INFORMATION WITH AS A
RESULT THE LACK OF MANDATORY
COLLECTION AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS A COMPREHENSIVE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
ACCORDING. TO THE LARGEST
ACROSS THE BORDER. IF THEY
DON'T. AT THE MOST PROFITABLE
U. S. B. CORPORATION THAT
BENEFIT IN CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
AND REQUIRED TO BE CLOSER FOR
CREDIT RATING WHICH INCLUDES
ONE AND THREE EMISSION. THE
GREATNESS OF THE VENDORS THAT
THERE ARE CORPORATIONS EXCEPT
FOOD CLOTHING THE CARBON.
FOOTPRINT FONG. WE KNOW IT CAN
BE DONE THERE ARE ALSO WIDELY
YOU STANDARDS COMPANY.
PRACTICES USED. TO BUT HE IS
THE POINT THERE ARE NOT AND
COVERAGE PARTICULARLY THE
WITHOUT. LINE IN. EARLY
RECORDING A TOTAL CARBON.
SELECT MISSION GAP A THE
CABINET MISSION ON AVERAGE
ABOUT ELEVEN FOUR TIMES HI.
THAN ONE TO MENTION. THE THREE.
COMPONENT HEARING LARGE IMPACT
AGREE HAVE DOCUMENTS. COULD NOT.
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF CORPORATE
I WOULD REPORTING YOURSELF
MISSION SECONDARY WHICH IS NOT
DIRECTLY FROM MY CAN OFFER. AND
QUICKLY ALREADY HAS AND THE
FACT IS HAT NOT BE CASE
PUBLICLY THAT YOU'RE A QUICK
NOT THE- SIXTY EIGHT DID NOT
BURDEN WITH THE REPORTING.
MICHAEL BILL I THINK BECAUSE I
CONSUMER AND HOW MAKERS THE
MARK PICTURE THE IN FOR THAT.
TO PREVENT HEAD LEVEL WE HAVE
GOTTEN INCLINING YEAH WHICH IS
HOW YOU KNOW ALL TOO WELL THE
THAT. HERE AND URGE THE
COMMITTEES I'VE- THINK YOU. RON
MISS ALICIA LOPEZ GIVE. YEAH
THANK THERE IS A MILLION OF THE
MY NAME IS LISA THIS YEAR AND
I'M SCHOOL HERE TO GOING
SPEAKING A MEMBER AND I IN A
THE OF BOTH AND OF THAT YOU
TAKE. WHEN I WOKE UP EARLY TO
COME DAY LAST FALL I THOUGHT
HOW DARK IT WAS BEING I LOOKED
THE WINDOW TO SEE I WAS AN
ACTUAL ORANGE ALLOWED PER WERE
KIND OF MILES YEAH THOUGHT CHAU
THAT THE CAR OF CRAZY SENDING
UPON THIS. I THINK WELL I
THOUGHT ORDERS TO ON EVERYONE
SCREEN AND ARCOT IN SECONDARY
THE CLINIC AND I PLENTY OF
CALIFORNIANS HAVE STORY OF
THEIR OWN HOUSES DOWN VETERANS
GUY AND THE WORSENING WILDFIRES
ARE THE DIRECT RESULT OF THE
CLIMATE CRISIS BUT CLIMATE
CLINTON FINISH THE OLD BY SOME
OF THE WORST POLLUTERS MAJOR
CORPORATIONS IF WE KNEW EXACTLY
WHERE THE MAJOR CORPORATIONS
WITH ENORMOUS EMISSIONS DRIVE
IF I CAN DESCRIBE ARE UTTING A
LOT THE DETAIL NUMBERS
ASSOCIATED WITH THEM WE CAN
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
ACTIONS. I THINK OUR LOOKING
OVER CORPORATE SUSTAINABILITY
REPORTS AND I'M STILL. SEVERAL
RUBBISH CLAIMS ABOUT THE
COMPANY THESE COMPANIES AREN'T
BUT I HAVE NO IDEA HOW ACCURATE
THESE CLAIMS ARE BECAUSE THE
DETAILS ARE CLEAR IT SHOULD BE
THE GOVERNMENT'S RESPONSIBILITY
TO HOLD CORPORATIONS
ACCOUNTABLE AND MAKE THIS
INFORMATION UNDERSTAND ABOUT
THE COMPANY AND EVERYONE.
ASSEMBLY URGE YOU ALL TO VOTE
FOR SB SIXTY TODAY SOME OF THE
MOST POPULAR CLIMATE CRISIS
WE'RE ALL EXPERIENCING ARE THE
SAME ONES WHO'VE BEEN ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO ABSENT THE ONLY
HURT THE PLANET AND OUR
COMMUNITIES THE CLIMATE CRISIS
YOU'LL BY GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND CORPORATIONS ARE
BY FAR THE WORST POLLUTERS TO
PLEASE NOT YEAH I THINK YOU
SIXTY TO AVERT THE WORST
POSSIBLE OUTCOME. SENATE
STATION TO FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES INSPIRING RIGHT TO
RESPIRATORY INFECTIONS AND
GENERATIONS ROB DIBBLE LITTLE
PLANT MY GENERATION IS COUNTING
ON YOU TO LISTEN TO
CALIFORNIANS AND PROTECT OUR
PLANET AND OUR FUTURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS LOPEZ GERA
ALL RIGHT. OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT I SEE NOT IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WITNESSES SUPPORT. IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. BERMAN IF
YOU WOULD TO THEM UP. LADIES
AND IF YOU WISH PEAK AT THE
PARTY MAY PRESS WHY DIDN'T THE
AFTER TIME. AND LOCAL LINE TWO
THIRTY NOW YEAR OLD IS OPEN.
DESAMPARADOS BEHALF OF THE SEIU
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE THREE
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TWO ONE THREE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. RED HAT WILL OPEN
MY- OPEN MIND SIX EIGHTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YEAH THIS IS RICK MCDONALD
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
SIXTY ON BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO
ACT AND THREE FIFTY SACRAMENTO
THANK YOU. THE NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER SEVEN ONE FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE POLICE ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES IN
THE CORE AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE OFFICE OF
MAYOR LONDON BREED ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER SEVEN TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SEVEN TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR LINE IS
MUTED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
ARAMBULA BONTA NINE SIX SIX
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS JOYCE WALKER WITH THE NORTH
MOVEMENT SACRAMENTO EXPRESSING
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
SEVEN TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS JIM WEINBERG
FOR THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL TWO
SIXTY. AND SEVEN TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. EVENING
THIS IS JANIE GONNA BE
HAPPENING BERMAN FOR DEFENSE
FIND IT FOR THANK YOU. HE
BEFORE WE OPENED SIX FIFTY NINE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER IF YOU LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO SIXTY YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WELCOME MY SIX FIFTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI THIS
IS ANDREW YEAGER ON BEHALF OF
THREE FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO SIX.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR- NOW LET'S TURN
TO OPPOSITION I HAVE. LEO
SILVERTHORNE- LISTEN OPPOSITION
MISS SILVERTHORNE ARE YOU WITH
US. I AM. CLOSURES. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF OTHER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
MEMBERS ARE COMMITTED TO DOING
THEIR PART TO ADDRESS THE KIND
OF CLIMATE CRISIS HOWEVER THIS
BILL ENTIRELY BROAD IN ITS
SCOPE THE ONE THAT FITS ALL
APPROACH DOESN'T ALLOW FOR THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT'S PROVIDED IN
THE INTERNATIONAL PROBES NAMELY
FOR THE BROADER INTERNATIONAL
COMMITTEE TO EVALUATE WHERE
BEST TO TRACKING WORK TOWARDS
REDUCING GLOBAL EMISSIONS.
SECOND DAY FOR EXAMPLE BY
RETREATING FROM THE HEAVY DUTY
AND HEAVY TASK OF COLLECTING
THREE DOLLARS WINCOTT MIGHT BE
BETTER SPENT ON TRACK DIRECT.
AND STUFF LIKE THAT. I WANTED
TO THE ONLY YOU WANT TO CAST
THE BILL AS BRINGING YOUR-
HEALTHCARE COMPANY. REALITY
THAT THERE ARE DIFFERENT IN THE
IN A VERY AMERICAN TO COPE THE
MISSION IT'S A BIG DATA AND I
THOUGHT IN VERY STAGES. THAT A
IN FACT THEY ARE ON THAT OTHER
LEVEL. INFORMATION ON HOW TO
COLLECT REPORT DATA ON
EMISSIONS AND CLIMATE. THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE ENACTED BY
CALIFORNIA REALLY SHOULD ALIGN
WITH COMING NATIONAL
INTERNATIONAL. GLOBAL ISSUE
ADDITIONALLY THE RESULT OF
THREE MISSIONS ARE SOMETIMES
INCLUDED IT BECAUSE THEY DO
REQUIRE SACRIFICES IN COSTS
THAT ARE PRIMARILY BORNE BY OUR
SMALL AND MEDIUM BUSINESSES I
TOLD THE TEACHER LETTER STEP
THREE EMISSIONS ARE
COLLECTIVELY DATA DATA. WERE
COLLECTED VIA MODELING. THE
COMPANY I. IT HE HAD UP FROM A
SMALL BUSINESS. IN MY MAKE ITS
OWN DETERMINE ABOUT WHAT NASA
THAT MISSION ARE REPORT TO THE
NATION YEAH WE CAN WORK ON A
HOT. SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE
STUCK WITH THE CHOICE WIENER TO
RETAIN CONTRACT WITH LARGE
COMPANIES. THE BILL IT MUST I
TO DO THE EXPENSE BURKE
AUDITING OWN ADMISSIONS DATA OR
ARAMBULA COUNTRY WITH THE WITH
GRAPHS. THE. NINE LIKE THE
TECHNICIAN IN. ON THE RECORD
THAT WHICH GAVE. SO WHILE I DO
IT. THAT COMMITTEE WHERE CAN
THE OFFICE DOCTOR HE WORK ON
THE BALLOT. ON THE READING LIST.
DISCUSS CONCERN. BECAUSE THE
DOCTOR REQUIRES. USUAL ADDITION
WORK. ON A RESPECTFULLY BUT-
OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU SORTS
GOING ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION SEE NO ONE IN THE
GAME I NO ONE ROOM ONE TWELVE
MEMORY TURN TO THE PHONE. FOR
THOSE OPPOSITE. TO SB. TWO SIX.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB TWO SIX ZERO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
WILL OPEN MY THREE SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE THREE
SIX FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOUR LINE IS NEEDED WERE UNABLE
TO HEAR YOU. SOME OF THEM WERE
ABLE FOR THE NUMBERS. I DON'T
KNOW IF WE GOT CONFUSED WITH
THE LINES ARE GETTING RICHER
MAKE AMERICA A LOT OF YOUR
MONEY WITH CALIFORNIA LOCATION
IN SUPPORT OF FIFTY TO SIXTY
PEOPLE WITH A MIX UP WITH THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHTY. THANK YOU.
OKAY WILL OPEN AT SIX NINE
SEVEN. GOOD EVENING JUSTIN
HIGHER POLITICAL CONDO IN THE-
SHIP GROUP AND WE MUST RESPECT
WE OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ONE SIX TWO THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
THE COR COMMUNITY HAVE TO BE
HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION OPPOSED
THAT B. TWO SIXTY. THANK YOU
NINE SIX FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING MISTER KAREN
MEMBERS TRICIA GERINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. MY SIX
SIX FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
NUMBER SEVEN TAYLOR FOR THE
PERSONAL INSURANCE FEDERATION
WHICH ACTUALLY IN OPPOSITION SO
THE REASON I PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED THANK YOU. ONE SEVEN
OH ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
SEVEN OH ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
IF YOUR MIND IS MUTED OR UNABLE
TO HEAR YOU. HELLO BONTA LINE
THREE NINE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MODERATOR ALL MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
JEREMY YET HERE THEY HAVE TO
THESTATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NINE TWO
THREE ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
TWO THREE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
RELATED MUTED WE'RE UNABLE TO
HEAR YOU. WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
SEVEN FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IN THE FUTURE MEMBERS THE
SMART GATE NOT BE HAPPY
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO AT THE
TWO SIXTY AT A MANUFACTURING
RECORD THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE SEVEN EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MARKUP
PARTS OF THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION YOU CAN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. ONE
SEVEN TWO FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE SEVEN TWO FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOUR LINE IS NEEDED WERE
UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. HELLO
LEVINE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH
MEMBERS OF THE MONIQUE WAITED
FOR THE CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION ALL THROUGHOUT THE
VISION THE LINE ARE COMMON BUT
THE CHAMBERS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND BEFORE WE OPEN NINE
SEVEN SEVENTEEN JUST AS A
REMINDER YOU MAY PRESS ONE TO
ZERO FOR SB TWO SIX ZERO THREE
OPPOSITION. BY SEVEN SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE SEVEN
SEVENTEEN. NINE SEVEN SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN SEVEN SEVENTEEN. IF YOUR
MIND IS MUTED SEVEN ONE SEVEN
WE CANNOT HEAR YOU. AND AT THE
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK
YOU SIR. ALL RIGHT NO ONE ELSE
ON THE PHONE LINE WE BRING IT
BACK TO THE CHAMBER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. I SEE NO MICROPHONES
REYES THOSE I DO CENTER
HERTZBERG. SECOND YEAH-
PRESIDENT. NEWSOME A NOTE YOU
DON'T KNOW I MEAN PEOPLE TOO
MUCH OF COURSE IN KNOWN FOR IN
THE MIDST OF IT READING BUT
BUT- AND I KNOW THAT THE SPA
REACHED OUT MANAGING GET TO
TAKE THE CALL THE MISTER SO
THOSE OF A- BUT THIS. THIS THIS.
IS SET FOR ON PAGE FOUR. THAT'S
ABOUT THREE AND- BOTTOM OF PAGE
FOR OF FONG. BUT THEY'RE NOT IN
THE MOOD EMISSIONS A SOCIAL
DEPORTING C. SUPPLY CHAIN
BUSINESS TRAVEL AND COMMUTES
BUT WAY WATER USE REGARD OF
OKAY SO FORMALLY MOM POP UP.
AND I'M WORKING SOMEBODY
HAPPENS TO BE A BIG AND SOLD TO
GET BUSINESS OF PAID BILLS I
HAVE TO REPORT STUFF IS THAT IS
THAT WOULD THAT MEANS. COULD
YOU CAN HELP ME ON THAT IF TO
THE- SO WE DON'T GO AHEAD YES.
THANK YOU- BEFORE SO ONLY
ENTITY THAT HAS TO REPORT IS
THAT THE- WITH REVENUES OF A
BILLION DOLLAR OR DOLLAR OR
MORE. HI IN ADDITION THE BILL-
ALLOWS AND WE ARE WORKING WITH
SOME OF THE- TO CLASS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE VERY CLEAR ON THE
BILL- DIE. IF THAT THERE ARE.
THERE IS A PATH TO FOR A BIG.
THROUGH ITS THREE IN A- WE
USING SORT OF FORMULA IN AB SO
THERE ARE SOME. THAT ARE NOT IN
POSITION TO PROVIDE IT- BUT
THERE ARE A- FOR. ARE TO BE
ABLE TO. THAT SO THAT ON
BECAUSE UNDER THAT THERE IS.
WHERE FOR EXAMPLE IN THIS CHAIN-
BE DIFFICULT BECAUSE A BUSINESS
TO. IMAGE OF AN HONOR TO DO IT
WHERE THERE'S A BUSINESS A OR
SUPPLIED- PER THAT JUST PROVIDE
IT- BUT I DO SINCE WANT TO SAY.
THAT THERE ARE ALL. THERE'S A
LARGE NUMBER OF BIG CORP.
THERE'S OR CALLED. SUPPLY CHAIN.
AS A HIGH AND FIFTY FORM
CORPORATION INCLUDE MICRO-
STILL BLACK AND DECKER WALL.
ALFA HELP. MCDONOUGH NOW NOR TO
COCA COLA AND MANY MORE. THAT
ARE ALREADY THIS THERE ARE CALL
THIS THEIR SUPPLY. AND MAKING A
THE METS WHEN THE NEW TO. OUR
CAMP IT SO IT ALREADY. WITH
SOME OF BECOME. IT'S IN A- STE.
ON BUT THERE IS FLECKS WHAT CAN
I ASK YOU QUESTIONS MESSAGE OF
THE UP ON THIS. WHERE DOES IT
YOU COULD JUST I JUST WANNA
MAKE ONE AND ASK QUESTION
BECAUSE WORD IS A SAY THE
DOESN'T THAT IT SAYS. WHAT THE
REQUIREMENT IS UNDER TELLING
YOU FOR SOME WHO USED TO OWN A
COMPANY HAD THE WORD WITH. WITH
WITH THESE BECOME THEY JUST
WANT WORK WITH THE PERSONAL
HOPE PER TRY TO GET SMALL
COMPANY. TO PARTNER IN TWO
WORLD WHERE YOU CAN HAVE A
SMOKE AND PER. A OR EVEN IF M.
AS- AND YOU SELL THROUGH THEM
ALL THIS THE QUAL. AS A- GROUP
ENTITY YOU CAN SAY THE BIG CO
DOES THAT BUT THE REALITY IS A
SIGN OF. AND THEY SAY A YOU MAY
THESE. BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
THIS LIVE. WE'RE NOT GOING TO
AND WORK WITH YOU BUT WE'RE
JUST SAY IN HERE. BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T SAY THIS IN THE TOP
BOTTOM OF PAGE FOR PAGE FIVE.
AND THEN LATER ON THE TALK
ABOUT. THE AUTHORITY OF THE-
TO. WHICH WAS ADDED IN THE- OF
UP IMPOSING MINISTRY CIVIL. SO
NOW SOME WHO'S WORK ON A
MICHAEL. I GOT A BUSINESS
LICENSE SURE. I'VE GOT A LOT
ENOUGH TO GET CONTRA UNTIL
WHERE THE S. ARE PUTTING THIS
BILL I'M LOOKING THIS. AND I.
SB SOMEBODY ELSE SIMPLY ELSE.
SENATE WIENER YES I YOU A
SISTER. FOR ANSWER THAT'S
BECAUSE OF QUESTION I WANT MAKE
SURE THAT ONE THING IS. THE
SUPPLY. ONLY HAVE TO RE THEIR
SCOPE ONE THEY DON'T HAVE TO
DISTRIBUTED BAIL THEY DON'T
HAVE TO AND- SURVEY SAYS THIS.
THE PEOPLE IN SLICE IT ONLY
HAVE TO SERVE. ONLY HAVE TO
PROVIDE A THE CHAIN THERE'S
WONDERFUL OP. SAID- IN OF
ITSELF FOR THIS. IS A SICK-
LIMITATION IN TERMS OF. WHAT
THEY. AND THEY SCARE THE
BEJESUS OUT OF THE PERSON
DOESN'T HAVE A LAWYER. AND THE
BIG CODES ARE PROTECTING THEIR
LIABILITY AND THEY DON'T WORK
ANYBODY UNLESS THEY CAN VERIFY
THIS STUFF. AND IT BECOMES
IMPOSSIBLE I STARTED A SOLAR
COMPANY IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES ON
MARTIN LUTHER KING AND ALAMEDA.
AND I LEFT BECAUSE I COULDN'T
FILL OUT OF THE FORMS WITHOUT
LYING ABOUT. ME ALL INTERESTING
IN THE PRACTICAL WORLD I LOVE
THE FACTORY ESTIMATES THAT
THAT'S REALLY GOOD I APPRECIATE
THAT. I'M JUST SITTING IN THE
PRACTICAL REAL WORLD THE S. IS
HAVING SOME FLEXIBILITY. I'M
PARTICULAR CONCERN ABOUT THE
LITTLE GUY IN THE ABILITY OF
THOSE TO CONTRACT WITH THE BIG
PLAYERS WE GET BIG BUSINESS
BECAUSE- OTHERWISE IT'S HARDER
AND THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
SO MANY COMPANIES ARE GROWING
SO. YOU KNOW I'LL I WILL VOTE
FOR THIS TODAY ON YOUR WORK IN
FOLLOW UP ON THIS BECAUSE
YOU'RE WORKING ON IT OKAY. BUT
I JUST THINK IT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE TO RAISE. WHEN
I LOOK AT THIS BECAUSE I THAT'S
WHAT I'M PARTICULARLY CONCERNED
ABOUT IN THE CHILLING EFFECT IT
HAS. ON THE RELATIONSHIPS
BECAUSE IF I'M A LAWYER GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR A BIG COMPANY. I'M
JUST GONNA SAY. LETS NOT WORK
WITH THESE PEOPLE IS NOT WORTH
THE RISK SO YOU'VE GOT A BILL
THE FLEXIBILITY ES ENTRE SAY I.
THREW THE CHAIR- CENTERS FOR I
AGREE WITH YOU A 100% AND THIS
WILL PROVIDE THAT- AND WE WILL
ACTUALLY MAKE SURE TO KEEP YOU
UPDATED ON THIS AND I WOULD
LOVE ACTUALLY AND I THINK
YOU'LL FIND INTERESTING. TO ME
WITH CARBON ACCOUNTABLE ONE OF
OUR SPONSORS WHO THIS IS WHAT
THEY DO. ON THAT I THINK YOU'D
HAVE A REALLY INTERESTING
CONVERSATION WITH THEM. ALL
RIGHT OTHER QUESTIONS SENATE
WHITE HOUSE COULD. HAVE MISTER.
CHAIR I. STAYED OFF THIS BILL
IN EQ ARSENAL. I THINK I'VE
TALKED FRANKLY. WITH THE AUTHOR
USUALLY TALK FRANKLY- TIMES
THOUGHT IT WAS. MAYBE GIMMICKY
OR SILLY AT AT AT AT THE FIRST
LOOK. I'M I'M- FIVE MOVING
TOWARDS SUPPORT HI I HAD BY
REMOVING THE CIVIL AND CRIMINAL
PENALTIES THAT WAS A AMENDMENTS
TODAY I KNOW THAT THAT WAS NOT
EASY AND ALSO- THE ANALYSIS AND
THEN- DORMANT COMMERCE CLAUSE
ABOUT THE- COMPETITION I GUESS.
YOU KNOW I'M I WANT TO BE
HELPFUL AND I WANT THIS MEASURE
TO BE HELPFUL AND I'M THINKING
OF THE- BILLION DOLLAR
CORPORATIONS WHO ARE STANDING
ON THE SIDELINES AND WAITING.
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
LEADERSHIP OF CALIFORNIA'S
GONNA SAY WHICH DIRECTION WE'RE
GOING TO A MOVIE AND M. HAND
HOW THEY CAN MERE MERE GOOD
BEHAVIOR BECAUSE JUST THE
MILLION DOLLAR BILLION DOLLAR
CORPORATIONS IS NOT THE BIG
PROBLEM WE'VE GOT. COUNTRIES
LIKE CHINA THAT'S EMITTING 30%
OF THE EMISSIONS AND WE GOT THE
UNITED STATES WAS JUST GOT 15%
MISSION SO A LOT OF THIS IS IT
IS THE INTERNAL OF- PROBLEM-
BUT- I GUESS IF WE MOVE ONE
CORPORATION. BY HAVING THIS
MESSAGE THEN WE'VE- BEEN WE'VE
BEEN AN IMPROVED DID AND IF WE
CATCH. ONE OR TWO CORPORATIONS
THAT ARE GREENWASHING THEIR
THEIR NUMBERS AND WE ACTUALLY
CORRECT AT HI BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THAT CARP IS GONNA COMMEND
THAT'S PROBABLY A GOOD- A GOOD-
MEASURES SO. I'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON THIS-
SO THAT IT'S ROBUST AND IT'S
MEANINGFUL FOR THE TIDE DAY
INTERNATIONAL DIALOG THEY THINK
IT'S KEYED UP FOR. THANK YOU SO
I. CAL SKI OTHER QUESTIONS
SAYING NONE. OF WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE SENATE LEADERS ARE
MOTION. SO HERTZBERG MOVES THE
BILL. SIR WIENER DE CARA CLOSE
THANK YOU- YEAH AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE- CENTER LOCALES
KEYS- COMMENTS I THINK THIS
BILL IS THE EXACT OPPOSITE OF
GIMMICKY IT OR GIMMICKY WE
WOULDN'T HAVE HAD ALL THE EIGHT
HUNDRED POUND GORILLAS FROM THE
CORPORATE- FROM THE COMPANY
COMPANIES REPRESENTING THE
BIGGEST CORPORATE ACTORS IN THE
WORLD- OPPOSING THE BILL-
BECAUSE IT DOES ACTUALLY WILL.
DO SOMETHING SIGNIFICANT- RIGHT
NOW AND FOR ANYONE WHO FOLLOWS
MY WORK RIGHT IN TERMS OF-
CLIMATE CHANGE- I'D BE COVERED
VARIOUS ASPECTS OF IT I DO WORK
AROUND LAND USE AND WE'VE HAD
BIG FIGHTS IN THIS CHAMBER.
ABOUT FOCUSING MORE HOUSING
NEAR JOBS AND TRANSIT. FOR
DRIVING LESS WORK AROUND SOLAR
AND THANK YOU COLLEAGUES FOR
SUPPORTING A NUMBER OF MIND OF
OUR SOLAR BILLS. SO I WORK IN A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT AREAS
AROUND CLIMATE AND BIG
CORPORATIONS ARE CERTAINLY NOT
THE ONLY- CORPORATE WE'RE ALL
OF US ARE OUR CARBON EMITTERS-
IN VARIOUS WAYS. BUT- ARE ARE
BIG CORPORATIONS ARE
SIGNIFICANT EMITTERS OF CARBON
TO HAVE A SIGNIFICANT ROLE TO
PLAY AND THAT'S WHY IT'S STILL
A SMALL PERCENTAGE BUT MORE
MORE LARGE COMPANIES LIKE THE
MICROSOFT TO MCDONALD'S AND
WALMARTS OF THE WORLD. ARE
RECOGNIZING THAT THIS
DISCLOSURE IS IMPORTANT THAT
THEY WANT TO BE GREEN AND THEY
WANT TO BE VERIFIABLY GREEN
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW A LOT OF
COMPANIES CLAIM TO BE GREEN BUT
IT'S NOT VERIFIED AT ALL. AND
YOU KNOW WHEN THE AMAZONS AND
UBERS OF THE WORLD AT CENTER AT
CENTER ETCETERA START HAVING
DISCUSSES DISCLOSE THEIR ENTIRE
CARBON FOOTPRINT. THAT'S GOING
TO PUSH JYJ PRESSURE. ON THESE
COMPANIES TO REDUCE THAT
FOOTPRINT BECAUSE THEY'RE GONNA
LOOK BAD IF THEY DON'T AND
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO SEE SOME
INDUSTRIES WHERE WE KNOW THAT
THERE. ARE CLIMATE PROBLEMS AND
WE'RE NOW GOING TO KNOW FOR
SURE AND THE PUBLIC WILL KNOW
FOR SURE THIS IS AN IMPACTFUL
BILL- WE'RE GOING TO KEEP
WORKING ON IT. AND COLLEAGUES I
APPRECIATE YOUR FEEDBACK AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR WIENER THAT
AND SHE COUNCIL STRATEGY CALL
THE ROLL. A. MOTION BY SIR
HERTZBERG. YES THIS IS
DESPERATE SIXTY RIGHT. WE THE
MOST BY SEN HEARD DEMO IS PASS.
THE FAVORS THANK YOU BOTH.
SORRY THE MOVE IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
BURKE HI. I'M BURKE I POURED
JEFF. ZERO I DID ASARA WINE
DRESS SO I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG I'D JONES.
JON SNOW LAYERED BY LAYERED AYE
STERN. STERN I WAKE HOUSEKI.
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER.
WIENER ICE YOU HAVE OR YOU HAVE
EIGHT TO ONE AS OF NOW
POLITICAL ALL RIGHT BUT WE HAVE
TO RETURN TO ITEM NUMBER%
FIFTEEN SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX BY
CENTER GONZALEZ- TO ENSURE THAT
WE'VE TAKEN ALL OPPOSITION SO
THERE WAS NO- MAIN OPPOSITION
WITNESS WITNESS LISTED. ARE
MADAM MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
QUEUE UP THOSE ON THE PHONE I
SEE NO ONE IN THE GALLERY- WITH
WILLING TO TESTIFY WISHING TO
TESTIFY ON S. B. SEVEN SEVEN
SIX I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. MADAM MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN OPPOSITION. TO SB SEVEN
SEVEN SIX. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK ABOUT OF
SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE NO ONE IN OPPOSITION ABOUT
THE SEVEN SEVEN SIX ALL RIGHT-
THE BILL'S ON CALL BUT I THINK
WE NEED TO GO AHEAD AND REVOKE
THIS SO- WE DON'T.
ALL RIGHT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO VOTE AGAIN
WE ARE GONNA LOOK CALLS LATER
ON IN THE BILL ALL RIGHT. SO
NEXT. WE WILL GO. TO SIR WHAT
CAL SKI. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- FIRST I'D LIKE TO START
OFF BY ACCEPTING TO PROPOSE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS- IN THE
BILL ANALYSIS UP TO THIS BILL
SB THREE OR FIVE THREE ONE AT
ITS CORE IS ABOUT- BASIC RECORD
KEEPING TRANSPARENCY AND
PROTECTIONS FOR CONSUMERS THAT
HAVE DEBT SO BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN WE PASSED THE
FAIR DEBT BUYING PRACTICES ACT
WHICH BROUGHT NEEDED REFORM TO
THE LARGELY UNREGULATED AND
BROKEN SYSTEM OF DEBT BUYING IN
CALIFORNIA. AT THE TIME THERE
WERE WIDESPREAD CASES OF
COLLECTING THE DEBT AGAINST THE
WRONG PERSON WIDESPREAD CASES
ABOUT TARGETING THE THAT THAT
ALREADY BEEN PAID OFF AND
EFFORTS TO COLLECT THE INCOME
INCORRECT AMOUNT OF DEBT.
PROBLEM THE PASS ALONG WE
SOLVED IT RIGHT. WELL THE HELP
TO DRESS THESE ISSUES BY
REQUIRING DEBT BUYERS WHO HAD
DEBTS SOLD OPERATIVE WORD BEING
SOLD TO THEM AND THEY HAVE TO
HAVE PROOF THAT THEY HAD
OWNERSHIP THAT THEY HAVE BOUGHT
IT TO ALLOW CONSUMERS TO
REQUESTS AND TO REQUEST THAT
PROOF IN LAW ALSO REQUIRED THE
DISCLOSURE OF THE BASIC
INFORMATION SUCH AS HOW. MUCH
THE DEBT WAS OWED IF THERE WERE
ANY FEES OR INTEREST. AND THE
DATE OF THE LAST PAYMENT. NOW
WE COME OVER. TODAY AND WE GET
REPORTS FROM LEGAL SERVICES ON
DEBT COLLECTORS ARE GOING OUT
OF THEIR WAY. TWO RESEARCH- WE
DIDN'T FIGHT THAT DEBT THIS
THERE WERE ONLY COLLECTING ON A
SIDE DEBT SO WHICH IS A SIGN
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T BY SO HERE WE
GO AGAIN WE GOT. BECAUSE THE
DEAL BECAUSE THE ASSIGNED IT IS
NOT BEING SOLD CONSUMERS RIGHTS
AND ALL THE PROTECTIONS THAT WE
THOUGHT WE PUT IN PLACE BY THE-
FAIR DEBT BUYING PRACTICES ACT.
WHICH CIRCUMVENTED ANY DON'T
REPLY SO WHAT WE SEE ON THE
STREET DEBT COLLECTORS ARE
TARGETING WRONG DEBTORS THEY'RE
COLLECTING THE INCORRECT AMOUNT
THE TO THE CONSUMER HAS NO WAY
TO DETERMINE THE TRUTH OF WHO
IT IS SO. YOU KNOW THE
HIGHLIGHT THIS THAN THE NEED
FOR THE- THIS BILL IN FRONT OF
YOU THE BUREAU OF CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION FOUND THAT
FROM 200-016-2000 SEVENTEEN
THAT'S THE LESSON WE HAVE-
INFORMATION COLLECTING A DEBT
NOT VOTE WAS THE NUMBER ONE
CONSUMER PER. COMPLAINT IN IN
CALIFORNIA TWO OR THREE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
ELEVEN COMPLAINTS THAT AND THAT
ONLY INCLUDES REPORTED. SO THIS
BILL. ASIAN WHEN YOU REVISED
MACHIN WOULD REQUIRE DECAL. WHO
HAVE LIQUID DEBTS ASSIGNED TO
THEM TO HAVE PROOF THAT THEY
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO COLLECT
ON THE DEBT. THE BILL ALSO GIVE
CONSUMERS THE RIGHT TO REQUEST
STEP PROOF ALONG WITH SOME
BASIC INFORMATION WITH REGARD
TO THE- THE DEBT- ALL THESE
RIGHTS THAT APPLY TO THE FEAR.
DEBT BUYING PRACTICES AND SOLD
THAT APPLIES TO SIGNED. IN OF
SB FIVE THREE ONE WILL ALSO
REQUIRE A SIMPLE WE CALL IT A
GOOD BYE LETTER. IN OTHER WORDS
HAVING THE ORIGINAL CREDITOR
WHOEVER YOU. HAD THE DATE WITH
BEFORE- SEND NOTIFICATION TO
CONSUMERS ON WHO THEY'RE
SELLING TO THAT TO OR WHO
THEY'RE ASSIGNING DID IT TOO
ALONG WITH THE REMAINING
BALANCE THIS WILL ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA. DEBTORS AND
CONSUMERS ARE MORE LIKELY TO
OPEN. UP THE MESSAGE IF IT'S AN
EMAIL OR A LETTER IN BELIEVE IT
RATHER THAN BEING TOLD BY SOME
THIRD PERSON THAT THE THIRD
PARTY DAY THEY NEVER HEARD OF
THAT THE- THEM- MONEY AND
THERE'S ENOUGH SCAMS GOING OUT
THERE SO. LET'S HELP CONSUMERS
AVOID CONFUSION THE SUSPICIONS
OF FRAUD AND- THIS CONTINUITY
IS VERY IMPORTANT IN IN TODAY'S
AGE AND I HAVE LEE FERRAN WITH
THE PUBLIC LAWCENTER. TO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO AYE
CASKEY ALL RIGHT NOW WILL GO TO
ORANGE COUNTY'S OWN LEAF
AARON'S. WE ARE YOU ONLINE THIS
VERY ONLINE. HE'S HERE. I AM
GOOD EVENING WONDERFUL CARING
MEMBERS THANK YOU AYE I AM IN
ORANGE COUNTY TO NATO AND MY
NAME IS LISA AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF LITIGATION AND
POBLANO WITH THE PUBLIC
LAWCENTER WHICH IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION PROVIDING FREE
LEGAL SERVICES TO LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS. IN ORANGE COUNTY.
AT THE BANK TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE THIRTY ONE WHICH WILL
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL PROTECTION
FOR CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
DEALING WITH THAT COLLECTION
ACTIVITY. AND I CAN THINK
LOCKED. HE'LL BE WORKING WITH
LOW INCOME CONSUMERS OVERSEE
COLLECTION LETTERS FROM OR HAVE
BEEN FUELED BY DEBT COLLECTOR.
ONE OF THE FIRST QUESTION WE
ASKED IS WHETHER OR NOT THE
LIENT IS THE MIGLIOR WITH THE
DEBT COLLECTOR. MOST OF THE
TIME OUR CLIENT THEY KNOW
THEY'VE NEVER HEARD OF THEM.
DEPENDING ON THE INFORMATION
PROVIDED IN THE COLLECTION
LETTER OR IN THE LAWSUIT AFTER
SOME INVESTIGATION WE CAN
USUALLY FIGURE OUT WHO THE
ORIGINAL CREDITOR IS- AND
SOMETIMES IDENTIFY THE ACCOUNT
THE DEBT COLLECTOR. COLLECTING
I BECAUSE SOME THAT IT BETTER
UNREST. IN BUT MANY
CALIFORNIANS EXPECT NAVIGATING
THE COMPLEX NETWORK AND THAT
COLLECTORS AND I THINK NEEDS ON
THEIR OWN. AND THEY MAY NEVER
BE CONFIDENT BUT AT THAT
COLLECTOR IS TRULY COLLECTING
AND THAT THE SALE. WHAT WE DO
NOW IS OUR CLIENTS KNOW THEIR
ORIGINAL CREDITORS. BUT MUCH
MORE LIKELY TO REVIEW MAIL SENT
BY THEIR ORIGINAL CREDITOR. THE
REQUIREMENT IN SB FIVE THIRTY
WIND THAT THE ORIGINAL CREDITOR
CREDITOR PROVIDE INFORMATION OF
THE ENTITY THAT WILL BE
COLLECTING THAT THAT. WOULD
ALLOW DEBTORS TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS OF THAT
COLLECTION AND WILL ALLOW THEM
THE OPPORTUNITY TO RESOLVE
THEIR DEBT MUCH EARLIER IN THE
PROCESS THE FACT THAT THE FEES
AND COSTS HAVE BEEN ADDED ON.
IN ADDITION WHEN OUR CLIENTS
ARE FACING COLLECTION IN SOME
INSTANCES A DEBT COLLECTOR
ATTEMPTING TO FIND AT THAT. I'M
IN THE HOSPITAL HOSPITAL AND
MEDICAL THAT WAY TO PROVIDE IT
WILL NOT SELL THE DEBT BUT
INSTEAD OF FINDING THE RIGHT TO
COLLECT TO A THIRD PARTY DEBT
COLLECTOR. SENATE OVER CATHY
EXPLAINED THAT MEANS THAT THE
FACT THAT BUYING PRACTICES ACT
DOES NOT APPLY. AND THEY DON'T
HAVE AND THE DEBT COLLECTOR
DOES NOT HAVE TO PROVIDE THE
SAME INFORMATION WHICH IS BASIC
INFORMATION BY THE WAY. THAT
THAT THAT BUYER DOES. SB FIVE
THIRTY ONE WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEBT COLLECTORS BETTER AND FIND
THAT WOULD HAVE PROVIDED
INFORMATION TO THE BETTER SUCH
IS THE NATURE OF THE UNDERLYING
THAT THE DATA DEFAULT OR THE
DATE OF LAST PAYMENT. IN THE
NAME AND ADDRESS OF THE
ORIGINAL CREDITOR. IN ADDITION
THE BILL WILL PREVENT A DEFAULT
JUDGMENT FROM BEING ENTERED OF
THIS INFORMATION IS NOT
INCLUDED IN A LOT. CALIFORNIA
BETTER SHOULD NOT END UP WITH A
DEFAULT JUDGMENT FROM A DEBT
COLLECTOR THAT CANNOT EVEN TELL
THEM TO THE ORIGINAL CREDITOR
AND- ADVOCATE AT THE FIVE
THIRTY ONE IN THE URGENT I
THOUGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WAS FOR AN ART. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT I SEE NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. DO WE HAVE. AT A
MODERATE OR ANYONE ELSE ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT OF SIR WHITE
HOUSE SKIS S. B. FIVE THREE
ONE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE THREE ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO ACTIVE TIME. AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE FIVE FIVE FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ANCIENTS LAURIE
ON BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXTOPEN NINE SEVEN
TWO NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DANIEL CANDOR HI THERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT OPEN
NINE SEVEN THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING SIR MEMBERS
HELLO TRODDEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTER FOR RESPONSIBLE LENDING
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE THREE ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WHEN SEVEN
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE SEVEN THREE ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IF YOUR LINE IS MUTED
WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. AND
WITH NO RESPONSE I'LL CLOSE THE
LINE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
LET'S TURN TO OPPOSITION I SEE
NO PRIMARY OPPOSITION WITNESS
LISTED AND I SEE NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY AND I SEE NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE- MEMORY OR IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE THREE
ONE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU'RE NOT POSITION OF SB FIVE
THREE ONE YOU MAY PRESS SPOT
WANTED ZERO ACTIVE TIME. AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE UP SEVEN TEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE SEVEN
ONE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY ONE ONE TWO ONE SEVEN
THREE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
RIGHT NEXT CALLER WELL. NINE
SEVEN THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBER ECONOMICALLY THAT THAT
THE CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION AND YOUR MAIN
OPPOSED TO SENATE BILL BY
THIRTY ONE AS AMENDED WELL WE
APPRECIATE THE ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
IN THE AMENDMENTS THAT THE
INCLUSION OF MORTGAGES WOULD BE
PROBLEMATIC OTHER AMENDMENTS
TAKEN HAVE TWO HUNDRED AND-
OTHER ISSUES. FIRST THE MEASURE
SEEMS TO CONFLATE CIRCUMSTANCES
BURKE THAT AND THE FINES WITH
THIRD PARTY AGENCY TO COLLECT
HER SUPPORT VOLUMES THAT ARE
SOLD TO THAT FIRED CREATING
CONFUSING REQUIREMENTS FOR
DOCUMENTATION THAT MAY NOT BE
AVAILABLE. THIRD PARTY
COLLECTORS WORK DIRECTLY WITH
THE CREDITORS COLLECT IN THE
NAME OF THE CREDITOR MEANS. THE
REMEDY IS BACK IN HIGHER
LANGUAGE TARGETED CHARGE THAT
THAT THE LENDER HAS BEEN
UNLIKELY TO BE COLLECTED AND
SOLD TO A THIRD PARTY
COLLECTION AGENCY MANAGER NOW
HOWEVER TARGET DELINQUENT THAT
TURN THAT IS DEFINED BY THE
MARCH TWENTY FOURTH AMENDMENT
MEANS THAT THIRTY THIRTY DAYS
PAST DUE AND NOT CHARGE. WHICH
PRESENT CONCERNS AT A POIGNANT
CONTINUE TO GRAPPLE WITH AND
HOPEFULLY RECOVER SOON FOUND
THE ECONOMIC IMPACT AT THE END
OF THE CALL THE NINETEENTH
CAMPAñA. WE ARE UNAWARE OF THE
SITUATION WHERE THEY'RE
CONFUSION BY THE DEBTOR IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT ANY BAD ACTORS SHOULD NOW
FALL UNDER THE PURVIEW OF THE
ACT YEAH I BY WAY OF OFFICERS
AT THE NINE OH WAIT. ARE WE'VE
BEEN IN CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR AND FOUNDER OF THE
MEASURE AND APPRECIATE THE
DIALOGUE THAT WE HAVE HOT YOU
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
TOGETHER TO ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS ALTHOUGH WE MEAN. TO
THE MEASURE UP AND PRINT. IN
YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE ON
THE PHONE LINE AND. THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE.
ADAM LOTTERY WILL BRING IT BACK
TO BACK TO CHAMBER. HELLO HI
YES ARE YOU IN A POSITION GO
AHEAD GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION.
HEY CLOSE BURKE HEAR ME HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
COLLECTORS. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING IS CORRECT IN
CENTER WILL CAPS HE HAS TAKEN
AN AMENDMENT- TO MAKE THE BILL
CLARIFIES THAT THE BILL IS
PERSPECTIVE. THEN WE WOULD
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR IN THE
COMMITTEE STAFF CONSIDER WOOD
COUNTY THAT IS CORRECT. I'LL
THAT THE SERVER CAL SKI. THAT
IS CORRECT. RIGHT THANK YOU
SENATOR NOT EVERY DAY THAT
YOU'RE WORKING WITH YOU IS
ALWAYS. IT'S GREAT CHATTING
WITH YOU ALL RIGHT. ANYONE ELSE
ON THE PHONE LINE. NO CAR NO
ONE ELSE COULD YOU ALL RIGHT
OKAY NOW WE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE CHAMBER ON SEEING NO
MIKE MICROPHONES REYES SO I.
CAL SKIDOO CARE CLOSER MOTION
FIRST OF ALL. YES SENATOR
GONZALEZ WAS THE BILL SO WE CAN
SKI. THIS BILL REPRESENTS A
COMMONSENSE- SOLUTION TO A- BIG
PROBLEM I REGIONAL APPROACH.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT. BENJI
COUNCIL CAN CALL THE ROLL
PROCESS BE FIVE THIRTY ONE BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE KEY WITH
THE MOTION BY SENATOR GONZALEZ
AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
THEN RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS- BURKE. HI
BURKE HI JEFF. ZERO I GOT IT-
I. WRESTLE I DRIVE SO I
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG I'D JONES
NO JONES KNOWS LAYERED. BY
LAYERED ICE STERN AND I STERN
HIGHWAY CAL SKI BY WHITE HOUSE
SKI I WIENER. WIENER HI YOU
HAVE STEPHANIE YOU HAVE NINETY
ONE SO FAR WITH ONE MEMBER
MISSING ALL RIGHTS WILL PUT THE
BILL ON CALL- MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AS
MUCH FUN AS WE'VE HAD HANGING
OUT HERE TODAY- THIS IS GOING
TO COME TO AN END SOON. WE HAVE
ONE I KNOW SAID EARLIER IS
DISAPPOINTED- WE HAVE ONE MORE
BILL CENTER COVER HEROES SB SIX
SEVENTY AFTER THAT WILL BE
LIFTING CALLS. FOR THE COMING
YEAR- YOU CAN PRESENT YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- FIRST I'D
LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND I WANT
TO THANK. YOU AND YOUR STAFF
FOR WORKING. SO DILIGENTLY WITH
MY OFFICE- SB SIX SEVENTY
ATTEMPTS TO ACCOMPLISH TWO
GOALS. ONE IS TO STOP
IMMIGRATION CONTROL CONSULTANTS
FROM PRACTICING LAW WITHOUT A
LICENSE. AND THEREBY- ARGUING
OR INJURING THE IMMIGRATION
CASE AB OF THEIR CLIENTS-
RESULTING IN DEPORTATION OR
EXCLUSION FOR AN FROM ADMISSION
TO THE UNITED STATES NUMBER TWO
TO PROTECT IMMIGRANT CONSUMERS
FROM BEING PREYED UPON WHERE
THEY GET CHARGED EXORBITANT
FEES AND THEY'RE GIVEN FALSE
HOPE AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO THE
THOUGHT THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO EMIGRATE WHEN THERE
REALLY IS NO CHANCE FOR YEARS
AGO I DID A BILL TO ELIMINATE
THE PRACTICE OF THE IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANTS AND THAT WAS NOT
SUCCESSFUL LAST SESSION ANOTHER
ATTEMPT WAS MADE AND THAT. ALSO
WAS UNSUCCESSFUL SO FOR FOUR
YEARS NOW WE TRY TO GET THIS
DONE AND IT HAS NOT BEEN
SUCCESSFUL TO ELIMINATE THE
PRACTICE SO WHY DO IT NOW I
BELIEVE I BELIEVE THAT
IMMIGRAION REFORM IS IMMINENT
AND THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS FINALLY GOING TO TAKE ACTION
TO RESOLVE- HOW IMMIGRANTS CAN-
BECOME LEGALIZED CITIZENS IN
THAT THAT'S MY HOPE AND MY
PRAYER. MORE IMPORTANTLY WE
NEED TO PROTECT IMMIGRANT
CONSUMERS AND STOP THE ILLEGAL
PRACTICE OF LAW AND WE NEED TO
ALLOW THE THOUSANDS OF SMALL
BUSINESS. ENTERPRISES TO
CONTINUE. THE PRACTICE AS LONG
AS THEY ARE FOLLOWING THE LAW
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE IN THE
DATA SHOWS VERY CLEARLY THAT.
THAT A MAJORITY OF THE OF THE
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS
CURRENTLY ARE ARE WOMEN BECAUSE
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES. SO SIX.
SB SIX FIFTY FIFTY WOULD DO THE
FOLLOWING IT WOULD CHANGE THE
NAME OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANTS TO ONE THAT IS MORE
APPROPRIATE TO THE SERVICES
THEY ARE AUTHORIZED TO PROVIDE.
A PROVIDE WOULD LIMIT THE FORMS
THEY CAN FILL OUT AND I'VE BY
A- I'VE BEEN ASKED TO TAKE. TO
LIMIT MORE FORMS AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT THAT BECAUSE I THINK
THAT MAKES MORE SENSE- THEY
SHOULD NOT BE PRACTICING LAW
SHOULD THEY SHOULD NOT BE
GIVING LEGAL ADVICE OR IF
THERE'S OTHER FORMS THAT THEY
NEED TO BE RESTRICTED FROM
USING THAT'S FINE. AND RESTRICT
THE LANGUAGE CONSULTANTS USED
TO DESCRIBE THEMSELVES. SO THAT
THERE'S NO CONFUSION THEY ARE
NOT ATTORNEYS NOR DO THEY HAVE
THE EXPERTISE IN IMMIGRATION
MATTERS. AND FINALLY THE TO
REQUIRE AN EDUCATIONAL
OBLIGATION THAT THEY- THAT THEY
THEY PERFORM. A SUMMARY OF THE
AMENDMENTS IS FOUND IN IN THE
ANALYSIS AND SO I'M I'M NOT
GOING TO REVIEW ALL OF THAT- IN.
AND I'VE BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY OVER THE PAST YEAR
TO ENSURE THAT SMALL BUSINESSES
IN OUR STATE RECEIVED THE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES THEY NEED
TO STAY AFLOAT DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THESE FORM PREPARES
ARE ALSO SMALL BUSINESSES AND
AS I SAID. OVER 60% ARE.
MINORITY OWNED WITH- BUSINESSES
MINORITY WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES
AND I'VE BEEN PRACTICING FOR
DECADES. AT A TIME WHEN SMALL
BUSINESSES AND WOMEN OWNED
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN HIT. THE
HARDEST. BY THIS PANDEMIC TO
PUT THEM OUT OF BUSINESS
BECAUSE THERE'S SOME BAD ACTORS
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE TO ME
IT'S NOT LOGICAL AND IT'S NOT
FAIR AND THIS IS AN EQUITY
ISSUE I'M TRYING TO CARVE A
MORE BALANCED APPROACH TO THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE BECAUSE NOT
EVERYONE CAN AFFORD AN
ATTORNEY. OR AS ACCESS TO A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION THAT
PROVIDES THE SERVICES AT A LOW
COST THE NUMBER OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING SOME OF
THOSE WHO MAY TESTIFIED TODAY
IN OPPOSITION. HAVE INDICATED
THEY CURRENTLY SERVE 10215% OF
THE IMMIGRANTS THAT WALK
THROUGH THEIR DOOR LOOKING FOR
SERVICES AND THAT'S DUE TO THE
LACK OF CAPACITY IN THE
ORGANIZATION. AFTER RECOGNIZE A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS CANNOT
MEET THE DEMAND ALONE AND THAT
FORM PREPARES CAN WORK
COLLABORATIVELY TO PROVIDE
THEIR AUTHORIZED SERVICES THIS
IS PARTICULARLY TRUE IN MY
REGION AND- SENATE DISTRICT
TWELVE. WHERE THE IMMIGRATION-
THE OFFICIAL IMMIGRATION
SERVICES ARE NOT LOCATED AND
WHERE IMMIGRANTS HAVE TO
TRAVEL. MANY HOURS IN ORDER TO
GO SEE A- A- PROPERLY LICENSED
INDIVIDUAL. IN ORDER TO GET
IMMIGRATION SERVICES SO I'M
GONNA AND THERE AND IT'S BEEN A
LONG DAY AND WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ASSUMING
THEY'RE STILL ON THE PHONE.
IT'S ONE WHO DID IT ONE WITH
THE ADDRESS AND MIKE BELOW.
THANK YOU SENATE CAREER AS-
IT'S A GOOD TEARS IF YOU'RE
AVAILABLE. I AM RIGHT THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. OKAY THE GERMAN TOM-
BURKE AND HONORABLE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- AS PREVIOUSLY
STATED MY NAME IS ONE POSSIBLE
PETER I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF ONE STOP
IMMIGRATION CENTER. FIVE ONE
THREE THREE NOT FOR PROFIT
CORPORATION. I DO NOT HAVE A
HORSE IN THIS FIGHT. EXCEPT
THAT I'M NOT A VITAL ROLE BIG
BOOTY MIGRATION CONSULTANT. ARE
THEY IN THEIR COMMUNITIES. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ALONE
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANT HELP. UP
TO TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
IMMIGRANTS. WOULD BE ELECTION
OF PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN THE NEED
FOR IMMIGRATION SERVICES
CONTINUES TO GROW. REALLY THE
ISSUE IS ALL ABOUT THE ACTION.
UNDER CURRENT LAW I HAVE THREE
WAYS TO GET HELP TO FILL OUT
AND SUBMIT IMMIGRATION
DOCUMENTS. GRATION APPEALS
ACREDITA PROVIDERS ATTORNEYS
AND IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS.
GRATION ISSUES REQUIRE THE
SERVICES OF AN ATTORNEY BUT
MANY DO NOT THERE ARE NOT
ENOUGH PREMIUM IMMIGRATION
ATTORNEYS TO MATCH BUT THE MAN
MOREOVER NOT ONLY IS THE COST
OF AN ATTORNEY OUT OF REACH FOR
MANY BUT NOT OFTEN BEEN NOT
ATTORNEYS WILL NOT EVEN ACCEPT
A CLIENT ONLY REQUIRES THAT
TRANSLATIONAL ALL FORMS. THE
ONLY OTHER LEGAL OPTIONS FOR
IMMIGRANT- FROM ACROSS THERE
NOT. ALL THESE WORKERS DO YOU
THINK TRAINING THEY ARE NOT
REQUIRED WORK WITH AN ATTORNEY.
BUT I THE OUTBURST. NOT ONLY
ARE NONPROFIT. UPDATED IN URBAN
AREA BUT ARE NOT NEARLY ENOUGH
OF THEM- TO MEET DEMAND. OKAY
HAVE MASSIVELY. AND FUNDING
SHORTAGES- TO ISSUE GROWING
WORSE WITH EACH PASSING YEAR.
THE FACT IS NONPROFIT TOURNEY'S
SIMPLY CANNOT FEEL ABOUT GAPS
IN SERVICE. IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANT OR FORCED TO CLOSE
THEIR DOORS. SENATE BILL SIX.
IF THEY CALL IMMIGRANT BILL AND
ONE DAY IT SHOULD BE BRING IN
THE RESPECTIVE GROUPS IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION ARE
GATHER THANK. TAKING FOR THE
IMMIGRATION NEED THANK YOU SIR
RIGHT I RECENTLY ASK FOR YOUR
FOR ENABLE ON THANK YOU SIR
NEXT MISTER BELOW THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I AM
LIKE BELOW ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL NOTARY ASSOCIATION A
DOWNTURN CAPS WORTH. YOU KNOW
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS VERY
CONTENTIOUS ISSUE OVER THE
YEARS. EVEN THOUGH THE SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION REALLY TO SHARE A
COMMON GOAL TO PROTECT AND
CONSERVE THOSE SEEKING
IMMIGRATION SERVICES. AS THE
SENATE CALAR HEROES NOTED THERE
HAVE BEEN ATTEMPTS TO ELIMINATE
THE INDUSTRY WHICH HAS BEEN
REJECTED AND THIS IS A MORE.
BALANCED APPROACH THAT WOULD
FURTHER REGULATE THESE
CONSULTANTS AND ENHANCE
CONSUMER PROTECTION- WE BELIEVE
THAT THE REGISTERED AND BONDED
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS DO
EXCEPTIONAL WORK IN THE MAIN IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES. IF YOU READ
ABOUT UNLAWFUL IN THE CURRENT
AND LAWFUL IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANT IN THE NEWS. WE
THINK MORE OFTEN THAN NOT IT'S
A AND REGULATED KNOW TORIO. BUT
NAY DIVISIONAL WHO'S NOT
BACKGROUND CHECKED NOT
REGISTERED NOT BONDED NOT
TRACEABLE AND THERE IS REALLY
IS A COTTAGE INDUSTRY THAT
PREYS ON VULNERABLE. IMMIGRANTS
SO WE THINK THAT THIS IS A
BALANCED APPROACH THAT SHOULD
BRING THE SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION TOGETHER TO STOP%
FRAUDULENT ACTIVITY ILLEGAL
MATERIALS ENHANCE CONSUMER
PROTECTION ADD TO THE
REGULATION. BUT CHANGE THE NAME
TO FORM PREPARES AND WE THINK
THIS IS A VEHICLE THAT COULD
BRING THE PARTIES TOGETHER.
ONCE AND FOR ALL AFTER MANY
YEARS OF CONTENTIOUS DEBATE AND.
FOR THAT REASON WE WOULD ASK
FOR YOUR I. PHONE. THANK YOU
MISTER BELOW ALL RIGHT. DALLAS
TURN TO OTHER WITNESSES IN THE
CHIU NONE AND GALLERY NO
INTEREST ONE TWELVE. ON THE
PHONE LINES MADAM THOSE WHO S.
SIX SEVENTY COULD YOU QUEUE
THEM UP PLEASE. YES SIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
SEVENTY MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE SEVEN THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SEVEN THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND WITH NO
RESPONSE WE'RE JUST WAITING FOR
A FEW ADDITIONAL PEOPLE THERE
CURRENTLY OPERATOR. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE OPEN MIND SEVEN THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MANY
MUSICAL WORK CLOTHES FOR A
RETRACTOR AND IT- SUPPORT OF-
BILL SB SIX SEVENTY. THANK YOU.
LINE THREE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THERE YEAH
THIS IS GREG MCGILL IN- WITH
THE LATIN AMERICAN IMMIGRATION
ASSOCIATION- IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. ONE SIX FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
HI YOURE ON. OKAY MY NAME IS A
YEAR AND I AM FROM THE FUNDING
THE VEHICLE PROFESSIONAL
SERVICE AND I THINK FOR THE
BILL. THANK YOU. ONE SEVEN
FORTY YEAR LINE IS OPEN THANK
YOU MY NAME IS EARL GOT TO
THAT'S TO MEMBERS AND LOS
ANGELES. THIRTY SIX YEARS I'VE
BEEN IN THE AND THEN IN THE
IMAGE. SEALED AND TWICE YEARS
AS A CONSOLE. THE MODERATE
CALIFORNIA I WILL ANYWAY AND
ENSURE ROAD IN FAVOR OF THE
BILL. SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME'S
MARK HOLDERS ARE GOING TO BE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CORPORATE IF YOU ACCOMPLISH IN
CALIFORNIA- I. SUPPORT SB SIX
SEVENTY AND I RESPECT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR BIBLE
ALL RIGHTY THANK. YOU SENATOR
COLLINS. THANK YOU SO. ANY FOR
YOUR WIDE THIRTY NINE AFTER MY
IF YOU TO WITH OF SB SIX
SEVENTY LET YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AT ZERO AT THIS TIME. BY SEVEN
THIRTY NINE RELATED OPEN. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS ANGELA THE HOUSE
BY NOT AS IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANTS I'M A LEGAL
DOCUMENT ASSISTANT HERE
PACKAGING OUT OF SACRAMENTO AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE DO
HAVE ONE MORE LINE CURRENTLY
WITH AN OPERATOR. THANKS FOR
YOUR PATIENCE TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE SEVEN FORTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO IT WILL BE YOUR
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANT WITH
HERMAN DOT COMMUNITY SERVICES I
WAS SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL.
ALL RIGHT AT THE TIME YOU KNOW
WHEN I THINK YOU. OKAY LET'S
TURN TO I'VE TO THIS IS LOU IN.
MR DANIEL SHARP MISTER. THE L.
MISTER SHARP ARE YOU A THE
PHONE. I AM GOOD EVENING CHAIR-
BERGEN COMMITTEE MEMBER. DANIEL
SHARP ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. THE CHIEF OF THE
OFFICE OF IMMIGRANT AFFAIRS IN
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AND
BUSINESS AFFAIRS. WE'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROTECTING OVER
TEN MILLION COUNTY RESIDENTS.
MORE THAN A THIRD OF WHOM ARE
IMMIGRANTS. I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR CAFIERO FOR HER
CONTINUED EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
THE PROBLEMATIC. IMMIGRATION
CONSULTING INDUSTRY. SHE MEN AT
INTO. THE COUNT OF COMMITTED
THEM THE DEEP FLAWED INDUSTRY
TO THE GREATEST EXTENT POSSIBLE
HOWEVER THIS BILL INCLUDES
RELATIVELY MINOR CHANGES TO
EXISTING LAW. DESPITE RENEWED
HOPES OF IMMIGRATION REFORM AND
A LAPTOP CAL IMPORTANT CLIMATE
IMMIGRANTS CONTINUE TO NEED
LEGAL ADVICE. NOT CLERICAL
SERVICES IN ORDER TO NAVIGATE A
COMPLEX FEDERAL SYSTEM. OUR
DEPARTMENT WHICH IN WITH THE
COMPLY ABOUT BONDED STATE
REGISTER TO TALK IN THAT HAVE
CHILLY PROVIDE LEGAL ADVICE IN
CHARGE THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
WITH THEIR SERVICE. AND SO WE
REQUEST INCLUSION OF ALL
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS LAID OUT IN
OUR LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE.
MEETING COULD BE A CAP ON
FOREIGN PREPARATION AND ALL
RELATED SERVICE. THE LACK OF A
C. CAP REP REPRESENT AN
ENORMOUS LOOPHOLE IN EXISTING
LAW A FEW CAPITA CORRESPONDS TO
THE LIMITED NON LEGAL SERVICES
THAT THE BUSINESSES ARE
SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE WOULD HELP
PROTECT HARD EARNED DOLLARS
WOULD BE A GREAT HOUSEHOLDS. IN
A LETTER CONSUMERS TO HUGE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A LEGAL
PROVIDER WHO CAN COUNSEL AND
REPRESENT THEM. IN A FORM
PREPARE. WHO CAN. ULTIMATELY
ONLY INVESTMENT DIDN'T MAKE
SERVICES IN FIRST. WELL DRESS I
STATEWIDE. SHORTAGE WHILE WE
BACK. WE URGE YOU TO C. CAPS IN
ALL OTHER PER TO ME. TO REDUCE
THE HIGH TO FIX INDUSTRY.
ANOTHER COMMUNITY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR KIND. AND PERCENT OF
THE TIME OTHER THAN TO WORK
WITH L. A. COUNTY ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. THANK YOU. MR
THE L. GREAT DAY AS CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE HI MY
NAME IS JOSEPH MIGUEL AT DIRECT
APOLOGETICALLY XIN PROCUREMENT
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS CHALLENGES
THEY WANT MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION WITH NATIONALLY
BACK AND PROVIDE SERVICES IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY ORANGE
COUNTY TULARE COUNTY AND
SACRAMENTO COUNTY REGULATED
PROJECTING UPSET ON COME AGAIN-
AND I APPRECIATE HER WORK I
THANK THEM NUMBER TWO BAD
ORGANIZATIONS OFFICE. I EVER.
MATT LEWIS WE OPPOSE THE BILL
I'M NEED INDUSTRY IT'S GOING IS
COMPOSED OF THIS. I NOT TRACK.
OFTEN TELL IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES BUT FALLS MESSAGES
THEY CAN. THEM IN THE CAR
IMMIGRATION MATTERS IN REALITY
THIS IS A QUESTION BECAUSE-
LIKE FOR THEM. AND OPERATE
IMMIGRANTS FEDERAL. ARE CLEAR.
TURNING AND NOW JOURNEY
REPRESENT. RECOGNIZE AND
ACCREDITED BY THE PART OF JUST.
LED BY ATTORNEY QUESTIONS.
THEREFORE IMMIGRATION BECAUSE-
BLACK METAL IF YOU. RESOURCE
TRAINING AND NOW NEXT. ALSO THE
CLINTON AND I SUCH IN ME.
IMMIGRATION IT'S WITH AN THE
BILL PROVIDE EVERYTHING. ABOUT
THE TYPE OF IMMIGRATION FOR
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS TO FILL UP.
THIS IS A LEGAL PERSPECTIVE
OCCURRING LAW. OUR LEGAL
SERVICES. REPRESENT VICTIMS OF
IMMIGRATION PROBLEM. WHAT IT
DOES ALL ABOUT IT BUSINESS ON
THE SAN FERNANDO HIGH HAS
RECITING L. A. COUNTY FOR MORE
THAN THIRTY YEARS AND WAS ON
THE VERGE OF THE PETITION DUE.
SIX AGGRESSION COMES OFFICE.
ALSO THAT YEAR A U. S. CITIZEN
A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT WHO IS
PART OF A YOUTH PROGRAM FATHER
WAS SENT TO A DETENTION CENTER
AFTER. THAT YOU CAN SEE MEMBERS
INCLUDES OAKLAND. ELECTION THAT
THESE SERVICES. ARE I LOVE I
LOVE BECAUSE ITSELF OUR LEGAL
TEAM CURRENTLY IS THAT THE
SENATE. IN THE CENTER. COOL YOU
CAN REMOVE POSTED AND THE
SENATE BOB HI AFTER. THE
THOUSAND NINE. FOR SERVICE IN
ENGLISH CONSULT. BERMAN HE
PLAYED HAPPY I CAN'T PROPERLY
ELEVEN LAW TICKET TO MITIGATE
IT AND CONFLICT OF THE- AVERAGE
WE HAVE NOT SEEN IT BECAUSE
DROP OF. EIGHT SIX IT IS
IMPORTANT TO READ THAT. HAD
BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY THE BILL
BUSINESS. TO PROVIDE LEGAL.
SERVICES TO IMMIGRANTS GIVES
UNDER MY ITS INVESTMENT IT ALL
THESE REASONS I RECORDED BILL
WILL GO BY MANY OF. INCLUDING
ANYTHING YOU'RE GOING TO
CONTACT CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ASIAN AMERICAN
JUSTICE LOS. ANGELES. OVER THE
PHONE LINES OF THOSE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. SIX
SEVENTY. PLEASE GIVE US YOUR
NAME- SO SEE ASIAN. AFFILIATION
IN YOUR POSITION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX SEVENTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT
THIS TIME. OPEN MY NUMBER SEVEN
ZERO FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING MAKING SURE
MEMBERS CHRIS RESPONSIVE POLICY
ADVOCATE WITH WESTERN THAT ARE
AMONG POVERTY RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION. AND WE DO HAVE ONE
THAT'S CURRENTLY WITH AN
OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
AFTER WAITING LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
SEVENTY ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
WELCOME ONE SEVEN HUNDRED YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FIVE SEVEN
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING NIGHT BOTTOM ALL THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION. ACTIVELY
OPPOSED THE BILL AS PRESENTED
WE ACKNOWLEDGE AND RESPECT
SENATOR PROBABLY YET- FOR HER
WILLINGNESS TO ADDRESS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH HER
STAFF. AND THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. AND AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE COMPUTER ALL
RIGHT. COMING BACK TO THE
CHAMBER I SEE SOME OF THE
ROSSO'S MICROPHONE UP SENATOR
ALSO. YES THANK YOU- I TO WANT
TO START OUT BY. OUR TECHNOLOGY
IN THANKING THE AUTHOR I KNOW
THAT SHE HAS SPENT- BUT WE
SEVERAL YEARS TRYING TO. FIGURE
THIS OUT- I HAVE SPENT MOST OF
MY ADULT LIFE ON THE ISSUES OF
IMMIGRATION. AND IMMIGRANTS AND
WHAT THEY GO THROUGH. AND WHAT
THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE TO GO
THROUGH- THIS IS UNFORTUNATELY
HAS BECOME AN INDUSTRY. OF TOO
MANY PEOPLE. ARE TO TRY TO
REGULATE. AND IT'S GOTTEN SO
OUT OF CONTROL. TOO MANY PEOPLE
ARE GETTING- HURT BY IT AND
THEY GET HURT BY IT- NOT JUST
BE BY RISKING DEPORTATION. THEY
GET HEARD BY BECAUSE MANY TIMES
THEIR DEPORTATION COULD RESULT
IN HARM TO THEM PHYSICAL
VIOLENCE EVEN DEATH WHERE THEY
ARE SENT BACK TO THEIR IS. TO
THEIR HOME COUNTRY. THIS SHOULD
BE VERY EASY FOR THESE
ORGANIZATIONS OR ENTITIES TO
FIGURE OUT. THEY'RE EITHER A
NONPROFIT AND THEY FOLLOW THE
RULES. OR THEIR BUSINESS AND
THEY FOLLOW THE RULES. BUT THEY
CAN HAVE IT ALL WE AND NO-
THERE IS THIS OVER AND THEY
KNOW WHAT WHICH WHY THEY DO
THEY DO. PLANER WITH- KNOWING
THAT THEY ARE- GIVING
INFORMATION THAT'S NOT CORRECT
OR MAYBE THEY DON'T KNOW IT BUT
THEY'RE ACTING AS IF THEY KNOW
WHAT INFORMATION TO GET THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN OUT OF PROPERLY
TRAINED THEY HAVEN'T GOTTEN THE
CREDENTIALS AND IT'S SHAMEFUL
IT'S JUST SHAMEFUL TO DO IT IN
THE COMMUNITY THAT NEEDS THE
SERVICE SO BADLY- YOU KNOW
OTHERS ARE. LEFT WITH THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY YOU KNOW THE
COUNTIES OR THE CITIES OF THE
CITY ATTORNEY'S COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THEY ARE LEFT
HAVING TO FIX. OF PROBLEMS THAT
ARE CREATED BY THESE ENTITIES I
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THE COLUMN
BECAUSE- THEY SHOULDN'T BE
CALLED A NOTARY IN THE MORE
THEIR CLINICAL CONSULTANTS
THERE THEY MAKE UP ALL THESE
TITLES AND THERE'S A HUGE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT'S BEING
PAID TO THEM. SO I FEEL REALLY-
I'M NOT ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE OF THE AUTHOR OF THE
SENATOR- WE'RE BOTH WE'VE HAD
SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS AND WE'RE
BOTH. ON THE SAME SIDE AS FAR
TRYING TO FIX THS BUT I DON'T
THINK THAT MORE RULES ARE GOING
TO FIX IT I DON'T THINK THAT
MORE WORK I THINK THAT MORE
RULES ARE GOING TO MAKE THEM
LOOK LEGITIMATE. BOMB AND I
DON'T MEAN TO PUT EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF WHO DOES THIS IN THE
SAME BRACKET IN THE SAME
CATEGORY BUT THEY ARE MOSTLY.
DOING AN INJUSTICE TO OUR
COMMUNITY- OTHERWISE THEY
WOULDN'T HAVE A PROBLEM MEETING
THE ACCREDITATION REQUIREMENTS
I MEAN JUST THE FACT THAT
THEY'RE PUT ON THE SAME LEVEL
OF YOU KNOW EITHER YOU GO TO A
BOARD OF ACCREDITATION GET
PROPERLY TRAINED AND
ACCREDITED. OR YOU KNOW TURNING
OR YOU GO TO THE IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANTS THEY AREN'T AT THAT
LEVEL THAT'S NOT WHERE THEY
SHOULD BE PUT. SO I REALLY- I
THINK THAT WE SHOULD. CONTINUE
TO DO THE OTHER SIDE WHICH IS
THE OTHER DIRECTION WHICH IS
NOT LEGITIMIZE THEM. OF FIGURE
OUT THE FOR THE ENFORCEMENT AND
LAST I WANT TO SAY. IS THAT OUR
STATE HAS INVESTED TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO PROVIDE
THE KIND OF REAL QUALITY
SERVICES THAT OUR COMMUNITY
DESERVES. EVERY PART OF OUR
STATE WHERE THEY'RE IMMIGRANTS
WE SHOULD BE PROVIDING THIS
EVERY PART OF OUR STATE WE NEED
TO EXPAND THE CAPACITY. AND I
AM FEARFUL- NOT THAT THERE WILL
BE A DOOR WHERE SOMEBODY COULD
WALK IN AND SAY I NEED YOUR
IMMIGRATION SERVICES BUT THAT
WHEN THEY WALK THROUGH THAT
DOOR THE GETTING LEGAL ADVICE.
AND THE PROPER ADVICE BY A
PROPERLY TRAINED PERSON- THAT'S
WHAT I'M WORRIED ABOUT AND
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE WHEN
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM SO UNFORTUNATELY. I
CANNOT- SUPPORT THIS BILL YOU
VERY MUCH. THIRTY BORDERS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THERE
IS A LAW CLINIC AT THE LAW
SCHOOL AS A TEACHER IN COLOR A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT. OTHER WORDS.
FROM ONE LANGUAGE TO ANOTHER
CAN MEAN TOTALLY DIFFERENT
THINGS AND CAN HARKENS BACK TO
THE HOLE ON THE TYDEUS
RESISTIBLE GATHERS YOU KNOW A
LAWYER VERSUS PREPARE AND HELP
FOLKS WERE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF-
THINKING THAT THEY WERE GETTING
A SERVICE THAT THEY UNDERSTOOD
IN THE HOME COUNTRY BUT IN
THEIR NEW ADOPTED COUNTRY IT
MEANT SOMETHING TOTALLY
UNREGULATED AND- WITHOUT
SUFFICIENT EXPERTISE. THAT THEY
WERE EXPECTING I THINK THIS IS
A VERY SMART WANT TO COMMEND
THE CENTER FROM SALINAS THIS IS
A VERY SMART WAY OF ALLOWING
BUILDING BLOCKS- TO BE
ESTABLISHED IN TERMS OF WHAT
TERMINOLOGY IS APPROPRIATE- SO
THERE'S SOME DEGREE OF
CONSISTENCY. AND WHEN
INDIVIDUALS DO NOT HAVE THE
SUFFICIENT EXPERTISE BUT
PRESENT THEMSELVES IN WAYS THAT
ARE ANYTHING OTHER THAN
DOCUMENT PREPARERS IT'S KINDA
MINDS ME OF. THAT OLD
LEGALZOOM- ENTERPRISE WERE THEY
PRODUCE DOCUMENTS ARE NOT
LAWYERS SIX MAKE AVAILABLE
WHATEVER IT IS THAT YOU WERE-
SEEKING TO ACQUIRE AND BY
VIRTUE OF THEM GIVING THEM TO
YOU. SOME FOLKS WERE THINKING
THAT IT WAS VALIDATING WHAT.
FORMS THEY WERE FILLING OUT.
YOU CAN'T FIX ALL OF THE
UNEXPECTED EXPECTATIONS OF A
CONSUMER BUT YOU CAN CERTAINLY
START WITH HAVING A CONSISTENT
SET OF TERMINOLOGIES SO I'M
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY AND SALAS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- I TOO WANT TO
THANK SENATOR KABBADI AT ALL
FOR- BRINGING THIS FORWARD I'VE
ONLY BEEN IN THE SENATE NOW FOR
ALMOST TWO YEARS AND I'VE SEEN
JUST VARIOUS. ITERATIONS OF
WHAT- THIS BILL COULD LOOK LIKE
BUT I'M I'M- WHAT I'LL SAY IS-
I'M I'M GLAD THAT THIS IS
MOVING IN A DIRECTION THAT
SEEMS MORE POSITIVE IN MY
OPINION. HELLO I TO WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL BUT- WHAT I
AM HOPEFUL OF IT IN LOOKING AT
THE L. A. COUNTY LETTER. THAT
OUTLINED QUITE A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS THAT COULD BE AMENDED
DOWN THE ROAD. LOOTING- OF
COURSE PROHIBITING NEW
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANT
REGISTRATIONS WHICH WHICH HAS
BEEN DONE IN OTHER STATES OF
COURSE CLEAR DISCLOSURES BUT I
WAS A KEEN ON OF COURSE
EXPANDING THE LIST OF
PROHIBITED IMMIGRATION FORMS
WHICH I KNOW IS STILL VERY
MURKY WE DON'T KNOW WHICH ONES
YOU KNOW GET US IN TROUBLE
ESPECIALLY ARE THE ONES THAT-
FOR ASYLUM SEEKERS AS WE KNOW
IT'S BEEN ONE THAT HAS BEEN
RAISED IN THE PAST AND ISSUE
THAT'S BEEN RECENT PAST AND
SETTING FEE CAPS. IN MY
DISTRICT TO HEAR SO MANY- OF
ARE UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THAT PAY EXORBITANT
AMOUNTS OF MONEY TO PEOPLE THAT
THEY JUST DO NOT TRUST AT THE
END OF THE DAY AND WHO END UP
PUTTING THEM IN A WORSE
POSITION AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
TALKED ABOUT BEFORE- LONG BEACH
NOW AS- YOU KNOW. NOW I ALSO
SEE ABOUT THE THOUSANDS
CHILDREN THAT HAVE COME TO THE
CONVENTION CENTER WHO WILL NEED
SERVICES AND I'M WORRIED THAT
WORKING GOING TO POTENTIALLY.
CONTINUE TO EXACERBATE THE
PROBLEM BY ALLOWING YOU KNOW
MORE IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS
ARE FORM PREPARES TO CONTINUE
ON AND BE GRANDFATHERED IN IN
THE PLACE WHERE. YOU KNOW WE
NEED WE NEED THEM THE MOST NOW
BUT WE NEED THEM TO ENSURE THAT
THEY'RE GETTING IN ORDER- AND
THAT AGAIN THE DISCLOSURES ARE
CLEAR. AND THAT WE KNOW
EXACTLY- WE HAVE WE HAVE A
BETTER WE HAVE THEM IN A BETTER
PLACE SO. WITH THAT SAID- I
KNOW YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
ON THIS- AS IT MOVES FORWARD I
WON'T BE. VOTING ON THE BILL
TODAY BUT I JUST WANNA THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS- TO THE
ATTENTION OF ALL OF US IN
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION
AND- I'VE- PEOPLE HAVE TO SAY
APPRECIATED THANK YOU AND I.
APPRECIATE THE STAKEHOLDERS FOR
CALLING INTO. ALL RIGHT ANY
OTHER COMMENTS NONE QUESTIONS
DONE ALL RIGHT IS THERE MOTION.
BOATSWAIN MISTER AND I'M SORRY.
SERVICE STERN. I DON'T MEAN IF
YOU LABOR DAY SAYS CENTRE
GONZALEZ JUST- IT JUST TOUCHED
MY SHOULD I WAS OPENING HER
CLOTHES MAYBE CENTER COPYRIGHT
COULD ADDRESS THE FOR
OUTSTANDING- FOR OUTSTANDING
AMENDMENT REQUESTS FROM L. A.
COUNTY- THAT'S GOING TO BE TO.
BE AN ABILITY TO REACH THOSE I
THINK IS GOING TO BE THE REASON
I CAN'T CAN'T BE THERE TODAY-
CONSPICUOUS AND CLEAR
DISCLOSURES. SPANOULIS V. CAPS-
SO SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF THE AUTHOR HERE AND
I'VE BEEN BEEN THERE WITH HER
IN YEARS PASSAGES. IN THOSE L.
A. COUNTY POINTS ARE VALID SO
IF YOU MISTER ADDRESSING YOUR
CLOTHES FEEL FREE. ALL RIGHT.
SINGLE OTHER MICROPHONES UP- IS
THERE A MOTION. SIR HERTZBERG
MOWS THE BILL SO CABALLERO
BIGGER CLOTHES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR- LET ME JUST
ASSURE YOU THAT- I'VE LOOKED
OVER THAT THE LETTER FROM L. A.
COUNTY- AND I'M GOING TO BE
WE'RE WORKING ON THE LANGUAGE
AND WILL BE ACCEPTING ALL OF
THE AMENDMENTS THAT THEY
SUGGEST WE THINK THAT THEIR-
THEY'RE REALLY VALID IT'S JUST
A QUESTION OF WORKING OUT.
WORKING OUT THE LANGUAGE- LET
ME BE REALLY CLEAR ABOUT ABOUT
WHERE WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS ARE A
LEGITIMATE BUSINESS WE'VE NEVER
SAID THEY CAN'T OPERATE THEY
SHOULDN'T BE PRACTICING LAW BUT
WE HAVEN'T ARTICULATED EXACTLY
WHAT THAT MEANS- OTHER THAN
TELLING THEM THEY SHOULDN'T BE.
PRACTICING LAW AND QUITE
FRANKLY THE BAR HASN'T DONE.
ANYTHING ANYTHING ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THEY'RE PRACTICING
LAW THEIR LEGITIMATE WHAT WE'RE
DOING. IN THIS BILL IS WERE
ADDING SAFEGUARDS AND BOB I
REALLY WANNA THANK LA COUNTY
FOR THEIR LETTER BECAUSE THEY
GAVE IT SOME SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS AND FRANKLY. IN THE
LETTERS THAT I'VE REVIEWED
THEY'RE THE ONLY ONES THAT THAT
HAD. ON SOME SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS THIS REALLY IS AN
EQUITY ISSUE AND IT'S A
CONSUMER PROTECTION ISSUE WE'RE
NOT DOING WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO
PROTECTS ONSUMERS TODAY. AND
AND YOU KNOW WE HAVE WE HAVE. A
HISTORY. OF. SETTING UP BOARDS
AND BUREAUS TO REGULATE THE BAD
ACTORS. IN ORDER TO GET
COMPLIANCE WITH CONSUMER
PROTECTION. SO. SO WE DON'T
WALK IN AND SAY OKAY YOU'VE
GOTTEN BACK THAT BAD ACTORS AND
LET ME JUST TELL YOU THAT WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO GET DATA FROM
ALL THE DIFFERENT ORGANIZATION
INCLUDING THE AG'S OFFICE THE
AG'S OFFICE AND THE DIFFERENT
COMPANIES- DEPARTMENTS THAT
THAT DO IMMIGRATION- REVIEWS
WITH WITH THE CONSULTANTS TO
FIGURE OUT WHETHER THEY THEIR
APPROPRIATELY BONDED AND THEYPAID THEIR FEES AND THEY'RE
WORKING ACCORDING TO THE LAW
THE LAWS AS THEY ARE IN PLACE
RIGHT NOW AND QUITE FRANKLY
WHAT THE DATA SEEMS TO SUGGEST
AND NOBODY'S KIT KEEPING THIS
DATA ON A STATEWIDE BASIS. BUT
THE DATA SEEMS TO SUGGEST THAT
IN REALITY IT'S NOT THE
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS BETTER
THE MAJORITY OF THE CASES IT'S
A NOBODY ELSE IS THE NOBODY
ELSE WHO HAVE SOLD THEMSELVES
AS ATTORNEYS AND THEY'RE OUT
THERE DID YOU KNOW ACTING
ACTING AS IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANTS CONSULTANTS AS WELL
SO WHAT WHAT THIS BILL WILL
START TO DO IS TO SET SOME
PARAMETERS AROUND WHAT KIND OF
FORMS YOU CAN USE WHAT KIND OF
FEES YOU CAN CHARGE. HOW YOU
CAN DESCRIBE YOURSELF AS AS MY
GOOD A SENATOR FROM FRESNO SAID
WORDS MATTER AND SO WHAT WE
CALL THEM AND WHAT THEY'RE ABLE
TO DO BECOMES VERY VERY
IMPORTANT AND- IN REGARDS TO
THE MONEY THAT WE SPEND THAT
THIS THE STATE HAS INVESTED IN
GOOD LEGAL SERVICES THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT THAT MONEY HAS
BEEN WELL SPENT. AND AND I
TOTALLY DISAGREE THAT IF WE
PASS THIS BILL FIRST IT IN SOME
WAY IT ABROGATE THE COMMITMENT
FOR THE INVESTMENT. THAT WE'VE
MADE WE COULD. WE COULD MAKE A
TEN TIME INVESTMENT. TEN TIMES
INVESTMENT AND WE SEE I THINK
WE STILL WOULDN'T HAVE ENOUGH
RESOURCES. FOR ALL THE
QUESTIONS IN THE ISSUES THAT
THAT IMAGE IMMIGRANTS HAVE IN
NEED- WE DON'T HAVE THOSE
RESOURCES SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO USE A VERY WISELY. AND FOR
MY MONEY TO HAVE. THE FORMS
FILLED OUT ONLY THE FORMS THAT
WE INDICATING DICTATE WILL MAKE
A BIG DIFFERENCE BECAUSE THOSE
FORMS ARE GOING TO TAKE SOME
HELP AND HAVING SOMEONE WHO
UNDERSTANDS HOW TO FILL OUT
THOSE FORMS. CORRECTLY IS THAT
AN APPROPRIATE TASK FOR WENDY'S
PREPARES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE BUT TODAY. THANK
YOU. THE MOTION BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG. MANAGE ACCOUNTS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY FIVE
AND A COPY AT ALL- THE MOTION
IS BY SENATOR HERTZBERG THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND THEN RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION. I'M SORRY.
WHERE AT. I WE STATE THAT THE
PATH OF AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND THEN RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
UMBERG HI AMBERG HI FORTUS
PORGES HI CABALLERO I ZERO I
DID I SAW. DID I SEND NOT
VOTING. GONZALEZ AND SALAS. NOT
VOTING HERTZBERG- HERTZBERG AYE
JONES. JONES I LAYERED BY
LAYERED I STERN. STERN NOT
VOTING. I THINK YOU I THINK YOU
NEED TO SAY THAT SENATORS TURN
TO STERN. STERN NOT VOTING
THANK YOU WHY CAL SKI HI MY CAL
SKI I WIENER. WIENER NOT VOTING
SO YOU HAVE. ONE TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE SIX SEVEN AND EVERYONE IS
HERE SO THAT SEVEN TWO ZERO ALL
RIGHT THE BILL IS OUT. ALL
RIGHT IN A MOMENT WE'RE GOING
TO OPEN THE ROLE OF THE BILLS
THAT ARE ON CALL ON BEFORE WE
DO SO CENTER HERTZBERG YOU WISH
BE RECOGNIZED I DO MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH. BEFORE YOU OPEN THE ROLE
I WANTED TO MAKE A STATEMENT
REGARDING. FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE. SB TWO BY SENATOR BRADFORD-
AS WE KNOW THE CURRENT VOTERS
THREE TO. ONE OR SOMETHING I
CAN RECALL BUT IT'S NOT PASSED
I- IT HAD SERIES OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR-
AS I MENTIONED IN MY COMMENTS
WITH REGARD TO THE MEASURE.
POMPOUS SERIES OF CAR OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
PROPONENTS OF THIS MEASURE AND
I AM. IN BOTH RESPECTS BELIEVE
THAT- WE CAN REACH AN AGREEMENT
AS TO AN AMENDMENT IN THE WITH
REGARD TO THE ISSUE OF.
RECKLESSNESS AND THE LIKE- SO-
I HAVE HAD A CONVERSATION WITH
THE WITH THE AUTHORS I SAY AND
I WILL SUPPORT THAT MEASURE I'M
DOING IT NOW BECAUSE YOU HAVE A
SON'S ROLE OPENS WE CAN'T BE
TALKING ABOUT THIS. ON THE
CONDITION THAT WE CAN SOLVE THE
ISSUE WITH RESPECT TO GENERAL
INTENT VERSUS SPECIFIC CONTENT
VERSUS RECKLESS AGAIN NEVER
SUPPORTING SPECIFIC CONTENT
ONLY LOOKING FOR SOME LESSER
STANDARD- AND IF WE CAN'T REACH
SUCH AN AGREEMENT- AND I
CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT WITH THIS COMMITTEE-
I WILL RESERVE MY RIGHT TO NOT
VOTE FOR THIS. AND TO ARGUE
AGAINST IT ON THE FLOOR BECAUSE
I THINK THAT- THE FACT IS THAT
BY. ALLOWING THE- A WRONGFUL.
DEATH ACTIONS. UNDER THE BANE.
ACT IS A DRAMATIC SHIFT FORWARD
DRAMATICALLY IMPROVES COULD
CONSTITUTE IS A CIVIL RIGHTS
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS FOR. A
WRONGFUL DEATH ACTIONS IN STATE
COURTS WERE TO DRAMATICALLY
MORE- AVAILABLE IN THOSE KINDS
OF CASES WITH THAT I JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY THAT I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND I
WILL VOTE FOR TODAY'S AN
ACCOMMODATION TO CONTINUE THAT
DISCUSSION HERE WITH THIS
COMMITTEE. AND WITH THE AUTHOR-
AND- THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALLOWING TO MAKE THAT STATEMENT
UNCONDITIONAL LOVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR HERTZBERG I
UNDERSTAND IT SENATORS STERN
WISHES WE RECOGNIZE AS WELL.
SIR STERN DID YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED. YES CHAIR. VERY
BRIEFLY WITH THAT UNDERSTANDING
I HAVE NOT HEARD BACK FROM THE
OTHER BUT WITH THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S UNDERSTANDING WITH THE
AUTHOR- ANY ISSUES HE JUST
RAISED THE EXPECTED RESOLUTION
OF THOSE ISSUES BEFORE THE
FLOOR ALSO BE. REPORTING THAT
MEASURE- HOPING WE CAN WORK IN
GOOD FAITH HERE TO SOLVE THAT
ISSUE. THANK YOU SENATOR STERN
SOMEWHERE CAL SKI. THE
PHARMACIST DIRECTOR AS- A AYE
TO DID NOT VOTE ON THE BILL AND
I DID NOT SPEAK AND I THOUGHT.
I DID HAVE A CONVERSATION
SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
PROPONENTS IN THE IN THE AUTHOR
AND GETTING THE ASSURANCES ON
THIS STANDARD OF CARE LANGUAGE-
CHANGES THAT ARE NECESSARY AND
WANT TO BE CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT.
I HAVE SUPPORTED THE OTHER-
PORTIONS OF THE BILL THE
DECERTIFICATION AND HAVING POST
INVESTIGATE OFFICERS SET UP OF
THE FIRES REPORT AND HAVE THIS
SERIOUS MISCONDUCT. A STOP IN
THE PART. PART OF THE BRAIN
CHECK THAT. NOW ALLOWS ATTENDED
LEGISLATION NOW ALLOWS THE
WRONGFUL DEATH ACTION IN THIS
IDEA OF PLANTINGEVIDENCE AND
INJURING- INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT
HELPING PRISONERS IS ALL. WAS
WAS NEVER A PROBLEM IS FOR ITS
IT'S THE LANGUAGE. THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO FIND IN BETWEEN
SPECIFIC IN GENERAL INTENT SO
I'VE GOT THE INSURANCES FROM
THE AUTHOR DID. THEM HE
UNDERSTANDS THE CONCERNS THAT
SHARES- VOICE IN WE'VE HAD
HOURS OF CONVERSATIONS OVER THE
LAST WEEK SO I'M HOPEFUL THAT
THIS THING CAN LAND AN OB-
HELPING A GET OUT THE
COMMITTEES THERE. PARTY THANK
YOU SIR WHAT CASKEY- WITH THAT.
MADAM CHIEF COUNSELS DR IF YOU
WOULD OPEN THE ROLE. I WOULD
START WITH THE SPEEDS OF PHONE
NUMBER ONE. WELL CONSENT
CALDERON SECTIONS CALENDAR
FIRST YES RIGHT. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR COLORADO. W. AT ALL
RIGHT HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
JONES JONES HI THAT IS. ELEVEN
TWO ZERO. FILE NUMBER ONE CAN
THINK CALENDARS OUT TELL COULD
SINK COUNTERS OUT. F. OKAY NOW
WE'RE AT S. B. TWO WHICH IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE- AMBERG.
SORRY AT ALL. DID I SELL MY
DATA SO I HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE JONES. JONES NO STERN.
COULD YOU SAY THAT AGAIN STERN.
STERN I. WHITE HOUSE SKI I WAKE
CAL SKI I THAT'S ONE TWO THREE
FOUR FIVE SIX THAT SEVENTY TWO
WITH EVERYONE VOTING BILLS OUT.
ALL RIGHT. THIRTY THE NEXT ITEM
IS SB TWO EIGHTY NINE BY
SENATOR NEWMAN WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING HI. REGIS PORGES NO
JONES JONES NO STERN. STERN
STERN I WIENER. WIENER HI THAT
IS. THAT'S NINETY TWO BILLS OUT.
THE NEXT BILL IS SB THREE
NINETY TWO BY SENATOR ARCHER
LET THAT. WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I BORJAS BORJAS I HERTZBERG.
THIS IS SB THREE NINETY TWO
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYEIT'S
A BILL BY SENATOR HARD TO LET
THAT IN IT IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE. HERTZBERG BY JONES JONES
HI STERN. STERN AYE STERN AYE.
WHITE HOUSE SKI. TELL YOUR NO
WAKE SKI NO THAT IS. THAT'S
TEND TO ONE. THE BILLS OUT.
NEXT IS S. B. FIVE FIVE ZERO BY
SENATOR DOLLY WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING HI. HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
NO STERN. S. NINE STERN AYE
WIENER NO WIENER NO THAT.
NINETY TWO BILLS OUT. THE NEXT
BILL IS SB SIX OH FIVE BY
SENATOR EGGMAN WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING HI. PORGES. BOARD IS NOT
VOTING. HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI
JONES JONES NOT VOTING. STERN.
STERN AYE STERN AYE WIENER. HI
WIENER HI YOU HAVE. NINE TWO
ZERO. BILLS OUT. THE NEXT BILL
THE S. B. SEVEN OH TWO BY
SENATOR LIMON. BUT THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE BORJAS. WE'RE JUST
NOT VOTING JONES. JONES HI
STERN. STERN AYE STERN AYE
WIENER FIVE LEADER HI SO YOU
HAVE TEN ZERO BILLS OUT. WE-HAVE SB SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR LEYVA. WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING HI BORJAS NO BORDERS NO
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI JONES
JONES NOT VOTING. STERN. STERN
AYE STERN AYE WIENER HI WIENER
I SO YOU HAVE ONE. YOU HAVE
NINETY ONE ON THAT ONE. FILLS
OUT. WE HAVE SB SEVEN FORTY
FOUR BY SENATOR GLAZER WITH
THAT SHARE VOTING AYE STERN.
STERN HI STERN AYE WIENER AYE
WIENER AYE THAT IS ELEVEN TWO
ZERO. THOSE OUT. SB TWO SIXTY
BY SENATOR WIENER WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING HI BORJAS. PORGES
SNOW CABALLERO. OKAY THAT'S.
THAT'S EIGHT TWO TWO. BILLS OUT.
S. SB. FIVE THIRTY THREE BY
SENATOR STERN WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE BURGESS- GORGEOUS NO.
OKAY. THAT'S NINETY TWO. FILLS
OUT. SB FOUR FIVE TWO BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE FORGES. PORGES NOT
VOTING. JONES THIS IS S. B.
FOUR FIVE TWO AND IT IS FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
HI. JOHN SNOW. STERN STERN AYE
STERN AYE WACO'S KEY. AYE AYE
CASKEY AYE WIENER WIENER HI SO
THAT'S. NINE TWO ONE. SENATOR
THAT'S NINE VOTES TO ONE THE
BILLS OUT. SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX
BY SENATOR GONZALEZ WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I'D CENTER BURGESS.
THIS IS SB. SEVEN SEVEN SIX
ITEM FIFTEEN CENTER BORDERS NO.
JONES JON SNOW WHITE HOUSE SKI
ARE Y. CASKEY I WINNER WINNER
HI THAT IS NINETY TWO BILLS OUT.
SB FIVE THIRTY ONE BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE PORGES. PORTIS NOT
VOTING. AND I THINK THAT IS.
812-345-6789 TWO ONE. FILLS OUT
THE BILL IS OUT AND THEN. WE
ARE READY- THIRTY SIX SEVENTY
SEVEN ALL I HAVE. SO WE ARE
ADJOURNED UNTIL MAY FOR THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR PATIENCE THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR DILIGENCE.